foreign
welcome to Simply launch YouTube channel
in this session we will be learning the
complete software testing but before we
begin I would like to take a quick
confirmation from the viewers if I'm
clearly Audible and the screen is
visible if yes kindly type yes in the
chat section and if there are any
problems that we could rectify please do
let us know in the chat section
all right I see a lot of positive
responses from our viewers thank you now
I think it's clear to get started so
before we get started with software
testing I would like to tell you guys
that we have daily updates on multiple
Technologies so if you are one of those
Tech Geeks in a continuous hunt for
latest technological Trends then
consider getting subscribed to our
YouTube channel and don't forget to hit
that Bell icon to never miss an update
from Simply learn now without further
Ado let's get started with the agenda
for today's session
so at first we will get started with
selenium and in selenium section we will
learn the Advent of selenium Then
followed by that we will understand what
exactly is selenium and the
technicalities of selenium followed by
that we will understand selenium tool so
it then we will learn how to install
selenium in our local systems then we
will learn the selenium IDE tutorial
followed by that we will get started
with selenium Webdriver tutorial so once
we are done with the selenium Webdriver
tutorial we will get started with XPath
and selenium Webdriver followed by that
we will learn selenium Chrome driver
tutorial once we are done with the
selenium Chrome driver tutorial we will
get started with test NG annotations
then we will have a head-on-head
comparison with selenium and qtp
followed by that we will go through
selenium jobs and salary Trends in the
current ID industry
and finally to make things interesting
we carried out a survey on the major
testing software companies and collected
some most frequently Asked interview
questions based on selenium now this
will be helpful for your software
testing career so followed by selenium
we have another tool that is jmeter so
we will get started with jmeter
installation then we will learn
performance testing followed by that we
will learn jmeta load testing and
advancing ahead we will learn about
jmeter API testing and finally in J
meter part we will learn the jmeter
script recording so once we are done
with the jmeta script recording and J
meter tool we will get ahead and learn
the chain cans so in Jenkins part we
will have a brief tutorial about what
exactly is devops where we will
understand the fundamentals of devops so
that we have a clear idea what we are
dealing with and why we are using
Jenkins in software testing followed by
that we will learn the critical part of
CI CD pipeline then we will get started
with what is Jenkins and then we will
learn how to install Jenkins in our
local systems once we are done with
installation part we will go through
continuous Integrations in collaboration
within Jenkins and finally to make
things interesting we are including some
most frequently Asked critical genuine
based interview questions so with that
we are done with the agenda and I hope I
made myself clear with the agenda now
without further Ado let's get started
with the first part that is selenium now
over to our training experts
hey there welcome into the world of
selenium if you are going to embark on a
journey of automation I promise you this
is the right place to start so let me
take you on the first lap of this
journey this is a video tutorial what is
selenium from Simply learn what is in it
for you before you start understanding
any automation tool it's good to look
back into what manual testing is all
about what are its challenges and how an
automation tool overcomes these
challenges challenges are always
overcome by inventing something new so
let's see how selenium came into
existence and how did it evolve to
become one of the most popular web
application automation tool selenium
Suite of tools selenium is not a single
tool it has multiple components and we
will be looking into each of them as you
know every automation tool has its own
advantages and limitations so we will be
understanding the advantages and
limitations of selenium and how do we
work around it selenium jobs and salary
very important isn't it you are here to
learn selenium you definitely want to
know what's the market demand on the
skill what worth you will be once you
are skilled on this automation too so
what we will do we'll just discuss some
stats on the job market related to test
Automation and selenium in particular
all right so let's get started manual
testing and its challenges what is
manual testing manual testing mainly
inverse physical execution of test cases
against various application and to do
what to detect bugs and errors so as a
definition if you can say it is one of
the Primitive methods of testing a
software execution of test cases without
using any automation tools it does not
require the knowledge of any automation
tools and can practically test any
application this could be a simple a
definition can be let's do one thing
let's take an example right before we
start understanding why what are the
challenges of manual testing and why we
have to really look into any automation
tools let's take a simple example say we
have a simple use case as a user I want
to log into my web application using
username and password a very common a
use case isn't it and this is a common
use case for any kind of web application
under test now let's say for example I
have a web application here say I have
this community.simplylearn.com for me to
actually enter into this application
what I need to do is first login into
this application so this is a simple
login page which accepts a user ID or an
email ID a password and you click on the
login now as a tester you would write
multiple test cases to test this use
case for example you will have multiple
data test cases like valid credentials
invalid credentials null value and so on
you will also test multiple links on
this page probably the forget password
link the sign up now so whatever links
are made available you're going to test
that then you will say test this check
box so you will check the remember me
functionality and when you log in back
again you want to validate if all your
previous data are filter you will also
check for error messages on an invalid
login you will do accessibility testing
you will also do a performance on this
page like say for example response time
after you click on login in button and
so on so while you're doing a manual
testing literally you can do any kind of
test you want so this is what you do in
the first place and then you start
executing this test cases one by one you
will find bugs your developers are going
to fix them and you will need to rerun
all these test cases again and again
until all your bugs are fixed and your
application is ready to ship now this is
a very simple use case now let's look at
a little complex use case now say you
have an account creation form like this
so I have this online pan application
form right this is still a simpler form
I would say now look at the amount of
data you need to fill here each and
every field you need to test and you
need to test this with hundreds of
transactions because you're going to
have those kind of data sets with you
and then you want to repeat them again
and again until you are satisfied that
your application is working as per it is
designed so now if you go back to our
presentation now this brings us to the
first demerit of the manual testing and
what it is this is very time consuming
process and hence it's going to get very
boring for any manual tester also it is
more error Pro the risk of error is
pretty high why because it is done
manually and human mistakes are bound to
happen it requires presence of tester
all the time since its manual execution
tester's presence is required all the
time one needs to keep doing manual
steps over and over again and hence he
needs to be sitting in front of his PC
manual creation of logs and repositories
creating manual reports grouping them
formatting them so that they are like a
good looking reports sending those
reports manually to all the stakeholders
say collecting logs from the various
machines after you execute the test
cases consolidating all those results
and logs right creating repositories
maintaining them wow this is a huge long
list of mundane tasks one needs to do
and this you need to do and do again and
again until your testing is completed
right so this is going to be a manual
process and it's going to be very
tedious and as I said it was also error
Pro limited scope the scope of manual
testing is very limited for example say
regression testing ideally you would
want to run all the test cases which you
have written but since it's a manual
process you would not have the luxury of
time to execute all of them and hence
what you do you will pick up choose your
test cases and then execute that way you
are kind of limiting the scope of
testing also say working with large
amount of data which is manually pretty
impractical what about performance
testing so you want to say collect
certain metrics on various performance
measures as a part of your performance
testing you want to simulate certain
multiple loads on your application which
is under test hence performing this
manually is definitely not feasible and
to top it all the say you're working in
an agile model where your code is being
churned out by developers say every week
testers are building their test and they
are executing them as and when the bills
are made available to them for testing
now this happens iteratively and hence
you will need to run all the test cases
which you have created multiple times
during your development process and
doing this manually is going to become
definitely very tedious and boring and
is this really effective way of doing it
not at all so what do we do we automate
it so this tells us why we want to
automate one one is for the faster
execution two to be less error prone and
the most importantly to help you run
your test cases frequently as many times
as you want so there were many tools
available in the market today for
automation so one such tool is selenium
Advent of selenium much before selenium
there were various tools in the market
like rft qtp just to name a few popular
ones selenium was introduced by a
gentleman called Jason hunkins way back
in 2004. he was an engineer at
thoughtworks he was working on a web
application which needed frequent
testing and he realized the inefficiency
manual testing this application
repeatedly so what he did was he wrote a
JavaScript program that automatically
control the browser actions and he named
it as JavaScript test run he also made
this open source which later was renamed
as selenium core and this is how
selenium came into existence since then
selenium has become one of the most
powerful tool to test web application so
what is selenium selenium is the most
popular and widely used automation tool
for automating your web application it
enables us to test web application on
all kind of browsers like IE Chrome
Firefox Safari Edge Opera and even the
Headless browser selenium is an open
source and it's platform independent the
biggest reason why people are preferring
this tool is because it is free of cost
whereas the qtp and rft which I
mentioned earlier are the chargeable
tools selenium is also a set of tools
and libraries to facilitate automation
of web application it is not a single
tool it has multiple components in it
which we will be seeing in detail in
some time and all these tools together
they help us test the web application
you can run selenium scripts on any
platform it is platform independent as
and why it is platform independent
because it is developed in JavaScript
it's very common for manual testers not
to have in-depth programming knowledge
so the selenium has a record and replay
back capability and this tool is called
as selenium ID which can be used to
create a set of actions as a script and
then you just have to replay that script
so mainly this is used for demo purposes
because selenium itself is such a
powerful tool and it offers so rich
functionality you would want to be in a
position to take the advantage of all
its future however if you have testers
who do not have enough of programming
knowledge to start with there is still
this ID which is a record replay tool
which you can use to create your test
scripts it also provides support for
different programming languages like
Java python C sharp Ruby and so on so
you can literally write your test
scripts in any language you like or
which you know of so one need not again
know a complete in-depth an advanced
knowledge of any of these languages
selenium supports different operating
systems and browsers it supports Windows
Macs Linux and say if you want to run
your test on Ubuntu machines yes that is
also possible it's on any platform of
your choice selenium you can run the
test cases selenium Suite of tools so
now let's go little more deeper into the
selenium so as I said it is a suite of
tools and these are the major components
of the selenium selenium IDE selenium
remote control which is in short called
as RC selenium Webdriver and selenium
grid from selenium 3.0 version onwards
you will not find the remote control
anymore because it has been deprecated
but you still have your ID Webdriver and
grid components now let's take a deeper
look into each of these components and
understand how they function in this
Suite of tools selenium integrated
development environment which is called
as selenium IDE so it is the most
simplest tool in the suite of selenium
it's an integrated development
environment it has a record and Playback
functionality and it's a very very
simple and easy to use too however it is
mainly used as a prototyping and not
used for creating the actual automation
for your real-time projects why because
of its own limitations since it's just a
record and replay tool so this ID is
available as a Firefox plugin and a
Chrome extension so either you can use
Firefox or the Chrome browser to record
your description the commands created in
the scripts where you are going to
record are these commands are called
selenis commands and these are the
commands which interact with your
browser you can also write some of these
commands manually while you are
recording your scripts and we'll see how
to do that when we talk about the ID in
detail and it is again a platform
independent so you can deploy ID on any
platform of your choice so you can have
it on your windows Linux and Mac OS
however the only requirement is you
should have either Chrome or Firefox
browser support on that particular
platform earlier selenium IDE was only a
Firefox extension it died with the
Firefox version 54 or I 55 I guess so ID
was not supported from the 55 version
onwards and this was sometime during
2017. however very recently all new
brand selenium IDE has been launched by
apply tools and they have made it cross
browser that is it is available both on
Chrome and Firefox now so you can
install this extension as a Chrome
extension or as an add-on on your
Firefox browser it's a completely
revamped version which was done by apply
tools they literally rewrote the
complete code and now they have made it
available on the GitHub under the Apache
2.0 license and it also comes with many
new features now like reusability of
test cases it has a better debugging
technology now and most importantly it
supports parallel test execution it has
introduced an utility called selenium
side Runner that allows your test cases
to run on any browser so you can create
your automation using your idea on
Chrome or Firefox however through this
side runner from your command prompt you
can execute any of your test cases on
any browser of your chest and thus by
achieving your cross browser testing you
can also run parallel testing using grid
without writing any specific code to do
this again this can be done using the
selenium site Runner and having the grid
installation done so let's look at how
IDE looks like and what are its
components are and how do we work with
ITV let's go to the Firefox browser now
and launch the ID and see how the ID
looks so let me go to my Firefox now on
this browser if you can see here there
is an icon here which says selenium ID
and this appears after you go ahead and
install the selenium ID plugin so now
I'll just go click on this and then I
already have a project created so this
is the ID window which gets open for I
have a pre-recorded script here and what
the script does is I just open amazon.in
website and I am searching for the
product iPhone also I have an assertion
statement here which asserts for the web
page title and then I am closing the
browser so let's first execute the
script and see how it works and then we
will get into the details of what are
the different components available on
this ID so for me to execute what I will
do is it a ID has a very beautiful
feature here to control the speed of the
execution so what I'll do is I'll reduce
the speed a little bit so that you
should be able to see the complete
execution step by step now to execute
the script I'll just go here and say run
current test so this opens the Firefox
window and the amazon.in website it
should search for iPhone product now
then it is going to do the title
assertion and close the browser so if
you look here all the statements look in
green now so that means every step has
been executed successfully and there are
no errors so now let's look at the
components of this ID so the first
component which you need to understand
is how do you record the test so there
is a start recording button made
Available to You clicking on which you
can launch any website of the
application under test and you can start
recording your steps and once you have
recorded you can use this play button
which is nothing but your run current
test button to execute your test so if
you want to execute multiple tests then
you have an option to do so here which
says run or tests this particular window
what you're saying here right so this is
the window where you have all your
commands which gets recorded when you
record your script and these are pretty
simple commands and they're very
self-explanatory let's say for example
open so it says open and the target is
amazon.in that means it is giving
instruction to your browser to open this
particular website setting the window
size clicking on a button so this is the
search button which we have and then
typing what is the product which you're
searching for and then you have multiple
assert statements made available to you
on this idle so these are all called as
the selenis command and as simple as a
close browser command and now if you
look here in this window this is log
window so every step which gets executed
here there is a log generated showing
you the status of the execution of that
step so if it all there is a failure you
would see a red failed Mark against that
particular step and the test case will
not say completed successfully it will
say the failure occurred okay so it is
very simple and very user friendly kind
of an ID so let's go back to our
presentation so we saw the play button
here and we saw how to record it I also
showed you the commands the command
window what we have so these are the
selenium commands and then we saw the
log which indicated the execution of
each of this command now saving the
script so let me go back to the ID again
so once you have created your test
scripts you have run it successfully you
need to save your project so for you to
save the project when you click on the
save project every ID project it is
saved with an extension dot Sid which is
nothing but selenium ID so you just go
ahead and click on Save since I've
already saved this project I'm going to
just say cancel so that's the x file
extension it uses to save your project
for more details on how to use IDE you
can watch our video on selenium ID on
Sim learn.com selenium RC this is
selenium remote control so this was
developed by Paul Hammond and he
refactored the code and was also
credited with Json as a co-creator of
selenium RC is used to write web
application test in different
programming language the server itself
is written in Java language it supports
multiple programming languages like Java
C sharp Pearl Python and PHP it
interacts with a browser with the help
of RC server it uses a simple HTTP get
and post request for communication this
RC server is also a selenium 1.0 version
but it got deprecated in selenium 2.0
and was completely removed in 3.2 and it
got replaced by selenium Webdriver we
will see why this happened when we talk
about the selenium web driver this is
the architecture of selenium remote
control so when Jason Huggins introduced
selenium the tool was JavaScript program
and he called it as JavaScript test
Runner and it is also called a selenium
core so every HTML has this JavaScript
statements which are executed by this
web browser there is a JavaScript engine
which helps in executing this command
now this had a major issue of something
called a same origin policy now what is
the same origin policy same origin
policy prohibits your JavaScript from
accessing elements or interacting with
the scripts from the domain different
from where it is launched and this was
for the security measure for example
every web page inside google.com domain
like say your search email Google Drive
can be accessible but nothing outside
this domain like say if you want to
access Yahoo or an Amazon that was not
possible due to security reasons
obviously so the testers had to install
the selenium core and the web server
which contained your web application
which you are basically testing on the
same system and this was not feasible
and effective all the time now to
overcome this to overcome the same
origin policy what Paul Hammond did was
he created something called as this
remote server which is selenium remote
control server and it acted like a proxy
to trick the browser in believing that
your core which is your selenium core
and your web application under test are
on the same domain this thus by
eliminating your same origin policy and
this was called as your selenium remote
control which was a version one of
selenium now if you look at the simple
architecture of this what are the things
it has so one is your script right first
you need to write your scripts using any
supported language like say PHP Java
Python and Ruby as I mentioned now
before we start the testing what is the
requirement of the selenium one version
is you need to install the RC server now
this RC server is a separate application
so once you install this this selenium
server is responsible for receiving the
selenis commands now these are the
selenis commands which you have written
in a scripts it interprets them and it
executes it on your browser and the
results are sent back to your test
script and this browser interaction
happens only through this RC server
again as I said using a simple HTTP get
and post request to communicate now upon
receiving these instructions right from
the selenium core the response is sent
back to this RC server from your browser
and back to your test scripts so the
cycle starts from your test scripts the
selling these commands are interpreted
by your RC server those are sent to the
browser and it's a simple JavaScript
which executed on your browser and the
results after the execution are sent
back to your test scripts through your
RC server this is a simple cycle now
this cycle is repeated for every command
written in your test script until your
complete test case is executed okay so
this is how the RC worked now this RC
had few shortcomings and what are those
one is the architecture of this RC
itself was complicated why because of
this intermediate RC server which we
have between the browser and your test
script and this RC server had to be
installed before running any test
scripts so that means this became an
additional setup and it acts as a
mediator between your selenium commands
and your browser also the execution of
commands takes a very long time it is
pretty slow why because every command it
needs to make a full trip from your test
script to your RC server to the core and
to the browser execute the script and
then again back in the same line which
makes your overall test execution very
slow and now because of this shortfalls
Webdriver was introduced so selenium
Webdriver selenium webdrivers were
introduced by a gentleman called Simon
Stewart and it was developed in the year
2006. it is the first cross-platform
testing framework it is a programming
interface to create and run test cases
it makes provision to act on web
elements so basically there are multiple
locating techniques with selenium
Webdriver provides us for finding those
elements and to perform operations on
those web elements Webdriver does not
require a core engine like RC and it
interacts natively with the browser
application so there is a direct
interaction with your browser
application and it eliminates the need
of having that intermediate RC server
and that makes the architecture pretty
simple this Webdriver again it supports
multiple languages which we already
talked about and also it has integration
with multiple Frameworks so once you
understand how the web driver Works what
are its functionalities and what are the
drawbacks you will appreciate the fact
that so how does selenium Webdriver
overcomes this even in Webdriver we have
test scripts we also have a web browser
here and then we have a web driver
however what we do not have this
additional server which RC required and
this makes the architecture of the web
driver simpler the browser is controlled
directly from the operating system level
now due to this direct communication the
speed of test execution is much faster
than RC now how does this web driver
work so we have something called as
client libraries or the language
bindings so we know now that selenium
supports multiple languages and you're
free to use any supported language to
create your automation script and where
are these libraries available so if you
go to
seleniumhq.org so let me go to the
browser and show you that so in the
selenium hq.r if you go to the downloads
so here you will see something called as
selenium client and Webdriver language
binding and depending on the language
which you want to work with or which you
want to create test scriptures you can
download this client libraries so if
you're working with Java download the
client library for Java so if you're
working with python you have a
corresponding link which you through
which you can download your client
libraries and then selenium provides a
lot of apis for us to interact with the
browser and these are called as the rest
apis so then we have the browser drivers
through which we interact with the
browser now what are these browser
drivers so there are drivers specific to
each browser so let me show you that on
our
seleniumhq.org so here if you just
scroll down you have something called as
third party drivers bindings and plugins
for every supported browser of selenium
you have a corresponding driver file
available now say for example if you
want to work with Firefox Mozilla gecko
driver is what you need to download and
these driver files so if you go and
click here you will get an executable
driver file for any of the platforms
which you are working so if you're
working on Windows Mac OS or Linux you
can just download the corresponding
driver files here so these drivers see
these driver files are the ones which
interact with the actual browser and how
does this happen this driver establishes
the connection with the real browser
without revealing the internal logic of
the browser functionality now what does
that mean say we want to execute a test
script and how does this test script
gets executed first is it it sends an
HTTP request which is generated and sent
to this browser driver which we just saw
for each of the command in your scripts
and then this driver receives the
request through your HTTP server and
this HP HTTP server does all the
execution directly on the browser and
then the execution status the complete
status is sent back to your test script
so let me show you a simple use case how
it works with the Webdriver so for that
let's go to my Eclipse here so I already
have a test script written here in
Webdriver and what this basically does
is it launches amazon.com amazon.in
website it uses the Firefox browser and
then I'm also fetching the page title
and printing it on the console and then
I'm closing the browser this is a simple
functionality which I'm doing here so if
you look here so the eclipse is the ID
which I'm using I've already installed
selenium here and I've written a simple
Java class and this Java class we have
multiple methods one is to launch
browser one is to fetch the title of the
page and one is to close the browser now
while launching the browser I set every
browser has its own driver files so
somewhere in this Java class I need to
tell selenium as which browser to use
and how is that done that is done by
this first two statements here where I
am doing a system.set property and where
I'm indicating that this is my driver
file which is gecko driver to be used
and using this I want the selenium to
launch the Firefox browser and after
this all the operations any operations
which you want to perform on your web
application under test you can do it
here now let's go ahead and execute this
and see how it works so simply what I
need to do is I'll just say execute this
as a Java program so the Firefox browser
is getting launched so you can see
amazon.in being launched here and since
we are not doing any operations here
what I am simply doing is printing the
title of the page and closing the
browser that is it so if you see here
you can see the page title is online
shopping site so and so and this is what
I'm printing through this method which
is fetch page title a very simple way of
writing a automation script using
Webdriver so now you saw how we write a
small test script using the Webdriver
function now say if I want to run the
script on multiple browsers and on
multiple operating system and I do not
have just one test case I say say I've
got hundreds of test cases now with this
approach what you can achieve your best
is you can sequentially execute on every
browser available and all your 100 or
200 test cases whatever you have now
this is going to take quite a long time
to execute and hence to reduce the time
taken for the execution selenium has
something called as grid selenium grid
the main objective of the grid is to
minimize your test execution time this
grid is designed to distribute commands
to different machines simultaneously in
real time environment you always have
the need to run test cases in a
distributed environment for example a
web application for which say you have
automated thousands of test cases and
you want to run them as a regression
Suite across multiple browsers and Os
what you need to do is you need to run
them parallely and not really
sequentially so grid allows this
parallel execution of test on different
browsers and operating system you also
want an integration with reporting tools
so that you can get a Consolidated
report after the tests have been
executed on multiple machines so grid
can be integrated with such many other
tools how does the grid work so grid has
this Hub and node concept which helps in
achieving the parallel execution let's
take an example say again your
application supports all browsers and it
also supports different OS like the one
which you're seeing here like Windows
Mac and Linux and your requirement is to
run tests on all the supported browsers
and operating system like this one so
what you do here is you configure a
Master machine that is this which is
also called as Hub by running something
called a selenium Standalone server and
this selenium Standalone server can be
downloaded downloaded from your selenium
HQ website so let me show you that let's
go to my browser and in the downloads
here if you see selenium Standalone
server version
3.1.4.5 and this is what you need to
download so using the server you create
a hub configuration like this once you
do this you also need to create nodes
specific to your requirement like a
Windows 10 like a Mac machine with
Firefox with the Windows 8 with a chrome
and Mac say with Safari browser and the
node configuration is also done using
the same server which is the selenium
Standalone server so you create a node
configuration on this node machines so
once you have the setup created through
your master that is your Hub you can
control on which nodes you want to
execute which test say for example here
say you want to run some test on your
Mac machine with Safari browser only so
you have a kind of smoked a switch you
need to run now through the master you
can control this complete execution so
what Master does it it selects this
particular node depending on the
configuration which you have set on the
Master machine also you could have
multiple possible combinations like say
I want to just run smoke test on all my
notes I want to run specific component
tests on say only Windows 10 with an
edge browser or I can say I want to just
run my complete regression Suite but
only on Mac machine and so on and all
this is controlled through your master
so what happens on the Node once it gets
the command from the master the node
actually runs the specified test on the
browser so you can check out our
detailed video on selenium grid for you
to understand how the grid works and how
do we do this configuration and execute
the test to summarize the selenium
versions selenium version 1 comprised of
an ID RC and grid as we discussed
earlier RC was on its path of
deprecation and Webdriver was taking
birth so selenium 2 had an earlier
version of Webdriver and also RC existed
from 3.0 onwards RC was completely
removed and Webdriver took its place
also there's a four dot version around
the corner it has more features and
enhancements so some of the features
which is expected are like w3c Webdriver
standardization they have an improved
idea and also I believe there are some
improvements done to the grid advantages
of selenium speed in accuracy see since
there is no manual execution your test
can run faster and with grid it helps in
parallel execution so you can actually
execute large volume of test cases
within a short frame for example let's
say before your release of product
during your last lap of testing you find
a bug and it has to be fixed so the
developer fixes the bug and what you
want to do is you want to run all the
test cases pertaining to that area can
you imagine the amount of time which
will be required if you have to do this
manually but by automation you can
achieve this in a short duration of time
and you can also enable releasing your
product in time and with less or no
human error the second Advantage is it's
an open source so it's available free of
cost and anyone can download and start
using it supports a wide spectrum of
programming languages it is not
restricted to any particular programming
language whatever language you are
comfortable with you have an option to
use that and to write your selenium
scripts selenium has support for almost
all browsers and operating system
including a headless browser so this
helps you to create test cases once and
run them across all browsers and
operating system and thus saving your
time for manual execution it also helps
in achieving a broad test coverage it's
a pretty easy to use tool you can check
out all our videos and you can just
Master the skill of writing automation
scripts reusability and add-ons of
course like any programming languages it
provides you a mechanism to reuse your
code and avoid redundancy limitations so
like any other tool selenium also has
certain limitations so let's look at
what they are and see if there are any
workarounds also since selenium is an
open source you do not have much
technical support available however
there are loads of documentation
materials forums available which you can
refer to this tool is for automating web
application it cannot handle mobile
application or desktop application
automation however what selenium
provides is a support for integrating
tools like APM tool for mobile testing
selenium is not very good with image
testing since especially it is designed
for web application automation but then
we again have many other tools which can
be integrated with selenium like Auto it
and cql selenium again has a limited
reporting capability it can help create
basic reports but we definitely need
more so it provides supports for tools
like test NG report NG extent reports
which you can integrate and generate
beautiful reports powerful isn't it of
course it does not have a test
management capability a tool need not
have all these capabilities but again
you can integrate with the test
management tool used in your
organization since selenium supports
multiple programming language the
developer of the automation script need
to have some basic knowledge of any
programming language to write effective
automation scripts of course a deep
Advanced knowledge is not required a
basic knowledge is more than sub issue
so if you look at all the selenium still
provides a complete solution for your
automation need and that's the beauty of
selenium and that is what makes it the
most popular today most popular tool
today for Automation in this video we
will look at how to install selenium on
Windows system selenium installation is
a three-step process so it has certain
prereqs the first prerequis you need to
have Java on your system so we will be
installing Java first and then we will
be working with Eclipse ID so we will be
installing eclipse and then we will
install selenium for Java we will
install the version Java 8 and for
Eclipse we have a version 4.10 this was
the last stable version which was
released in December last year so I'll
be using that version and selenium we
will download the latest 3.14 version
okay so let's get started with our first
step which is the Java installation so
to install Java let's go to the browser
and simply just search for Java 8
download
so now you will see that there is an
oracle site which is listed there and
that is where you would be downloading
all your Java package so go ahead and
click on that and for you to download
any jdk package from the Oracle site you
need to create an account so if you
already have one you just need to log in
using that account and then you can
download any of the jdkits and if you do
not have one please go ahead create a
new account on the Oracle log into that
account and then you can just download
the Java it so since I already have an
account and I have already downloaded
the package but I'll show you how and
where to download it from so in this
page if you scroll down so you will see
this Java development kit 8211 so this
is the version we'll be downloading it
so click on the accept license agreement
and then since we are working on the
Windows system today so we will be
downloading this the windows package so
just click on that and it will get
downloaded in your downloaded folder and
as I said I've already downloaded the
packages so here it is what I've done is
I've just created a directory called
installers and I'm going to be keeping
all my installables here so here I have
a folder called Java installer and this
is where my installable is so now that
we have this file so we will just go
ahead double click on that and launch
this installer the installer is launched
and just click on run so this will take
a few minutes to install Java the
installer is launched now just click on
the next button here so here for the
installation directory you can change
the directory to the choice of whatever
drive and the folder structure you want
to I would like to leave it as default
here and we'll just go and click on next
and then the Java installation is in
progress so let's wait until this is
completed it really shouldn't take too
much time maybe just a few more minutes
here
okay accept the license term just click
on next we leave the destination folder
as it is
so jdk8 is successfully installed on
your system so close the installer now
and let's go ahead and check whether the
installation is done properly so for
that what I'll do is I'll go to my
command prompt and I'll just say Java
minus version so it says Java version
1.8 and this tells us that the Java is
installed successfully now after this
installation there are couple of
configurations which we need to do and
what are those configuration one is you
need to set the path variable and then
we are also going to set a Java home
directory so for that first let's go
ahead and check where is the Java
installed actually let's figure out the
directory first so if you remember the
directory structure where the Java got
installed was in program files Java I
have there are certain previous versions
which are installed and then uninstalled
it so that is why you see some residuals
here sitting here that's not worry too
much about that instead let me go to the
latest one what I have installed which
is this okay and there is a bin folder
here and this is the path which we need
to set in our path variable so what I
will do is I'll just copy this path and
then go to your control panel here go to
your where is my system yeah so click on
the system go to Advanced system setting
and here in the environment variables
find the PATH variable okay and then say
edit now what are we doing here in the
path variable is we are going to add the
Java bin directory to the path be very
careful whenever you are editing your
path variable do not overwrite anything
always go into the edit mode go towards
the end here and then just say Ctrl V
paste the path which you have just
copied from the Explorer window that's
it now just say okay done so your path
setting is done so what's the next one
we need to do we need to add a new
environment variable called the Java now
what I'll do for that is I just say new
I'll just type Java home here and what
is the value of this we need to set we
need to set the same path but without
the print directory so we just need to
set the path till your Java directory
that is this so we'll just copy the path
again and paste it here that is off just
say Okay click on Okay click on OK here
and we are done so again let's go to our
Command Prompt and just say Java minus
version
so everything seems to be fine so now
successfully we have installed Java on
the system so what is our next
installation step what we have now we
need to install the eclipse so let's go
back to the browser again so to download
Eclipse we will be downloading the
package from the eclipse.org so when you
go here to eclipse.r you can see the
latest version which is available and
the latest version available when this
video was made was 20906 so especially
with Eclipse since it's an open source I
prefer to work with the last stable
version and so does most of the
developers do and hence that is the
reason why I have picked up the version
which is like last year's version which
is 4.10 which was released in last
December so you can always choose to go
with the latest version but then if
there are any issues and if you are like
first time working with the eclipse
you're going to get confused as where
this issues are coming from right so I
would still recommend that you use the
last stable version which is available
with your Eclipse so now to get the last
stable version what you need to do is go
and click on this download packages and
here if to scroll down this page you can
see here more downloads so there is a
list of all the previous releases of app
Clips which is available and this is
what we need to download so just click
on that 4.10 version and then click on
the OS on which you want to install
eclipse for us it is Windows so I'll
just click here on the 64-bit windows
and then click on the download and you
will be downloading the complete package
so once you download this is what it
will look like so let's go back to our
directory of installers so this is the
installer for the Eclipse which I got
now what's the next step I need to do
just launch this installer and install
Eclipse so I'll just say double click on
this I'll say run
so here you will see multiple options
here for Eclipse installation so
depending on your requirement you can go
ahead and install any of these packages
so for us we just need an eclipse ID for
Java developer so I'll select this and
I'll say install so again you'll have a
choice of directory where you want to
install so I have chosen D drive here
this is a default directory name it
takes which is okay we can leave it as
it is and then also you have an option
to create a start menu entry and desktop
shortcut so just leave the default
selection as it is and go ahead and
click on install so this will take a
while to install the eclipse
just say select all you can close this
window just say select all and accept it
okay so the installation has been
completed successfully so let's go and
click on this launch and let's see the
first window what opens
when you launch the eclipse you need to
specify a workspace directory now what
is this workspace directory so this is a
directory or a folder wherein all the
Java files or any programs or any
artifacts which you're going to create
through Eclipse will be stored in this
particular folder so this could be any
location on your system so this is you
can go ahead browse the location and
change it so for in our case what we
will do is I'll go to the D drive and I
already have a directory so here I'll
create I'll just create select this
folder and then create a folder called
workspace I'll say my workspace and then
I'll say launch so every time I open the
eclipse right so if this is going to
take as my default workspace and all my
programs all my javascripts all my
automation scripts are getting are going
to be stored in this particular location
so we'll say launch
so this is a welcome window which opens
we can just close this and there we go
the eclipse is open with a certain
perspective so there are certain Windows
here which we do not need let's just
close them so now the first thing what
you do after launching the eclipse is go
ahead and create a new project so I'll
say file new and since I'm going to be
using Java with selenia I'll say create
Java project so give a project name
let's say my first project now you have
an option here to select the JRE which
you want to use so we just install this
jdk 1.8 okay so I'm going to click on
use default GRE otherwise you also have
an option to use a Project Specific gr
for example I could have two different
projects where one project I'm going to
be working with GRE 1.8 and there is
another project which I want to work
with the latest Java maybe Java 12 and I
can have more than one Java installed on
the machine so this gives me an option
to select whichever Java I want to work
with so if you have another Java
installed here it will show up in this
list so and you can just go ahead and
select that now since we have only one
Java installed on our machine which is
Java 1.8 I will say use default GRE
which is 1.8 and I will click on finish
now if You observe this folder structure
the project which is created see all the
reference libraries to this particular
Java have been created here now we are
ready to create any kind of java
programs in this project so now we have
successfully done the second step of our
installation which is the eclipse
installation after this we need to
install the selenium so again let's go
back to the browser and see what files
we need to download to install selling
it so let me go to my browser and here I
will be going to the
seleniumhq.org so if you are working
with selenium this particular website
the seleniumhq.org is going to be a
Bible everything and anything related to
selenium is available in this website
whether you want to download the files
whether you want to refer to the
documentation anything regarding to
selenium is available here so what we
want now is the installables for
selenium so here go to the download tab
now for you to install selenium and
start working with selenium there are
three things which are required for you
to download one is a standalone selenium
server so this is not required
immediately when you get started with
selenium however when you start working
with remote selenium Webdriver you would
be requiring this when you have a grid
setup you will be requiring the
Standalone server so for that what you
can do is you can just download the
latest version available here so when
you click on that it will download the
file into your download folder so this
is one particular file which you need to
keep next selenium client and Webdriver
language bindings now in today's demo we
will be looking at selenium with Java so
that means my client package of java is
what I need to download so whatever
programming language selenium supports
we have respective downloadables
available with that so if you're working
with python then you need to download
your client library for Python and since
we are working with Java you need to
download this package so simply what you
need to do click on this link and it
will download the Java package for you
which are basically the jar files so we
have client libraries now and then there
is another component what we need now
with a linear you're going to be
automating your web browser applications
correct and you also want your
applications to run on multiple browsers
so that means your scripts the
automation scripts which you create
should be able to run on any browser
selenium works with multiple browsers
like Edge Safari Chrome Firefox and
other browsers even it has a support for
headless browser now every browser which
it supports comes with its own driver
file now say for example we want to say
work with Firefox driver so that means
for us to start working with Firefox
browser we need to download something
called as a gecko driver here and if you
want to work with Chrome browser you
need to install the Chrome driver so
depending on what browsers you'll be
testing with go ahead Click on each of
this link and download the latest driver
files now since we are going to be
working with Firefox in this demo what I
need to do is I just need to click here
on the latest lick so when I click on
the latest link it is going to take me
to this driver files so driver files are
specific to each of the operating system
so if you go down here you will see
there is a separate driver file
available for Linux for mac and for
Windows so depending on which operating
system where you'll be running your test
download that particular driver file and
this is the driver file I need because
we are working on Windows machine so
these are the three different packages
which we need to download from the
selenium hq.org for us to install
sending so let me show you the folder
where I have already downloaded all this
so if you see here selenium Java
3.141.59 okay this is nothing but our
client Library which we saw here let's
go back to the main page here that is
this so once I download this this is a
ZIP file after I unzip the file this is
the folder structure I see and let's see
what is there in this folder selector so
there are two jar files here and then in
the lips there are multiple jar files
and we will need all this to work with
selling it and then we also downloaded
the driver files so what I did was after
downloading those driver files for the
browser I created a directory here
called drivers and have kept all my
browser drivers here so I have a driver
if I downloaded for Chrome I want to
work with Firefox so I have a gecko
driver here and then for Internet
Explorer that's it so this is all we
need so once we have all this what you
need to do is go to your eclipse in the
eclipse right click on the project which
you have created and then go to the
build path and say configure build path
go to the libraries tab here now do you
see this JRE libraries here this is what
got installed first and now similarly we
are going to add the selenium Jazz to
this library and how do we add that on
your right you can see this add external
jars click on ADD external jars go to
your folder where you have downloaded
your selenium which is this select all
the jar files which is available so I
have two jar files here I'll just say
click open again I will click on ADD
external jars now from the lips folder I
will select all this five so select all
the five jars and click on open so you
should see all the seven jar files here
so once you have this just say apply and
close now if you look into your project
directory here you'll see some a folder
called referenced library and this is
where you will see all the selenium
charts here this is a very simple
installation in Eclipse when you want to
install selenium you just need to export
all the jars of the selenium into
eclipse and now your system is ready to
start working with selenium scripts all
right so now let's just test our
installation by writing a small selenium
test script so for that what I will do
is I'll go to the source folder right
click new and I'll say Java class so
let's name this as say first selenium
test and I will select this public
static white Main and I will click on
finish all right so now let's create a
use case say we want to launch a Firefox
browser and then we want to launch the
Amazon site so this will be just two
simple things which we will be doing in
this test script so for me to do that
what I usually do is I create a method
for any functionality which I want to
create here so now I want to do a launch
browser so I'll create a method here
called launch browser now whenever you
start writing your selenium scripts the
first line what you need to do is you
need to declare an object of Webdriver
class so here I'll say
Webdriver driver driver so now if you
hover over this error what it is showing
it says import web driver from or dot
open qa.cellaneous so if you remember
when we installed the selenium we
imported all these jars right so that
means what whenever we want to use a web
driver we need to import this class from
these packages so just go ahead and
click on this import State done now next
step now for us to launch a Firefox
browser it is a two steps process which
is involved here one is you need to set
the system property and then you need to
launch the driver so let's do that I'll
say system dot set property so use this
method set property so this takes two
arguments the key and the value pair now
what is the key I'm going to mention
here I am going to be mentioning the
gecko driver and the path for the gecko
driver okay because since I'm working
with the Firefox so in double quotes
I'll say Webdriver dot gecko dot driver
this is my key and the value is going to
be sorry the fully qualified path for
your driver files and you know know
where we have kept our driver files
let's go to that driver files in D colon
I have selenium tutorial in installers I
have driver folder okay so I'm just
going to copy the complete path from
here Ctrl C and I'll paste it here Ctrl
V along with this I need to provide the
file name for the gecko driver which is
gecko driver dot exe and let's complete
this step next so once I've set the
property I need to provide a command for
launching my Firefox driver and how do I
do that I simply use this driver object
which I have created driver equal to
new Firefox driver again similarly the
way we imported packages for Webdriver
we also need to import the package for
Firefox driver so just hover over the
mouse over that and select import
Firefox tracker with these two
statements we will be able to launch the
Firefox browser and as I said in our use
case what is the next thing we want to
do we want to launch say Amazon dot in
website for that there is a command in
selenium which says driver dot get and
you pass the URL here so for me to write
the URL what I usually do is I go to my
browser I open the website which I want
to work with in our case it's amazon.in
and I just simply copy this fully formed
URL go to my eclipse and just paste it
here now this ensures that I don't make
any mistakes in typing out the URL let's
complete the statement and we are done
and now in the main function I'll just
create an object of this and we will
call this method so I'll copy this class
for selenium test say obj equal to new
for selenium test and now I'll say say
obj dot this is our function launch
process so let's save this and execute
this Ctrl C right click run as Java
application okay so the Mozilla Firefox
has been launched now it should launch
your amazon.bingo so there goes our
first test script which runs
successfully in this session we will be
looking at how to install selenium on
your Mac machines
selenium installation on Mac is a
three-step installation one we need to
install Java which is a prereq and then
we need an ID to work with so we will be
installing eclipse and then we will
install selenium and these are the
versions of the installers which we are
going to use so we will be using Java 8.
Eclipse version 4.10 which was released
in 2018 December and then selenium
version 3.14
so let's get started with our first step
which is the Java installation
so for us to install Java let us go to
our browser
and simply what I'll do is I'll just
Google for Java 8 download
okay so we would select the Oracle site
for downloading the SD
okay so once you go here you can see
that we have something called as Java
software development kit 8 u211 so this
is the version we'll be working with so
in order for you to download you need to
have an oracle account so since I
already have one I have directly been
logged into that so if you do not have
an oracle account please go ahead create
an account for yourself so that you can
download any of the Java installers
now let's go for and download our
package so I'll be downloading this
package for that I need to click on
accept license agreement and then since
we are going to be working on Mac this
is the package which I'm going to
download so let's go ahead and click on
that
and now the download is going to start
however we will not wait for the
complete download to happen since I have
already downloaded the package and I
have kept it in one of my folders so let
me show you where that is
so let me go to my finder so what I have
done is I have created a folders called
installers and all the software which we
are going to require today for us to
work with selenium is what I have
downloaded it and kept it here so we'll
go step by step so that you understand
what each of these packages are so as
you see here I have the jdk 8 which I've
already downloaded so let's go ahead and
install jtk so how do we install jdk so
you have the DMG file here you just go
ahead and double click on that
okay and then I'll double click on this
package
and then we will say continue and
install
so it's going to ask me for my password
okay I've given my password and I'll say
install the software
probably it will just take a couple of
minutes to install Java okay there you
go so now the Java has been installed so
let me close this window let me close
this window too and then now I'll go to
my terminal window so let's open my
terminal and here
let's say Java minus version bingo so
there we have Java 1.8 installed on our
system now there are couple of other
things which you need to do apart from
installation of your jdk you also need
to set some system variables right so in
Mac how do you set the system variables
or the environment variables you do that
in your bash profile so let's see how we
do that all right so what I will do is
I'll use an editor which is my VI okay
and then I'll open my bash profile so
what is Bash profile it's a config file
for your bash cell this is mainly used
to export variables in your shell like
in Windows we are going to do the system
variable setting from the advanced
setting right so similarly we are going
to do that here so I'll say VI Dot bash
underscore profile so this is the file
where I will be adding Java home path
now I have other parts here already
written because I'm working with other
multiple software on this machines and
now I'll go to the end of this file and
I'll say
export
Java home
equal to now what is the path we need to
give for Java home we need to give the
path where the Java has been installed
on your system okay first let's go and
find out that path so let's go back to
our finder
and then I have a folder called Library
here so here
there is a Java and then there is
something called as Java virtual
machines so if you have a single Java or
multiple Java versions installed so all
those versions you're going to see under
this directory which is Java virtual
machines and Java one dot is is what we
install just now so let me go and open
that folder there is something called as
content and then home and in this you
have your JRE and Bin folder so that
means I need to give my Java Home Path
until here till this home directory so
simply what I'm going to do is I'll just
go here say get info because I want to
just copy the path and what you can do
is you copy this path
okay and then go back to your shell
and here I'm going to paste this path
plus I want to tell the home directory
so I'm just going to type out homie home
that is it so you have now set your Java
home environment variable so simply you
do
save the file Escape colon WQ and come
out of it and now what you need to do
for this batch profile uh to be
activated you just exit out of this
terminal okay close this terminal window
and I'll go ahead and open another
terminal so let me close this info text
so here let me again give Java minus
version
okay so everything seems to be working
fine so this completes our Java
installation now your system is ready
and you have your Java up and running
other thing which you also can do is go
to your system preferences okay here you
will see this Java control panel okay
this is another way of finding out that
your Java has been installed
successfully on the machine so you can
just open this Java control panel and if
there is any settings which you want to
do here you can do it through your
control panel also
on it
let's close this
let's minimize this window
and this folder Windows
so we have successfully done our step
one so what's our step two we need to go
ahead and install the eclipse now same
thing what I will do I'll go to my
browser
okay and now I'll open another tab here
and I'll say
Eclipse download
and we'll go to this eclipse.org
now here whenever you're going to do
this installation you will see the
latest version appears here my
recommendation to you is instead of if
you're working first time instead of
working on the latest version available
I would suggest that you work with the
last stable version and that's exactly
what we are going to do today so for me
to go to the previous versions I just
need to go here on this download
packages click on it
okay so once you click on that on this
page if you scroll down you will see
something called as more downloads right
in this you will see all the bills of
Eclipse which is available all your
previous versions So since today I'll be
working with 4.10 version I will go
ahead and click on this 4.10 this 4.10
was released last year this is 2018
December okay and now when you look at
this installer you have multiple
packages available here so depending on
your need you can choose which package
you want to work with so today for our
demo what I would be using is Eclipse ID
for Java developers
so since we are going to be working on
Mac I will go ahead and click on this
downloadable
and then I'll click on this download
which is going to download this
particular file for me I've already
downloaded this file and kept it in my
folder
let's go to my folder
okay it's not opening so let me click
from here
and then let's go to our selenium demo
folder and in that installer okay so now
do you see this Eclipse Java 2018-12 are
blah blah blah dot DMG so this is the
file which we're going to be using to
install Eclipse now as simple as what we
did for jdk I'm going to double click on
this and install the eclipse let's see
how the eclipse gets installed
all right so now I'll just move this
folder into applications
done so my eclipse is ready now so
simply let's go ahead and launch so what
I'll do I'll just simply search for that
on my system Eclipse there you go and
I'll just double click this
is an application downloaded from the
internet are you sure you want to open
it yes please go ahead and open it
okay it is launching it so did you see
how simple the eclipse installation is
it's just downloading the package I'm
just installing it on your Mac machine
all right when you start the eclipse for
the first time you need to set your
workspace so workspace is place where
you are going to keep all your folders
all your Java code or whatever you're
going to do in Eclipse all under that
particular directory
um so right now it gives me a default
directory rather what I will do is since
I have created a separate folder for our
demos I will go ahead and select that
folder which is my simply demo
and then in this I will add
a folder called
workspace
okay so that means in this particular
location whatever files I'm going to
create whatever code I'm going to write
in selenium is going to be stored at
this location and then I'll go ahead and
say launch so it'll take a minute to
load your workbench yeah there it goes
so when you launch your Eclipse right so
let me just make this window bigger the
first screen what you are going to see
is the welcome screen
just go ahead and choose the welcome
script and this is the first view of
your eclipse what you're going to get so
let's close out all the windows which we
are not going to be working today and I
just need this main screen here now what
is the first step you're going to do
once you have the eclipse I would go
ahead and create a project first so I'll
simply say open file new Java project
let's give a nice name to this since
this is our first project which is going
to be created so I'll say selenium
first project
now if You observe here
so we have a jdk already installed and
Eclipse needs a jdk to work with and
what it has done while I create my new
project it has already given me an
option to use the execution JRE which
you already have in the system okay
that's why it is already chosen Java one
dot it in case you have multiple Javas
installed in in that case what you can
do is you can always go here select this
and select the Java of your choice so
say if you've got the latest Java which
is Java 12 installed on your system it
will give you an option here along with
Java software 8 it will give you Java 12
here so you can go ahead and select that
for this particular project that option
is also available now since we have only
one jtk installed here I will go ahead
and create this project
so I'll just click on finish and it's
going to create a projection so there
are few default things which it creates
created one is definitely the Jr system
libraries right this is what we told
Eclipse when we created project that my
Java is 1.8 so what it has done is it
has imported all this jar file which it
requires for our Java programs to work
in our Eclipse ID and then it creates a
SRC which is your Source directory
wherein where we'll be creating all our
Java code or our selenium test scripts
okay good so far so this is a simple way
of installing your eclipse and getting
your Eclipse ready to work with your
Selena all right so now let's go back
so we have done the installation of java
we have done the installation of eclipse
now what's left just the selenium right
right so what is that we need for
selenium let's go back to our browser
okay and this time we will go to
selenium
HQ dot OT
so this is going to be a Bible for you
if you're going to be working with
Selena so in this website what I do is I
go to downloads
and there are two things which we need
to download for us to work with Selena
one is the selenium Standalone server
right so when you're going to be working
with remote selenium Webdriver is when
you would require this however I would
suggest that we download whatever is
required for us even though we might not
use it immediately so what I just need
to do is I need to click on this and
it's going to download This Server form
okay so I have already downloaded it and
I'll show you that and then what we need
is the selenium client and web driver
language findings okay we need a client
so what is the client which you are
going to work with we are going to
working with Java client with the
selling it and for that I need to go
ahead and download this if you're
working on say C sharp or a ruby or
python then you have the respective
packages which you can go and download
now since we are going to be working
with Java here I would go ahead and
click on this and this is going to
download the Java client firmly now as I
said since I've already downloaded it so
let's go ahead and look at what are
those downloadables what we have so
let's close out this window now if you
see here uh one is the selenium server
Standalone which we just downloaded and
then when you download the client
libraries what it does it it creates a
zip file it downloads a zip file and it
unzips it and what is contained in that
particular folder so if you look here
selenium Java 3. in this folder you have
multiple jar files with which is what we
will be working with cellular so here
you have two jar files here and then
under the folder Labs you have other jar
files now these are the files which we
will need and now let's see how do we
utilize this file in our eclipse so for
that let's go back to our Eclipse okay
so let me maximize this window so in
Eclipse first thing what you need to do
is click on your project okay right
click on that
and then you have something called as
build path go to the build path and say
configure build path now here in this
configured build path what you need to
do is go to your libraries okay go to
add external jars
now when you click on that this is where
you need to select all your jar files
from what you have downloaded from the
selenium site so that is present in our
selenium Java 3. so what I'll do I'll
simply select
these two first
okay
then again you click on the external jar
file so what we have is in lips so
select all the jar files in the lip say
open okay you have all the jar files
what we need identified it go ahead and
click on apply and close once you do
that how do you know whether all those
jars have been imported correctly go to
the reference libraries here you should
be able to see all the selenium jars
which we have downloaded to be listed
out here and so it lists here so that
means we have successfully imported
selling to test our installation let's
go ahead and write a small test script
so for that I'll go to my source folder
right click new and we'll create a Java
class so let's name it
selenium
first test and I will also use a public
static word menu and I'll click on
finish
let's remove all these comments here
which we do not need so before even we
write a first line of code first what we
need to do is create an object of web
driver so I'll say web driver driver
okay so now if you see this error it
asks us to import this particular
Webdriver class from a package and that
package is org dot open QA dot selling
okay so now you can see this import
statement
now let's go ahead and write our test
case now for this test case what we will
do is we will simply launch a browser
say Firefox browser and we will also
launch a website now I'll create a
method for that I'll say public void
launch browser
so if you have looked at our previous
videos on selenium Webdriver Basics I
have explained there that every browser
which you want to work with in selenium
comes with its own driver and this
driver is what we need to download from
the website of selenium and I'll show
you how to do that so if we go to that
seleniumhq.org under the downloads tab
if you go down you will see something
called as third party drivers bindings
and plugins so all the browsers
supported by selenium are listed here
and their corresponding driver files are
available so now since we are going to
be working with Firefox in this demo I
will go ahead and click on this latest
release of Mozilla gecko driver so gecko
driver is the one which will be using
for launching or Firefox so just click
on this and this will take you to the
latest version of the gecko driver
available so just scroll down and
depending on the OS which you're working
with in our case it is a Mac OS so just
click on this file and download this
file
similarly
say if you are working with the Chrome
driver what you need to do is go to this
chrome driver go to the latest click on
that and select the release which you
want to work with and just download it
now I've already downloaded this file
and I'll just show you where they are
all right so in this directory which is
my installers directory I have another
directory created called as drivers and
what I do is usually I keep all my
driver files under this folder okay so I
have a chrome driver and gecko driver
already downloaded in kept it
now let's go back to our code and see
what is that we need to do to launch our
browser so there are two steps which we
need to do for launching any browser
which you want to work with Okay first
is you need to set a system property for
that what I do is
system
dot set property
and this accepts a key and value here
now key for this is gecko driver is what
I need to provide here and now that is
in the course because it's a string
argument I say Webdriver Dot
gecko dot driver
and the value is nothing but the path to
your gecko driver which you have just
downloaded okay let's go to my finder so
that's here so what I do is I simply
right click on this file get info and I
copy this complete path
go to my eclipse
paste this path here and then the file
name which is gecko driver
that so this sets a path to my gecko
driver now next step is actually
launching the web browser and how do I
do that I say driver
equal to Mu
Firefox driver
now we need to do the same thing again
we need to import this class so I say
import Firefox driver
all right so now with these two steps
what we do is we simply launch the
Firefox browser and then let's go ahead
and also launch a website say amazon.in
so for that I have a command called
driver.get
which accepts a URL now this URL needs
to be fully formula so for that what I
do first is I go to my any browser I
launch the amazon.in website okay and
then I copy this complete URL
go to my eclipse and just paste it here
that's it we are ready to launch the
browser and launch amazon.in so let's
quickly create a class here object here
of this class so selenium first test
obj equal to new selenium first test
done and then I need to call the method
which is launch browser
okay so now I save this file I do a
right click on this and I say run as
Java application now this should launch
your browser
okay which adjusted and then it should
take us to amazon.in bingo there goes
our first script so we have successfully
executed our first script so that means
your selenium is up and running
successful
let's talk about automation Frameworks
okay so guys to be precise with you I'll
be talking about the automation
framework when we will start automation
but as that's a part of the organization
Basics so file just will give you a
basic
knowledge of it and that's what
automation framework is and then we'll
be seeing how we will be going to create
a framework so first of all what is
automation framework
so it's a set of protocols rules such as
coding standards object repository and
data hand
and beneficial in terms of code we use
portability maintenance
the framework provides the basis of test
automation simplifies the automation
effort so that happens actually when we
need this automation suppose you are
automating only one functionality you
have written only one test script of
course you don't require to write an
automation framework for this
because there's only one script if there
is any there is any change comes you can
go ahead and make the change and run but
when this first script one one
automation script becomes hundred then
it becomes very difficult to manage them
suppose in 100 test case 100 test
scripts there is a username and it's a
password so there is a username and
password in more than 10 test Scripts
and that happens then and if there is
any change comes in the password or in
the username you may have to go to the
10 page script separately and make the
change which will be very cumbersome
process and it may be possible that you
make
you made an error okay it may be
possible that you you know somewhere you
have written something different
somewhere you'll be something different
or spelling error or space error may
have also if I talk about what you have
done you have created your scripts but
that is keeping in mind for Windows but
what if you have to run it on Linux and
you'll go back on all your scripts and
make that change what if you have
written your script for Firefox browser
and you may have to run it for Chrome
browser then it will be difficult to
make multiple changes so it's always
suggested that you create a framework
for that because framework is the one
which will help you out and solve all
these problems instead of writing one
thing again and again we will write it
only at one place and reuse that again
and again it will be very easy for us to
maintain it because that's in terms of
Frameworks that's in the framework where
you can make changes very easily the
portability so of course you have
written a lot of Windows and you can run
it on any other rotating system the
framework provides the basis of this
Automation and simplifies the automation
effort it is actually helpful when you
have multiple scripts for multiple test
cases so framework is very important and
that's the reason if you go and say that
you have done the automation or you have
a knowledge of automation you will
always ask you about the keyword there
are no they will not go in the basics
they will always go with the automation
so it's very important
so what are the automation Frameworks do
we have we have linear framework we have
structured framework data driven
framework keyword driven hybrid results
there are multiple types of Frameworks
we have what is the methodology for
automation first of all uh you know
methodology means how you decide whether
you need to automate or not so first of
all you take a decision whether this
project needs to be automated or not
because that is becoming very complex
you have 10 methodology you have Nest
resources all those things you have less
budget because of that you thought to
automate that when you have thought of
automating it what tool do you want to
use you think on that so you pick three
to four tools it certainly depends you
pick three to four tools create a proof
of concept
create a proof of concept guys are you
all aware what is proof of concept POC
obey is aware of that anyone who is not
aware of that can just say Engineers
heard of it question is aware of that
okay wait not created on my own yes
let's perfectly fine of course okay says
no so guys what is proof of concept is
whenever you are suppose you are
shortlisting samples you have multiple
automation tools in the market correct
so how do you decide whether which pool
is best for you of course you can go
ahead and you know take a list of tools
you can see pros and cons of those tools
but those pros and cons of the tools
depending on the Blogger the betting on
the editor who is writing about that
particular tool it may not be applicable
it may not be possible that those
advantages or disadvantages are actually
correct for your project so always what
we do we shortlist few tools like three
to four tools we develop or create a POC
ddpoc means you actually use those tools
to
automate one simple slip use
all three tools what you have
shortlisted two or to make a simple
script and then figure out the pros and
cons of that tool based on your
experience and based on what other
people say and then you create a PPT and
show it to the management and this is
the tools we have taken up this is the
POC this is how it works this is the
advantage this is a disadvantage and
then you shortlist one tool out of it
and that's what we call test tool
acquisition and it does not like uh you
are talking and we are learning scenario
and you will go ahead and say it's a
lady and that's it they will accept it
no you have to tell them that this is
the POC and this is the benefits of
opting selenium tool and then if they
are happy with that then they will go
ahead with that they will say go ahead
else they may ask you to come back or
for a bit more details and all this
stuff okay and it becomes very difficult
to you know uh to embrace your
management when there is an existing
tool running like qtp is running and you
wanted to suggest them selenium tool
then it becomes very difficult because
they may say that all the other projects
are working perfectly fine with the qtt
why should we go ahead with selenium
what is the best part that's what you
need to highlight and need to say that
these are the things which automate with
futurefield selenium you can do that so
that's where testual acquisition comes
then you do the test planning uh that
what all test cases should be automated
and start developing your test cases or
test descriptions then you execute them
and manage them then you show the result
of all those test cases and send it to
all the stakeholders then this is the
result
so in this video we will be looking in
detail about how the selenium ID works
so what is selenium ID selenium ID was
developed way back in 2006. it was
created to facilitate a simple record
and replay of the test automation so
record and replay tools were pretty much
invoked during this time and the main
advantage of using such tool was an
automation engineer was not really
required to know any knowledge of
programming he could just use this
record replay tool and create the
Automation and this IDE was available as
a Firefox extension so for one to use it
you need to just go ahead and install
the extension on Firefox and then use
its recording and record the steps of
your test execution it is a very simple
interface which helps in building the
automation scripts and how this works
you just need to start the recording on
ID perform your test steps on the
browser and these steps gets recorded in
the script and then what you could do is
you could export the script into say a
web driver or a j unit Ruby or any
javascripts and then you can use it now
however the record and replay tool is
not a very powerful automation tool and
hence this IDE is mainly used for
prototyping or you could say demo
purpose now since selenium Webdriver
itself offers such powerful capability
of creating robust scripts ID more or
less remains as a prototyping tool only
so in short as I said IDE is a part of
overall selenium set of tools and mainly
developed to speed up the creation of
test cases and what is the other
advantage of that one need not really
have any programming knowledge to use
this tool and mainly it is used for
writing some quick test for demo
purposes advancements with the new
selenium ID back in 2017 selenium ID
development was completely stopped the
last supported Firefox version where
this IDE was available as a plugin was
Firefox 54 and from 55 onwards the
complete integration point was removed
or it was completely broken however
recently applied tools help revamp much
of the selenium ID code they basically
rewrote the whole idea the code and then
now they have released a new version
under the Apache 2.0 license and it is
completely managed by the selenium
Community now let's look at some of the
features of this now traditionally the
selenium ID was only a Firefox plugin
however the new ID supports both the
browsers the Chrome and the Firefox and
thus making it cross browser so before
even we start looking at the other
features of the selenium ID I would like
to show you how do we install this
Firefox Plugin or the Chrome extension
so for that let me go to my Chrome
browser so in the Chrome Birds browser
what I'll simply do is I'll search for
selenium ID for Chrome so then let's go
to this chrome.google.com and here you
will see it as an extension selenium ID
so go ahead click on add to Chrome so
this will add this extension to your
Chrome browser so now it says selenium
ID has been added to the crew so how do
you make out if it is added so you can
see this particular icon here which says
selenium ID so this is the way you can
go ahead and install it on the Chrome
now on the Firefox I have already
installed it since we want to use the
Firefox as a browser for all the Demos
in this video so here again you can see
the selenium ID so if I click on this
IDE it is going to open a window for me
and the first window when it opens it
says either open a new project or open
an existing project or simply you can
start recording a new test case in which
case it creates a default project for
you first so what I will do is I'll say
open an existing project and I've
already got a project created so let me
go to my folder where I have this
project so I have this project created
and I've opened it I also have a simple
test case written now what this test
case does is let me show you here it
simply goes to google.com and then here
what I'm doing is I'm searching for
selenium HQ documentation and then I
click on this site which is
seleniumhq.org and docs so which should
take us to this particular website where
the documentation is available so this
is a simple script which I have tried to
write it in this ID so let's keep both
these windows open and let's go back to
our presentation to see the first
feature of this selenium ID the first
feature what it says is improved locator
functionality what are locators so these
are nothing but the techniques used for
locating your web elements on your
website now for example in our example
here now there are type here the type
which says name equal to Q so name equal
to Q is a locator now this is a locator
of what initially if you saw I went to
google.com and this is the search button
which I used right the search text and
then I said enter so this is nothing but
your web element for which the locator
is name equal to Q now what happens in
ID is when you record it it has taken
the attribute name and it is recognized
this particular web element using this
attribute however it also has a feature
wherein it also records its multiple
locators available for that particular
web element for example it also has a
CSS located it has an expat locator now
how does it help here say for example
tomorrow this particular attribute name
right for the search box if it changes
then what id does is when you execute
this test script it falls back on your
other locators mentioned here in the
structure and then if none of these
locators work only then the test case is
going to go and fail not otherwise so
how does this help this helps to make
the test cases more robust otherwise
having just one locator that is high
possibility the test case might break or
become pretty brittle as and when the
web elements change their attributes so
this is what the locating techniques are
and that is how they have improved the
locator techniques in the functionality
in the new ID now what's the next one
parallel execution is possible with this
new ID so the first IDE the traditional
one or the parallel execution was not
possible however this is a new feature
which has been added so we will be
looking in detail how to work with this
parallel execution later in this video
next is you can add control statement in
your scripts now what are these control
statements like if else while Loops for
each loops and even the switch case the
earlier ID also had this provision but
you had to install a plugin to enable
the use of this control statements and
now with this new ID it is available out
of box automatically waits for page to
load in any automation synchronization
between your application under test and
your automation scripts is very
important your script should not run
faster than your application otherwise
your scripts are going to start failing
so it is necessary to have enough load
times on the operations of your web
elements and also enough load times on
your page now this load time ensures
that all the elements of your web pages
and the page itself is loaded completely
before even a single line of script is
enough this new ID takes care of
providing that enough wait time and also
you have a global set speed option which
you can use to control your execution of
your scripts so that is something which
I will show you now so if I go back to
this so can you see this clock icon here
so it says test execution speed so what
you can do is right now it is set to the
fastest so I can actually control the
execution speed here so right now I've
just kept it a little slower so let's
see how our test scripts run so you'll
be able to see a remarkable difference
when I slow down the complete speed of
this so now do you see how slow it is
initially when I ran it you are unable
to see what I entered in the search
field of the Google right so now it's
clearly taking time on each of the steps
which we have mentioned there so now it
is executed successfully so next it
supports embedded code you can run a
simple JavaScript from your test script
right and how do you run that by using a
simple command called as execute now
let's see how do we do that so let's
take the same example here now after
clicking this okay so this is our ID so
what I will do is I'll first execute
this test case and then in the end where
I will show you how do we add a single
JavaScript and do some functions so let
me get the speed back to a little normal
because we do not want to waste too much
time so I'll just play the script once
so now we are in the selenium
documentation now if you look at this
page this is a pretty long one so now
I'm going to write a simple JavaScript
wherein I scroll down towards the end of
this page that's all I'm going to do now
for me to do that what I can do is in my
scripts itself I can just add another
line here okay here I will say add a new
command here I'll say execute script
which is my command and what is the
script which I want to execute it's a
Java Script which I'm going to write
here I'll say window dot scroll by and
I'm just going to mention some
coordinates here start from 0 and I'll
say one five zero zero okay this is all
my code is and now I'll simply run this
test again let's see what happens so
it's going to the documentation now it's
clicked on the link okay let's move down
do you see this initially it was right
here on the top of the page and and once
the JavaScript was executed it brought
me somewhere to the middle of this page
that is how you can insert a Snippets of
JavaScript and it has to be in context
with your currently selected window okay
and that's how you run it all right
let's go back to our PPT okay what's the
next feature so every IDE has a debugger
which allows step execution adding of
break points now apart from just having
a breakpoints or adding the step
execution there is another feature which
it provides called I will show you that
which is called as pause on exception so
let's close this window and let's just
keep this ID window open here right so
can you you see here pause button it
says pause on exception so what it does
is if you enable this button okay and
when you're running the script so if at
all there happens to be an exception in
your script it stops the execution at
that particular exception field and we
will see this in detail when we look at
complete debugger for the ID can be
integrated in CI since you can execute
scripts from some command line right we
also talked about the parallel execution
and you can also export the scripts to
any of the programming language you want
so since you can do that these scripts
can be run from command line and hence
they can also be integrated with your
Maven project and through gen Keys you
can run it and that's how you achieve
your CI working principle of selenium ID
selenium ID works on a very very simple
principle one is the recording it
records user interactions with the
browser and which forms basically your
ID script and using this ID script which
is a recorded script you execute the
script and verify and monitor for its
stability and success rate and thirdly
what you can do is you can simply save
your recorded script for your future
runs or regression testing and these
scripts can be saved either in the form
of an ID project itself or you can also
export these test scripts into the form
of a JavaScript or your Ruby scripts or
even the Webdriver scripts now let's
look at the components of this ID
interface itself the first one is the
menu bar so let's go back to our ID
window so here in the menu bar what you
can see is is a project name so either
you can edit the project name here or
you can simply create a new project open
an existing project and save the current
project okay so these are all the
options available and since we have
already created a project here I will
not be showing how to create a new
project so that we can do it little
later now next one is the toolbar so
this is the toolbar what we have here
for the ID now there are multiple
components in the toolbar so let's see
one by one so it says run all test now
if you have multiple test cases written
okay so this is an option where all the
tests can be run one after the other
this is to run your current test which
the focus is on So currently our focus
is on search so if I click on this
button it is going to execute the search
test for me IDE has this debugger option
where you can do a step execution right
you can do step-by-step execution using
this option we'll see how to do that for
example let's say we start from here
okay and I click click on this so what
it does is basically it has just
executed the first step for me so let's
keep this side by side so that we can
observe the complete execution now if I
go and press on this again step over
current command so that is the next
command it is going to execute now it
says type into this all right so now you
can see this is selenium HQ
documentation okay then again I say step
send Keys which it basically it said
enter and then it is going to click on
that documentation which it did and now
we have a script written which Scrolls
down on this particular page so let's
execute that and that is what it is so
this is how the step execution happens
so let's close this window and let's
come back to our ID window then we have
buttons here where you can say record or
you can stop recording okay then you can
pause the execution and then there are
other options available for disabling
breakpoint so basically you can add
break points any barrier so for example
if I want to add a breakpoint on the
click here so what I have to just do is
I have to just click here so this adds a
breakpoint and if you want to remove all
the spray point you just say disable
those break points so when you run the
script even though you have a breakpoint
available here for that particular run
your breakpoint will be disabled and
your execution will not stop at this
point and let's enable them for now and
what we will do is we'll just run the
script until there so now it has stopped
here at this click now from here either
you can execute the rest of the test
Case by just clicking on this run button
or you can stop the execution okay so
for now what we will do is we'll just
stop the execution so once you stop the
execution you will see that this is in
red which means that this particular
line was not executed or it failed
either of the things because you have
aborted at this particular line and the
rest of the things what you see in green
it shows that all these test steps have
been executed successfully so what is
our next component let's come back here
so we saw the menu bar here we saw the
toolbar we saw start and stop of
recording address bar now what is this
address bar so this address bar is where
you actually write your url from where
you want to start your recording and as
in when you start writing more and more
test cases it keeps a complete history
of all the websites which you're working
on next then we have a test script
editor box which is this so let me just
minimize this little bit okay this is
nothing but your test script editor box
and this is where all your script steps
are all your interactions are recorded
now there are four attributes in this
okay can you see a command Now command
is nothing but the actual operation or
the action performed on your web element
so there are multiple actions you can
perform like in this case we have
something called as open we have got
type we have got send keys and we have
got clicks so these are all the selenium
commands which are available and then we
have something called as Target now this
target is nothing but the web element on
which you want to perform the action and
now this target as I said earlier also
it is identify by multiple locating
techniques and if you click on any of
this like we looked at the name here now
similarly the website which we are
clicking on if you look at it there are
multiple locating techniques which are
available here so the one right now
which is being used is the CSS
identifier you can also have X path here
which is a relative X bar so these are
all the locating techniques and this is
where which is applied on the target
value so value is an optional field so
you can send any value to your web
element for example in this case where
we are sending the value which is our
text which is selenium HQ dot
documentation so this is the value which
I want to send it to as a search text to
my google.com and then comment or the
description so here you can mention any
description about that particular line
which you have recorded for example I
can say here sending search text to the
Google search input box and this gets
recorded here against your instruction
now let's look at the test case pane now
test case pin that is here so if you
look here now it contains all the test
cases which you have recorded now there
are multiple things here one is your
tests say I can always go ahead and
create another say uh test case two okay
I can add few more test case here test
case three so all these test cases are
here now I can also have a test Suite
now there is already a test Suite which
I've created which is called the Google
suite and now if I want to add test
cases under this what I can do is I can
just say ADD test and now I can add any
of this test which I just created under
this test Suite so say I have selected
the first three and I've added it so we
have test Suite we have tests here and
then executing so executing is basically
it shows that particular test case which
is currently in the execution mode so
whichever test case we run you will see
all the test cases listed here which
have been executed at that point of time
that is your test case pin and then we
have test login reference this is a very
important window which you need to be
aware of now here this is a running log
so as and when you are going to run your
test cases the every instruction the
every test step as and when it runs it
is going to log here whether it is
passed whether it has failed whether the
command was executed properly or not and
this is how it records it it's a running
law also there is something called as
reference type now for example just go
ahead and let's select one of this
command which you have written here so
which is send Keys now this reference it
will show you the complete description
of the command and how to use that
command so say for click it says
references click locator clicks on the
target element it gives you a complete
detail of what exactly the command does
let's create a test script now for say
amazon.in so let's go back to our ID
what we will do is we'll create a
completely new project so let I'll click
on the create new project are you sure
you would like to without saving it yes
proceed further and let's give the name
as Amazon Project now in this new
project what I will do is I'll say I'll
add a test and my test name is search
iPhone now basically what is the use
case which I'm going to automate as I
will launch amazon.in and I will search
for iPhones and once I get the iPhones
let's verify the title of that
particular page just the simple steps
we'll go ahead and do that so for that
first what I need to do is I need to
enter the URL now this URL needs to be a
fully formed URL so for that what I will
do I'll first launch amazon.in on any
browser I'll just copy this URL and I
can close this browser window and in
this URL address space I could say
amazon.in and I'll say enter and now I
would click on this recording button
which says start recording so once I do
this what it does is it launches the web
page with amazon.in and from there I can
start recording my script so let's do
that I'll say record it so let me just
keep this Windows side by side so that
you can see what is happening on the ID
window here now here what I will do is
I'll click on the search and I'll say
iPhone and I will click on the search
button and here I will also click on
this best seller once I'm in this window
I'll say right click now when your
selenium ID is in the recording mode you
will get this option here which says
selenium ID and there are a lot of
options here which you can select now
for this particular moment what I want
to do is I want to assert the title so
I'll just put an assertion pointer for
assert title and then I will close my
browser window now let's see what are
all the commands which it has recorded
let's go one by one right so it is done
it is opening the amazon.in it is
setting the window size fine it clicked
on the to search window button and then
iPhone is what you are searching and
then it said submitted it's basically
clicking on that button and then we said
we also want to open the best seller
like and here is our assert title right
so it's a very simple test so let's go
ahead and execute this now since I also
have a close command here this script is
going to execute so fast that you will
not be able to make out all the steps
what we have written so for that what I
will do is I will comment out this slide
now how do you comment out any command
here just select the command and can you
see your enable and disable command just
click on that so now your command is
disabled also what I will do is I will
reduce the execution speed so that you
should be able to see exactly what is
happening so let's go ahead and execute
this test first so I'll say run current
test okay I have not stopped the
recording so that is the first thing
after closing the window I also need to
click on the stop recording now your
script is ready to be executed so let's
go and run the current script again I'll
just bring this side by side so that you
can see each of these commands being
executed here okay it is searched for
the iPhone it's clicked on the best
sellers and it has done the title
assertion now if you look at the log
here as I said see every step as in when
it was executed it has been logged here
can you see here and it puts an OK and
it color coded in green which says that
this particular command was executed
successfully now let's go ahead now this
is what we did by simply recording all
the steps from the browser now one more
thing what we will do is say I want to
continue recording here right I'm not
completed my test case so what you can
still do here is you can come towards
the end of the script and press on
record button again and then you can
continue recording from here now say for
example after the best sellers what we
have got say I want to click on uh say
hot releases hot new releases so I do
that okay it says it has recorded the
click and then I want to stop the
recording just the another step is what
I wanted to add now it has stopped the
recording so can you see this new line
which has got added so that means you
really need not restart recording all
the steps again if you want to add
something in the middle of your script
you can always go towards the end of the
script or anywhere in between and you
can add more commands there or you can
record anywhere in between the script
and that is how Vista so let's go ahead
and again execute this then I will show
you another feature of this okay it's
done the title assertion now and it is
also clicked on hot new releases done
now let's say for example I need to add
another command here now instead of
going ahead and using this recording
what I will do is I'll manually add
certain command here say for example
let's go to this Amazon website and say
you want to click on this card so let me
add a command manually here so what is
my command my command is click and then
what is that I want to click I need to
identify that web element for that I can
use this here which says select the
Target in the page so I click on that
and I simply select this target which is
my cart and that is all I need to do so
my command is written there so I'll just
simply go ahead and execute this again
let's see what happens so let me close
this window here okay let's run this
test cases bring this window to the site
so now you can see one by one the
instructions being executed okay the
iPhone has been searched the best seller
has been clicked assert title so it says
your shopping cart is empty so that
means it is successfully able to click
on the cart so now with using ID there
are multiples thing you can do you can
simply record your script while you are
running your test case you can add a
command all by yourself you can stop
recording anywhere and again restart
from the same point now we have our
complete test script ready now let's go
ahead and save this so how do you save
this simply go here and save your
complete project so all the projects
from the ID are saved as Dot site file
so let's name this as Amazon Project and
I will save it so if I show you in my
finder how it looks like this is a
project we created so it always stores
with the file extension dot Sid right
that is selenium ID now also I said you
can export test cases into multiple
format so search iPhone is my test case
so what I can do is I can just say right
click and I can say export now right now
you can see only three options which
says Java junit javascripts and python
however the older IDE had multiple
options of export which had even the web
driver scripts and also the javascripts
this is still in works and they would be
adding more support for other
programming languages here so but for
now the only options what is available
to us is Java J unit JavaScript and the
python so let's go ahead and Export this
into Java J unit so it is going to
Simply Save a test dot Java file so let
me go here in the ID test I'll save this
file so if you go back to my finder you
can find our search iPhone test dot Java
so you can open the Java file like and
you can see here it's a simple junit
test it is exported into so if you have
an eclipse ID you can use this test and
execute it from your Eclipse site
selenium commands selenium commands can
be broadly classified into three Action
commands accessors and assertions what
are Action commands Action commands are
the commands which interact directly
with the web elements on your
application so let's look at what these
commands are so if we go back to our
previous example where we had written a
test script for amazon.in so if you look
at all these things like open set window
size click type so these are all nothing
but called as Action commands and if you
go here you can see let me do one thing
so let me just come to a blank line and
now let's look at the list of commands
so you have a whole list of commands
here listed in the alphabetical order so
like add selection there are multiple
assert commands which is made available
to you and then there are set of
commands where you say click or click at
a particular location closing the
browser using a debugger command double
click drag and drop Echo I'll just
explain how to use an echo command so
this is a command which is not or used
on your web element but something which
you want to say display on your console
and then there are if else statements
which are used as commands here then you
have something called as execute script
for you to execute any say JavaScript or
any different script which you want to
execute from your test script here and
then you have few mouse commands here
open which is what we use for opening an
URL pause and so on so there are
multiple commands which you can look at
and try to use this commands in your
script so these are all called as the
Action commands so let's go ahead and
use this Echo command and see what it
does so now in the same script what I
will do is towards the end of the script
I'll just add this command I'll say Echo
and say I want to just display a message
saying that this is the end of the
script execution that is all I want to
do now I'll just go ahead and run this
and what we want to observe here is how
this particular message what we have
given here is displayed on the console
in the log so now if You observe here so
go to this last statement what we have
so it says after clicking on the card it
said Echo this is the end of the script
so this is what we displayed in using
the command Echo okay so this is how you
can use the echo com another feature
here what you can do here is now say for
example I just added a simple Echo
statement here now for me to execute
that what I did was I executed the
complete script you really need not do
that always instead of that what I can
do is I can just come to this particular
line I can just say right click and I
can say play from here so what it does
is from this point it is going to play
the script for me and not right from the
beginning of the script so I'll show you
how now with this command if you look
here see it started running the script
here this is running search iPhone and
then it executed only one command which
says Echo this is the end of the script
so this is also possible to do with the
ID accesses accessors are the selenium
commands that examine the state of an
application and store the results in a
variable so these are those commands
which allow the user to store say
certain values into your user defined
variables and these stored values can be
later on used either to create
assertions or you can have some
verification points created so let's see
some of the store commands in action so
I have few store commands here which
I'll be demoing so first one is a store
so simply using a store command you can
store any kind of user defined messages
in a variable and then after that you
can either use it for displaying it on
your console or you can can do some
assertions with that similarly store
title so you can store the title of any
of the web page under test then store
text so store text is basically used to
capture the text attribute of any web
element on your web page and store it in
a variable use it as an assertion Point
store value so store value again is used
to store the value attribute of any web
element like so you have a lot of web
elements on the web page and say one of
the attributes is what you want to do in
assertion on so what you can do is you
can use the store value command here get
the value attribute of your web element
and store it in a variable so let's see
all these commands in action so let's go
back to the same example so we have this
Amazon test script example so what I'll
do is say instead of using Amazon let's
do one thing so let's create another
test case itself so I'll go here I'll
say add new test and I will name this
test as accessor test and we will use
the same Amazon site here I'll say click
on start recording keep this window side
by side so first we will look at store
title so simply what I need to do is go
to this Amazon site which we have
learned right click on this go to the
selenium ID and you have multiple
options here so go ahead and select
store title so once I click on that it
is going to ask me the variable name
where I want to store the title of this
page so let's create a variable here
I'll say where title and I'll say okay
done now come back to your IDE all right
so I will stop the execution here now I
have this store title command I created
a variable called Val title and I'm
storing the actual title into this
variable so let's also display this on
our console so I'll add a command here
Echo and in Target how do I use the
variable now this is the way to use it
I'll say dollar and in flower braces I
will give the variable name which I have
defined earlier so it is where I T L E
title okay so this is all my script is
where I'm storing the title of the web
page and I'm displaying it in my console
or the lock so now there are some extra
commands which gets added here now
because we are doing the recording on
that so whatever the mouse movements
happen it is going to record we do not
need this so I will go ahead and delete
this particular command so let's close
this window and execute this test first
so the script has executed successfully
but let's go and see whether did we get
the title displayed on the console yes
so it it did open the Amazon site it has
set the window size it captured the
title here in this line and then after
assigning it to the variable we said
Echo and that variable name and it is
displayed as the title of the page so
now similarly let's go ahead and let's
see how do we use the store text command
now for store text I need an use case
here say for example what about this
cart let's say we want to display the
text of this particular element now the
text of this element is cut so now
instead of again going and re-recording
all the the steps I will simply manually
add this command so now after displaying
the title okay so let's go ahead here
and I will say store text and in store
text I need to pick the text from this
web element cart so what I will do is
I'll use this target select Target and I
will select this particular element
which is cut after this I need to create
a variable where it can be stored so
I'll say where car text now similarly I
will also display it using Echo command
Echo Dollar in the flower braces I'll
say where car text so let's execute this
and then let's look at the other command
so I'll just say I'll close this window
again run this test so now look at this
log lines so our last statements was
storing the title and displaying the
title after that we added store text
okay so here is the command and set it
is executed successfully it was able to
retrieve the text from the element cart
and the text retrieved was cart and
which is what got displayed played with
the echo statement on our console so now
let's move to our next store command
which is store value now as I said store
value for us to use that particular web
element should have the attribute value
so first let's examine which element we
can take and display the value now on
the same website I have the search
button so I will right click on this and
I say inspect element now look at all
the attributes of this element it is of
type input it has a class name it is of
type submit and also it has this value
attribute which is go and this is
exactly what I want to retrieve and
print so we will be using the search
button now similarly same thing what I
will do here I'll go ahead add a command
here as a store value same way I will
select the target as a select Target
from page I will click on the search
button all right so here it has taken
the target here in the value I will
mention the variable name where I want
to store the value so I'll say where
button and value and similarly I will
say Echo and I will print the value of
this variable which is dollar where BTN
value let's go ahead and execute this
I'll say run current test so it has
taken the title it is printed the value
on the line 7. so it says store value on
this particular element and the value
was stored in the variable where BTN
value so that command was successful and
the value actually which was got stored
and which we retrieved using Echo
statement was geoku and that's exactly
what we had here if you want to check
again go here to inspect element the one
which is highlighted so as you said the
values go and that's exactly got printed
on our console now apart from this I
also said there is a simple command
which is just store so let's use that
also now after all this here I will say
store and say we want to just store a
user message I would say a Target as all
store commands demo and this message I
will capture it in a variable so where
string since it's just a text and then
like I did it in the other that string
then I'll say Echo and the variable name
so now if we close this and one way to
do it is execute the complete test so
which will execute all our store
commands and also the last line is this
the line number nine in the log which
says the store command which we use to
store the text all store commands demo
and that is also displayed using the X
so all the store commands we have demo
successfully let's close this window and
go back to our presentation so this is
all about the accessor command now what
do we have after accessor so we have
something called as assertions now what
is an assert so assertion is nothing but
it verifies the current state of an
application with an expected state so
this is something where you compare your
actual result with the expected result
now assertions are of three different
type one is assert verify and wait for
now what does Assad does when the assert
command is executed and if it fails
right the test stops immediately after
this statement so if you are asserting
say a title of a page and if you find
that the title of page is not as
expected as soon as it finds that
failure your rest of the test case test
is not going to run and it's going to
immediately stop the test and also it is
going to flag the test case as say what
is verify verify something where the
selenium ID it locks that particular
assertion as fail however it would
continue with the rest of the steps in
the test case and then at the end of it
the your overall test case is flagged as
fit that is what verify does so verify
is called as soft assertion whereas
assert here is called as hard assertion
white is called harder session because
as soon as an assert statement fails the
complete test execution stops at that
statement whereas in soft asserts what
happens is after the failure happens the
test continues with the rest of the
steps and continue it completes its
execution and then Flags the test case
has failed and when is this usually used
in cases like as the same example so if
you are asserting a title you really do
not want the test case execution to stop
even if there is a failure why because
none of your steps are going to be
dependent on this assertion point and
this is where you will require a soft
muscle wait for wait for something which
waits for a certain condition to be true
after that it proceeds to your further
steps so if the condition goes false
here for whatever say if you are waiting
for an element to appear on the web page
and if that element does not appear the
test fails however it carries forward
and completes the test by executing the
rest of the steps and then Flags the
complete test case as a failure which
will be something similar to a softer so
let's see all these things in action
let's go back to our ID we will create
another test case here so I'll say
assert test now for this what's the
example we can take so first for assert
title let's do the assert title on
Amazon itself and let's change the same
test case to verify and see how this
test case behave now for this I will
launch the recorder with the same
amazon.in okay my recorder is launched
now simply I will go to this website and
I'll say right click selenium ID and
I'll say assert title then I'll stop the
recording now here I will remove this
command which has got added which I
don't need so this is my asserted now we
have already seen a subtitle passing in
couple of our other examples now I want
to show you a failure on yourself so for
that what I will do I will modify this
actual type so here in the last line
I'll just remove this amazon.in so now
ideally this test case is going to fail
for us because the title which it is
expecting and what it is comparing
against are not the same first let's
execute this uh well I also need to show
some statements after this so what I
will do is let's add few more statements
here let me start the recording here
again say after asserting the title we
want to go and click on this bestseller
and then I will close this now let's
execute this stop the recording and
execute this test now do you see this
assert title is in red that means it has
failed the validation here so you see
here in the log it says open the site
done set window size done when it comes
to assert title it says actual value was
something different and it did not match
with what you are trying to look for a
sir test ended with one error now after
this assert please observe that there
are no other statements which got
executed the test stopped right away
after this failure this is called as
hard asset now let's go ahead and change
this assert title to verify title so
simply what I will do in the command
itself instead of assert I'll say verify
title and now let's execute this and see
what happens now let me close this
window first and then I'll say run test
running a search test amazon.in was open
window size was set verify title failed
because the titles were different
because we have modified that however do
you see this fourth line being executed
click on linked as bestseller and click
on close now since I it was a very fast
execution and I closed the browser
probably was you were not able to see
the best sellers click here that is fine
but in the log we can see here that the
steps four and five got executed even
after the title verify title step field
and if you compare it with the previous
example where assert title failed the
two lines after that the line 4 where we
are clicking on the best seller and
closing the browser are not getting
executed so this is the main difference
between the verify title and the assert
title so now let's look at wait for how
do we use wait for now for weight 4 I
want to look at some kind of website
where it would load an element uh
dynamically after a while so for that I
have a website here let's let's create a
new test again let's go to the tests
pane I will say assertion test and now
uh let's go to a browser we open a new
window and there is a demo site which I
want to use so let me search for that
and then I will use that URL so I'll say
internet I'm going to use the dynamic
loading do you have here yes Dynamic
loading page element rendered now see if
you look at this website when I press on
the start button right after a while
this hello word text is going to appear
on this webpage so in our use case what
we will do we will launch this website
we will click on the start button and
then we will put an assert on this text
using wait for let's do that so let's go
here let me copy this this is the one
let me say Ctrl C and in my new test
I'll say Ctrl V and then I'll say start
recording so it's going to launch this
let's close the previous windows now in
this I'm just going to click on start so
that is going to get recorded done and
now while the recording is still on I
will add a command here for wait for so
I'll say wait for element visible that
is exactly what we are saying right so
wait for is used until for a condition
and until that condition is true so I am
saying here please wait for this
particular element which I'm going to
give it in Target until it is visible
now the target is I'm just going to
select the target from this web page
itself so I'll say select Target and I'm
going to select this particular text
come back here to your ID so wait for
the element to be visible what is the
element to be visible is this hello
world hello world text and then you need
to give a value here now what is this
value since we are using wait for we
need to mention a timeout so we have to
tell basically to ID that okay wait for
say one second two seconds or three
seconds whatever it is required and that
timeout value is needs to be mentioned
here so and this is in milliseconds so
what I will say is I'll say so let's
fail this test case first so I'll use a
little lesser timer so I'll say three
thousand so that is a 3000 milliseconds
which is three seconds that is it and
then we can say so what we'll do here is
We'll add an assert so I will say assert
text now what is the assert text I'm
going to do I need to look for the same
element so I'll simply say select Target
this one and what is that I'm going to
assert with I'm going to assert with the
same text so I'll just copy this text
and I'll put it in the value there's
another way of doing that which we have
done it previously so I can just go here
do a right click go to selenium ID and I
can say assert text which is basically
going to give me the same command so let
me just go ahead and remove one of them
either of them you can remove okay so
let's stop the recording I will not
close this browser because I want you to
see how the dynamically loaded element
behaves and we'll go ahead and execute
this so I'll say stop recording and I'll
say execute this test now it's here all
right so it's waiting okay it is failed
now see this so it says wait for element
visible after that value we have
mentioned is 3000 let's wait for three
seconds which was not enough because and
it failed with saying that unable to
locate the element within the timeout
period now let's go ahead and change it
to a passing value so I will say 10 000
here which is 10 seconds so let's close
this and let's again execute this and
bring this to the side so that we can
see okay it is waiting on that wait for
element now look at the problem here
what we have done is we have closed the
website and after that we have added the
assert text so this is a mistake what we
have done and hence though it has found
that element here for weight four what
did it do it went ahead and close the
window and after that it's definitely
not going to find the ascertain right so
that's the mistake what we have done so
let's go ahead and debug this so what we
will do after this wait for element we
want this assert to be put after that we
don't need this click content because
this was an additional step which got
added delete it and then close okay fine
so now let's go ahead and rerun this
we'll say run current test I'll move
this to a side okay it's waiting all
right done so now it is able to do an
assert text on this all right so this is
how you use the weight for key features
of selenium ID let's look at the first
feature reusability of test scripts so
many of the test scripts have test steps
that involves signing into an
application or creating an account like
for example a login screen is a very key
example in this case where whenever you
are testing your application first you
need to log in and then perform any
other test so now it's going to be a
return or a waste of time to recreate
the login steps again and again for each
and every test case so we do not want to
definitely do that so as we know since
the record and replay tool does not have
enough capability of writing a common
test cases or a common functions and
calling those common factions like our
regular selenium Webdriver has however
what id is done is it has given us a
provision to run one script from another
script so what a basic what we do here
is especially for a login we write one
test case which is going to log into
your application and call this test case
in the other test cases so let's take a
look at how this works so for that let's
go to our ID so in this ID we'll do one
thing let's go ahead and create a new
project so let's say login project in
this project I will create a new test
case we'll call it as login test let's
say add now in this login test I need to
give a URL now for this purpose I will
be using again a demo site so first let
me launch a demo site here file new
window and I will say the demo site
code.uk okay this is a simple demo site
which has a login functionality right so
here I will go to the login screen now
this also allows me to add few users and
using the same users we can go ahead and
do the login now coming back to our
login page so this is the URL which I
need to learn launch which is going to
give us username and password we will
use to login into this application so
give this URL here and say start
recording move this window here for
recording and this here now what is the
first step we want to record we want to
come here click on the username and I'll
say user one okay and I'll say password
PWD one and I will click on test login
and then what we will do is we will
assert this text so here I'll say right
click selenium ID assert text that's it
and then I will close the browser okay
this is all my test is now come back to
your ID let's see if there are any
unnecessary commands which it has taken
Okay click type all done and now for the
time being I'm going to comment out this
close comment because I want the browser
to be still open so that we can see the
actual test execution properly till the
end of the script this is the login test
case now simply if I run this let's
execute this let me execute this and
show stop the recording and execute this
test case so it typed user one it typed
PWD which is my password here and then
clicked on the button and then
definitely it was the wrong password so
it gave me fail docking so this is fast
fantastic however this is with one value
I have used it but this is a function
which I want to use it every time and
also the probable use case I might have
is that I might need to log in with a
different user ID and password and apart
from that even just to test this login
test page I would want to test with
multiple user ID and password like valid
credentials and invalid credentials now
for that purpose what we will do is we
will parameterize this name that is user
ID and the password and how do I
parameterize it simply go here instead
of giving a hard coded value here what
you can do is just say use any variable
name here and we'll Define this variable
somewhere else so I'll say username this
is the variable similarly for my
password in my value field instead of a
hard coded value I'll say dollar and I
will say password now I I cannot run
this program as it is because there is
this variable is not defined in the
login.test what I will do now is I will
create my actual test case so I'll say
here I'll say invalid credential as my
test case and I'll say add now here is
where I will assign values for my
variables now which are those variables
I need to use username and password so I
need to assign some value here and then
call this function login test so let's
do that in this video previously we also
saw how do we use user variables and how
do we assign value by using the store
command so I'm going to say store and
then my target is going to be the actual
value so user 1 and where is that I'm
going to pass this to my variable
username so let's just check once if the
variable name is username yes all right
done now I have done the username now I
need to pass the password so I again
I'll say store the actual password which
is pwd1 in my case and what is the
variable I need to use here after to use
password because that's the variable
which we have used in login test here
and then after that I need to use a
command which is called as run now what
this run command does is run and
whatever Target you give which is
basically your another test case it is
going to run the test case now in our
case our test is login test this is all
our test case is going to be okay so
what is that we did we do in this test
case we created a variable username and
password and assigned the actual
username and password and then we are
just calling this login test and in this
login test this username and password
will get passed which will be user 1 and
pwd1 and then it will execute this test
with the or with the value which we have
passed to this variable nibs so now
which test case we need to run the
invalid credential so let's go ahead
close this window and execute this test
executed so now look at the log of this
invalid credential test see running
login test called by invalid credential
before that it said store this Value
Store user 1 in the value username that
is your variable this is the slide and
then the password then it says run login
test so it called the login test
functionality and in the login test we
have all this clicking on the password
field clicking on the username and then
asserting the text and that's exactly
what is done here this is how you use it
so now let's write one more test here
for the same login test so let me add
another test I'll say valid credentials
and I'll say add now same thing I will
do here I'll say command store my target
will be now I'll say user 3 value will
be username right okay now second
command will be again storing this time
it is for the password my password is
pwd3 and the variable name is password
and same thing I'll just call run and my
login test that's it now similarly let's
run this test and see what happens now
this test is going to fail why let me
close this window I don't need this why
did this test get well because my
assertion Point let's go to the tests
I'll show you my assertion point in
login test is look for failed login
however we created a test case for valid
credentials right because our valid
credentials said that the login was
successful which did not match with what
we were asserting which is fine right so
we just wanted to see whether we can
write a test case with valid credentials
and invalid credentials and this is how
you do that by passing the variables
through your test case to your actual
test case the next feature is the
debugger in the ID like every other ID
offers a debugger functionality so does
selenium ID so let's look at what are
the different functions available for us
in the debugging so there are multiple
functionalities which the selenium IDE
offers us so one is called as the step
execution so for us to look at how each
of these debugging techniques Works what
I'll do is let's go ahead and create a
new test script so let's go to our IDE
and I will create a new test case so
I'll say new test case let's use
Facebook login this time so I'll say FB
login test or we'll just say FB test so
now for this FB test I would go ahead
and use the Facebook login page so I'll
just copy this URL paste it here and
then I will minimize this other Firefox
window and I will launch the recorder
now so I'll click on start recording now
let's keep this side by side and what is
that we are going to do here is let's do
a simple login functionality so I'll
just use some email ID here so I'll say
my user gmail.com this is just a dummy
user ID and password values and I'll say
password as password one then I'll click
on login button let's stop the recording
here so let's read the script once
whether it has got everything whatever
we need okay it is launched Facebook it
clicked on email ID there's a double
clicks here because I happen to click
twice on the email ID field so what I'll
do I'll remove one we don't need it and
then I'm typing the keys which is
myuser.gmail and then I'm clicking on
the password field typing the password
and clicking on the login button and
then once I do that okay so I'm going to
get this Pages the password you have
entered is incorrect so let it be so we
will use the script until here and check
out some of the login options okay so we
have completed writing of the script let
me go ahead and close this window now
first thing what we will do is we'll
just simply execute the script so we
have to just say run current test so
it's going to log in your Facebook it
will enter my user at gmail it will
enter the password it will log in and
that's about it so now your script is
executed now let's go into the debug
mode as we said there are multiple
options for debugging what is the first
option let's see so first option we have
is something called a step execution so
what the step execution does is from
your script you can execute all the
steps one after the other so you can
basically control the execution of each
step and how you do that what you have
to do is just go and click anywhere so
let's start from the beginning let's
close this window of our previous run
and there is an option here which says
step over current command so when you
click on this what it does is it
basically executes your first line where
your cursor was and it stops immediately
after that so if you look here it has
launched the Facebook page which says
open the URL Facebook and then let's go
ahead and just do the simple step
execution again I'll click on that it is
going to execute this command where it
set the window size to certain value
again I will do a step execution now
observe what happens here it clicked on
this email field do you see the cursor
there now let's do the next step again
again I will do step over current
command now the current command was it
entered my user and Gmail you can see it
on the left side here now it will be
more visible again I will do a step
execution it is going to click on the
password field now it is going to enter
the password and now the last step is
it's going to click on the login button
and with this all our commands are
executed and this is how you do the step
execution and now where is this useful
say if you've got a very long test case
written and you want at certain point
you want to start doing the step
execution to see where your test case is
filled probably one of your web element
you entered is wrong or probably the
text which are entered is wrong so for
you to debug such cases you can use this
step over current command functionality
so what's our next command breakpoints
so there are break points which you can
insert in your script okay so let's
close this execution and let's come back
to our script so what I will do is first
let's add a breakpoint how do you add a
breakpoint say for example we want to
add a breakpoint after we type in our
email ID so here what I do is I simply
go and click here so once you click here
this is where your breakpoint is added
other way of adding break point is you
can right click on any command and you
can use this toggle breakpoint so if
there is no breakpoint it adds the
breakpoint and for you to remove it you
can simply go and select the toggle
breakpoint again so now I've added a
single breakpoint now what you need to
do is once you execute this once you say
run test what it will do is it will come
till here till your break point it will
execute all the commands before that and
it stops or pauses your execution at
this point okay let's go ahead and see
how it does so what I'll do is I've
added a breakpoint at the click on
password field and I will say execute
this test do you see here it says paused
in the debugger so by adding breakpoint
my test has entered the debugging mode
and where is it stopped to at the point
where I added this breakpoint so just go
back here and see whether the previous
steps have been executed yes my previous
step was adding this myuser gmail.com
into the email field which it is done
and it is paused Here and Now from here
I can either run the rest of the tests
if I just click on this run current as
what it will do is it will go ahead and
execute all the steps or even I can do a
step execution from here so say if I
want to do a step execution I'll do this
let me minimize this window a little bit
so that you can see and I'm still again
doing that step execution so it added
the password and after this I'll say
just go ahead and complete the test so
it is clicked on your sign in login
button and it is logged so this is how
you can use the breakpoint so that is
about adding the breakpoint let's see
what's the next removing the break point
so I showed you so if you want to add a
breakpoint you just click here or you
can do a right click and do toggle
breakpoint if you want to remove the
breakpoint just click again on the same
place where it has added the breakpoint
or you can always do this toggle
breakpoint so this is the way of adding
and removing the break points what is
the third option disabling now say for
example my test cases are pretty long
one okay so I might have a multiple
breakpoints so say let's add one
breakpoint here at the email and then
before clicking on login let's add
another break part now when I execute
this it is going to stop here and then
again if I say continue execution it is
going to come and stop here so let's do
that first and then I'll show you how
the disable works so let's close this
window again execute this bring this
window here can you see this it's paused
here okay and here now you should be
able to see now I'll say just run after
this breakpoint do you see here it is
paused after entering the password it
has not clicked on the login button it's
paused at the click and now I'll say
again complete the test so your click on
the login button is done and it is
logged so it's a little bit slow yeah
now we've got that login page at some
point of time while I'm debugging my
test case I would want to just disable
all the breakpoints and not remove
everything for that I have an option
here which says disable breakpoint so if
this button is highlighted here that
means I have selected disable breakpoint
so what this does is when I execute this
test it ignores all these breakpoints
for this run it ignores this breakpoints
until I have selected this disable
breakpoint button okay so let's see this
let me close this again and I have
enabled this disable breakpoint is what
I have selected I'll just simply go
ahead and run this test case do you see
that it did not stop at this breakpoint
it went ahead and completed the
execution why because I have temporarily
disabled it once I removed the selection
and run it it is again going to stop at
the breakpoints so this is how it works
so we saw adding of Records removing of
breakpoints and disabling of breakpoints
what is the next one enter debugger by
using play to this point option okay now
another way of doing this is so let's
remove all this breakpoint now for
example like the last time we said we
want to add a breakpoint here so now
instead of doing that what I can do also
do is I can just right click on that
particular command and I can say play to
this point only so when I select this
what happens it acts like a breakpoint
and it comes and pauses at this
particular command where I have set play
till this point so let's try to do that
so let me close this window and then for
say type the password so here okay I'll
say right click play to this point so it
is going to execute all the steps until
the password and it will stop here can
you see this paused in the debugger so
it again enter the debug mode and now it
has stopped at this point so now there
are multiple options now every time last
time what we did we did a step over and
also we said continue with the rest of
the test now what we will do we'll just
stop the execution so this is also an
option available so if you want to
change something here you do not want to
continue with your execution you can
simply go ahead and stop the execution
so we saw how do we use the play to this
point option now debugger command now
all these things whatever we did now
adding the breakpoints this was done in
the ID there is also a way of adding a
debugger programmatically and how do we
do that let's see now in the same place
say after entering the password so here
I will insert a command in this command
I'll just say debugger this is all the
commands now what happens when I execute
this test cases at this point wherever
it finds this debugger command this
program enters into a debug mode and it
comes and pauses the script here let's
see this in action so simply I'll just
play the script let's type the email ID
D let's type the password okay it is
going little slower here okay and there
there you go now it is paused in
debugger so this debugger did the same
job as what we did earlier with the
breakpoints now let's go ahead and just
stop the execution because let's not
keep logging into Facebook with invalid
username and ID okay so this is how you
can use the debugger command so I will
stop the execution here close this
window and now let's see the next one
let's close this window so we saw the
deeper pause on exception okay this is a
very brilliant feature of this ID I'll
show you how it works now let's say let
me remove this command now I do not want
the debugger I'll say delete this
command let's click let it be there now
if you look at this what we are doing is
we are identifying this elements like
email password and then clicking on the
login button now say for example say
this click so let's run this then I'll
show you what it is and I wanted to
comment uh stop here okay so I will
execute this all right so now it is
paused here so now what I will do is the
click right so this is where I'm
clicking is this login button so this
login button is identified by some
identifier which is an ID now there is a
possibility that tomorrow this
particular ID might change or any of the
locator might change on this particular
website and if that happens the first
point of failure what you will see is
when you click on this button because
this script will say that this element
is not found in such cases if you are
using pause on exception that is here
pause an exception what happens is
whenever this script finds an exception
it goes and pauses at that and enters
into a debug milk otherwise what happens
whenever you find an exception your
complete test script will stop executing
because there is an error and your test
case fails instead since we are in a
debugging mode if you choose this option
what happens is if there is an exception
it is going to come get into the
debugger mode and it is going to pause
the execution at that point and once it
pauses what you can do is you can go and
correct it and then continue your
execution so let's see that in action so
now for Example The Click button so here
the ID is U underscore 0 underscore a so
say I try to change this let me add 1
here and then if I execute this this
script should fail from basically
because it is not going to find this so
can you see us trying to find this ID
and since this particular element with
this ID does not exist this whole test
case should fail for me now as I said
earlier in this video so if by any
chance if one of the element ID is not
found so if that is not found it always
falls back into the other locator
techniques and that is what it did in
this case it tried to locate the login
button using some other idea and that's
what it says element found with the
secondary locator okay to use it by
default update the test step and to use
it as a primary locator and that is
where the test case pass so let's try to
see if I can make this test case fail in
any way for that let's remove this and
let's try on the email ID so what I will
do is let me try to comment this out so
remove the debugger and I will add a
command here I'll say insert new command
and in this I will say click and then I
will use the target as ID equal to email
now in this case I do not have a
fallback ID because I am not using ID to
recognize the element rather I added my
own command and I added my own locator
here so now let's try with this and now
instead of this is the right ID so what
I will do is I'll just change this ID to
something like underscore one so that
this test case fails for me now let me
close this and let's run this test case
and basically this test case should fail
so if you see here in the log it's
saying trying to find the element with
ID email underscore one so this ID has a
default timer so it will keep trying to
find the element until the timeout value
is completed now there we go so it had
an implicit timeout of 30 000 so that is
30 seconds 30 000 milliseconds which was
30 seconds now after that this desk is
filled so this is the scenario we wanted
what happens here is it simply started
executing the moment it found an
exception it completely stopped so as a
tester what you need to do is you need
to go back look for this red lines where
it has failed correct it and then rerun
the whole test now instead of that what
this poisson exception does is let me
click on that so this is what is
selected now what it does is when I
execute this this is going to come and
stop here let's see that so let me close
this and run this program again so run
current test I'll bring this to the side
now CS it's trying to find the ID since
the timeout is almost 30 seconds we need
to wait until it pauses at this so now
do you see this now it is not exited
from the test it is just at the same
step where it is unable to find this
email field okay and it's saying okay it
failed with an implicit timeout of 30
seconds but now since I'm in the
debugging mode and how did I get into
the debug mode by selecting this option
pause an exception now what I can do is
I can go ahead and change this back to
the actual one and then from here I can
just simply do this I I can say run the
test now so now see what it did the
moment I changed that and I said run it
passed and how did it pass because I
gave the right ID here and that's
exactly you can do with this deeper cup
control flow statements so in the Legacy
ID these control flow statements were
available as plugin so one had to
install the plugin for you to use any of
this control flow statements however in
the new idea these are available out of
box so let's see what this control
statements are so let's go to my notes
so there are two types of control flow
statements one is conditional branching
and the other one is looping so in
conditional branching we have a regular
if else if nested if else and end and
when we talk about looping there are
multiple Loops available one is the
while envelope so how does the while and
loop work the code between the while and
the end is executed until the expression
is true and then we have a do repeat so
do repeat where the commands after the
do will get executed first and then the
condition is checked and this is
evaluated in the if statement times n so
you can specify a number of iterations
you would like a piece of code to be
executed using this Loop and then
there's another loop which is a for each
Loop so this provides the ability to
iterate over collection objects like say
if you have an array object with you and
you want to say a Traverse through the
array and perform certain operations on
each of the array element so that is
possible using the for each Loop so
let's go and write a test script and see
how this work so what I will do is I
will demonstrate a use case for the if
else and then for the looping I have a
few test scripts which I've already
written which I will show you and I will
walk you through them it's a simple
counter which we can use where we'll be
incrementing the counter using one of
these Loops so we'll just see how the
loops are to be used what is the syntax
to be used and how they execute in the
ID so let's go to our ID now let's
minimize this so this was our previous
test test case so what I will do is I
will close this project and open another
project so I have another project here
which is called as control flows so as I
said I have few scripts written for some
of the loops however for the demo use
case we will go ahead and write a new
script so I'll say add new test and we
are going to be working with a demo site
called calorie calculator okay so let me
name the test case itself as calorie
calculator test so let's look at what is
our use case now in this use case this
is my use case I am saying go to this
calorie counter website okay so let's
see what that website is I have this
website open here so this is a calorie
calculator website in this website we
are saying if the gender is male then
click on the mail radio button so you
have multiple Fields here where you are
accepting the age of a person the gender
of a person the height the weight and
then the activity level of the person
and when when you click on calculate
this is going to give you the number of
calories so for our purpose for raw demo
use case what we will do is we will
store the gender to be selected in a
variable say for example I want a gender
female to be selected and then I'm going
to write an if condition here that if
the gender is male right so if the
gender is male then click on the mail
radio button here and then I'm saying
click active from the activity drop down
so there's a drop down called activity
here in this I am going to go and select
active as daily exercise or intense
exercise three to four times a week this
is what I'm going to be selecting and if
the gender is female so if the value
passed from the gender is female then
what is that I want to do I want to
click on this radio button female and
select very active intense exercise from
this activity drop top a very simple use
case so this is what we are going to
write in our test script so let's
minimize this window we can just close
this window for now we don't need this
and here so how do we start this test
case I need to enter the URL so for me
to enter the URL let me go to that copy
copy this URL Ctrl C minimize this and
Ctrl V so now here I will start my
recording by clicking on the start
recording button so now this URL is open
now the first thing what I need to do is
in my test script I need to write a open
command so I'll say open and my target
is what this URL done the next command
is as per our use case I want to store
the gender to be selected in a variable
so we will use the store command and
when we use the store command we need to
specify the target so let's say the
target is f and where is that I want to
store I'll create a where gender that's
my variable so I have stored this now
what is the next thing I want to do so
once I have stored this first is I need
to put an if statement because my use
case is if the gender is male and if the
gender is female now since byte default
the mail is already selected here so
let's put an if condition for this
condition if the gender is female okay
so that is exactly what I'm going to do
so here I will say if in the command
once I say if in the Target you need to
specify the condition now condition is I
want to check for dollar that's my
variable where gender I want to check if
this is equal to F and how is that I can
check I need to use 3 equal to here in
double quotes I'm going to mention F now
this is what I have stored in the
variable that gender this is what I'm
going to check so if this is the
condition in the next line now all the
next lines whatever I'm going to mention
are the ones which will be executed if
this condition is true now in the next
line what I want is I want to select
this radio button correct so now what I
will do instead of writing all the
commands manually I will now use a
recorder to do that since I'm already in
the recording mode I'll just go to the
URL or the website here and I'll go
click on this female so on the right if
you see these steps are getting recorded
and then our use case also said that
from the activity drop down we want to
select very active so now if you look
here all our steps have been recorded So
I clicked on the female radio button and
then we selected the ID activity here
which is our activity drop down and then
we clicked on the desired value which is
very active and then you end the if
statement here so but we also want to
add an else statement so instead of
saying end here I will say else so that
means if the gender selected is male
okay what is that we want to do I want
to go and select in the activity field
as active because the mail is already
selected so I'm not going to select it
again and then I will end the if Loop by
end statement that is all so this is all
my scripted so let's stop the recording
here there are some mouse move Mouse up
which I really do not need so what I
will do is I'll just delete this so this
is the simple statement what I need in
the else where I'm saying select so
select is something a command which is
used to select a web element which is
your drop down so you select the drop
down here and one once the drop down is
clicked and then you go ahead and click
on this particular Target is nothing but
your active daily exercise or intense
this value from the drop down is what
I'm selecting and same same thing what
we did in the if statement so let's
remove these also we don't Mouse move at
and mouse up at so all these statements
we don't need so same thing if I'm
saying the if statement says if the
gender is f that is female click on the
radio button then go to the select
activity select the activity by clicking
on very active and then end the loop so
this is all our script is now let's go
ahead and execute this and see whether
it works so let's minimize this window
and I will simply say execute the
current test let's slow down the
execution speed little bit so that you
can observe what exactly is happening
now I'll say run the current test so the
calorie calculator is open so we are
passing the value f for the gender
correct so so that means it entered this
Loop you can see here in the lock so if
the gender is f which is female yes it
found the condition to be true and then
it clicked on this radio button it went
to the select field which is your
activity drop down it selected the very
active option from here and then it
ended now in the same program what I
will do instead of f let's pass the
value M male and let's see what happens
and then we will go ahead and execute
this program so let's close this window
again and execute the test script again
so now according to the script we are
not reselecting the radio button because
this is already selected by default and
in this test script if you see now all
the green colored one if you see okay
the open command ran successfully store
command run successfully it came to the
if condition it checked if the gender
was F or M it found that this condition
is not true so can you see here all
these other statements in the if are in
black color that means these were not
executed instead it came to the else
part and then it executed all the
commands in the else part so this is how
you use a if condition in your selenium
ID so let's close this now as I said
there are other looping statements what
we have like while and loop or do repeat
and time set so I have couple of
examples written here let's walk through
that and see so let's take the while
loop first so what happens in this while
loop let's see in this while loop what
I'm basically doing is I've created a
counter and I am counting it from one to
five and then displaying the value of
the counter and I'm using a while loop
for that so here it says first I am
setting a counter value to 1 and then
I'm saying while the counter value is
less than 5 this is the loop while and
end so whatever commands are within that
those get executed until the condition
is true so this Loop will get executed
until the counter becomes 5. so once it
sees that counter is 5 it is going to
exit the loop and just print the value
of the contact it's as simple as while
loop so just pay attention to the syntax
the way it has been used here so this
execute script is what a simpler
statement what I have used this could be
anything it could be any of your web
elements you're performing certain
operations say there is a calculator
which you are using say a calculator and
a test so if you want to key in certain
numbers until say the sum of the numbers
is 30 or something an example like that
could be a valid use case for your while
loop so you could use that so let's
execute this and see how the counter
works so if I execute this command so
now take a look at the log here this is
running while test so first statement
where it assigned the counter value and
then it got into the while loop and it
executed the volume until the counter
was assigned the value file and once the
counter became 5 the while loop got
exited and we are printing the counter
value so this is how a while loop is
used now similarly the same function of
using a counter I have tried to use a
dual Loop here so let's look at it now
in the do Loop what happens is the first
the script is executed because it's the
first command after the do statement so
whatever is between the do and repeat if
is executed and then the condition is
checked here so here what I'm doing is
I'm just first assigning a counter with
value 0 and I'm incrementing the counter
every time by 10 and then I have a
condition that once the counter becomes
50 please exit the loop that's all I'm
doing here and another statement what I
have written here is every time the
counter gets incremented I am printing
the value of the counter so let's
execute the script can you see that the
weight is executing it call it now let's
see the log running do Loop test okay
the counter has been initialized to zero
and then it executes the script and this
script is doing what it is just
incrementing the counter by 10. the
counter becomes 10 and then 20 30 40 and
50. so as soon as it becomes 50 it's
going to exit the loop and print the
value of the counter so one thing to
notice is there is no web element or
website testing which I am doing from
the script however one thing what the ID
needs is it needs a starting part so
whenever you create a new test kit it
asks you to at least give it a URL from
where it can start though it is not
going to launch that URL it is going to
launch your browser definitely before
even it executes a single line of test
so that is something a mandatory in the
ID so we saw do Loop we saw the while
loop there's also of course something
called as time slip so which is what I
have said here times and N so this is
something you can specify a number of
iterations you would like to perform a
set of commands so now in this example
what am I doing I'm simply incrementing
a counter by one right and I'm saying
just increment that is this is the only
command which I want to execute but I
want you to execute two types that's all
so there is no other conditions here it
is simply saying there is a set of
command or a single command which I want
to execute it twice and the number of
times which I want to execute is what I
mentioned here in the Target so first
initially I am assigning a counter with
value 100 and then and I am saying
increment this counter by 1 2 times and
then print the value of the counter so
let's execute this and then change the
number of times so if I say run test
here so can you see this the number of
times it got iterated and now the value
is hundred into why because initial
value was hundred in the loop which is
the times Loop I'm saying the iterations
is 2 2 times execute the command which
increments the counter by one so that is
why your counter value becomes 102. now
say I increase this to say 10 so that we
get a feel of how the loop executes here
and same thing I will execute it now see
it you can visually see the number of
times the loop is getting executed all
right and in the log you can see the
values also here okay can you see here
so this Loop executed 10 times and hence
the counter value because hundred and
ten so these are a simple ways of using
these Loops in the ID so you can
implement this Loops for any kind of
functionality you may want to perform on
your web elements or any logic which you
want to build for your test cases
selenium side Runner selenium side
Runner is a command line Runner tool
which allows the user to run your
selenium ID test cases on any browsers
or to run the test cases parallely and
also it gives you a mechanism to use the
grid setup to run your test cases on a
remote machine okay so for us to work
with this selenium side Runner there are
certain installations which we need to
do and some of the installation prereqs
are one is you need a node.js server and
what is this node.js server node.js
server is a powerful JavaScript based
platform and this is the platform which
is intensively used by many developers
across the world for developing their
web applications and it's an open source
and it is available free of cost to
everyone to use it so we will need to go
ahead and install a node.js server for
this so now let's look at all the
installation steps which are involved in
installing the side Runner and running
it okay so let's go to my notes so the
selenium hq.org has a complete
documentation on how how to install this
command line Runner how to use it and
what are the different ways we can use
this Runner I'll just show you where it
is and you can use this as a reference
for any of the tests which you're
creating and using the site Runner to
run it so let me open a new window here
let's go to this website
so if you see here it has a complete
guide on how to use this command line
Runner right including the setups what
is the prereqs installing the browser
drivers and how do you do the different
configurations which are available with
the site Runner so you can configure
various browsers with that you can set
different capabilities for the browser
if you want to use the selenium grid to
run your test cases on remote servers it
also gives you complete details on how
do we do that and also using the
parameters changing your base URL so
this is a complete guide which you can
refer to when you're working with the
site Runner okay so let's go back to our
installation
so coming back to our installation here
so the first prereq what we need for the
selenium side Runner to run is your
node.js okay so if you go to this
website node.js.org
let me open the same browser okay
all right so here you will see that the
node.js is available as an installable
for all the platforms right do you have
a Windows installer you have a Mac OS
installer you have Linux installers also
so if you're working with the Windows
machine there are two options for you
either you can go ahead and download the
MSI installer or you can just download
the zip and unzip it into any folder on
your system okay and since I am using
Mac machine what I have done is I have
downloaded this version PKG version and
have installed it on my machine okay so
once you download say if you're working
on the Windows machine so say 64-bit is
what you require and you click here and
download the zip package I'll show you
how the folder structure looks like so
this is where I have downloaded the
node.js installable now if you look at
the windows one so this is what happens
when you download the zip file and unzip
it this is the folder structure it
creates and this is what we would need
right so npm is something which we would
be using to install all the packages
which are required on this node.js
server and I'll explain to you what
those packages are okay so so once you
do this installation you need to go and
check if your installation is gone
properly or not so for that what you do
is go to your terminal window or in your
case if you're using a Windows machine
just open a command prompt right and
then you have to just give this command
here you say npm minus V which is
basically saying what is the version of
the node.js which we have installed it
is 6.9 okay now what is this npn npm is
nothing but it's a node.js package
manager and it gets installed with your
node and this is used to install all
your other packages or what it is called
as modules on your system okay so now
with this we know that our npm has been
installed properly so let's move to the
next step of installation so now we have
our node.js installed now next thing is
to install the selenium site Runner now
the selenium side Runner is a library
which is available to us and we need to
install this Library using the npn so
let me go back to my terminal again so
I'll just show you the command what it
is what we use for installing this
package or the library and since I've
already installed on my machine I will
not be doing the installation here so
what you need to do so if you are a
Windows user you can directly give the
command as npn install minus G selenium
site run okay so this is the command
which you need to give however if you
are a Mac User or a Unix user since you
need to use a root user here what you
need to do is just say sudo once you
press enter here it will go ahead and
install this complete library on your
system now since I've already installed
I'm not going to do that okay so I'll
just exit from this now once the
installation is done how do you check
whether your installation has gone
correctly or not you have to just simply
give a command like selenium side Runner
minus version okay and now this will
give you the version number if the
installation has been successful so
right now the version installed which is
the latest version is 3.11 okay so so
far we have done the installation of the
node.js server we have done the
installation of the selenium now while
you all also you do this installation
you need to know that where is the
selenium ID side Runner has been
installed right as as I said it's a
library or what you popularly call as
module in your npn so for you to check
whether where it has got installed you
simply need to go to the directory I'll
say LS minus user local library so if
you see here you'll see something called
as node modules so whatever packages
you're going to install using npm would
get installed in this directory the node
modules directory so let's go ahead and
see whether I have my selenium side
Runner there or not so I'll just use the
same LS slash node modules okay do you
see this selenium side Runner is what
has got installed and previously to that
when we installed the node.js server it
also installed this npm right so that is
also available under the same folder so
far so good so we have our selenium ID
installed now now what else is required
so we installed the node.js we installed
the selenium side Runner now now we need
this browser drivers now what are these
browser drivers now what you did using
your IDE was let me
in ID was we said right in the ID itself
I said run the current test and since
I'm using Firefox browser here any test
case using the IDE plugin on your
Firefox you execute is going to execute
on the Firefox browser correct same way
if you are using the selenium IDE on
Chrome which is an extension on Chrome
and you run the test cases there it is
going to use the Chrome browser to run
the test case however any test cases or
any automation scripts you're going to
write you want your scripts to run on
all the browsers because you want to do
a cross browser testing right so for
that purpose what we do through command
line is we install this browser drivers
right so say if you want to run your
test cases on edge browser so that means
you first need to install your Edge
browse driver on your systems before you
run your test case on edge process if
you want to do it for Chrome similarly
you need to download the Chrome web
driver and install it for Firefox to say
and once you install that then you
should be able to run it on any also now
where are these Chrome browsers
available so if you go to the
seleniumhq.org let me show you that
okay in the selenium HQ website if you
go to this download tab right and if you
go down here you will see something
called as third party drivers bindings
and plugins and here you have a list of
all the browsers and its corresponding
driver files which are available and
this is what which you need to go and
download for example say I want to run
all my tests on Chrome browser right so
what I do is I click here okay in the
download session go to the latest Chrome
driver available click on that and then
depending on which OS you're working on
if you're working on Mac just download
this if you're working on Windows you
download this and once you download the
driver what you need to do is you keep
that drivers like for example uh can you
see this driver file so this is my
driver file this is my executable driver
file so what I did was I just downloaded
this file for mac and I copied it to the
location where my tests are present okay
now so once I have this available what I
need to do is I need to install this
driver using again the end PM command
and to install this driver what you need
to do is you need to be in the same
directory where your driver file is
present okay in the same directory you
just issue this command you say npm
install minus G and your Chrome driver
this is it so once you install this
driver you should be able to work with
your Chrome driver got it very simple so
similarly if you're working with
different browsers so if you also want
to run your test cases with Edge or
Internet Explorer or the Firefox browser
same way you need to download all the
drivers from this location
so from here like you have edge browser
your Opera browser you have a Mozilla
Firefox browser so any of the browser
which you want to work with you have to
just download your driver from here
place it in this location and install it
using npn command okay so since I will
not be executing this command again
because I've already installed it so
once your drivers are installed what's
the next step we are ready to execute
our test cases okay so these are all the
installation steps which are required to
get your command line Runner which is
called a selenium side Runner ready for
you to execute your test from the
command line all right okay now let's go
ahead and see how do we execute the test
cases so let's go back to our previous
example in this video where we wrote
some of the test cases for testing our
control flows okay so these are all the
test cases now if You observe here I
have not created any test Suite here we
just had a default Suite which was
created when we created the project and
we just went ahead and created all the
tests here for the side Runner to run we
need to have a test with so if I just
try to run the test let's try to run
this what is the name of this project
control flows so I'll show you what
happens if there is no test Suite
defined for this so let me clear the
screen and uh which is our project here
this one okay so what I will do is let
me simply go ahead and execute this
project so to execute any test this is
the command which you use you simply
call selenium side Runner and the
project name okay and also once you have
installed the selenium side Runner you
can also check the version of it so
let's execute this selenium side Runner
and the project name project name is
this
okay so now if I press enter now see
what happens
okay it's saying running the default
Suite can you see here it looks for a
test Suite to start its execution okay
so it picked up the default switch which
is here
okay since it was created when we
created this new project fine however
it's a test Suite failed to run why
because your test Suite must contain at
least one test and all our tests are
residing outside the test Suite we have
none in the default test way correct so
what we will do let's go ahead and
create this test Suite instead of
default what I will do is I'll say first
rename this so let's give it a proper
name so we'll say Ctrl flow test test
Suite okay done so I have renamed it now
let's go ahead and add all those test
cases which we have created to this so
I'll just simply say ADD test and select
all these tests so we have around four
tests here so I'll just select all that
done so I'll save this project
go to my folder ID tests and the same
fairly name I'll just say replace now we
have a test Suite called control flow
test now let's go ahead and run that
again now let's see what happens
okay so there are multiple test cases
here so let's see all these test cases
will be run one after the other
sequential so we have that calorie
counter test case and then we have the
loop test cases all right so it is done
so now let's understand the flow of this
test case Okay so this is where we
started running our test Suite so it
finished first test case it finished the
second test case it finished the third
test case and then the fourth test case
so all the four test cases it has
completed and it says all the four past
total four and it also shows you the
total time taken for the complete test
Suite to run and for every test case
what is the amount of time required to
execute that so this is all the
information which is available here if
at all there is a failure in any of the
test case that would get reflected here
it would say Four Past One fee and total
four executed okay so this is the kind
of report what you will get to see good
Surfer okay so let's go back to our
notes and see whether we have done
everything so the other way of running
is say you have multiple browser drivers
installed and you want to run this on a
particular browser so during that time
what you can do is you can use this
command you can say selenium site Runner
minus C minus C is nothing but setting
the capabilities capabilities for what
for the browser and then you give a
browser name here so you can say Chrome
or you can say Firefox whatever the
browser of your choice and then give
your project name so with this what
happens is if your browser is installed
now we have to install the browser using
this command correct so if your browser
is installed it will execute this
particular test Suite on the browser
which you have mentioned here right and
that is how you use the selenium side
Runner to run your test cases on
multiple process now simply what you can
do is you can create a shell script or a
bad script you can add this line into a
bad script for the multiple browsers and
you can execute this so that way all
your test cases would execute it on all
the browsers so that that way you can
achieve your cross browser testing so
other thing if you remember I also said
that command line Runner like if you go
back to our presentation it says we can
run it for parallel testing now let's
see how do we achieve this parallel
testing now to achieve this parallel
testing there are certain steps which
you need to do in the ID so let's go
back to our test Suite so we have this
test Suite so if you go here and go to
the settings can you see this run in
parallel so you need to check this
checkbox to run all these test cases in
parallel so right now what happened when
we executed it all the test cases ran
sequentially one after the other okay so
for every test case there was a Chrome
browser launched and the Chrome browser
was closed before the next test was
launched now let's try to do this I am
going to check this checkbox where it
says run in parallel and I'll say submit
I'll save this project again now same
thing I'll overwrite this project save
done replace now let's go to our
terminal window and run this test cases
again for that what I will do I'll call
the same command again however now
please observe the number of Chrome
browser windows it's going to open okay
I'll show you that so it has started
running the test Suite okay can you see
this three Chrome browser windows open
at the same time okay and one by one
they're going to get closed out okay so
there was also the fourth one open but
since the test case was so small that it
was too quick for us to see here now
look at the complete execution here so
what it has done is it opened all the
browsers in parallel okay and it ran all
the test cases parallely you will see a
big difference and since this is a very
small test case you might not be able to
see a big difference in the execution
time however if you have got a bigger or
bigger test cases which you are running
you will see a remarkable difference in
the time taken by the suite to run the
test cases still here you can see okay
it's almost 11 seconds it took whereas
in the previous example it took 13
seconds as I said the difference is very
small because our test cases are very
very minute test cases all right if you
have a bigger test cases where it
launches the browser launches your app
application under test then you are
doing multiple operations you will be
able to see a remarkable difference when
you run the test sequentially and when
you run it parallely so this is how you
work with the idea and this is how you
achieve the parallel execution okay so
that completes our selenium site Runner
now let's look at some of the
limitations of the selenium ID the first
limitation is you cannot export your ID
scripts to Webdriver scripts the support
is yet to be added right so earlier in
this video I showed you there are ways
to export the scripts to junit and
python however the previous IDE did have
this capability of exporting your
scripts to Webdriver scripts and that
support is yet to be added to the new ID
data driven testing like using Excel
files or reading data from the CSV files
and passing it to your scripts so this
capability is not yet available in the
ID so you cannot do data driven testing
database testing is also not possible so
you cannot actually connect your
database read the test data from your
database or even you cannot perform any
kind of database testing reporting
facility so it does not have a good
reporting we saw when we use the command
line Runner or through the ID when we
run the test there's a very minimal
reporting capabilities what we could see
so it does not really have uh
capabilities of reporting like your test
entry or the report engine what exactly
is the selenium Webdriver and how we can
go ahead with that
so coming back to the selenium Webdriver
so here a selenium Webdriver is one of
the most important component of this
alignment test suit when we talk about
the selenium uh tools suit over here
like we talk about okay I want to create
a whole together regression test suit so
selenium Webdriver is very important
component for that and when we talk
about uh the selenium web driver it
allows the cross browser compatibility
which means like you want to test your
applications you can have a test suit
there one for the Chrome browser one for
the Firefox one for the Internet
Explorer you can then say like okay I
want to test and validate my application
across all these three browsers and in
future if Safari browser comes in all
you have to do is like you have to just
run the same script with the web driver
of the Safari so this web driver is not
only static for One browser it's a
actually approachable for across
multiple browsers there so that enhances
the compatibility there that yes this
set test suit even if you're writing the
test suits in case of selenium it's not
limited to 1 browser so it's kind of a
cross browser here so these are small
small benefits although we are talking
about the selenium web driver here but
if you closely see these all points are
actually defining why exactly the
selenium is best when we talk about the
Weber automations or the web testing
automation here right
and then it's actually supporting
various programming languages like a
programming languages yes it's there
it's even supporting different browsers
and then of course it's supporting
different operating systems also because
you can pretty much run these test cases
are under Linux Max or Windows whatever
platform you feel like you want to use
you can pretty much use it so you don't
have to worry about like where exactly
this web driver is getting deployed and
from where you are trying to refer it so
that kind of compatibility is also
something which is available here so you
don't have to think about the uh
specific different uh versions or the
different operating systems as such over
here and then let's talk about further
on this one so it also provides the
compatibility across different
programming languages so you can see
like what are the different benefits you
got you got benefits like uh you know
it's it's supporting different
programming languages it's supporting
different browsers and ultimately it
lost it's supporting the different uh
particular uh operating systems or the
platforms here so these are small small
things like different uh benefits which
we get with the help of selenium here
and uh it's it's having the support
across different programming languages
so it doesn't matter that if you're
working with Java or if you're working
with dotnet this is going to work for
across a different different platforms
like different uh environments you can
actually deploy so these benefits are
something which can definitely help you
to see like how the overall uh benefits
can be achieved over here and uh
definitely the Chrome browsers are the
Safari the Firefox the Oprah different
uh platforms you will be able to see
like how the execution needs to be done
and how the setup used to be performed
here so that's where the complete uh
implementations uh needs to be performed
here right and these web driver provides
a faster execution of the test scripts
because that's the kind of automation
which we are looking forward that we are
not trying to see like how the systems
can be implemented so when we are trying
to talk about the automation here so
these web drivers basically help us to
go for the faster execution also so it's
not only about that we are trying to see
the setup like we are trying to go for
the configurations here it's also like
uh the performance and the efficiency
which we're getting with this one is
quite beneficial so you can get an easy
and a faster execution of the test cases
so it's it's having a lot of benefits if
we talk about in these features only
itself you can see like there are a lot
of benefits which we got over here so
it's fast it's efficient and on top of
that it's not depending on any kind of
environment it's quite generic like you
know it's it's something which you can
use for Windows you can use it for Linux
you want to use it for net you want to
use it for Java it's kind of uh generic
for a lot of Technologies platforms and
programming languages
right now why exactly we require the
selenium Webdriver like what is the
purpose of using this one so let's
explore on that part here so selenium
FIB driver provides a user-friendly
interface that could uh you know it can
be easily understood by a particular
person like when we uh when you are
using this uh selenium web driver so
this is something which you can easily
understood like uh it's pretty easy for
you to understand that and it's not that
much complex for you to understand that
okay you are going to take a lot of time
to consume you're going to take a lot of
time to uh you know understand that so
that's not a kind of interface which we
are getting when we talk of the uh
selenium web driver here right and the
web driver is something which is having
uh much more uh features as compared to
the uh selenium RC and selenium IDE
there so when we talk about the uh
selenium web driver so this is something
which is having uh much more features as
compared to the other components like
you know these the other components is
also about the selenium only but yes the
when we talk about selenium uh web
driver so it's having much more features
as compared to the selenium RC and the
selenium ID here so you don't have to
worry about the features like all
together selenium uh pep driver is
something which is quite efficient and
better as compared to the other
components so that's another benefit
which we get with the selenium here
so selenium uh we have got some other
components like a selenium remote
control here so uh RC is something which
enables the uh the creation of uh you
know automated web applications like uh
in in case of programming languages such
as Java C sharp uh node.js different
different programming languages are
there so we can pretty much uh use the
remote control uh selenium remote
control over here which will enable the
uh the creation of the automated web
applications there so that's the purpose
of using the selenium remote control
here it's uh it's not something which is
being used nowadays because most of the
functionalities have nowadays moved on
to the uh selenium web driver here so
that's a migration which has happened
over there and that's the reason why we
are not going to use much of the
selenium remote control over here so
that's not being used as such as
compared to the other components but yes
the selenium Webdriver is something
which is quite popular and because of
its features and the efficiency we are
going to use uh the particular uh browse
the uh web driver as compared to the any
other component as such here right now
selenium IDE
needs not additional any kind of setup
is required like uh you know apart from
installation of the browser because uh
in that case everything will be
integrated in that like because we are
using we are integrating in the complete
uh selenium IDE over here so all you
need to do is like you need to do the
installation of Chrome browser that's
also because you want to go for the uh
specific Chrome driver which you require
for the execution of the test cases so
for that only you are basically trying
to install the Chrome browser but other
than that there is no other component
which you actually require when we talk
about the selenium IDE here
so uh the IDE makes the life easy
because it helps us to go ahead with the
debugging mode here like a kind of a
debugging environment you will be able
to do that so even if there is any kind
of issue any any kind of problem which
comes up so it will be very easy for you
to debug those things and go ahead with
that part so uh tracking the exceptions
managing the exception so all those
things can be easily handled up with the
help of the selenium IDE here so
selenium IDE is something which is kind
of a bigger package which is uh further
comprising of different different
components like it's something which is
giving us a variety of things here right
now how exactly the selenium web driver
is at all different from the selenium
rzn IDE because those are also the
solution which is available there from
this Lane now unlike the selenium IDE
selenium Webdriver can actually work
with different browsers so that's
something which we have already focused
on that it's having the compatibility
across multiple uh browsers there that's
the first benefit which we get over here
in this one now also the web drivers is
something which does not require any
user to start the server or anything
like that there so just in case of a
selenium RC you have to start some
server because you're ultimately
connecting to that server and that's how
the communication is happening but that
kind of stuff is not there in the uh
selenium web driver here
also the selenium Webdriver is an API
and it's not a GUI based plugin so uh
it's it's something which can easily
handle like uh it's having the uh quite
uh efficient uh connectivity or you can
say like the uh integration is also good
there because we most of the application
nowadays are working on the API format
which is pretty generic so with there is
no GUI based interface which we have to
explore or which we need to integrate
here so it's all like other apis call
which we need to do in order to use uh
make use of the selenium web driver here
now in selenium Webdriver the apis are
entirely object oriented in nature as
compared to the selenium RC and selenium
ID so which is not a kind of object
oriented in nature but selenium
Webdriver is something which is quite
object oriented here also uh web driver
the selenium web driver is actually uh
supports multiple
listeners right so uh which is available
there as compared to selenium RC and
selenium ID here so these are some
couple of features which is available
there also it also supports the testing
of the IOS and Android which is not
being supported in the RCN IDE there
because most of the applications are
nowadays also have the counterpart
Android or the iOS applications so if
you don't have the interface or
integration with those platforms then
it's a incomplete way of testing here so
not only the web applications but even
the mobile applications also now getting
integrated with the help of the selenium
Webdriver here so these kind of features
which is not exactly available in the RC
or the ID over here but definitely it's
it's going to be available there in case
of selenium web driver so what exactly
is the overall need of the web driver
like the selenium Webdriver here so uh
let's talk about that that uh how
exactly we can use it for the software
automation here so there are a couple of
benefits which is available there so
let's focus on that one by one the very
first one is the open source now it's
something which is available or which is
available as an open source over here
which means like it's something which
you can use without any license without
any cost uh just like that you can go to
the selenium.dev website and you can
start downloading the selenium related
uh details also limited components
second is multilingular support it's
having the support for different kind of
programming languages not only for the
Java based applications it's actually
supporting like different different
programming languages so you just have
to learn one single tool and then can
survive or that can support multiple
programming languages here several
operating system support yes it's not
only related to the windows or Linux
platform here so it's actually supported
across uh Windows Linux Mac OS different
operating systems are actually supported
here so different operating systems is
supported by this particular selenium
here multiple Frameworks are there so
that's a multiple framework support
which is available in this one uh user
friendly it's quite user friendly there
and the developers were more comfortable
with the Java programming languages so
they get a quite a comfortable and
integrated with the selenium because
it's also using the same Java syntax
over here in this one it's cross device
testing uh definitely both mobile
desktops are different platforms
different operating systems Mac OS iOS
Android different uh platforms are
actually supported by this uh particular
selenium here so selenium Webdriver is
something which is having like cross
device testing here
Community Support is there it's kind of
Open Source yes but uh it's having a
very good Community like a lot of people
are actually there who can contribute to
this selenium you can get the
information from there and it's kind of
a huge efforts like a kind of a huge
Community efforts which you can see over
here in this case also a compatibility
testing so it's having a very good
compatibility here so uh when you're
working with this uh selenium so it's
compatible with pretty much any
programming languages any platform any
operating system so that kind of
benefits you get with the help of this
selenium web driver here and uh unlike a
selenium RC you don't have to start any
kind of server component here uh which
you need to connect so it's like uh on
demand like when you're running the
scripts uh kind of a local Chrome
browser will be uh initialized
and your test cases will be executed and
uh performed and that that's how the
whole executions will be performed there
so there is no involved like you have to
go somewhere start some server start
some remote server there and then the
communication or the execution of the
test cases will be initialized so it's
not like that kind of communication here
right so let's talk about the uh web
driver architecture here now in this one
there are some different uh components
which is available there in this
architecture components the very first
one is the selenium language bindings
here now these are actually available in
different different programming
languages like Java Ruby python c-sharp
JavaScript these are the different
programming languages bindings which is
available there then with the help of
Json wire protocol these are going to be
connected to the different drivers Now
browser drivers is the one where exactly
the request will be sent out so this
selenium Webdriver is actually going to
connect or send the request to this
drivers so uh depending on the platform
also and depending on the different uh
systems you can actually go for the
browser drivers here so you want to go
for Chrome driver you want to go for
Firefox you want to go for Opera you
want to go for Safari Edge these are the
different browsers which is available
there earlier the Internet Explorer was
also there but now in the latest version
say it uh each browser or each driver is
something which is available there and
these are going to be connected through
the actual uh particular browsers like
the Chrome Firefox and also it will be
sending the request over the HTTP the
HTTP that request will be sent out to
the real drivers so the browser drivers
and then the real drivers will be there
so the driver is going to initialize the
Chrome browser and then the whole
request will be processed there our
websites will be open the clicking the
access everything will be done after
that on that case so these are the
different uh
steps which is involved when we are
basically going for uh from one step to
another like where the communications
will be performed over here in this case
right so uh again uh it's not dependent
on any programming languages it's not
dependent on any kind of uh browser any
kind of components here so right from
the uh language bindings it will go to
the Json wire protocol from there it
will be sent out to the browser drivers
various browser drivers whatever their
browser drivers you want to use you can
use that and then those drivers are
actually going to connect with the real
drivers or with the real browsers over
here so that the communications or the
uh exact end result you should be able
to see so
for instance if you run a particular
Chrome browser a chrome driver there so
you will be able to see like a Chrome
browser getting initialized and the
website is getting accessible so all
that activity will be open or will be
performed over there so these are the
parts of the sequence these are kind of
architecture components like one to
another these will be processed or these
will be executed here right so uh these
programming language these selenium
programming languages again it's
actually a kind of a generic one so
these are the client libraries which is
available there depending on this one
for example for Java I can download some
binaries I can download some jar files
so that will be reference or utilized
into my source code for Ruby it's maybe
like different uh third party libraries
or shared libraries which will be
available there for python it will be
available in the form of modules uh
c-sharp JavaScript so each and every
programming languages is actually having
its own uh
libraries now these libraries are
actually required so that we can get the
whole interface of the selenium it's
okay like I am writing some test cases
I'm writing the complete test suit and
I'm using it but unless and until I
import my uh selenium libraries it will
not work for me I will not be able to
work on that part because I will not be
able to get those features as such in
order to get those features I need to
download these bindings or these kind of
language bindings there corresponding to
my programming language and these are
easily available on the selenium website
so if you go to the selenium website
whatever the programming languages you
want to follow you can download these
findings these windings will be nothing
but the archives where you will be
having some kind of executables
depending on that programming language
right now from there uh we will be using
our libraries like these bindings in
order to interact in order to initialize
the selenium so then we will be going to
the Json wire protocol so it's kind of a
connector between the libraries and the
web drivers now uh programmingly uh
using these uh with the help of these uh
client libraries we're going to send the
request to the web drivers it also helps
to enable the transfer of data between a
server and client because of course uh
you have to get your end result process
right so that's where you need to go for
the execution so what you're going to do
is like you're going to see like okay I
am going to run or I'm going to execute
this uh Json wire protocol over here and
it's going to connect between my client
libraries and the web drivers here so
that's the communications and the
connectivity which we want to establish
or we want to provide here now these are
selenium browser drivers are actually uh
specific browsers now because the Json
wire is going to connect uh to the
specific uh browsers uh the drivers here
so that the communication can be happen
now uh these drivers are actually used
uh as in drivers in order to interact
with the exact browser because these are
not the exact browser now if you want to
interact with the Chrome then you
definitely have to use the Chrome driver
if you want to use for the Firebox then
you have to use the Firefox driver so
depending on the programming language
you have to Define like which driver you
really need to process or you need to
really go ahead with that part so that's
where the selenium browser drivers
really comes into the picture and then
uh the exact browsers will be there now
once the executions will be done at last
you will be able to see like all these
browsers getting open if you're going to
use the Chrome browser then Chrome
browser will be initialized if you're
using the Firefox then the Firefox
browser will be initialized so whatever
the browser driver specific driver you
will eyes so according to that you will
see a particular browser being invoked
over here so that's how the
communication happens and it's kind of a
sequence here like step by step here so
each and every stage is very important
because that's how the communication
will happen over here and you will get
the end result or the desired output if
you have any kind of feeling component
over here so that's where the whole
connectivity will be breakdown and you
will not be able to get any kind of
values X expected so this is something
which we really need to consider or we
need to go ahead with that part here if
getting your learning started is half
the battle what if you could do that for
free visit skill up by simply learn
click on the link in the description to
know more
so what are the different drawbacks
which we got with the help of the
selenium Webdriver here so when we talk
about the selenium web driver so what
are the different drawbacks which we are
getting over here so that we can
understand like how exactly we can talk
about that part here now the drawbacks
of a selenium web driver is something
which we uh you know use because this is
kind of uh main component you can say
like you know using which you can
actually do the complete validation but
the problem is that it's not something
which you can use for the desktop
application so for the desktop
application this does not works so this
web driver is something which is uh
supported for the web applications only
it's not something which we can use for
the desktop applications as such so
that's a kind of a limitation which we
get with the help of the selenium web
driver here so it's only there for the
websites for the web portals
secondly the it requires the acceptance
of the teams uh you know in order to
manage these scripts because these are
the programming languages of course
there although it's a test suit but uh
it requires a programming language
efforts as such in order to go ahead
with that in order to manage these
things so it requires a kind of export
team who can actually handle these
scripts or we can work on these
requirements so uh that's a kind of
overhead because if it's not like very
easy to manage these like uh pretty much
a person who is an expert in these
things can only handle these kind of
requirements so it's kind of a
limitation where we will be only
depending on an expert to manage these
scripts as such right now um it's not
having any kind of uh reporting inbuilt
or reporting capability over here so
it's not available in this one so test
reports which is getting generated here
is uh with the help of the junit and
test NG so there is no default reporting
mechanism which is available over here
in this one so we only have the
mechanism of the junit like we can
extend our test scripts in selenium by
integrating with jhunit and the test NG
here so that we will be able to get a
proper reporting so for the uh reporting
purposes we actually use the components
like this junit and the test NG over
here to go ahead with that so these are
the ways in which we can actually go for
the integration where we can integrate
the selenium and the other Frameworks
like junit and the uh test NG kind of
component same
and that's a whole basis because alone
the selenium Webdriver is something
which can execute the scripts process
the request but it's not going to handle
any kind of uh reporting mechanism so
reporting mechanism is something which
you can only get with the help of the
junit or the test uh NG here because
these are the additional packages which
you need to integrate so it's it's a
kind of a custom solution which we need
to design uh you know where we don't
have only the web driver available over
here like the core components but also
we have like other components available
over there which will be of course
having the other components like distant
G and the change unit here so that's
also something which you can integrate
all together with this one right also uh
it's very difficult to manage there is a
lot of management or the maintenance
activity which we get over here also
it's very difficult to scale this up
also depending on the load or depending
on the requirement it's very difficult
to scale it up also if you are using for
some in infrastructure some kind of a
load there so having it increased to a
different level is kind of a difficult
task here also maintenance activity is
quite huge so if you want to have a
proper materials or management you have
to get a couple of uh you know experts
in that case so that they can easily
manage those things so these are the
different requirements which is
available there where we can see like
how exactly the uh we can you know
manage all these things now it also uh
you know allows the cross browser uh
compatibility testing here so uh it's
something which can easily handle like
different requests across the browsers
so um image testing is not available so
uh you don't have to uh you know use the
selenium alone like selenium alone is
not compatible for testing the images
here so if you really want to test the
images so you have to integrate secretly
uh in with your selenium so that you can
have a complete package so again a
selenium is some cases it's not
sufficient for like most or a variety of
things there so in some cases you have
to actually
go for any of the tool Integrations so
that you can have the complete details
you can have the complete component here
so that's where the real mechanism comes
in like yes uh you don't have the exact
single tool available for taking care of
all these things but yes you can have
all these things integrated with the
other tools other components there and
from there you will be able to get a
complete values and the complete
implementation here right so these are
the you know different uh drawbacks
which we get once we start using the a
web driver here so let's go ahead uh
with the uh particular demo over here to
understand like how exactly the selenium
Webdriver can be utilized can be used so
that we will be able to run some test
scripts here so we are going to run a
prepare a test suit here so that we can
get it executed with the help of
selenium so that's what we are trying to
do here so for this one we require some
couple of components to be there like
the jdk eclipse and all so let's talk
about that component so let's go ahead
with the implementation
so let's begin with the uh
configurations of this web driver here
now the very first thing which we
require is that we require to the
installation of the Java here now let's
uh go ahead with this URL so now this
one is something where we have to see
like how uh we can go for the
installation of the uh jdk here now here
we need to go for the jdk installation
that's the version which we want to
install now it variety of our versions
are available there like which version
you want to install you can go with that
GDK 11 8 it is the most stable version
so you can go ahead with the jdk8 here
so you can download here
different platforms it's available like
Windows platform uh whatever the
platform is there all you need to do is
like you need to just download this exe
file now once the exe file is downloaded
so what happens like you will be able to
do the installation now I have done the
installation of this jdk here so if I
have to open my command prompt here I
would be easily able to see that I'm
using a jdk version of
1.8.0 over here in this one so that's a
version which I'm using but I've gained
of course if you're using some different
version of gdkit that will also work
here the only thing is that you need to
see that you need to go for a compatible
browser a compatible uh Java and the
compatible Eclipse tool here so that's
what you require now what I'm going to
do is like I'm going to install or
download the eclipse browser also now
let's download the eclipse here now we
got an official website of eclipse here
from where we can download these eclipse
different platform you can do it like uh
this is the one which is available there
now you can click on download this one
so that will help you to download the
eclipse here so uh here the uh download
will work just like that you can do the
download here even if you want to go for
a different offerings like uh you want
to go for different platform uh you feel
like uh you want to decide that which
package actually you need to do because
uh in the eclipse also you got like
different things
um IDE Eclipse IDE for the Java
developers for uh the C plus C plus plus
so different uh different uh operating
system and different uh packages are
also available there so it's basically
up to you like which exactly environment
you want to follow
so I want to download this uh 64-bit
over here in this one so let's download
this here now uh let's Again download
this this is kind of a exe file which is
available here so let's download it
again now um it will be working on like
uh it's kind of a download which is
getting started over here so it's close
to 102 MB which is available there this
is the sdq table which is going to help
us to do the installation of eclipse now
this is the uh latest version uh 2020
version is what it is getting installed
over here
um and uh it's completely there I have
already got the jdk installed because of
the fact that using this jdk the eclipse
will be open if you don't have the jdk
install the Java runtime then the
eclipse will not be installed for you so
uh in order to get the eclipse uh
installed in executable perfectly fine
you need uh the jdk install to be done
here so we got like one more minute here
to complete the download and this is
just 102 MB package or installer which
is available there and once this is
installed we will be able to get ahead
with this installation of the eclipse
here so once the eclipse is installed
all you can do is like you can go ahead
with the uh particular configurations
you can create some couple of projects
in case of eclipse
um then we'll also see like how we can
download the
programming languages binding so that
also we are going to download so these
are the different components which
you're going to explore while working on
this one so uh let's wait for this uh
download of this is Equitable to be
performed here so that we will be able
to proceed further with this one so
let's wait for that so it's hardly
taking one minute more to complete it
so selenium and Eclipse both are the
Open Source One you're getting a donate
to a close Community page there because
that's a donation which they want but
again you can use it like 100 open
source and free of cost here so you
don't have to pay any cost as such over
here in this case so there is no cost
associated with this one so just 10
seconds more and uh then we can pursue
with the installation of the eclipse
here and here we go so the installer is
almost done here so I can pretty much go
ahead and open the file so this will
help me to do the installation of the
eclipse here so the eclipse installer is
what it's getting started initialized
over here in this one
uh now the Java runtime is already
available with me we require the uh
specific uh jdeck installed the Java
command line is working we can download
the eclipse here and uh then we can go
for the uh specific executions like we
can go and uh download the uh browser
drivers here now the thing is that if
you really want to go for the Chrome
browser or Firefox or any kind of those
things in case of your uh particular
system in case of your Windows machine
over here you don't have to necessarily
go for any kind of uh a kind of a driver
as such here because of the fact we got
a links over here like this Mozilla for
the Firefox uh this one is there for the
uh particular selenium this one is there
for the Chrome now Chrome is something
which we have already got here like we
have already got the Chrome browser
installed
but let's see like uh we can download
this driver also like uh depending on
that we can go ahead with that part and
then we can also download the Java
client uh libraries over there from the
bindings over there from the uh specific
selenium dot Dev website over there and
uh we can download and we can integrate
it so let's do it one by one so first of
all let's see like you know once the
installation of the eclipse is done and
then we'll be able to go ahead with the
third component or the third request
which is the a web driver or a
particular Chrome browser a driver over
here so this installer is going to give
us the same thing here so I'm going for
the uh specific Java developer here so
let's go for the installation here now
this is going to uh install uh the uh
Java 8 right uh this runtime over here
so uh if you feel like you want to use
the jdk 11 because that's something
which is available there now if you're
using an existing ones like uh you're
already using a an existing once over
here the jdk and also uh that's where
the installation is going on like uh
it's it's going on with that part here
but we already got some system related
uh gdks which is installed but uh you
feel like you want to go ahead with this
one
um like you're not doing these separate
installation of the jdk or JRE so there
you can actually use this once here so
let's select this one like I pretty much
want to use like any one of these uh
jvms over here like which I feel like I
can configure or I can utilize so that's
pretty much we can do here so it's like
uh we can use these variables like we
can go for these jvms or if you feel
like you can go for an external jvm also
there so it all depends on you like how
the uh installation you want to perform
here
right and this is the location Let's uh
go for the desktop location there
and or you can go for the default
location also over here in this one so
let's go for the installation now just
accept it and uh the installation will
be proceeded over here so uh even if you
have not done a separate JTAG
installation so this will basically have
a jdk installed I have selected the Java
11 over here but you can go for the 15
also in this case in this scenario so
the whole installation of the eclipse is
what it's happening over here
so once the eclipse is installed so then
we can pretty much go ahead with the
next component there which is like uh
dealing with the uh specific selenium
related components and Chrome browser
again it's already something which is
installed there but we'll see like how
we can download the Chrome driver how we
can configure and we can utilize that so
that's what we're going to follow here
so it's going for the installation and
uh it's something which we are trying to
do like uh it's uh this installer is
pretty much downloading some couple of
components as such uh like this J uh JRE
is something which is getting installed
or downloaded from the eclipse website
and uh that's where the uh you know all
the components is getting installed so
one by one all the components will be
downloaded from the eclipse website here
and it's a complete package which means
like you don't have to necessarily go
for a separate installation there is
another installer which is available for
Eclipse where you just have to unzip up
for a zip file and you can pretty much
use it but in this case
this is something which is having all
these things integrated all together
inside that so that's another component
which is being available here
so the installation is still going on
there so uh it depends because all these
things are getting cached uh from the
internet so it also depends on like how
much size of file is getting downloaded
here so let's uh you know let's uh wait
for the installations to be complete and
then we'll proceed further so now the
installation is done so we can launch
our Eclipse here so that's what we are
trying to launch here now apart from
eclipse what happens like we require
some other components also like we
require this linear web driver also
there so for that we have to download
the Java related client bindings so for
that uh Chrome browser first of all it's
already installed so we don't have to do
any kind of installation there uh yes I
can go ahead with the exe file like of
the Chrome browser driver that I'm going
to use it so I'm going to open the uh
specific downloads here now in this
segment what happens like selenium.dev
is the website which is available there
now here we can go for the downloads now
related to your programming language
whatever gaming language you are trying
to use so you can download the language
binding for that now language binding is
something which is utilized so using
which you will be able to see like how
you can establish the connectivity it's
just a kind of a libraries where you can
do the connectivity and you can see that
execution so what I'm going to do is
like I'm going to download this binding
save so let's download this one now it's
again available as a zip file which is
available there so uh depending on the
version you can go for the beta download
version also now I'm going for the
stable version which we want to utilize
we want to refer it so it's going to
download zip file so this ZIP file will
have all the jar files and all the
required libraries there
and when I'm going to create a project
into my eclipse at that moment of time I
would be requiring all these components
like all these uh various uh libraries I
should be added up into my uh project as
such in case of the eclipse so that's
what I need to do here so let's go to
the eclipse here so here we are going to
expand this like a package Explorer and
here we're going to go to file new and
Java project so I'm going to create a
Java project over here so
um in which we will be creating some
couple of class files in which we will
be having the selenium related test
cases like how we want to process or how
we want to execute that part so I'm
going to proceed with that part so let's
put the uh project name here so I'm
going to say like selenium
just a project name I want to put uh
then the jdk now if you want to go for a
specific jdk like another version so you
can go with that but right now I'm using
like jdk 1.8 which is pretty much
configured so I can use that uh you feel
like you want to use uh the specific JRE
of uh uh GRE which is available as part
of jdk 1.8 that also you can use or if
you want to use like a jdk so that also
something which you can utilize over
here in this one so there are different
things like you can configure the gr's
also so if you have some custom path
which uh where you have the Java
available or the jdk or Jr is available
there so that also you can easily refer
it so you can simply say that yes uh
this so and so location I want to refer
I want to see my source code so that's
where you can do the you can go for the
execution now once you're providing
these values like the install Gres which
you want to provide which you want to
process here next thing what you need to
perform is like you need to go ahead
with that execution so I'm completely
okay with the jdk whatever the
environment I want to process I can
easily do that and I'm completely okay
with that
right so let's go with that part and
then click on next
and this is the source directory which
is available there right and if you want
to add any additional libraries so uh
here exactly you can add your selenium
related libraries using which you will
be able to see your source code working
fine but I'm not going to do that
activity here so I'm going to do that
later on so that we can get a complete
things in a sequence
and then here we go like finish so you
will be able to get
the gr related libraries and the source
folder here so right now it's completely
empty project there is nothing available
as such here and what I'm going to do is
like I'm going to create a class file
over here to see to be the specific
source code of the selenium to how the
web driver is getting loaded up and
processed so that's stuff we are going
to talk about here so let's see like
what content we need to really put up
over here in this one now if we
downloaded this selenium programming
language bindings here so let me extract
it
uh you can pretty much keep it into the
eclipse folders also or if you wish you
can keep it aside in some specific
folder because it's just going to be
referred with every project so it's just
a kind of a shared release which is
available there so whatever project you
want to onboard you want to use so this
kind of uh package or this kind of uh
share Library you can easily utilize and
you can implement it so we are just
trying to extract it now once the
extraction is done so you will be able
to see like some couple of files and
folders uh now this is having a
particular uh two executable files like
client number combined this is kind of
connecting uh acting like a selenium
client and which is using to connect and
process all the requirements
we also have a sources file which is
available for this one but again it's
something which depends on the
requirement so you don't have to put
these sources uh jar file also over here
because that's not required so you can
pretty much uh use this executable jar
file because in this one you will not
have any kind of source then of course
uh your uh selenium related jar file is
further on dependent on some
dependencies like this so these jar
files are also uh something which you
should be putting up into your uh
specific
um a shared Library so that your
selenium related jar files should not
started failing so uh we'll we'll try
that scenario also so that we can get
the complete output and complete in
science here so let's see now uh we'll
go to this uh we'll import this
particular file over there and for that
we have to write a class file so let's
see like how we can do that so we have
already got the selenium web driver so
uh the eclipse is what we have followed
so we have created a new uh jar project
now we want to create a new class file
the build path configurations we will be
taking care of that later on but right
now we are going to see like how we can
proceed further with that so I I'm going
for this uh specific component here
right so uh whatever the browser or
whatever the driver you want to follow
you can do that so Firefox if you want
to use you want to use our Chrome
browser it all depends on you like it
all depends on the away like how you
want to configure it so uh let's see
let's uh import this uh particular
component here now if the specific uh
Firefox browser is installed that's
great if it's not installed so you can
just go back here so here you will be
able to see like this browsers like
these specific components which is
available here
so this is the driver which is available
so for the windows 64-bit you can Again
download this one here
so whatever the platform you want like
if you want to use for the Chrome
browser you can go for that if you want
to go for the Firefox Edge whatever the
driver you feel like you want to go you
can do go with that part here
so let's uh open this one here and
extract this one also so that we should
be able to refer it over here into our
specific source code so this is the
driver this is the exe file which is
available there now all we need to do is
like we need to just open our Eclipse
there so uh in our Eclipse uh we should
be using or we should be referring to
this one here so this is a kind of a
path which is available similarly we
will also be giving a path over there so
that uh we can refer to that specific uh
driver that driver over here so let me
open that and uh let's see so I'm going
to create a class file here you can
create a package
called com and in that package you can
further on create a class file
like
selenium test
uh
it's also uh depends like this is just a
custom name so uh you feel like you want
to give some different name you can
go for uh you know any kind of class
name over here but this is something
which is uh something we are going to
see like how the execution needs to be
performed and needs to be done here so
there are different uh you know names
like uh you want to follow some
different name you can do that also
now if you see closely here let me save
the file here now in this one you are
getting some errors uh related to this
one like you're getting the uh error
codes related to the Imports here like
how the uh specific execution should be
done here right now the thing is that uh
this is something which is uh really
causing the problems uh like how the
import or the execution should be done
right also uh the thing is that uh
we require these Imports to be available
there right so uh that's definitely we
are requiring over here and uh that's
that's something which we uh require uh
we want to process as such also so right
now let's uh have an uh particular
Declaration of the uh package also there
because it's something which is there in
the com package so let's have the
package com also here so it's there in
the com package uh but again those
errors are not related to that so these
are like related to the configurations
which we are trying to put and uh during
the copy pastry there might be a
conversion of the code so that I have
taken care great so uh let's see now
what I have to really do is like we have
to see like how we can proceed further
on the uh for the most executions and we
need to get this driver like we need to
get this one so I'll right click on my
project here and go to the build path
and click on configure build path
so first I'm going to uh add my binding
jar file there the Java binding the jar
file which I downloaded just now this
client combined one here so only this
jar file we are trying to add up over
here and with that most of the uh
related errors related to that uh
Imports will be resolved now I'm not
sure that how it's going to work how
it's going to uh you know function
whether it's going to success or failure
that's a different story but yes all you
have done is like I right clicked on my
project going to the build path went to
the configure build path here and went
for the add external charge so these are
the external jars which you have to do
we have to put up over here
so only the combined client combined jar
file is what I have put up over here in
this one in the referenced libraries you
will immediately be able to know that
part of the jar file here
now this is the directory where you will
be having the exe file available for
that driver for the Firefox so let's get
the path for our component also so we
got the path so let me paste it over
here
and here we go so we got the path here
this is the folder where we got our
driver available here and let's try to
resolve it let's try to run it over here
great
so now I'm going to right click here
just say run as and Java application
now in this one I got an error saying
that some com Google common collect
emittable map some class file is not
available there this is the fact that I
did not imported those uh dependent jar
files also which we got downloaded from
the uh Java binding file here so that
zip file was also having some of the jar
files there in the library folders so in
this one also you will be able to see
like some executions of the jar files is
required over here as an inputs as a
standard Imports so let's import this
one and this is the reason why we got
the error at the first place because we
are not importing those ones those jar
files which is being required by our
client combined jar file also so these
are the dependent jar files which we are
trying to import here so ultimately and
last you will be able to have your
referenced libraries available here with
all these jar files component available
here
right now since our driver is configured
everything is configured now the next
thing which we require is the browser
now I have the Chrome browser but
unfortunately I don't have the Firefox
browser so let's go ahead and download
the Firefox browser so for that
let's open the browser so I'm going to
download a Firefox browser over here
into my system so uh the official
website is something which is quite good
so we can go for the download Firefox
here now uh why because I require now
I'm using the Firefox here if I am using
the Chrome browser I will not be having
or facing any kind of issues as such but
since I'm using the Firefox uh driver so
I require Firefox browser so the
dependency of the browser is there when
we want to go ahead because uh pretty
much my uh code base is going to connect
or this
one is going to connect to the driver
here but driver ultimately internally or
require a browser show that it can
perform these occasions it can do that
execution so these drivers are going to
just uh communicate between the your
source code and the actual browser here
so uh after the driver you also require
the browser to be installed like the
Chrome browser to be available here so
that you can pretty much use it and you
can perform the configuration so let's
see uh we are getting the browser over
here in this one and uh we got the
browser installed perfectly fine over
here so we should be able to see the
browser because in this one we are
basically trying to open the browser and
getting a website called
www.google.com here and then we are
having a particular sleep one and then
ultimately the driver is getting good
here
so let's see so once the browser is
downloaded and installed so right click
on run as Java application
so you will be able to see the browsing
here so okay it's connecting the browser
the Firefox exe file is getting executed
a browser is getting executed and it
will be maximized automatically you can
see here like it's you know getting
maximized automatically here and uh we
just have to wait for a couple of
seconds more and uh here we go we got
the browser closed automatically also
because there was a slip of a couple of
seconds over here and you got the
failure like you got the complete uh
component or it got the driver closed
there driver close means that definitely
the browser will also be closed here and
you can see here that the specific
output which is being performed or which
is getting executed over here it's
actually showing us like how the
executions and the uh setup needs to be
performed or needs to be done here
so this is the way that how
the pro the implementations really
performed or really gets executed over
here in this case you got the browser
execution and everything will be
perfectly fine so again I'm right
clicking over here just click on run as
Java application the same browser will
be open again uh it will be
automatically refreshed you will see
that progress like this and after a
couple of seconds uh the thread will be
on sleep but yes after that it will be
closed automatically over here so like
that you can program how to open a
website how to proceed further from
there you want to click on some buttons
you want to do some processing that's
all up to you like how you program how
you code it over here so this completely
helps you to see like how exactly you
can go ahead with the complete program
and this program will help you to
execute a good amount of testing
validations and running or executing
some couple of test cases so this is
what we have in this demo where we saw
like how we can configure the different
drivers the web driver the browser
driver an ultimately the browser and the
selenium web driver here so you're using
the selenium web driver over here which
is going to invoke the browser driver
and this browser driver is going to
invoke the browser as such over here in
this case so that's it for this demo
let's move on to main content here so
that was the demo in which we executed a
very simple program in order to execute
the selenium Webdriver which is going to
further invoke the browser driver the
Firefox driver and then it was invoking
the specific implementations there right
so this is what we did and if we
summarize this demo so in this one we
downloaded uh the selenium Webdriver we
installed it we configured it we
integrated the eclipse with the selenium
Webdriver
and we also executed a specific test
script in order to see like how a
particular browser will be imported and
the previous case is yes the browser was
invoking a www.google.com website there
and we were getting the response
accordingly and that was the executions
mechanism like that's a whole basis that
how the selenium test cases used to work
and used to be integrated over there so
this is the complete way that how
exactly we did this demo here
first of all you should have Java 8 in
your system to run selenium
3.03 plus I would say so you should have
Java 8 if you want to run selenium 3
plus okay you can verify whether you
have Java and uh version 8 plus or Not
by going to command promises Java hyphen
version and since see if you have the
latest function of Java or more if you
don't have downloaded from the link
provided right here and install that in
your system and configure it second
selenium 3.3.1 is mentioned right here
but now the latest version is 3.5.3 you
can simply download the latest version
whatever you get from the selenium
website okay uh here it is talking about
the sdng so we'll be talking about test
NG at the later point when we will be
talking about unit testing framework so
as of now you don't need to download it
no need okay you don't need to download
it just set up selenium and Java in your
system system and make it ready
because from now onwards we'll be
writing the script consolation now let's
talk about the Project's setup steps so
first create a new Java project and give
a name
second create a new source folder and
provide this suitable name
so Source folder is automatically
created so you don't need to worry about
the signal right click on test Source
folder create a new package and provide
a suitable name this scripts so here
we'll be going to create a new
package we have already we already have
a package that is called as selenium
examples
so we will use it right click on test
Source folder create a new folder and
name it as resources
right click on the project create a new
folder and name it a slip so why they
are calling it as resources and why they
are calling it as left let me tell you
that
so they are asking us to create two new
folders in the project so like saying
new folder
give it a name resources and this
resources we will be going to keep all
our drivers that is Chrome driver
Firefox driver all those drivers it is
also to go it is also asking me to
create event okay that is also asking me
to create one more folder that is called
as lib
okay so in this lab we'll be going to
store all our selenium libraries
okay so earlier how we set up so there
are two ways to set up one is you are
going to the project
go to properties shower build path add
external jars and you select the
libraries which you want to add
okay the second one is you go to lib you
don't go you just create a left folder
you go here copy the libraries paste it
here inside this after pasting it doing
the right click do the right click and
say say
here's that let's see I completely not
here why I'm not getting that option you
can try it right now if you like
so download the libraries create a new
folder right in this in a project by
creating the folder you will get here
live and you can paste all your
libraries right into this folder and
then you can select your library
do the right click and then you will get
an option add to build path
you can then add your libraries directly
to your build path so how it helps
it actually helps you to manage all your
libraries at one project
and it will be configured in your
project how to add libraries into the
lib folder just copy the library
come here and paste it and done
so here if I go to Left folder copy it
and paste it
and done it will be added or you can do
the right click
go to properties
copy this path the location where this
lip folder is present
you can copy it
paste it here and here you can paste
your libraries this is also an option
after that you select your libraries do
the right click and there you will get
an option add to build path okay and
then the libraries will be added to the
build path
meanwhile I would suggest you to try
yourself as well it will be there in
your in your eclipse
you won't you won't face any issues like
I am facing
so that's what we do uh it is just that
uh we do create a library here so that
we can maintain all the libraries in one
folder in the same project instead of
you know go and explore like it is or
search for the libraries
it's completely there is no difference
you can use any way you can use any
approach just that when you do the right
click in the project and go to
properties and do add external jars then
it is getting added from some different
location
but here you are creating a folder in
your own project where you are working
so you don't need to go here and there
to search for the libraries that's it
yes it goes to the reference library
uh after you add it to the build path it
is you know adding it to the adding
files to the left reference library it
is same no difference do the setup okay
today itself so here you can see they
have created a lip folder on top of that
they have created two more folder that
is one is source and one is test so this
is what that we actually get it there is
no need to create test folder if there
is a 11 comes if you know build tool
even comes
then you will see automatically all
these architecture will be created it's
by default comes when you work on level
okay this is how they are saying that
your folder structure will look like
this
then they are asking us to add you know
libraries so they are asking us to copy
the downloaded selium jar into the left
folder like I have shown you
in this one
they are asking us to add the drivers in
the resources folder so just add the
drivers and the resources folder
asking us to test add the test engine
Library just ignore for the time being
will not be going to do that
and here you can see that guys
okay great away I hope you must be
getting the build path option and add to
build path by right clicking on the
project
so there are two ways like I mentioned
one is you select all the libraries and
say build path add to build path or
another way is add to external Char
files so you can choose any way it's up
to you if you don't have Chrome and ie
then install those browsers as well guys
it's for you as well if you don't have
IE and chrome just download them as well
no surajit you don't require any GitHub
account to get the checkout driver you
just what you need to do is go to Jayco
driver version and here you have Windows
zip file click on it and it will
download the zip file for you and that's
it done you don't need to create any
kind of a you know any account and all
that if you have an older version of
Firefox and install the latest version
so that we can work on latest version
and guys make sure that you have Chrome
in Firefox because these are the main
browser people uses and we'll be working
on all these browsers as well so this is
how they are showing us that you know it
has been added so they have maintained
the resources in a package but we are
maintaining it in a separate folder and
it is always suggested maintain your
driver's in a folder here you can for
the time being you can ignore this the
package okay so let's create this
architecture of course I have the
architecture correct
you have already created that and for in
resources let's copy the Jayco driver
Chrome driver and I driver as well so
let's go to that uh selenium resources
so here I have stored all my library all
my you know exes and libraries Etc so
here I need to add the Jaco driver how
to download whatever and repeating it
once again just take a look here for The
Deco driver click on this version
clicked on it you will get this page go
down you will get a zip file here click
on it and download it and unzip it
download it and unzip that that's it
second Chrome driver click on the latest
version 2.31 let it open you'll you will
get Chrome driver click on the zip file
it will get downloaded and then unzip it
and that's it after that IE driver so
for ID driver just move your cursor up
move your cursor up and here you can see
there's a different section completely
Internet Explorer driver server okay
so click on 64-bit windows
IE when you click on it it will start
downloading the IE driver server and
done so all the three drivers are
downloaded and now you can unzip them
and after unzipping you can add them to
your resource folder so gecko driver
copy this paste it and resource folder
go back let's see Chrome drivers this is
my Chrome driver
let me go inside copy this
again paste it here Ctrl V going back
Internet Explorer driver server open
this copy it paste it and done all the
three drivers has been placed in the
folder you don't need to add them into
the build path okay don't add them into
the build path so you just need to add
the libraries into the build path not
the resources okay okay all the setup is
done no more setup is required now
in this session we will Begin by
learning what X part is what is its
relevance and in the process of learning
about XPath we shall see its syntax and
different types of XPath locators we
shall learn the types of XPath different
text path functions and lastly we will
see XPath access while we learn all of
these we shall see the syntax often
along the side
but before we begin make sure that you
have subscribed to our YouTube channel
and click that Bell icon so that you can
never miss an update from Simply learn
okay so without further Ado let's get
started with what is XPath
expat stands for XML path language it is
a selenium technique that is used to
navigate through the HTML structure of a
web page it is a syntax or language that
makes finding elements on a web page
possible using XML bar expression
there are other locators in selenium
that search for elements using tax or
css class names and they are simple to
use but then they are not always
sufficient and effective there are times
when you need to select all Dom elements
of an HTML document which is when XPath
comes to your rescue the XPath helps in
dynamically searching elements with a
web page giving sufficient flexibility
to the user it has always been an
essential part of an automation script
development to locate a web element and
it has always been a challenging task to
find the correct useful and accurate
locator in an automation test
development process this is when XPath
comes to the picture and provides its
various functions to help write
effective experts and selenium
automation there may be times when
elements can be hard to find with
General locators like ID name class Etc
and this is when expat is used to locate
those elements on the web page
we can use expat in selenium on both XML
and HTML documents
XPath and selenium has a basic format or
syntax here we can use the syntax that
has many keywords these double slashes
are used to select notes in the document
from the current node that match the
selenium no matter where they are then
tag name is used to give the tag name as
an input this at the rate symbol is used
to select the attribute the keyword
attribute indicates the attribute name
of the node and lastly the value refers
to the value of the node next before we
move on to the types of XPath let's
first see the types of XPath locators
as we know by now expat is used to
locate web elements based on its XML
path here the term locator refers to an
address that identifies a web element
uniquely within the web page these
locators are HTML properties of a web
element which tells the name about the
web element it needs to act on
the first type of XPath locator is the
ID the best and the most popular method
to identify web elements is by using the
ID
and obviously each element's ID is
unique the second type is the class name
in this case the class name of the
element is used to find the element the
third type is the link text here the
links text is used to find the element
all the hyperlinks on the web page can
be identified just by using the link
text we can determine the link on the
web page with the help of an anchor tag
the anchor tag is used to create the
iPhone links on a web page and the text
between the opening and closing anchor
tags constitute the link text then comes
the expat locator that uses the name of
the element to find that particular
element the other type of XPath locator
is the XPath
this is required by the dynamic element
and to Traverse between different
elements of the web page the last type
of XPath locator is the CSS path it
locates the elements that have no class
name or ID now let's move further and
learn about the types of XPath
there are basically two types of X path
absolute XPath and the second one is
relativex path if we talk about the
absolute X path then it refers to the
direct way of finding an element
the major drawback of an absolute XPath
is that if there are any changes in the
elements path then the XPath will fail
the X path begins with a single forward
slash which states that we can select
the root node element
the syntax of the absolute expert looks
something like this you can determine
the absolute X path
of any Windows File by right clicking on
the file and then clicking properties
in the file properties first look at the
location which is the path to the file
next add a backslash and then the file
name to the end of the path these
actions will give you the absolute X bar
of that file now next let's see the
relative X path
in the case of relativexpath the path
begins from the middle of the HTML Dom
structure here the structure with a
double slash or double forward slash
that states that the element can be
searched anywhere on the web page
relative expert enables you to write
from the middle of the HTML Dom
structure without any need to write a
long X path the syntax of the relative
XPath looks like this
a relative path needs to be combined
with another path to access a file
creating a link to an absolute path is
easy since you are pointing to the
file's internet URL
if you want to find a specific files
relativexpath certain things must be
kept in mind
the file must exist on the same server
as the HTML file the path to the file
must be relative to the directory of
HTML file this is what sums up the two
types of xpaths for us the next Topic in
this session is the XPath functions
now the question arises what does the
term XPath function mean there may be
times when locating a particular web
element using general attributes XPath
and selenium provides XPath functions to
write efficient expats to discover
elements uniquely there are elements
with similar properties like the same
name or the same class name this is when
the simple XPath strategies are not
efficient and then we need the XPath
functions there are three types of XPath
functions
the first step is the XPath contains the
X path contains insulinium is a function
within the XPath expression used to
search for the web elements containing a
particular text it can find the element
with partial text it is used if the part
of the value of any attribute changes
dynamically like login information
Etc and here we can see the syntax of
XPath contains function the contains
method accepts two parameters the
attribute of the tag must validate to
locate the web element the value of an
attribute is a partial value that the
attribute must contain the second type
of XPath function is the XPath text the
XPath text function is a function used
to locate the element on the web page
using the web elements text it helps to
find the exact text element and it
locates the elements within the set of
text nodes
the function proves it worth if the
element contains a text like a label or
Etc
so here we can see the syntax of XPath
text on the screen
the text method here returned the text
of web element when identified by the
tag name and compared with the right
side's value now comes the last type of
XPath function that is the X path starts
with function
the expat starts with function is used
to find the element in which the
attribute values start with some
specific character or a sequence of
characters
the function plays a major role while
working with the dynamic web pages
we can also use this method to find
elements watch attribute value as static
that is not changing the Syntax for the
starts with function can be seen on the
screen
this starts with accepts two parameters
the attribute of the tag must validate
to locate the web element and the
attribute value is the partial value of
the attribute with which the attribute
is expected to start after the XPath
functions let's move on to our next and
final topic that is the XPath access
all the XML Dom elements are in a
hierarchical structure and can be either
located using absolute path or relative
paths for this XPath provides a specific
attribute called XPath access
in selenium are methods used to identify
those Dynamic elements that are
impossible to find by normal X bar
methods such as ID class name name Etc
access are so mean because they tell
about the axis on which elements lie
related to an element here an access
shows a relationship to the current node
and helps locate the relative nodes
concerning the tree's current node so
the X path axis uses several nodes to
find those nodes in the Dom structure
let's have a look on some access that
help in locating the elements on the web
page
the first X bar axis is the ancestor the
ancestor access selects all ancestor
elements grandparent parent pattern Etc
of the current node then comes the
ancestor or self this axis is used to
locate the current node along with its
ancestors along that comes the attribute
axis the attribute access are used to
specify the attributes of the current
node then comes the child access as the
name suggests it selects all the
children elements of that current node
the next axis is The Descendant axis
it is used to locate the children of the
current node to the leaf node
then comes The Descendant or self-access
that is used to locate the current node
with its descendants after that comes
the following axis which locates all the
nodes that come after the current node
now comes the parent access that is used
to locate the parent of the current node
and at the last we have this self access
the self access are used to locate
current or the present nodes there are
several other nodes other than these
that we have just seen
there is a preceding access used to
select all nodes that come before the
current node then a following sibling
node that selects the following siblings
of the context node and siblings are at
the same level as the current node there
is one axis called the parent that
selects the parent of the current node
let's get started what exactly is a
chrome driver now when we are working
with selenium so pretty much we are
going to use that tool for the automatic
test cases for the automation of the
test cases is what the made basis of the
selenium tool here so if you got a
website and uh let's suppose you want to
login you want to put some credentials
you want to do some transactions so if
this kind of flow you want to test it
out definitely having some back-end test
cases will not help you on that part
because they will not help you to click
on a particular button put some inputs
in the input text so it's it's more on
like a dealing with a more on the GUI
perspective so that's where the uh
selenium Chrome driver or the selenium
comes into the picture where it helps
you to dry those test cases where if you
are working on some kind of GUI related
interface and you want to test out that
application so this kind of
functionality will be helpful for you
and how exactly it goes on let's talk
about the Chrome driver game now Chrome
driver is a kind of a component which is
available in selenium like you pretty
much use Chrome driver only when you
feel like it's being utilized and at
that moment of time you are working on
uh the specific Chrome driver and it
gives you a kind of a Content here where
you feel like okay I'm going to use this
chrome driver to see like how the
implementation should be done and how
the automation should be performed over
here so Chrome driver specifically helps
you to launches the uh launch the Google
Chrome browser if you're going to use
Firefox if you're going to use Internet
Explorer then they have their own
specific drivers but this one means like
all your test cases is going to be
executed on the Chrome browser so if
your application is compatible with the
Chrome browser then this particular
driver makes more sense for you so it's
kind of a driver like a definitely this
web driver is going to have all the API
calls embedded inside that which is
going to help you to automate your web
applications testing so whether you want
to go for Chrome driver you want to go
for Firefox you want to go for Internet
Explorer it totally depends on the user
and your application's compatibility if
it's compatible with chrome you can
pretty much use the Chrome driver
without any issues as such here right so
why exactly we need to use a chrome
driver here now when we are using a
chrome driver so it's basically a kind
of main component which is being
utilized by the selenium by the selenium
web driver because selenium requires a
browser Plugin or a browser driver so
that it can send the request so it can
send the request to the Chrome and it
can process the request if the selenium
Webdriver is saying like I want to hit
onto some input box I want to hit onto
the summit box so those kind of requests
will be processed by the Chrome driver
so for that purpose we require higher
the Chrome driver which will only send
these notifications or the
communications which will be sent out to
the Chrome browser with the help of the
selenium web driver here now it's being
used to navigate between web pages so uh
if you want to navigate or if you want
to go from one web page to another web
page so for that also you can use the
Chrome browser Chrome driver here
so while doing the processing here what
you can do is like you can put the
inputs in the web pages like let's say
like you've got a login page so you can
put up a username password you can have
the credentials not only you can provide
the credentials but you can also click
on some buttons certain buttons like
okay let's click on the login button so
if you want to test out data how what
will happen that if automatically you're
going to click on the login button so
how your application is going to behave
so if this kind of a validation and this
kind of verification if you feel like
you want to do then in that case these
Chrome browser will be used by the
selenium to interact now the uh selenium
web driver or the selenium tool can
actually send the request and all these
requests will be processed by the Chrome
dropper so ultimately it's a Chrome
browser where you will see the end
results like the website is getting
navigated the browser is getting closed
automatically the browser is getting
started or initialized automatically
here so all that activity is going to be
done by the Chrome driver which will
intake all the specific requests from
the selenium web driver here now let's
see like how we can set up a chrome
driver for this one you require a chrome
like a Chrome browser unique wire
whatever the platform you're using
Chrome is pretty much installed there if
you already got a Chrome browser
installed all you need to do is like you
need to get a browser uh exe uh path
over there so that you can configure
that into your specific uh source code
here so as a chrome driver in the
configurations for that you can put okay
this so and so location we have the exe
file present there and the source code
can actually use it to launch the Chrome
browser and do whatever the activities
he want to perform on there as such
right so let's see like how we can set
up the Chrome browser uh and the Chrome
driver over here so that we can run some
couple of selenium test cases now for
the Chrome driver uh demonstration over
here we require four things one the jdk
installation the JRE which can be
installed from the Oracle we already got
the jdk installed into our system and
Eclipse also installed into our system
so these two pre request is already
being done now Chrome browser is
something which is also available over
here we already got the Chrome browser
embedded inside this machine so the only
thing which is left out is the selenium
here because pretty much though the uh
jdk uh eclipse and Chrome browser you
will already be having there onto your
development machines or into your
personal machines if you're already
dealing with the uh disk with the Java
programming source code so you already
have these things available there but
even if you don't have these things we
can easily download those things and
configure into our machine so that we
can start using that one right so we
have the respective links over here
eclipse is pretty easy to download just
download a file or exe file Eclipse will
be installed and you can start using it
and in order to make the eclipse work
first you have to do the installation of
the jdk or uh you know the Java which
you want to install so that that's what
you require here
right so let's open the selenium browser
here so I'm going to click on this
button here so this will help me to open
the selenium website selenium.dev is the
website which is available there which
can help us to see like how we can go
ahead with this uh particular selenium
download here so we are going to
download the selenium here and then we
are going to utilize that uh selenium
over here in this one to process it so
this is the selenium which we got this
is the website now here if you go to the
downloads like first of all you got web
driver IDE selenium gate these are the
different components which is there now
if you go to the downloads button
so here you will be able to see like all
the downloads which is available there
like the browser or if you want to see
like the web driver if you want to
install so these are the different uh
programming languages Integrations which
is available there right so you can see
like how the executions uh even if for
the C sharp you have this one here so
you also got the selenium ID which is
available there so all these different
components are available which you can
see which is easy for you to integrate
for the selenium here
right now since we are going to uh use
it for the Java so we have got like uh
the specific version over here
3.1. uh of 141.59 here so this is
something which we can use and uh you
can also go for the beta version also
but I want to download the uh stable
version over here you can go for the
beta download also right whatever
version you feel so let's go for the
download option over here so this will
basically help me to download a specific
file a zip file over okay now this ZIP
file is something which is uh going to
have all the required values and
attributes which is available there so
let's see like what exactly is available
in this file so this is kind of a
selenium which we are downloading and
this is what we are going to use in the
collapse also so in the eclipse we will
be using this stuff so that we can
utilize it
so let's open this one here
okay now you got this uh specific
Library files these are the different
Library files which is a required over
here you can say like as in dependencies
and uh these are the ones which is
available there these are the uh
executables like you can say like these
will help you to run any kind of
selenium test cases so all you require
to do is like you can just indicate
these ones into your class path while
running your uh Eclipse project you can
add these ones to the build path there
and this will surely work for you these
are the requirements like these are the
prerequis which is required in the
eclipse so that you can proceed further
with this one if these are not there
then it's going to show you the
compilations error so first we'll try to
put up the code base there and see that
what kind of error comes in and then
later on we'll see like how we can
resolve those errors as such here so
let's go to the eclipse right now what
we really need to do is like we need to
create a new Java project and uh create
a new class so that's what we need to do
and in that case uh we have to configure
the build path but I'm not uh going
going to add the external jars as of now
to put that class bar there so what I'm
going to do is like I'm going to first
see there that how I can do that
installation so I am going to copy this
code here because this is what I'm going
to put up into my a specific class so
whatever the name of the class you can
give so here we are using in the code
base as in the get started here so the
same class name we can use so that we
don't get any kind of issues so let me
copy this content
also uh provided like the driver the
Chrome is already installed here so we
don't require so you can see here that
we are giving the path of the Chrome
driver in case of Linux platform when
you're trying to deploy it like when
you're trying to put it up there so in
that case probably you have to do the
installation like you have to download
the Chrome driver for the Linux platform
but here it's pretty much like you can
simply use it or you can get it uh done
because already the windows platform we
are using it so we are launching the
eclipse here so uh in this one we will
be creating a quickly a class over here
in this one or a kind of a project so
that we will be able to proceed further
with that so we're going to create an
empty project here in this case
so we got the uh specific Clips opened
so we can go for a new Java project here
so I can say it like selenium so we can
give any project name here and uh we can
say it like finish so there will be some
basic structure which is available there
so I'm going to quickly create a
specific uh file like a class file here
now these are the jar files which is
available like white from the jdk but uh
we can easily go to the build path and
we can add the external charts but we
are not going to do that now we are
going to first see like what error we
are going to get so I'm going to create
a class here like a simple class so
getting uh started is a class which I'm
going to create here because that's the
one which is available into my content
of the class file so you can uh you know
if you feel like you don't want to use
the same name like this one so you want
to use some different names so you can
easily do a rename so that can be easily
done there now here the since like the
Imports is something which is coming up
like this is not uh something which is
coming up over here like uh it's not
getting resolved because of the fact
that we are pretty much using uh the
specific open uh the selenium jar files
the general jar files but it's not
getting that it's not showing that
output here so let's see like uh let's
open the uh specific downloads window
here so from where we can access these
jar files and we can refer it so we got
this one so let's extract this
completely uh you can put these uh for
jar files in any other locations if you
feel like you want to refer that so uh
you can keep put up into the default
location of the eclipse also if you feel
like this is getting referenced uh
pretty much frequently and there are a
lot of projects that you are working so
in that case you can have it into a
small folder or directly imported into
the eclipse itself so uh here I'm just
doing a one-time activity so let's
um use this downloads folder itself from
where we can simply import these HR
files here so these are the Javas which
is available there in the libraries we
also got like an additional jar file
which is available right so uh we can go
ahead with that part here so these are
the different libraries which is
available and these again the libraries
so let's uh you know change the build
path here so we'll go for the build path
here and uh we'll say like uh we can add
the libraries here now libraries is
something which we want to sorry we want
to edit the build path here
so here we're going to uh talk about the
external libraries like you know the
libraries which is available there which
we want to put up into this one so we
can say like add external charge so now
we can go for the downloads button here
and here we can put up this jar file
here now we also got a sources one a
sources jar file which is also available
there but what we have done is like we
have added only the executable ones
because sources ones and executable ones
this is just the same the only thing is
that the sources one will have the
source code also we don't require that
as such then lastly we comes up with the
change unit one then of course like a j
unit uh you know is also being
referenced here so for that we don't
have to download the JG red one because
most of the eclipse browsers are already
having the libraries integrated so all
you need to do is like you need to click
on the add Library here and we already
got the J unit in this one so we don't
have to really go anywhere there because
it's a part of the plugin of the eclipse
that it's already integrated there in
case of selenium you went for the add
external jar files and you added the jar
file there but not in this case in junit
it will be automatically referenced
because of the fact that we are using it
on over here in this case right so these
are the two references like J unit also
we reference it because we are running
some general test cases here so which is
like already a part of the uh plugins
here in the eclipse yes uh if you put
the plugin of the selenium and you
integrate in the same way then also you
don't have to go for this third party
references but it's okay like you can
reference it there and you know any
project digit of selenium can work now
because you got the basic executables
required for that so that that's how it
works on there
right now we also have got like a
certain other jar files which is uh
which needs to be added up over there
now those were not uh something which we
added because right now we just resolved
the issues related to the uh selenium
but uh these selenium executables may
also have some another dependencies so
for that what you need to do is like you
need to add and another uh folder like
uh you know another folder over here
which is like lib here so these jar
files will also coming up over here
because your code basis may be available
or maybe dependent on these ones so
these are the exact uh you know because
your selenium may be dependent on these
jar files there so that's also we are
going to add up over here so not only
the client combined jar file but other
dependent jar files also is going to be
there into the referenced Library ECF
right now let's find out the executable
path of the Chrome browser here so I'm
going to open the uh C drive here
because in that case we will be having
the Chrome browser installed so it's a
standard location where you will be able
to see your particular Chrome
application file here so pretty much
this is the directory structure which is
available there like in this one it will
be installed there so um you can get the
same information from the Chrome
shortcut also from a chrome uh icon also
that where exactly the zxe file is
referenced and if any difference is
there so you can do that now this is a
directory like this is the XE file which
is available there
so I'm going to just put that one over
here in this one
right so this is the way uh we are going
to put up the paths here in this one so
like how the uh path should be
referenced should be executed over here
and uh ultimately uh this is required
because definitely when we are going to
run the test cases uh this Chrome
browser will be sent the rectifications
to opening www.google.com here and it's
going to uh wait over there on that part
and uh it's going to search the specific
keyword over here called Chrome driver
so this is what it's this program this
basic program is going to perform here
so now let's run the Chrome browser here
so uh we're not going to run the Chrome
browser But ultimately the junit test
cases so you right click over here and
say run as junit test cases and this
will ultimately help you to launch a
Chrome browser now I have not triggered
it manually uh I have got it like
automatically over here and you can see
like the cursor is going to Blink
because it's basically waiting for the
selenium to put up the inputs and all
now if you have the test case executed
like you open this website go to this
website click on this and click on that
so according to that your browser will
start behaving without any interaction
from the human there now this is a kind
of a functionality which you will get
with the selenium and this makes easy
for us like if we want to move validate
or if we want to go through any kind of
web application waste testing this is
the ultimate Way like how we can go for
that verifications right so this is what
we have in this demo where we can see
like how the automatically we can do the
Chrome browser we can interact with
Chrome browser right from the selenium
over here so let's go go back to the
main content right so that was the way
that how we can configure the Chrome
driver with the selenium here so that we
can invoke Chrome browsers and when then
we can according to the statements we
can start sending the request so that's
uh pretty much which is there now the
various uh activities which we did in
this case was the jdk installation uh
Eclipse selenium a Chrome browser now
Chrome browser IDE and jdk is pretty
easy to download and you can configure
it and uh that that's the way that how
we can set up the Chrome browser the
main important thing is like how to
download the selenium and refer it into
your projects okay so that you can start
using the selenium over here
now we will come to various annotations
list and she will be going to talk about
test engine of the day what is distance
let's talk about that listing Next
Generation this is the full form of the
stingy what is test energy so first of
all the strategy is a unit testing
framework or I would say java unit
testing framework this specific to Java
there are two most popular limitation
framework one is geonet and one is test
and chief these are the two interesting
framework for Java and uh if I talk
about GNA junit it's
used a lot by Developers
the developer used this particular
framework a lot for the unit testing
purpose and when I talk about test NG
test NG it is used a lot by
testers
why there is a discrimination between
these two Frameworks then
okay what happens is you know developers
are keep on using UI unit from quite a
long time and they don't want to switch
to the new one that's only the thing
which I feel is they are using J unit
however if I talk about STG testing is
having more annotations
compared to J on it
if something more annotations means more
functionalities
let me write it here more
functionalities
the latest version of junit is geonet4
for testing G
it is actually
she spent 11 is the latest version of
President GM for a j unit as it's the
fourth version
for Janet there is a new version coming
up that is called S5 and it may be
possible that that will be more advanced
or more not more advanced but that will
be equivalent to test engine because I
have seen as an introduction that it is
having functionality similar to distance
G
so now then we won't be able to say that
test NG or sorry generate is behind the
change but as of now yes it is
in test NG if I talk about we'll be
going through some annotations
these annotations helps us to make our
test more reusable easily maintainable
okay
if you get stuck at any point of time
you can go to the documentation of this
engine will find each and everything
clear and very easily defined so test NG
uh documentation is very good so I would
suggest whenever you get time you can go
through with it but most of the 70
percent of the test engine functionality
is what we are going to take a look okay
because they are very helpful when we
talk about testng we always talk about
few annotations vision
when we talk about annotation what
annotation is can anyone tell me what
annotation is let me create a package
here
so actually testing learning testing is
very interesting thing
we are creating a class and we are
saying
that as
a login test cases
if you see here
verify
with valid
credentials
verify with invalid credentials
verify
um
suppose if you have any other test cases
well let's let me just think if you can
tell me one test case of login
one is with valid credential one is with
invalid credentials you can expand it as
much as you want
you but
this verify it with
with no credentials as well correct
or we can say verify with the special
characters
H key well injection
so there can be multiple methods correct
ways have you observed at any point of
time whenever you are working on Java if
you have written any programs or
anything like that have you observed
there is one annotation comes up there
is one line comes up that is at the rate
override sometimes at the rate
or surprise warnings
any one of you have have you ever seen
this kind of statement
the moment it seems
okay
we also get
deprecated
soon
let me come back from that so
whatever you write on top of your method
with at the rate sign
and anything post that
will be considered as a annotation on
top of a method on top of it to class
anywhere
okay these are called as annotations
and it can be anything I will say at the
retest I so it's not what you will
Define
this is you will say any name to it no
these are the annotations which are
being provided by test in GE
and every thing whatever you will be
going to Define here
has some functionality attached to it
has some functionality attached to it
so it's not that it is just for the name
purpose it will be going to add up some
functionalities
okay
yes okay
but okay
let's find
[Music]
so whenever I am talking about
annotation I'm talking about
few things which I am going to add on
top of methods or on top of a class
okay
and the actually place an important role
in your particular class or in your
methods
before I tell you about annotations
that what all annotations do we have in
test NG let me tell you how you are
going to download this test engine
first of all I said J on it J note is a
pre-installed
is pre-installed in Eclipse but testing
G is not
if you have to download this then just
go to
help
Eclipse Marketplace
foreign
right here
they're changing in the find okay this
will hang
let it come
here testing G and search for it
so to install it you write uh you go to
help Eclipse Marketplace
and inside that you mentioned
Destiny when you get the test change you
will see here test in G4 Eclipse just
click on install this is how install
button will look like click on that and
install the CNG and done test NG will be
installed in your system
okay
now let's talk about few annotations in
test.ng we are talking about annotations
from quite a long time now let's write
some annotations
at the rate
before
sweet
enter it before test
at the rate before class and the rate
before method
and the rate
list
enter it
after method
enter it
after
class at the rate
after test
enter it after suit
enter it before group
at the rate
after group
at the rate data
provider
and and and let's just think if I have
entered it parameter
okay so these are the annotations what
we have in test Ng
so here what it says score of Webdriver
automation framework without proper
design your test may look like the image
below if you don't
think and you know without any design
you may end up by saying login test
product test add to cart test checkout
test check out test payment checkout
test shipment payment test and
paymentation Etc
it may be possible that the things which
you are using here might can be used in
product test as well it might be
possible that whatever the things which
you are doing here can be used in add to
cart as well
so these are the things which we are
going to use now like this
series
so with page object you are creating one
object for sign in page product list one
object part one object shipment one
object payment one object order one
object when you are using the login test
when you are creating select product
test it might be using sign in page
objects as well as product list object
so it may be possible like I have shown
you just now in the uh Trivago in that
we were using multiple Pages multiple
page objects and we were coming up with
the test case and that's what it is
showing us in a comfort diagram if once
you can go through with that but this is
how we will be going to write our
information framework and that's what it
states consideration whenever you create
page object design always consider these
few things
always create a class for every web page
create a class for every web page
webpage elements web page elements are
instance variables of page with a class
of type web element storage saying that
whatever the elements you will be going
to write in that are always instance
or always instance variable we will be
going to do that service page would
include sign in page add to cart
which becomes a method in page object
class
so there will be Services Pages where
you may see sign in page add to cart
page add to cart query functionality or
methods I will say and then at the last
we have written in test you create
object of Facebook class and call the
methods
let's go
the three remote slides there are we'll
go through that and we'll see design
pattern test does not have any technical
code to communicate with deal with the
browser so test will not have any
technical code okay make sure that
whatever you are writing technically you
will be writing in the pages test call
Page objects and verify as a result test
is more readable like I've shown you it
was more readable form test object do
not verify page load we don't verify
whether the page is loaded or not okay
but they communicate with the browser
these are the syntaxes what you have
mentioned here if you see here they are
using we don't until now that is again
also a method so you can ignore it again
okay let's just take a look at this
because all these syntaxes is what we
are going to see
after the break let's take a look these
are the best practices one can follow to
make design robust and maintainable
create one page object class for each
web page
created one page object class for each
web page okay we'll be doing that each
page object method should either return
the object on that page or should return
the page object of the next page so
we'll see it is this is what we call as
in the name and language linking between
the classes linking between the classes
each page object should sell query date
whether the page is fully loaded before
giving control to the next step and data
used by the page object should be passed
through test and should not be hard
coded so now will not be hard coding
anything
and that's what here it is showing us a
very small example with a BMI calculator
and the test and here again
but
let me just create
an architecture of the framework and
then we will
see
all the things will be going to execute
this is my test
I'll be going to create few packages
inside it and I'll be going to tell you
about each package everyone has a
different way to define it and this is
how I always Define
some people say it as page package but I
call it as core package
this core package in this core package
I'll be going to initialize all my
elements
in this this is the heart of the package
if something goes wrong in this package
in this whatever I will Define in this
package if something goes wrong in that
nothing will get executed nothing will
be executed thank you second package
this is the package I am going to call
it as pages
pages is here we'll be going to create
all our Pages means all are classes for
web pages
so all the pages are maintained right
here
another package
we'll call it as
test cases here are keeping all my test
cases
another package
you tell
here I I'll be keeping all my utilities
another package
config
here I'll be keeping all my
configuration files
another package
logs
here I'll be generating all my logs
related to my project
a new folder
um
through one thing instead of creating a
folder let's use utilize this resources
and let's put here
one folder by the name of
drivers
so all are Firefox Chrome I drivers will
be placed at this location
one more folder
test data Excel sheet or whatever test
data you are using you'll be putting
your test data right at this location
screenshots
Etc
project level so all the screenshot will
be maintained in this folder
and this is the architecture of my
framework which will I I'll be going to
create
let's take up uh One More Concept that
is first principles and SRB let's see
that what it is so first principle
structures the desiccation and create
value of the test suits not all the
first principle can be followed in UI
testing use first Principle as a
long-term goal to maintainer of this
suit let's see that what all those five
principles are a vast isolated
independent repeatable
self-validating
throw timely so your test whatever the
test you are writing it should be fast
enough so that's why we always discuss
that void use of thread
pick up one more concept that is first
principles and SRB let's see that what
it is so first principal structures the
test creation and create value of the
test suits not all the first principle
can be followed in UI testing use first
Principle as a long term maintain a test
suit let's see that what all those five
principles are fast isolated independent
repeatable
self-validating
through timely so your test whatever the
test you are writing it should be fast
enough so that's why we always discuss
that void use of thread.c
what explicit weight put implicit weight
else you may be spending a lot of extra
time
so better avoid this
isolated independent
minimize dependency between test as far
as possible
so there shouldn't be dependent uh you
know your test cases should not be
dependent on each other because if one
fails it may be possible the other one
will not run in that case
okay don't make your test case dependent
on each other as much as possible and
also in your test case
insert at least in verification so of
course you will be having that
verification because that's it
requirement repeatable
configured test so that re-running the
test always give consistent result we
have to keep now our test case is
separately in different different
methods so that if even if we rerun it
won't impact you know the results and of
course it will not impact and it
actually doesn't apply to the size here
validating while writing the test you
should automate education as automation
suits run without human intervention
don't assume any human intervention so
always whenever you are creating your
framework your test scripts don't think
that you will be providing some input to
it
never ever give any input to your test
cases to your automation pack linkage in
such a way that it can be freely or it
can be run in your absence as well so
what you will do you will schedule it at
3 am in the night and it will run and
will give you the results you'll have to
make your test in such a way not that
that it requires your input like
verification here we are saying you
should automate verification and all so
when you are opening up a website you
should verify whether it has actually
opened or not that is actually opening
that particular URL or going to that URL
or it is going to some at a different
URL need to verify all these things
applicable unit test this test should be
true Row in the terms of coverage so
when I say in the comes of coverage you
know guys what happens in unit test
cases in unit testing we
we create some methods some extra
methods some extra line of code as well
but if we write some extra line of code
that means the program will when once a
program will get executed execution time
will be moved correct if you are adding
some more things if you are using
objects which are not being used
anywhere if you are creating object
which are not if you're creating
variables which are not being used
anywhere so of course Java while
executing Java will take care of them
and will see them correct we'll go
through through those steps which is of
no use actually in your steps
so here in terms of coverage what it
means is you should get the code
coverage that you have written 100 of
your you know you have written your
complete code but actually how much
percent is being used fifty percent
sixty percent seventy percent so there
are some code coverage tools which you
can use and can see that actually how
much code is being used
so when you write your script it may be
possible that the the fifty percent of
the script is only useful fifty percent
is you know it's completely not is of no
use
so when you get the coverage code
coverage report you can see that which
one is of no use and you can remove
those extra lines
that's a benefit of code coverage and it
is applicable of unit test it is
applicable in selenium as well
running or executing softwares or
applications with the aim of finding out
errors or bugs in the developed
application is called software testing
selenium and qtp are two software
testing tools used widely in the current
software industry
let's do a comparison between these two
testing Tools in this video in this
session we will be going through what is
selenium what is qtp then we'll have a
comparison between selenium and qtp
we'll then try to understand why one
should shift to selenium and finally how
to migrate from qtp to selenium so what
do you mean by selenium to put it in
simple terms selenium is an open source
testing program for web-based
applications spread across different
platforms and browsers
selenium is a set of four components
that are usually required at the time of
software testing they are
selenium integrated development
environment or IDE this is a web browser
add-on that creates tests very quickly
through its record and Playback
functionality depreciated selenium
remote control RC this is a test tool
that allows you to write automated web
application UI tests in any programming
language against any HTTP website using
any mainstream JavaScript enabled
browser web driver this is used for
cross browser testing
and selenium grid this is used for
cross-platform testing so what is qtp
qtp is a testing tool developed by
havelet Packard it stands for Quick Test
professional
identifying errors problems or gaps with
respect to the expected results of any
software that is being tested are the
functions of the hpqtp
vbscript is used by qtp for automation
purposes and it need not be installed
separately as it comes along with the
windows OS
the latest version of qtp is called UFT
and it is a combination of hpqtp and HP
Service Test
Hudson's and Jenkins are two open source
continuous integration system that is
supported by UFT it also provides
support for mobile testing
UFT Mobile support allows to create
agnostic scripts that is scripts
compliant with for all mobile platforms
this script developed in iOS can also be
run on Android let us now have a
comparison between hpqtp and selenium
hpqtp is a famous tool in the market of
web-based testing but with the dawn of
selenium's popularity and its ability to
do more than qtp ever could has made it
a worthy competitor
these are quite a few straightforward
differences between qtp and selenium
that might help people choose between
the two
qtp is used commercially and hence it
requires license while selenium is an
open source tool and is free for
everyone to use
qtp can be used to test both web-based
and desktop application while selenium
can only come in handy while testing
web-based applications
only qtp IDE can be used while doing qtp
test while in case of selenium tests
multiple Ides can be used like netbeans
Visual Studio eclipse
qtp can only support VB scripts while
selenium supports multiple programming
languages like dotnet Ruby Perl PHP Java
JavaScript
Etc qtp supports multiple types of
dialog box while selenium can only
support dialog box partially developing
time is high in selenium than qtp
authentication windows can be automated
in UFT whereas in selenium we have to
use Auto ID or use robot class in Java
qtp has a very good official technical
support while selenium has Community
Technical Support
qtp is comparatively more user friendly
and the scripts can be developed in a
short time on the other hand selenium
has less functionality as it is low
level and the scripts take up more time
to come and to be maintained
HP UFT is a tool used to integrate qtp
on the other hand selenium does not have
any tool used for integration
speaking of execution qtp can test one
application per machine whereas selenium
can execute multiple tests on a machine
at the same time moreover selenium takes
lesser CPU and Ram Power in the time of
execution as compared to qtp so why
should one then shift to selenium
a slight modification in the code has to
be tested to make sure that the code is
running fine and fulfilling the Target
now repeating the test again and again
can get costly the high portability of
selenium allows the automation Engineers
to write quotes without worrying about
the OS
the testing is ideally kept
self-contained within the program and
they can be modified as desired this
approach makes sure that any change in
quotes does not increase the development
and improves maintainability
the flexibility offered by selenium
allows coders to manage tests better
since selenium is open source users can
extend share and modify codes thus
saving a great deal of time and effort
for the programmers
so how to migrate from qtp to selenium
choose the script language keeping the
team's experience and the relevant kind
of automation framework in mind
put off building Frameworks and write
simple selenium scripts in the beginning
keep tracks of the issue that come up
with time and make use of the solutions
to build larger test Suites in future
once comfortable with selenium start
discovering tools that can be used with
selenium for example Maven testing G Etc
selenium jobs and sales a very
interesting topic so the market trends
for test automation are continuously
changing and selenium has seen an
exponential growth in a very short time
period this selenium makes it convenient
for clients to receive an Roi much
faster and how does that happen by
reducing the number of test Cycles
involved in testing their product in
present scenario selenium is a perfect
automation for any of your web web
application testing an automated web
application testing and it is the first
choice of your automation tester as well
as the companies also so as the
softwares are becoming more and more
complex so is the test Automation and
selenium is a key skill set for any test
automation engineer to have but of
course it's not the only skill set one
needs to have so if you look at a
typical job description here so go
another days when the engineers were
hired as a manual tester every company
today wants to hire Engineers who knows
how to do Automation and since selenium
is the most popular web application
automation tool companies look
specifically for selenium automation
engineers and this is the typical job
description of any automation engineer
to develop test cases to detect bugs and
errors automation framework designing
it's not just about automating your test
cases one should have the ability to
design the complete framework related to
the project to improve and automate test
practices to participate in
communicating best practices defining
test strategy test manuals for tracking
and fixing your software issues let's
look at the compensation part of it so
compensation varies from company to
company and it also depends on your
experience level so according to the
stats if you look at the U.S market it
can vary anywhere from twenty one
thousand dollars to one fifty thousand
dollars average could be of course
somewhere around ninety thousand dollars
and if you look at the Indian market
range it ranges anywhere from 2 to 10
lakhs per annum for a startup with an
average of 5 lakhs so the more and more
you're going to get experience the
better is going to be a compensation
package and the market has always been
very lucrative for automation Engineers
so since selenium is so powerful web
automation tools there are some of the
top-end companies who use selenium in
their various project they want to
provide their customers the best quality
software and help them reduce the time
to Market and hence they go in for
selenium so a lot of these companies
have selenium deployments in this video
we will look at most commonly asked
questions in the interview and some
guidelines on how to answer them
nowadays automation tool and especially
the selenium skills is a very key
requirement for an QA engineer or even
an automation engineer jobs so if you're
on the Outlook of automation engineer or
a QA engineer positions I am sure this
question bank will definitely help you
prepare for your interview so this video
consists of three parts basically three
different levels of set of questions one
is the beginner level second is the
intermediate level and then the advance
level question and each level has a set
of 10 most probable questions which you
might be asked in the interview so let's
begin with the beginner level questions
question one what are selenium Suite
components so selenium is a set of tools
and libraries to facilitate automation
on web applications you already know
this it is not a single tool so what are
those components which are comprised in
the selenium so selenium comes with four
major components the first one is the id
id happens to be the most simplest tool
in the whole Suite of selenium it is
nothing but an integrated development
environment which has a record and
Playback functionality this was earlier
available as only Firefox plugin however
you need to know that the new version of
selenium IDE is available as a Chrome
extension as well as a Firefox plugin so
that means you can either use any of the
browsers that is Firefox or the Chrome
for recording your test scripts also you
should also know that the new ID comes
with many new features and the now this
new ID is become more powerful than what
was available earlier so some of these
new features are like reusability of
your test cases it comes with a better
debugger now and most importantly it
supports parallel test execution and how
does it do that it has a utility called
selenium cytronome that's about selenium
ID the next component is the selenium
remote control so selenium remote
control or popularly called a selenium
RC is used to write web application test
in different programming languages it
supports multiple programming languages
like Java C sharp Perl python Ruby and
PHP it is nothing but it's a server
which interacts with your browser using
a simple HTTP get and post request for
communication selenium RC is also called
as selenium 1.0 version or selenium core
third component selenium Webdriver it is
a programming interface to run your test
cases and Webdriver was introduced by
Simon Stewart in 2000 0006 and this was
introduced to overcome some of the
limitations of selenium RC so asses of
architecture was very complex because it
required an additional server in its
setup and why was that additional server
for communicating with the browser and
what Webdriver did was it removed this
dependency completely web driver
interacts directly with the browser and
also makes your test cases run much
faster than your RC the last component
the selenium grid a very important tool
this is used to run multiple test
scripts on multiple machines at the same
time now with the selenium Webdriver you
can only do sequential execution but in
real time environment you always have
the need to run test cases in a
distributed environment so this grid
allows parallel execution of tests on
different browsers as well as different
operating system so the design is in
such a way that commands are distributed
on multiple machines where you want to
run the test and their executed
simultaneously this uses a simple hover
node concept where Hub controls the all
execution of your test cases on the
notes and this is how we achieve
parallel execution and what is a major
advantage of having this grid it is to
reduce your overall test execution time
question 2 what are the limitations of
selenium now like any other tool
selenium also has certain limitations so
when you are answering this question you
will also be expected to talk about what
is the workaround available for all
these limitations so let's look at them
one by one no reliable tech support of
course selenium is an open source so if
you look at it you do not have much
technical support available however
there are loads of documentation
available there are forums available
which you can refer to
seleniumhq.org is the website is your
Bible if you're working with the
selenium and then there are there are a
lot of selenium Google Groups and the
forums which are available for any kind
of support So selenium has been there
for quite sometimes so it's it's one of
the most mature tool available today so
even though we do not have a technical
support available there is enough
documentation available on the internet
the second limitation selenium can test
only web application selenium is an open
source tool that is designed to automate
web-based applications on different
browsers but it cannot handle Windows
GUI or non-html pop-ups in the
application now what is a workaround
available for that selenium provides a
support for integrating other tools like
autoit so Auto it is a tool for handling
your windows based activity selenium
also cannot automate mobile applications
but then what is available with that it
can integrate a tool called APM tool
which is a mobile automation tool the
third limitation limited support for
image testing selenium is a de facto
tool for functional web web application
tests so standard API allows interacting
only with the browser and it's hard to
test the images based applications using
selenium what is the other tool
available cqli is a very good tool to
use for image testing and this again you
can integrate securely with selenium
that's how you can achieve your image
testing through selenium but using the
securely tool no built-in reporting
facility so selenium does not have any
reporting capability as such of course
it does provide a very limited reporting
capability where some basic reports are
created but definitely when you are
working in a framework you need a better
support for a good reporting tools so
that way selenium supports some of the
tools like test NG report NG and extend
reports using which you can integrate
these tools with selenium and generate
beautiful reports Limited Test
management selenium does not provide any
test tool integration with test
management tools may require knowledge
of programming languages so since
selenium supports multiple programming
languages the developer of the test
automation will require to have some
basic knowledge of any of the supported
programming language why one in order to
write your effective automation scripts
and of course because selenium tool you
want to use it at its full potential
question 3 what are the testing types
supported by selenium so selenium
supports regression testing and
functional testing these can be called
as a very high level categories so what
is regression testing regression testing
is a full or partial selection of
already executed test cases which are
re-executed to ensure your existing
functionality does not break so let's
look at what are these attributes of
regression testing and why we say that
selenium helps us in doing regression
testing so regression tests are run
every time a new fix has been received
or a new feature has been deployed so
that is called as retesting you can
always select a full Suite or selected
test to test a fix or a complete product
so your selection can be based on
recently added features a test area
where most defects are there or
integration areas or even end-to-end
kind of tests you can also prioritize
your test cases based on critical
functionalities and business impact of
these test cases according to the
priority set so all this can be done
using selenium now what is the second
category of the testing which it
supports functional testing so
functional testing includes what your
smoke test sanity test say install test
database test basically any kind of
functionality which you are going to
test and if you look at the kind of
steps which are involved in that it
involves identification of your test
inputs expected outputs or the results
the test Case Logic itself and the
assertions so a typical flow will be you
identify your test input first then you
derive your test outcomes or the
expected outputs you design and execute
your test cases and then assert on the
expected versus actual outcomes question
4 what are selenium m2.0 and 3.0
versions so selenium was introduced by a
gentleman called Jason Huggins way back
in 2004 and that was selenium version
since then this tool has gone through
multiple changes to make it better and
better so if selenium 2. version had a
major change it took a Leap Forward in
terms of browser automation the selenium
RC the remote control had a disadvantage
of having the need of an additional
server to talk to the web browsers and
because of this the text execution was
much slower and the architecture itself
became very complex so if you look at
the selenium II it had two components a
successor to RC and the RC itself which
is called as your core so this successor
was nothing but your web driver API so
Webdriver apis made it easier to write
your automation scripts for any browser
by simply using a suitable driver for
any browser which you want to run the
test on apart from these two components
the the selenium 2.0 version also had
the ID and the grid components so in
summary if you look at it selenium 2.4
version has an ID it has selenium RC
which was on its way of deprecation
Webdriver API which was just introduced
in there a very very earlier version of
Webdriver API and the grid so what is
selenium 3.0 consists so selenium 3.0 RC
was completely eliminated now because in
2.0 it was already on its path of
deprecation and Webdriver replaced RC
completely so if you look at the
components of 3.0 we have ID we have a
Webdriver and grid as the major
components so now with this introduction
of web driver a full-fledged web driver
selenium became the most powerful tool
for web application automation question
5 a very important question what is same
origin policy and how is it handled now
same origin policy is a security ID
feature so it is a very important
Concept in web application security the
motor and what is this according to this
policy a web browser allows scripts from
one web page to access the contents of
another web page provided both these
pages are on the same origin now what
does origin mean origin is nothing but a
combination of your url schema the host
number and the port number it's
basically your domain now if a such
question is asked how are you going to
explain it so let's say you have a
JavaScript program which runs in a
certain domain say google.com Okay so
this program can access all the programs
which are from the same origin now
origin here is what google.com so for
example you can access other Pages like
your Google Drive your Google email or
your Google calendar however now if you
use the same JavaScript right so if you
use the same script from the google.com
to access another page or an element in
a different domain Say yahoo.com then
the security model of the web
application itself prohibits you to do
so so what happens because of that is
you are limited with access only to
those elements and Pages which are in
the same domain but now look at a case
that you want to run your test on
multiple servers and you might also want
to access multiple domains so due to the
same origin policy you will not be able
to do so and this became a major
limitation with a very early selenium
tool so how was this handled so this got
handled by Paul Hammond who created the
selenium remote control so he created a
selenium remote control server to trick
the browser in believing that the
selenium core and the web application
under test actually came from the same
domain and this is how the same origin
policy was handled and this slinium RC
which is selenium remote control became
the version one of selenium question 6
what is selenis and how is it classified
selenium commands for selenium ID are
often called as selenis they are a set
of commas that run your test and
sequence of this command is called as a
test script now these commands are
categorized into three major categories
one is the action command now Action
commands are the commands that generally
manipulate the state of your application
for example they can do things like
click on this link or select a
particular option open a URL type
certain text into an input box click or
double click on any web element and so
on so these are called as Action
commands the second set of commands is
the accesses now accessors examine the
state of the application and store the
results in a variable so it basically
allows the user to store certain values
to a user defined variable for example
if I want to store the page title of a
web page I can do that by defining a
user defined variable and then these
stored values can be later used to
create your assertions or verifications
in your test now few examples of such
commands are you can just use use a
store s t o r e or a store text store
title or a store value so these are some
of the accessor commands the third
category is the assertions assertions
are like your accesses but they verify
the state of your application and
conforms to what is expected so
basically it's a comparison of your
actual versus expected results there are
two types of assertions available one is
the soft assertions and the harder
sessions an example of your soft
assertion can be verify title wherein
you verify the title check whether the
expected and the actual outcomes are the
same and continue with your test case
now whereas an hard assertion is you do
an assert title using the command assert
title and if at all the assertion fails
the test case stops from executing
question seven mention the types of web
locator what is web locator a locator is
a command that tells the selenium which
UI element you want to operate on
selenium uses locators to find and match
the elements of your web page which
needs to interact with and there are
around 8 locating techniques in selenium
the first one is by ID now this is the
most common way of locating elements why
since the IDS are supposed to be unique
for each element the IDS can also be
dynamic in nature so you can identify
them by inspecting the attributes of the
web element so let's look at an example
so if we go to a Facebook right so if
you go to the Facebook and say if I want
to identify this element email so if you
look at this highlighted text here it
has a unique ID which is email so if I
am going to operate on this particular
element email I can directly use the ID
locating technique link text and the
partial link text so this type of
locator applies only to the hyperlink
text so we access the link by using this
locator which needs the hyperlink text
to be provided so for link text you can
give a complete text in the link text or
let's let's look at an example of that
so let's if we go to say one of the
e-commerce site which is say amazon.in
and say you want to click on this
today's deal link so if you look here in
amazon.in there are a lot of hyperlinks
available here and if an example if you
have to take an example say we want to
click on the today's date now if you
inspect this element you will see that
it has an anchor tag a it has an
Associated href link here and also it
has a text which says today's deal right
which is what is displayed on your web
page now similarly there is also a link
available here called customer service
so if you inspect that customer service
it also has something similar what the
today's deal had it has an anchor tab it
has an edge ref link and it has a long
text which says customer service which
is what is displayed now if you have to
use your web locator which is a link
text you need to provide the complete
text which is displayed on your web page
and there is another way of using the
link text by saying partial link text
where you can just give a partial text
which can be matched against the
complete text of your link and this is
how you can use your partial link text
or the link text the next ID is by name
so locating Elements by name is very
similar to locating by ID just that your
attribute instead of using an ID you're
going to use name in this case now if
you look at the same example of say
Facebook we identified this email
element using its ID you can also locate
the same element by using the name
attribute which is also unique in this
case which has a value called email tag
name that's the next identifier so
locate element using tag name of the
element now say if you want to identify
all the elements on your web page which
are of type button so that you can do by
using the tag name as button there for
example again on your Facebook page I
know that there is a single button here
which is of type button and which has a
tag as button and this is the only
button which is available on this page
so if I want to access this particular
element I can simply use a locator
technique called tack which is button in
this case next locator class name so
locate an element using its class name
attribute so you can use this identifier
only if you find that a class name is
unique for a web element which you want
to work with class names are sometimes
unique a web element can also have
multiple class name or even you will
find some elements which has no class
name so depending on what is available
in the attributes you can use this class
name for identification so example the
shown on your screen here where it says
find element by class name input text
basically this is going to list out all
elements on your web page which has a
class name called input text the next
identifier is by XPath now XPath is a
language used when locating XML nodes
what is XML extendable markup language
it can access almost any element even
those without any class names or names
or even ID attributes so whenever you do
not find a unique attribute for ID name
or class name you can construct an expat
to create an unique identifier for that
particular element now for example on
this Facebook page if You observe here
there is a label here called create an
account so if you inspect this
particular label it has no attributes
other than a tag called spack so if you
want to identify this particular element
and say display it this is one of the
ways to do it is through XPath CSS
selector so CSS selector are string
patterns used to identify an element
based on the combination of either the
HTML tag ID class or any other
attributes locating by CSS selector is
little more complicated than any of the
previous method however the advantages
CSS selectors work much faster than the
expat the performance of your test
scripts is much better when you use CSS
selector than any other locating
technique now again as an example if you
see the Facebook again you can identify
the same email here right I used an ID
here or a name attribute here to
identify it so assume that if you did
not have any of those things or if you
want to use a CSS selector here you can
still do that by using this syntax this
is how you use the CSS selector to
identify an element question 8 what are
the types of Weights supported by
Webdriver now before even you answer
this question you should know why do we
need weights in selenium weights play a
very important role in executing test
cases most of the web applications are
developed using using Ajax and
javascripts so when a page is loaded by
the browser the elements which you want
to interact May load at a different time
intervals not only this makes it
difficult to identify the elements but
also if the element is not located it
will start throwing element not visible
exception and how do we resolve this by
using the weights so there are three
different kind of Weights available in
selling it first one is the implicit
weight the implicit weight tells the
browser or your web driver to wait for a
certain amount of time before it can
throw no such element exception Now the
default setting is zero for this once we
set a time what web driver does it it
will wait for that time so if you have
mentioned 10 seconds it will wait for 10
seconds until it finds the element and
even in the 10 seconds it is unable to
find that element only after that it
throws an exception now what is the
syntax of this implicit weight is this
is the syntax of this where you use
diver dot manage timeouts implicit
weight and there is a timeout value say
10 seconds and the unit whether it's in
minutes seconds or milliseconds is what
you can mention implicit weight is
applied globally to all the elements
which means it is available for all the
web elements throughout the driver
instance implicit weight is defined only
once and it will remain same throughout
the driver object instance now let's see
what explicit weight is so explicit
weight is used to tell the web driver to
wait for certain conditions before
throwing an element not visible
exception it is defined to wait for
certain expected conditions only now
these expected conditions can check
whether the element is displayed on the
web page or not or can be clicked or not
so any kind of conditions you can
mention there so these are called as
conditional weights and they are applied
on a web element on a single web element
unlike the implicit weight which was
kind of Applied globally to all elements
it is definitely recommended to use this
explicit weight when your elements are
taking longer time to load and also for
verifying the property of the elements
like say visibility of the element
located element to be clickable or
element to be selected then we have
fluent weight now fluent weight is used
to tell the web driver to wait for a
condition that is very similar to the
explicit bit as well as a frequency with
which we want to keep checking the
condition before throwing the not
visible exception so fluent weight is
used to define the max maximum amount of
time you want the web driver to wait for
a condition then if you look in the
syntax then there is polling every
second so polling every and you give a
timeout this could be like five seconds
so start polling to see whether the web
element is available or not say once in
three seconds once in four seconds
depending on your use case and then dot
ignoring so you can also try to ignore
specific type of exceptions while
waiting now for example such as no such
element exception which is sometimes
thrown when searching for an elemental
page so you can mention even that here
so fluent way takes two parameters one
is the timeout value and the polling
frequency so when we have web Elements
which sometimes are visible after few
seconds or sometimes it takes more time
than usual like we have Ajax
applications as an example we can set a
default polling period based on our
requirement and then as I said you can
also ignore some of the exceptions while
pulling this element question 9 mention
the types of navigation commands
available in selenium so Webdriver
provides a base basic browser navigation
commands that allows the browser to move
forward backward refresh and using the
browser history and this is done using
some of the driver.navigate methods
right so these are some of the commonly
used navigation methods first one is
navigate 2. so this method loads a new
web page in the existing browser window
and it accepts string as a parameter and
returns nothing so it's a void so the
URL you mentioned here needs to be a
fully formed URL driver.navigate dot
refresh so this method refreshes or
reloads the current web page in the
existing browser window it neither
accepts anything so there is no value
path or it returns nothing forward so
this method enables the web browser to
click on the forward button in the
existing browser window again this has
this has no arguments to be passed or it
returns nothing
driver.navigate dot back so this method
enables the web browser to click on the
back button in the existing browser
window again this returns nothing nor it
meets any argument question 10 what is
the major difference between
driver.close and Driver dot quit so this
is again a very important question and
pretty confusing also sometimes so
selenium Webdriver provides two methods
for closing the browser window one is
browser.close and the other one is the
browser.quit so you might think to use
them interchangeably and that's that's
what everybody thinks that both anyway
does the same function so it can be used
however it is not so both are two
different methods Now driver.close
command is used to close the current
browser window which is having the focus
and in case if there is a only single
browser window open then calling this
driver.close actually quits the complete
browser session now it is used when
you're working with say multiple browser
tabs or Windows and you want to just
close one of them which is in focus in
the test right whereas the driver.quit
is used to quit the complete browser
session along with all its Associated
Windows tabs pop-ups and everything so
when do you use browser.quate it is best
to use use browser.quate or sorry
driver.quit when you no longer want to
interact with the driver object along
with all its Associated Windows tabs and
pop-ups generally it is one of the last
statements of your automation scripts so
in case you are like working with
selenium with test NG or J unit we
usually call this driver dot quit in the
after Suite that is at after Suite
method of our test Suite thus by by
doing that we close the complete browser
session at the end of the test fit
execution now let's look at some
intermediate level questions question 11
how to type in an input box using
selenium so selenium provides a method
or a command you can say to insert value
into any of the input box and this
command is called as a send Keys command
so send Keys is a method available in a
web element now this is how you use the
send keys so here is an example so first
you need to find the element using any
of the eight locating techniques and
once you find the element in this case
which is an email field you need to call
a method called send Keys send Keys
takes an argument which is of type
string so you can pass the value which
you want to pass to the web element so
in this case you'll be passing a Gmail
ID or any ID which will be your email ID
here and then similarly you do it for
your password fit so first you find the
element password and then you send the
password using send keys this is a very
simple method to use question 12 how to
click on a hyperlink in selenium so
wherever you are testing a e-commerce
application you are going to find lot of
hyperlinks on your web pages which you
will obviously need to test now selenium
provides two locating techniques using
which you can identify this hyperlinks
and using these is what you need to
operate on the hyperlinks on your web
pages so one is using link text and
other one is using partial link text so
using link text you give a complete text
in the link text that is if you look get
in your e-commerce let's say amazon.in
let's let's go to that website and see
what it means so in the amazon.in if you
look at some of these hyperlink texts
called today's deals or Amazon pay or
sell or customer service if you inspect
this element you will see that this is
associated with a link text which is
called as today's tip along with this
Edge ref and of course an anchor tag so
one way of identifying this link is to
use this complete text which is today's
date also there is another way by using
partial link text for say example you
have a link text which is pretty long
and you do not want to use this complete
text instead you can use the locating
technique called partial link text and
give a partial text from that in this
example instead of giving the complete
customer service here you can just say
use a customer or you can just use
Service as your text only thing what
will be required here is this has to be
unique on this page there shouldn't be
two elements which would have this text
which you are going to use so let's
click quickly see this in action how do
we use this link text and partial link
text now we will be using the same
example of amazon.in so my use cases
first I will click on this today's deal
and after a sleep of 2 or 3 seconds I
will also click on customer service and
I am going to achieve this one by using
link text so if you see in this program
so I have this method written which is
going to click on today's deal and this
is using a locating technique link text
and then I also have another meth head
here by using partial link text I am
going to be clicking on the customer
service link right so let's see how this
works so I'll just go ahead and execute
this so This launches the amazon.in and
the first thing what we are doing is it
is going to click on today's deal all
right that is done and then it will
click on the customer service link right
so this is how you can achieve clicking
on the hyperlinks in your web
applications question 13 how to scroll
down a page using JavaScript this is a
very important question and usually this
gets asked quite often in the interview
you should know that you can run
javascripts through selenium and
selenium provides a way to do this
selenium provides an interface called
JavaScript executor JavaScript executor
and this helps in executing any kind of
javascripts through the selenium
Webdriver so this JavaScript executor it
has basically two methods one is execute
script and the other one is execute its
async script to run the JavaScript on
the selected window or on your current
page but why do you need this right so
if if you're answering this question you
should also have a background that why
at all this is required because
sometimes you need to perform certain
functions which cannot be done using the
locators what has been provided like say
scrolling down the web page itself also
sometimes you will see that you are
unable to even identify some web
elements using all the locating
techniques which is made available by
selenium so in such situations what you
can do is you can directly write a
JavaScript and execute it using this
JavaScript executor and if you look at
it the syntax is something like this so
it says JavaScript executor JS is equal
to JavaScript executor and Driver now if
you look at this JavaScript executor is
an interface that means you cannot
create an object of it and hence you
Typecast it to your driver object now
how do you do this now first thing what
you do is you launch your web
application on whatever web application
is under test and then on that current
window you call this particular execute
script method using the JavaScript
executor and then you can perform any
functions here in this example we are
seeing a function which is crawling down
vertically so this function takes an
attributes or arguments like x
coordinate and the y coordinate now in
this example our x coordinate is 0 and y
coordinate is one thousand that means
when this command gets executed the page
is going to get scroll down vertically
by 1000 pixels so why don't we just see
this in action so let's go to another
program here called the scrolling
test.java so basically what I'm doing
here is I'm going to be logging into
amazon.in and then I will show you how
to scroll down by 600 pixels so it's a
very very simple code to write you
launch your application then you create
your object of JavaScript executor right
actually you Typecast it to the driver
and then you just use an execute script
command or a method this you see is your
actual script which gets executed which
is Windows dot scroll by 0 comma 600
which is x coordinate and y coordinate
let's go ahead and execute this so in
amazon.in is launched and you should see
the screen scrolling down yes there we
go so it just scroll down by few pixels
and that is 600 pixels what we mentioned
see I could scroll back again and that
is how you can achieve scrolling
functions and when do you usually use
this say if you have a very long web
page and you want to go and identify or
do some operations on the web element
which is probably available to you
towards the end of the page and that is
when you can use some of the scrolling
functions question 14 how to assert the
title of a web page selenium Webdriver
provides Webdriver methods and one such
method is called get title so what get
title does is it fetches the title of
the current page how to use this command
get titles returns string which is
nothing but your title of your page that
means you need a string variable in
which you can store this value so what
you do is you define a string variable
like it is defined in this example to
store your title and then you execute
this command driver dot get title which
is going to fetch the title and that
value gets stored in your actual title
once you get the title you can do any
operations with that in this case what
we are doing is we are trying to verify
the title there are two ways which you
can verify them one is using an if else
statement where you compare your actual
title with the expected title or
alternatively you can also use assert
statements here right so selenium
provises a search statement so using
assert you can validate whether your
title of the web page is as expected
question 15 how to mouse hover over an
element in automation many times it is
required to perform some action on the
element which gets visible only on the
mouse hovering on those elements now in
selenium action is a class which we can
use to achieve this functionality so
action class is defined in a package
called as selenium dot interactions this
has a set of apis to emulate complex
user gestures it helps in building the
patterns of action and then perform that
action on a web element now this action
class provides a rich set of apis like
so for Mouse events and even the
keyboard events so say for to perform
any kind of mouse event it provides a
method called move to element now in
this example what you do is you initiate
an object of mouse class and then use
this move to element method and what it
causes the element is scrolled into the
view first even before the move
operations happen so you could have
multiple actions like here in this
example we are just using move to
element but also you can if you want to
do a drag and drop observation you can
still have that so in such case where
you have multiple actions like a drag
and drop then you use a method called
build along with this so you say
actions. move to element dot build and
then dot perform so dot build method is
called before the perform method and
what it does is it generates the
composite actions which has all those
multiple actions which you want to
perform on a web element then after the
built-in action is done you call a
perform method which actually performs
that action on your web element and this
is how the move to element method of the
action class is used why don't we just
see that in action let's say let's go to
our Eclipse here and I have a mouse
hover test written here so let's say we
go to amazon.website so in the Amazon
if you go to the shop by category you
see that so the moment I Mouse over it
it is going to give me this drop down
list so for me to select any element
from this my first action on this
webpage should be to go and just hover
my mouse over this web element called
shop by category and that's exactly I'm
going to achieve through my automation
now here in my methods here what I have
written I have said Okay first launch
your website which is amazon.in and then
I'm finding that element which is shop
by category using an X path so you could
use any available locating technique to
find the element first and then I
instantiate an object of actions and
then simply I'm doing is I'm using the
method move to element and then I'm just
going to say perform that means my mouse
would or chili get moved or hovered onto
that particular element okay so let's
see this in action so I'll just execute
this test case Okay so Amazon dot is
launched and now we should see yeah the
mouse actually moved to shopback
category and because of that we got this
drop down list so and this is how you
can achieve your mouse hover
functionality question 16 how to
retrieve the CSS properties of an
element now CSS is nothing but cascading
style sheets it's a stylesheet language
used for describing the presentation of
a document written in your markup
language it basically describes your
HTML elements as how they need to be
displayed on the screen it's basically
the look and feel like your font size
the width height color and so on so it
provides a special and easy way to
specify various properties of the
element now why do we need this we need
to use a special method called get CSS
value to retrieve such CHS properties of
web element why because we already have
a method called get attribute which can
retrieve the value of the attributes
right however the get attribute method
can only retrieve those properties where
the attribute and its value are
mentioned in your Dom and and hence all
this font size color cannot be retrieved
through the get attribute method and
that is why we use the get CSS value so
basically it works like your get method
and you need to provide the attribute
which you want to fetch using the get
CSS value so in this example what we are
trying to do is we have a web element
called the email ID and of that we are
trying to fetch the font size so let's
again check this in action so if I go to
my web page here let's close this so if
I go to my Facebook and if I inspect
this particular element which is the
email ID and on the right if you see
there are multiple other attributes of
that element you see right so you see
the background color you see the color
here then you see something called as
font size and say for example we want to
retrieve the font size of this
particular web element and you will also
see on the left where you are seeing the
Dom here you do not see that font says
anywhere as an attribute and its value
here and that is why I cannot use the
attribute method to retrieve it now
instead of that what I am going to do is
I'm going to use the get CSS value and
use this font size for that so let's go
to my Eclipse I have a method written
here where I log into the Facebook and
then I'm going to first find that
element which is by ID and I'm going to
retrieve the CSS value and I'm just
simply printing it on the console so if
I execute this so it's going to launch
the Facebook and since I'm not going to
do anything on the Facebook web page as
such let's go to my console here because
this is where I'm expecting the output
so here it has given me that an output
in the console saying 12px which is
nothing but your actual font says what
you see here in your HTML page right and
this is how you can extract your CSS
properties of any web element on your
web page question 17 what is Page object
model popularly known as form page or
object model is a design pattern that
helps create object repositories for web
elements so writing m test cases without
say using any patterns may lead to code
duplicacy and also the code becomes
unmaintainable after some time and say
if you have web element locators which
changes over time then you will have to
go through the entire code base to make
all the required changes so under this
model for each web page in the
application there should be a
corresponding page class and this page
class will have all the web elements of
the web page and also it contains the
page methods which perform operations on
the web elements and the verification
steps required in your test cases are
the separate test cases they are not
combined in the same class now the tests
that use the methods of this page object
class whenever they need to interact
with the UI of that page the benefit
here is if the page UI changes then the
tests need not be changed only the code
within this page object class needs to
be teached that is you go and just
change the web elements or the locators
of the web elements only in one place
which is your page class and not in any
of your test class or not test classes
so how does this form help so it makes
the code more readable maintainable and
reusable so there are two ways you can
Implement a form or a page object model
one is done using the page Factory which
is offered by selenium and then you can
also achieve a page object model without
using the page Factory right using
directly the objects and the classes
question 18 can capture be automated
this is again a very favorite question
of the interview capture is a security
feature that prevents Bots and automated
programs from accessing sensitive
information yes and captcha cannot be
automated you will see that there are
many applications today who have
captured why because it's a security
feature it is a concept to differentiate
between human and computers the idea of
captcha itself is to prevent any
automated process or a robotic process
to do any kind of actions and say if you
are going to automate it then the entire
idea of having the captcha is lost so
you should never attempt to automate it
but then what do you how can you handle
this then one either you can ask your
developers to disable it in the test
environment so that you can test the
whole application without having to hit
on this capture other way of doing this
is you can use static data for your
captcha so that you can hard code that
value in your test for the time being
and then since your application has
captures one of its functionality if you
really need to test that you can just
test that separately as a manual testing
itself but not automated question 19 how
does selenium handle Windows based popup
selenium is an automation tool for
automating web applications it cannot
handle Windows based application however
we can use tools like autoit and robot
class along with selenium to handle such
pop-up so what are these tools robot
class is a Java class which along with
selenium can simulate your keyboard and
mouse events it also helps in up upload
and download of files and also to manage
the pop-ups so wherever you have a
requirement of doing a file upload
operation in which if your native dialog
box opens up then one of the way to
handle it is using robot class other
tool which is available for us is the
autoit tool it is a freeware and what it
does is it uses a combination of your
mouse movement keystrokes and Window
Control manipulation to automate any
such task which is not possible by
selenium web driver and again this
autoit tool can be integrated with
selenium and thus you can achieve the
automation of native window based
pop-ups question 20 how to take
screenshots in Webdriver take screenshot
interface can be used to take
screenshots in web driver so selenium
provides us this interface for managing
our screenshot operations now
screenshots are desirable for bug
analysis so selenium can automatically
take this screenshots during your
execution you know that it is very
important to take screenshots when we
execute the test scripts say if we have
a huge number of test scripts running
and if some of the test case fail we
need to check why this test case failed
so using the screenshot functionality it
helps us debug and identify the problem
by looking at those screenshots so
Webdriver has this built-in
functionality to take the screenshot
across the page and it's pretty easy to
use take screenshot interface is used to
capture the screenshot during the
execution now this interface has a
method called great get screenshot as
which captures a screenshot and it also
stores in a location specified by us so
let's take an example of our Facebook
page and say we fail a particular test
case on the Facebook application and
then let's see how we take a screenshot
at that particular moment when the test
case fails so let's go to the Facebook
page first and let's understand the use
case so in this Facebook page say if I
am signing up on this page I need to
enter all this field now as a part of
demo what I will do is I'll just enter
the first name and the surname and I
will click on the sign up button with
this test case it should basically not
sign me up rather it should give me some
error saying that you need to enter all
the fields and at that minute we are
going to take a screenshot okay so
that's our use case so let's see how do
we achieve that so if I go to my eclipse
and let's say we go to my screenshot
test.java I have a method written here
so and these are the operations which I
just described which I am doing it here
so I'm going to just send keys my first
name to the first name field second name
into the surname fit and then I'm just
going to click on the sign up button now
there are few things required for us to
do before we use the take screenshot
interface along with its method which is
the get screenshot us so I said that
this method stores the screenshot taken
in a file so that means I need to
provide it a file name and also a
location where it needs to be placed so
in our demo here in this test class what
I have done is I've created a folder
called screenshot in the same project
directory and then I am giving it a file
name called FB login.png so that means
after the screenshot is taken it is
saved in the file called FB login.png
and then it is stored in the location
screenshot folder and these are the
simple file operations of java which I
use to achieve this so let's execute
this and see how this happens so right
now I have the screenshot folder and
it's an empty folder so after the
execution I am expecting that this
particular file would get created so
let's see that in action so I'll go
ahead and execute this Java program okay
so we have launched the facebook.com and
then I entered the my first name second
name and it has also clicked on Signum
after which it has given all this red
marks here and now this is what I'm
expecting in the screenshot so let's go
back to our Eclipse I will refresh this
folder so I'll say right click and
refresh okay I have this file created so
let's open this file and see right so do
you see this this whole image has been
captured so now as a tester if at all
this test case fails for me I can always
open this PNG file and see what actually
happened and I can debug my test case so
this is how you use screenshot
functionality in selenium level
questions question 21 can you type in a
text box without using send keys so you
need an alternative way to use instead
of using the send Keys function and one
such alternative is using JavaScript
executor so selenium provides an
interface called JavaScript executor and
this helps in executing any javascripts
through your selenium Webdriver so you
can do any kind of function using this
JavaScript and one of the functions
which we can do is the send Keys kind of
a function now how to replicate a send
Keys function using JavaScript so let's
see an example here now since this
JavaScript executor is an interface you
cannot create an object of this
interface so what you do you type cast
it to your driver object check the
weight is done here in this example and
then you use document dot get element ID
to get the actual element on which
you're going to perform the operations
of sending the keys now what is this
document so it is an object right so
this document it's an object that
represents your HTML document which is
displayed in that window and this
document object has various properties
that refer to other objects which allows
you the access to modify any of your
document content so the argument which
you're passing through the Java execute
script is nothing but your JavaScript
now this JavaScript uses the document
object to identify your element and then
send the value which you need to send to
that element so let's see this in action
as how it works so let me show you a
small program here all right so I have a
method here wherein I'm trying to
identify the email field of your
Facebook page so if this is your
Facebook application this is my email
field and instead of using send key is
here I am going to pass a email value to
this and how am I doing that using a
JavaScript executor right so if I
execute this particular Java program it
is exactly going to do the same function
what I would do otherwise using the send
case so let's execute this and see if I
can see my user's ID email in the
Facebook application so the Facebook
application is launched and there we go
so we this is the value which I have
sent using my JavaScript okay so this is
how you can use a JavaScript executor to
replicate a send Keys method question 22
how to select a value from your drop
down list in the selenium Webdriver so
select class is a selenium Webdriver it
is used for selecting and deselecting
options in your drop down list the
objects of Select type can be
initialized by passing the drop down web
element as a parameter to its
Constructor like in this example I am
saying select drop down equal to new
select of test drop so test drop is
nothing but the web element which I have
identified using any locating techniques
after you create the select object then
you have three different methods
available for actually selecting your
methods and what are these methods one
is Select by index now the index starts
with 0 in the list so you can select any
element from your list using the index
site and then the second one is Select
by values so this is used to select an
option based on its value attribute
select by visible text so this is an
option wherein you can select a
particular list item or an option based
on the text displayed in the option so
that means whatever text you can see on
your drop down list is what you will use
it to identify that particular element
so let's see the demo for this so I have
again a same Facebook application which
I've considered here for demo so if you
go to our Facebook application first you
know that there is a drop down menu here
now this drop down is for selecting your
birth date this has a day values which
you can select the month values right
and the year now what I have done in my
code is first thing is I've identified
all these drop down boxes using one of
I'm using mostly the ID locating
technique here so you can use any of
your choice so once I identify the
element I created the select object
class for each of this and I pass that
web element to the Constructor of the
select class so now my select element or
the object is ready to use so my next
step what I need to do is I need to go
and select the actual dates now in this
use case what I want is I want to select
a date which is 10th June 2005. that
means on my select drop down of the day
I should be able to select the day 10.
now this I am achieving by using select
by value and then I'm selecting the bun
month based on the index which is the
index in this case is 6 which will
select the June form and then the third
one I am trying to select it by visible
text wherein I am selecting the year
2000 y so when I execute this program
let's see how the date selection happens
okay there we go so it selected the 10
the day 10 the June month and the 2005.
so this is how you use select objects in
selenium question 23 what does the
switch to command do so switch to
command is used to switch between
Windows frames or even the alert pop-ups
within your application right so there
are multiple things which you can do
with switch to now sometimes in your web
application say when you click on a
button it opens up a completely new
browser window or you will also see it
opens up another tab in your browser say
for example let's look at one of this
application which I have let me go to my
browser and say I launch HDFC bank.com
all right so this is my application say
which you want to test now when you
launch this first thing is I see this
advertisement and pop-up which comes up
which is right now an unwanted pop-up so
right now I'll just close this and now
if I want to enter this HDFC Bank
application first I need to do a login
so if I click on this login button see
there is a new window which opens up and
I need to go and operate into this
window so for any further operations I
want to do it on this web page I need to
switch to this window and then say I
want to click on continue to net banking
and then continue with my use case so
now in this application there are two
windows open one is your base window
from where we actually logged in and
after I clicked on the login there is a
new window opened up right so this is
where your switch to command will help
us to switching to this particular
window to do any of the operations on
this web elements present on this window
okay now let's see how do we actually do
this so in order to do this first you
need to get the handle of the window by
using a command called driver dot get
window handle all right so now when you
use driver.getwindow handle what you you
get is a unique alphanumeric value which
is an identifier for that window and
once you get this you use a command
called driver.switch2 dot window and you
pass that handle which you have fetched
previously and this command will
actually switch to the current window
which is in your focus now you will also
come across a case where there are
multiple windows open right now the
example what we saw we just had a single
window but say if you whenever you
launch an application say there are
multiple windows which are open so in
such case you can use something called
as get Windows handles right now get
Windows handles what it does it it picks
up all the active windows at that point
of attack and using a for Loop you can
read into every handle and then you do
your operation specific to your window
handles also there is another way
wherein you can switch back to your
parent window so if ever you want to
switch back to your parent window you
have to use the same command driver dot
switch to and the handle what you need
to provide here is your parent handle
all right so this is about Windows then
I also also said switch 2 can be used
for your frames so water frames frames
are usually used to divide your web
application or your web page or the on
the same domain into various different
windows or sections right so for us to
operate on Elements which are in
different frames we need to First switch
to a particular frame and then use the
web elements on that so the same command
we'll be using now instead of window
here I would say driver dot switch to
dot free similarly even the alert
pop-ups can be handled using the same
command so in the case of alert what you
need to do is you have to say driver dot
switch to dot question 20 how to upload
a file in selenium Webdriver right a
very important Concept in selenium web
driver we know that selenium Webdriver
is designed for automating web
application right and file upload is a
very common scenario which we get with
every web application which we are
working with now there are two ways to
do a file window a file upload operation
One is using the send Keys which is the
simplest method and the other the way is
using robot class now there are certain
prereqs required for you to work with
the send Keys option now if you are
using the send Keys option what you
basically need to do is you need to type
in the complete path of the file along
with the file name right in the file
select input field now this element
where you are going to enter your file
name should have certain attributes one
of the attributors it should have the
tag as input right and also it should
have an attribute called type which
should have a value or file only then it
is possible for you to enter a file name
and upload the file okay that is by
using the send Keys method then the
other way is using robot now when when
is that we need to use robot where
whenever you have an application and in
your application usually for your file
upload you have a button which says
upload a file and when you click on that
it opens a new window and this window is
your Windows Explorer window or a finder
window depending on what operating
system you're working and these are the
native windows and we know that selenium
Webdriver directly cannot handle the
native applications so in such case the
robot class helps us in managing these
native windows so what happens in the
robot classes it helps you manage your
file upload dialog box by simulating all
the actions required for selecting a
particular file from your dialog box and
then you go and upload them all right so
this is the example of using the send
Keys question 25 how to set browser
window size in Webdriver so you can
either maximize the window or set it to
a certain value now to do this you use a
simple functions provided by driver dot
manage one of the functions using
driver.manage is
driver.manage.window.maximize now this
command maximizes the current window and
say you want to set a particular window
size rather than maximizing it and then
for that you have a command called
driver
manage.window.set size now this set size
takes an argument of the type Dimension
plus so this is basically when you
create a dimension class you are passing
the size of the window which you want to
create here right so we use the
dimension class Define the new
dimensions of the window and then pass
the object of this Dimensions to the set
size method this is one way of doing it
we also saw that using JavaScript
executor we can do any kind of
functionality so if you want to minimize
or maximize or set a different size to
your browser windows this can also be
done using a JavaScript okay let's see a
quick demo on how do we use this driver
dot manage dot set size or the maximize
command so let's go to my Eclipse here
so I have this method written here so I
have two methods one method where I am
saying I am going to maximize the window
this particular command is where I'm
saying driver dot manage Dot
window.maxims and I'm launching a
Facebook application so first let's run
this particular method and see how our
browser window behaves so I'll just say
execute this
so now you will see the whole window
your browser window is in maximized mode
so now from here I'm going to execute
the other set of lines here using which
I'm going to set a certain size now I'll
just comment out these two lines
and then these are the two commands
which I'm going to use right so here
what I have done is I've defined an
object of the class Dimension and I've
used 600 600 which is the size of the
window which I want it to be and then
using the set size I'm passing this
Dimension object to the set size method
now let's see how do we look at this
browser window now did you see that so
it was at a certain size and it just
shrunk it shrunk because I have used a
smaller size window question 26 when do
we use find element and find elements
Now find element you can use this
command to access any single element on
your web page and what does it return it
returns an object of the first matching
element of the specified locator and
this is the most common command what we
use for working with every web element
on the web page what is find elements
find elements is used to return a list
of web elements right so each element
which it identifies is indexed with the
number starting from zero it's just like
an array I'll show you an example of
that so that you can understand it
better so let's go to my Eclipse here
right so if you look at this
locators.java I have different elements
which I have identified using different
locating techniques right so for that I
use a simple command called find element
now say I have a used case right wherein
I want to fetch all the web elements who
have a class name starting with the text
input let's see what that is so if I go
to my Facebook application if I try to
inspect this say first name right so
I'll say inspect element now here if you
see this particular web element has a
class name starting with text called as
input text likewise there are many
elements here like even the surname if
you look at it it has a class name
starting with input text okay so if I
have a use case like that where I want
all the web elements on the Facebook
page who have the class name starting
with mint now input if I have to do that
that is when I say I am going to use the
driver dot find elements so I say driver
dot find elements I give an XPath which
is going to pick up all those elements
which has the class name starting with
input this is my XPath expression once I
get all the elements what am I doing I
am going to store it in a list tag once
I have all these elements created it's
in an array I'm just going to Traverse
through the array using an enhanced for
Loop so in this program in this test
case I'm just picking each and every
element and printing the attribute ID of
each element so if I execute this now we
should see all the elements on the
Facebook page which has the class name
starting with input and we should see
all the IDS of that so this is what we
are getting so you are around getting 9
to 10 elements it has picked up and all
of them have the class name starting
with input and these are the different
IDs
question 27 what is pause on exception
in selenium ID so pause on exception is
a new feature of selenium ID it is one
of the brilliant debugger function which
this new selenium ID provides us what it
does is it enables us or when this
particular option is enabled the
execution of your test pauses if at all
there is any exception which occurs in
your test scripts and because of this
what you can do is you can go and handle
that error by say changing your command
in the script and then continue your
test execution so this helps in
debugging your code pretty well so
whenever there is an exception say for
example an web element which you are
trying to identify has a wrong identify
or it changes on your web page then you
can correct that command which caused
the exception and then resume the test
execution from that point onwards so
let's look at a simple use case and see
how exactly this works so for example
let's go to my browser here okay so have
a simple use case here where I want to
login into Facebook using my email ID
and password and what I have done is I
have created a script or recorded a
script using my selenium ID so these are
all the steps which it has wherein it
logs into the Facebook account then it
clicks on the email field enters the
email this is my value which I'm passing
clicks on the password field enters the
password and then clicks on the login
button now this is a clean test script
and all my web elements are correct here
so whenever I'm running this test with
this test script is going to pass now
say as an example say this particular
element which is my password element say
this ID changes so now deliberately what
I'm going to do I'm just going to give a
wrong idea so if I give a wrong ID and
if I execute a test script now it is
going to throw an exception at this
point so let's do that so it's going to
throw an exception but now since I want
to use that pause on exception feature
what I do is it's available here it says
pause and Exception by default it is
Switched Off so when you select this
that means this has been switched on and
now if I execute the script this is
going to come into a debug mode at this
point where my exception is going to be
true so let's see that so now I have
this I have changed this ID to a wrong
ID so I'll just say go and run this
current test so let's see how it
operates so let me just bring this side
by side so you can see here it has
entered the email and if you look here
in the console it is saying trying to
find the ID for which I have given PA
and 4S which is a wrong ID so it will
look for some time whether it can find
an element with this particular ID so
let's wait for it to throw the exception
there we go so now it tried enough and
actually that step has failed and there
is an exception saying that that
particular web element is not found
however my test case or the test script
did not exit it has come and paused and
it has entered into a debug mode here
paused in debug now as a tester or an
automation scriptwriter what I can do
here is I can simply go and and correct
this now I know this is my correct ID
once I correct this I can execute the
rest of the script right from this point
so now I have this option here if you go
here it says resume test execution so
I'm just going to click on that so it is
going to go ahead and enter everything
else if you see here I entered email
password and in this description what
I'm doing is I'm entering my first name
and my surname instead of clicking on
the login button so it went ahead and if
you look here it says FB test completed
successfully this is how the pause and
exception feature helps us question 28
how to login into any website if it is
showing an authentication popup for
username and password which will be
something like this so this is a typical
authentication pop-up which you normally
see when you are dealing with some web
application right and to handle them we
use something called as an alert class
and alert class comes with a method
called authenticate using basically by
using this method what we are trying to
do is it helps us skip the basic http
authentication box so how do we handle
it it is handled exactly the way we
handle any kind of alert box in selenium
now in this example first what we need
to do is we need to create a weight
object using an explicit width now this
weight is for what it is for the alert
to pop up so we basically wait until
that authentication alert pops up and
set the conditions in this explicit way
for as alert is present so that means
you are going to wait until your
authentication pop-up is C on your
screen and then once you have that
authentication pop-up which is on your
screen that is when you need to go and
handle it now to handle it for your
alert class you're going to call a
method as I said using authenticate
using and to this you pass a parameter
now this parameter has to be your
username and password however the way
the parameters are passed here is using
a class object called user and password
now this user and password class it is a
part of selenium Security package all
right and this is implemented from an
interface called credentials so you
create this object of class user and
password using the authentication
information which you have and then pass
this as parameter to your method called
authenticate using and this way you can
handle your authentication pop-up
question 29 what is the difference
between single and double slash in XPath
a very important question and it's a
very important thing for each of you to
understand single slash is used to
create an XPath with absolute path that
is the X path would be created right
from the starting node and the starting
node is slash HTML and the double slash
is created or it's a XPath with relative
path now relative path this x path would
be created using any starting location
or anywhere within the document for
example I could start with a div tag
wherein if I mention double slash enter
so this is going to be treated as a
relative path and whatever conditions I
am going to give it is going to try and
match those attributes with the stack
right this is called as a relative path
so why don't we just go and take a look
at how do we identify an element using a
relative as well as an absolute path so
if I go back to the same application of
the Facebook this is my Facebook
application now I have this grow path
installed which helps me in identifying
X parts of an element now say I want to
try and see what is the X path of my
element first name so in the inspector
tool I can see that it has a tag input
and it has a long class name and it has
multiple attributes which I can use to
identify this element so if I go to my
Crow path and again try to match this
element so if I just hover my mouse here
now here you can see this cropath gives
me both the path one is the relative X
path and one is the absolute X path now
look at the big difference between these
two now relative path was as simple as
using a slash slash input which is the
tag and an attribute called ID we are
able to identify this particular element
same thing thing if you want to use an
absolute path and you if you see here it
will start right from the slash HTML
which is your starting node of your HTML
page and then it travels down looking
into each of the parent and child under
this until it found this element input
right so this is absolute path so you
can use either of these paths to
identify your elements question 30 how
do you find broken links in selenium
Webdriver now HTTP is designed for what
to enable Communications between your
clients and servers and if you know
there are few commands like get put post
now get is used to request data from a
specified resource put command is used
to send data over your server and post
is used to send data to the server right
now while using these links and trying
to figure out if the link is valid or
not what you can do is you can use
something called as head requests now
what are head requests head requests are
nothing but there's something like a get
request but they do not have a response
body and usually this is used for
checking that what a get request can
return before actually making a get
request like say before downloading a
large file you would send a head request
before sending the complete get just to
know whether the link which is provided
for downloading a large file is a
genuine link or not and then looking at
the response code is what you decide
that so how do we do this
programmatically now selenium provides
something called as HTTP URL connection
class which has some methods to send
HTTP request and to capture the HTTP
response codes like the ones which you
see it on the screen so if we have to
see how do we do that now first thing
the logic behind how do we get this
broken links is you get all the URLs on
your website first after getting all the
URLs now how do you get the URLs by
using the tag a like it is done here so
once you get the complete list of all
urls you also check for a non-val A
non-null or a blank once that is one
kind of a check which you can put after
that you create get an HTTP connection
object with each of the URL and you open
the connection of the URL and you send
the request now this request whatever
you're going to send you are going to
send the header request to just to get
the head and not the complete get
request now only thing what you are
interested in getting a response code so
once you get the Response Code what you
have to do is you have to check the
Response Code against all your response
code now typically when you're checking
for your response code any response code
above 400 is treated as a client error
rest all the links below 400 are all the
valid links so here if you see 404 you
have a response called as link not fault
400 is a bad request 401 is unauthorized
so you can do a simple check there where
it says if your response code is above
500 then that particular link has an
error and that is probably going to be
your invalidly so let's see that in
action as how exactly the code is going
to look and how do we achieve that now I
have a test case written here called
broken links.java now here what I'm
doing is I'm logging into facebook.com
and then I'm fetching all the elements
with the tag a now when I say I'm
fetching all the elements with the tag
that means I'm going to get all the href
element from the page and once I get
that using a for Loop I'm going to
inspect each and every URL what I'm
going to fetch as I said my first check
would be to see if it is a null or is it
an empty if I find an empty or a null
value in the URL I'm just going to
ignore that and continue the loop and
this is where I actually do the
connection with my URL so I create an
HTTP URL connection with the URL which I
have picked it up from my website then I
do this I send a request here the head
request to get a response code so once I
get this response code is what I put a
if fill statement and check if my
response code is greater than or equal
to 400 so if I find that if my response
code is more than 400 that means this
particular URL link is broken and that
is how I identify so once you identify a
particular URL which is broken you can
make use of that information share it
with your developers and get it fixed so
let's go ahead and execute this so in
this test case basically what I'm going
to do is I'm just printing out all the
URLs and I'm printing the ones which are
valid and ones which are broken uh since
it's a facebook.com website I do not
have any broken URL but this is just a
logic of how do we find a broken URL so
if you look here there are a lot of
websites which is getting listed which
says is a valid link so that means it is
getting a response code which is more
than 500. so this is what we saw in the
demo as how do I iterate after I select
all the links on the page and then how
do I determine whether it's a valid link
or it's a broken Link in this session we
will learn about jmeter in this jmeter
complete tutorial we will be learning
everything related to jmeter starting
from its installation but before we
begin let me tell you guys that we have
daily updates on multiple Technologies
so if you are a tech geek in a
continuous hunt for latest technological
Trends then consider getting subscribed
to our YouTube channel and don't forget
to hit that Bell icon to never miss an
update from Simply learn now without
further Ado let's get started with the
agenda for today's session
so as discussed we will start with
jmeter installation then we will get
into the performance testing followed by
that we will learn the jmeter load
testing
advancing ahead we will dive deep into
jmeter API testing and finally we will
wind up the J meter tutorial for
beginners by the last topic that is the
jmeter script recording I hope I made
myself clear with the agenda now over to
our training experts let's get started
with what is jmeter
J meter or Apache jmeter is an open
source software which is a hundred
percent pure Java application
the application is designed to load or
test functional behavior and measure
performance performance testing means
testing a web application against heavy
load multiple and concurrent user
traffic it was originally designed for
testing web applications but has since
expanded to other test functions to
simplify let's assume that someday your
team lead tells you to perform
performance testing of some website like
google.com or facebook.com for around
100 users what would be the first thing
that comes to your mind
do you think it's practically possible
to arrange 100 people with computers and
access to the internet and accessing the
same website
now just imagine the infrastructure
requirement when this testing has to be
done for thousand or ten thousand users
this is when a need for software like
jmeter Rises
so what jmeta actually does is that it
simulates it will simulate real user
behaviors and perform load tests on a
server group of servers Network or
object
moving further let's have a look at the
prerequisites to install jmeter
the only prerequisite of installing
jmeter is that Java must be installed in
your system since jmeter is an entirely
based application that's why having Java
installed in your system is a must
other than that jmeter can be used in
many operating systems such as Linux
Windows Mac us or even Ubuntu
now that we know the basics of jmeter
let's go on to installing jmeter onto
our system first let's check if you have
Java installed in your system
for checking that we shall go to the
command prompt and type Java hyphen
version we can see that Java is present
in our system here it will show the
version of java present in our system
the next step is to download jmeter
go to Google Chrome and type jmeter
download now go to the official Apache
jmeter website and go to the binary
sections in the binary sections we shall
download the zip folder
once the zip folder is downloaded open
the folder location then extract the zip
folder once the folder is again
extracted go inside the folder and go
inside the bin folder here the bin
folder contains the jmeter script file
for starting jmeter now it's time for us
to launch a meter but before we launch a
meter we need to know that there are
typically two types of modes in which
jmeter can be launched the GUI mode and
the non-gui mode the non-gui mode May
refer to two types the first being
running jmeter in the server mode and
the second refers to running jmeter in
the command line
and if we talk about the GUI mode then
the GUI mode has a limitation which
slows down the CPU utilization while
running the recorded script but GUI mode
of jmeter is perfect for adding and
editing new configuration elements
thread groups and Samplers as a result
of which you can view a number of
different listeners helping for
debugging here today we shall be using
the GUI mode so to open the GUI mode
inside this bin folder select the
jmeter.bat file double click on this
file this may take a while and then the
jmeter window will open up on the screen
the home window is divided into two
sections on the left side all the
elements of the test plan are added and
on the right side all the configuration
of that element are added as we see on
the test plan element we can see the
configurations of the same here the test
plan is like a place or a container
where all the elements we will use to
perform this test will be stored all the
requests listeners and everything will
be stored here
so moving forward let's rename this test
plan let's name the test plan to be
first J meter now when you click outside
this window section you can see the
element name will change otherwise you
can just save this and also the name
will change
now when this is done the next step is
to add thread groups right click on
first J meter here and select the add
option then in this option select the
threads option and then thread script
the thread group refers to the users
that are used or created or needed to
run this test so let's name this thread
group to be jmeter
it has several different options like
the action to be taken after there is an
error you can choose it in the way you
want then there is this number of
threads where you can choose the number
of users you want
then there is a ramp up period in
seconds option that states the time gap
between the user's hits
third there is also a loop count where
you can choose how many times the test
will run for the number of users you can
choose the test to Run infinite number
of times
there is also a scheduler here that will
help you schedule the start time and the
tests and time for now let's leave
everything to be one only
the next step is to go to First J meter
and again to go to add in the Box it
appears select Samplers you can see all
types of requests that jmeter can work
on
for now we will choose the simplest of
them all let's choose the HTTP request
here you will have to give the address
to some home pages or websites
so let's make it a little easy let's
rename it to be home pages
here in the server name or IP Box we
have to give the server name or the IP
let's pick a website let's go to the
simply learn website copy the URL from
here
come back to the jmeter window and paste
it in the server name box keep in mind
we don't need to give HTTP or https
since these are protocols which will
come in the other box and they will be
automatically taken in the HTTP request
case then in the path dialog box since
we have to access the route page we will
leave a forward slash there
now when our HTTP test is ready we will
perform the test on it to determine what
the result of the test will be we need
to add some more test elements we shall
again right click on first J meter go to
The Listener options then in the Box we
can check the different type of reports
that jmeter provides us for now we shall
select two of these let's choose view
results in table
and the view result stream
now save the test and run it
for running the test there are three
simple ways first you can simply click
the green button here to run second you
can go to this run option and choose run
the test and the Third Way is you can
right click on first J meter and choose
to run
let's simply choose the green button and
run the test
after we run the test we shall go to
check the results of the test since we
had put the number of threads and loop
to be 1 there's just one entry in both
the results now let's try one more thing
we shall go to J meter and change the
number of threads and the loop count
let's make the number of threads to be
around 10 and also the loop count to be
10. and now run the test after running
the test we shall see the results in the
table and see the testing being
performed and the same happens in the
case of view results entry
since we have increased the number of
users and the loop count we can see the
test being performed accordingly
since a loop count now was 10 so for
each user the test will run 10 times
and here on the screen we can see the
time taken and the number of tests being
performed and the status of each hit
onto our website link let's get started
with what is performance testing
so performance testing is one of the
most important phases of any product
launch as it verifies and validates the
overall product performance this testing
can be done in different forms depending
upon the resource availability and the
type and volume of the user base the
main agenda behind conducting
performance testing on any product is to
make sure that the product's performance
is as expected before it gets launched
into the market so performance testing
is the process of testing a software
application under a specific workload
performance testing is a software
testing process used to test the speed
response time stability reliability
scalability and resource usage of a
software application under a particular
workload the main purpose of performance
testing is to identify and eliminate
performance bottlenecks in the software
application
performance testing mainly focuses on
three factors of a software program
first one is the speed here it
identifies whether the response of the
application is fast or not then comes
scalability where the maximum user load
is determined and the third one is
stability where the stability of the
application is checked under various
workloads now we know what is
performance testing let us understand
why if we need performance testing
the only concern of a software system is
not features and functionality the
response time reliability resource and
scalability are also important factors
so the goal of performance testing is
not to find bugs but to eliminate
performance glitches
performance testing is performed to help
the stakeholders with information about
the application concerning the
application speed stability and
scalability furthermore performance
testing reveals what needs to be
improved before the product goes into
the market if there is no performance
testing the software might suffer from
issues such as running slow while
several users use it simultaneously
inconsistencies across different
operating systems and poor usability
performance testing determines if the
software or application needs speed
scalability and stability requirements
under expected workloads application
sent to Market with poor performance
metrics due to non-consistent or
performance testing are likely to bring
a bad reputation and fail to meet the
expected sales goals now we know the
relevance and need for performance
testing let's look at the typescript
performance testing
so there are six types of performance
testing namely load testing stress
testing volume testing capacity testing
reliability testing and scalability
testing let's have a look at all the six
types of testing one after the other
so the first type is load testing load
testing is a type of performance testing
where the application is tested for its
performance on normal and Peak usage and
applications performance is checked
concerning its response to the user
request and its availability to respond
consistently within accepted Endurance
on different user loads here the main
consideration is the maximum load the
application can hold before the
application starts behaving abruptly
then another consideration is regarding
how much data the database can handle
before the system crashes the second
type of performance testing is stress
testing
stress testing is a type in which
different ways to break the system are
found that is how much load a system can
sustain
stress testing has an incremental
approach where the load is increased
gradually the test is started with a
load for which the application has
already been tested then more load is
added slowly to stress the system the
point at which we start seeing servers
not responding to the request as
considered the breaking point here the
major considerations are the maximum
load to a system consistent before it
breaks down then how is the system
broken down and how will the system be
able to recover once it has crashed
we also see in how many ways a system
can break and which are the weak nodes
that are to be kept in mind while
handling the unexpected load moving
forth the next type is volume testing
volume testing is the type where the
performance of the system is checked
with respect to the volume of the data
to execute a volume test a huge volume
of data is entered into the database
this test can be incremental or study
test in the incremental test the volume
of the data is increased gradually
generally with the application usage the
database size grows and it is necessary
to test the application against a heavy
database if we consider an example let's
say there is a website of college having
small amounts of data to store initially
but after 5 to 10 years the data stored
in the database of the website is much
more and has become huge
now comes the fourth type of performance
testing the capacity testing
so capacity testing is a type of testing
where the application is checked for its
capability to meet the business volumes
capacity testing is generally done for
future prospects here the main concerns
are if the application would be able to
support the future load if the
environment is capable of standing the
upcoming increased load and what are the
additional resources required to make
the environment capable enough
capacity testing helps in determining
how many uses or transactions of a given
web application is capable of supporting
and will perform well during this
testing resources such as processor
capacity
Network bandwidth memory usage disk
capacity Etc are considered and altered
to meet the goal to consider an
excellent example of capacity testing we
can see the case of online banking
moving forward the next type of testing
is the reliability testing
reliability testing is a type in which
the application is verified if the
application would be normal again after
an abnormal state
it estimates the time that the system
would take to return to its normal state
to understand the concept let's say
there is an online trading site that
experiences some failure and because of
which the users are not able to buy or
sell shares at a certain point of the
day but after a couple of hours they
were able to operate their shares and
the application became normal this is
when it can be said that the application
is reliable and can recover from its
abnormal State the last type of testing
is scalability testing scalability
testing is a type where the application
is determined if it would be able to
scale up whenever needed
the need for scaling up comes when there
is an increase in user load now when we
have learned the types of performance
testing we must learn the process of
performance testing
so the process of performance testing is
divided into eight parts that is
requirement Gathering selection of tools
performance test plan performance test
development performance test modeling
execution of test test result analysis
report now let's have a look at all of
these processes one after the other the
first step in the process is requirement
Gathering the requirements are
identified and gathered from the clients
by the performance team this includes
getting information on the application's
architecture Technologies database used
intended users functionality application
usage test requirement hardware and
software requirements Etc the second
step in the process is selection of
tools after the previous step POC or
proof of concept is done with the
available tools the proof of concept is
a sort of demonstration of real-time
activity but in a limited sense
the list of available tools depends on
the tools cost the protocol that the
application is using the technology is
used to build the application the number
of users we were simulating for the test
Etc now the third step the third step is
the performance test plan in reference
to the above two steps test planning and
designing are conducted the process of
test planning involves information on
how the performance test is going to
take place like the test environment
workload Hardware
Etc moving forth the fourth step is
performance test development in this
step the use cases for the identified
functionalities are created
these use cases are shared with the
client for their approval once the
clients approve the use case the script
development begins these scripts are
validated against several different
users and parallel to script creation
the performance Team sets up the test
environment the performance team also
takes care of metadata through scripts
if the client does not take up that
activity so the next step is performance
test modeling
performance load model is created for
the test execution this step aims to
validate whether the given performance
metrics are achieved during the test or
not then the sixth step is execution of
tests the scenario is designed according
to the load model and controller or
performance center initially the tests
are not executed with maximum users that
are in the load model the test execution
is done in incremental order let's say
there are thousand users then the
scenario will begin testing from 100
then go to 250 then 350 and so on it
will gradually increase and go up to
1000 users
the next step is the seventh step in our
process
that is the test result analysis the
test results are the most important
deliverable for the performance tester
this is where we can prove the return on
investment and productivity that a
performance testing effort can provide
what makes the result analysis process
more effective is that we must have a
unique and meaningful name for every
test result which will help us
understand the test purpose in the test
summary certain things must be included
like the reason for failure how the
performance of the application changes
regarding the previous runs it is also a
good practice to make a result summary
after each test run so that the analysis
results are not compiled every single
time the results are referred then the
final and the last step in performance
testing process is the report the test
results should be simplified so that
conclusion is clearer and should not
create any derivation
the development team needs more
information on analysis comparison of
results and details of how the results
were obtained the test report is
considered to be good if it's brief
descriptive and to the point now that we
know the performance testing the next
important topic to discuss is the
understanding of performance testing
metrics the first is processor usage
which refers to the amount of time the
processor spends executing the non-idle
threats second metric is memory usage
memory use is the amount of physical
memory available to the processor on a
computer system the third metric is test
time which is the amount of time the
disk is busy in executing read or write
request the fourth metric is the
bandwidth that shows the bits per second
used by a network interface moving forth
the next metric is the private bytes it
is the number of bytes a process has
allocated that can be shared amongst the
other processes these are used to
measure memory leaks and usage then
comes the committed memory this is the
amount of virtual memory used then the
next metric we have is the response time
it is the time between when the user
enters a request to time to the first
character of the response is received
next metric is the throughput it is the
rate at which a computer or a network
receives requests per second moving
forth the next metric is the hit ratios
the hit ratios are concerned with the
number of SQL statements that are
handled by cached data instead of
expensive input output operations
and the last metric in our list is the
top weights these are monitored to
determine what wait times can be cut
down to make the data retrieval faster
from memory apart from this some metrics
like the rollback segment garbage
collection thread counts hits per second
CPU Interruption per second this Q
length Etc now when we know almost
everything that is needed regarding
performance testing it is very important
to know the tools that make performance
testing possible here are the top 5
performance testing tools in the market
today the first tool we have is the load
Runner or HP load Runner as the name
suggests the load Runner is great when
it comes to handling a large amount of
users for testing the second tool in our
list is web loot web load is one of the
best testing tools for stress and load
testing the next tool in our list is
load UI load UI is a great testing tool
to map the scalability and speed of the
target product the fourth tool in our
list is new load it is one of the
fastest testing tools with a speed of
around 10 times the traditional testing
tools that are integrated seamlessly
into our existing software with a wide
array of tests the last tool in our list
is the Apache jmeter Apache jmeter is
one of the best and most used testing
tools in the market right now it is
highly capable of creating a large
number of virtual users working on web
server moving forth we shall talk about
jmeter and understand why jmeta is
preferred over all the other performance
testing tools in the market so moving
forth let's see what jmeter is jmeter or
Apache jmeter is an open source software
that has 100 pure Java application the
application is designed to load or test
functional behavior and measure
performance jmeter is originally
designed for testing web applications
but has since expanded to other test
functions to understand the concept of
jmeter let us assume that someday your
team leads tell you to perform
performance testing on some website like
Facebook or google.com for 100 users
what would be the first thing comes to
your mind do you think it's practically
possible to arrange 100 people with
computers and access to Internet and
accessing the same website now just
imagine the infrastructure requirement
when this testing has to be done for 10
000 users this is when a need for
software like jmeter arises so what
jmeter does is it actually simulates
it will simulate the real user's
behavior and perform load tests on
server group of servers Network or
object now let's have a look at some
reasons why geometer is used for load
testing we have divided these reasons
into six parts the first one is it's
free of cost second one is performance
testing of applications next one
platform independent the fourth one is
customizable fifth is recording and
Playback and finally six is the
community support let's see all of these
one after the other the first reason we
have is free of cost one of the main
deciding factors in any software is its
cost normally a software can range from
high as six to seven figures per license
here jmeter is free of cost very
intuitive and has all the possibilities
you need to automate your work then the
second reason is performance testing of
applications the application is used to
perform performance testing on different
types of applications like web
applications web services ldap database
and shell scripts jmeta can conduct load
and performance tests for many different
and servers and server types web HTTP
and https database via jdbc ldap and JMS
the third reason is
platform Independence
jmeter is written and developed using
Java to run on any environment or
workstation that accepts Java virtual
machine for example Windows Linux Mac
Etc the next reason we have is that
jmeter is customizable since jmeter is
an open source application it enables
developers to customize whenever needed
jmeter has a comprehensive and
user-friendly graphical user interface
parameters are easy to Define and
understand scripting is simpler and
clearer and adding and defining elements
is more intuitive also one screen shows
everything you need the script the
scenario and the analysis these Samplers
are highly customizable when determining
which request to be sent to the host
however Samplers don't enable full
control of test actions moving forth the
following reason is recording and
Playback
the application provides record and
Playback options enabled with the drag
and drop feature making the application
faster and easier the next and the last
reason on our list is incredible
Community Support jmeter is an open
source tool with a brilliant community
that keeps adding features and supports
users who run into issues and problems
this ensures new users always have
someone to answer their questions and
long time users can improve their
abilities on jmeter also having an open
source tool ensures that it keeps
getting better and is always in line
with user's needs and requirements
finally let's have a look into the demo
that shows the working of jmeter
so the first step is we shall go to the
Apache jmeter folder in that folder go
inside the bin folder and select the
jmeter dot path file
double click on this file
this might take a while
and then the jmeter window will open on
the screen
the home window is divided into two
sections on the left side all the test
plan elements are added and on the right
side all the configurations of that
element are added
as we are on the test plan element we
can see the configurations of the same
here the test plan is like a place or a
container where all the elements we will
be using to perform this test will be
stored
all the requests listeners and
everything will be stored here
I have renamed this test plan as
performance testing
now the first step is to add thread
group
right click on the performance testing
go to add then go to thread or users
and select thread group
let's name this as perform
here the thread group refers to the used
or created users or needed to run this
test
it has several different options like
the action to be taken after there is an
error you can choose it the way you want
then there is this number of threads
where you can choose the number of users
you want then there is a ramp up period
in seconds option that states the time
gap between the users hits third there
is a loop count where you can choose how
many times the test will run for the
number of users you can also choose the
test to run in finite times there is
also a scheduler here to help you
schedule the start time and the test and
time let's make the number of threads to
B2 and let's make the loop count to be
100. the next step is to add an HTTP
request for that right click on the
thread group go to add option and go to
the sampler option in the menu that
appears select the HTTP request option
here on the screen there is a server
name or IP Box we have to give the
server name or the IP in that let's pick
up a website and place the link in the
box which will use the simply learns
website here go to Simply learns website
and copy the URL from here then come
back to the jmeter window and paste it
onto the server name box keep in mind we
don't need to give the HTTP or https
since these are protocols which will
come in the other box and they will be
automatically taken in the HTTP request
case
then in the path dialog box we will
leave the forward slash there since we
have to access the root page and let's
rename this HTTP request as simple now
to get results we shall add listeners
listeners are something that are used to
provide the outputs of a load test there
are different types of listeners present
in jmeter and many may be added using
plugins we will use three different
listeners here to have an idea about the
representation that the jmeter provides
for that right click on the thread group
then go to the ad select listener option
and go to the view results entry option
then again right click on the listener
option and choose graph results and for
the third listener again right click and
select the view results in the table
option
now it's time to run the test
for running the test there are three
simple ways first you can simply click
on the green button here to run second
is you can go to the Run option and
choose the run the test and the third
way you can right click on the first
jmeter and choose to run let's simply
choose the green button and run the test
first we will have to save this J meter
test and then we shall go on to check
the results of the test
here in the view results tree we can see
the test being run
the same in the case of graph results we
can see the throughput option then we
can also see the time the test has been
executing since we had put the threads
to 2 and the loop count to 100 so the
test will run for a while
we can check the view results in the
table we can see different performance
testing metrics on the screen you can
see the thread name label sample time
per second bytes sort bytes and the
latency and in the tree option when we
click on the test we can see a lot of
information appearing on the screen
these are again several performance
testing metrics and in the graph results
we can see the graph coming up on the
screen now which represents the test
taking place with respect to the IP
address thread and loop counts so what
geometer exactly does is creates a
request and sends it to the server once
it receives the service response it
collects them and visualizes those
details in a chart or graph after that
it processes the service response and
finally it generates the test results in
several formats such as text XML Json so
that the tester can analyze the data
let's get started with what is load
testing
load testing is a type of performance
testing that determines an application's
behavior when a large number of users
access the application together here
performance testing is a software
testing process used to test the speed
response time stability and reliability
of the software application under a
particular workload the testing
determines A System's performance
according to real life conditions to
give you a better idea let's say you
have a printer so you want to test a
printer by transferring large number of
documents for printing or test a mail
server with thousands of concurrent
users or to test a word processor by
making a change in a large volume of
data this helps to know whether the
existing infrastructure is capable of
running the application or not
load testing checks how much load can a
system handle the testing identifies the
limitations due to Hardware like CPU
maximization Network bottleneck memory
limitation Etc and it also identifies
the issues and software configurations
such as web server application server
database server Etc
it helps to identify the maximum
operating capability of an application
and checks the performance of the
application under different load
conditions of system components and
database components load testing is
conducted to determine the number of
concurrent users that an application can
support without performance
deterioration the response time of each
transaction of an application and the
network delay between the client request
and server response are also checked
load testing proves itself very
significant when it comes to data mining
user demands and satisfaction several
tools make load testing possible such as
Apache jmeter web load load UI load
Runner new load load ninja Etc
here in this session we shall be using
jmeter for load testing
so jmeter or Apache geometer is open
source software that is 100 pure Java
application the application is designed
to load or test functional behavior and
measure performance performance testing
means testing a web application against
heavy load multiple and concurrent user
traffic it was originally designed for
testing web applications but has since
expanded to other test functions to
simplify let's assume that someday your
team leads tell you to perform
performance testing for some websites
like yahoo.com or google.com for 100
users what would be the first thing that
comes to your mind do you think it's
practically possible to arrange 100
people with 100 computers and access the
internet and accessing the same website
now just imagine the infrastructure
requirement when this testing has to be
done for thousand or ten thousand users
this is when we need a software like
jmeter
so what geometer does is it simulates it
will simulate real user behaviors and
perform load testing on a server group
of servers Network or object next let's
have a look at some reasons why jmeter
is used for load testing we have divided
these reasons into six parts
it is free of cost performance testing
of applications platform independent
customizable recording and Playback and
Community Support
now let's see all of these one after the
other the first one free of cost one of
the main deciding factors in any
software is its cost normally a software
can range from high as six to seven
figures per license here J meter is free
of cost very intuitive and has all the
possibilities you need to automate your
work
the next one is performance testing of
applications
the application is used to perform
performance testing on different
applications like web applications web
servers ldap database and shell scripts
jmeter can conduct load and performance
test for many different server types
like web HTTP and https database viajdbc
ldap and JMS the third important reason
is its platform independent in nature
jmeter is written and developed using
Java programming language to run on any
environment or workstation that accepts
a Java virtual machine for example
Windows Linux Mac Etc
the next reason we have is J meter is
highly customizable since jmeter is an
open source application it enables
developers to customize it whenever
needed jmeter has a comprehensive and
user-friendly graphical user interface
parameters are easy to Define and
understand scripting is simpler and
cleaner and adding and defining elements
as more intuitive also one screen shows
you everything you need the script the
scenario and the analysis the Samplers
are highly customizable when determining
which request is to be sent to a host
however Samplers don't enable full
control of test actions moving forward
the following reason is recording and
Playback the application provides record
and Playback options enabled with the
drag and drop features making the
application faster and easier
the next and the last reason in our list
is incredible Community Support jmeta is
an open source tool with a brilliant
community that keeps adding features and
supports users who run into issues and
problems this ensures new users always
have someone to answer their questions
and long time users can improve their
abilities on jmeter also having an open
source tool ensures it keeps getting
better and always in line with users
needs and requirements now after we know
about jmeter and the reasons to use shea
meter let's understand the process to
perform load testing with a Hands-On
demo the only thing that is kept in mind
before this demo is we must have a fully
functional jmet on our system and by now
we know that jmeter can be used in any
operating system like Linux Windows Mac
OS and Ubuntu in this demo we shall look
into both graphical user and
non-graphical user interface mode of
load testing
so the first step is we shall go to the
Apache jmeter folder in that folder go
inside the bin folder and select the
jmeter.pat file double click on this
file this might take a while and then
the jmeter window will open on the
screen the home window is divided into
two sections on the left side the
elements of the test plan are added and
on the right side all the configurations
of the element that are added as we are
on the test plan element we can see the
configurations of the scene here the
test plan is like a place or a container
where all the elements we will use to
perform this test will be stored all the
requests the listeners and everything
will be stored here so the first step is
to add listeners for that go to test
plan right click on the test plan go to
add then go to threads users and select
a thread group the test group refers to
the users that are used or created or
needed to run this test it has several
different options like the action to be
taken after there is an error you can
choose it the way you want then there is
this number of threads where you can
choose the number of users you want then
there is a ramp up period in seconds
option that states the time gap between
the user's hits then the third one there
is a loop count where you can choose how
many times the test will run for the
number of users you can also choose the
test to Run infinite times there is also
a scheduler here to help you schedule
the start time and the test end time for
now let's leave everything to be only
one
the next step is to add the HTTP request
for that right click on the thread group
and go to the option and go to the
sampler option and go to the HTTP
request option here on the screen there
is a server name or IP Box we have to
give the server name or the IP in that
let's pick a website and place the link
in that box we should use the simply
launch website here go to Simply learns
website and copy the URL from there now
we have copied the simply learns URL now
let's come back to the jmeter window and
paste it in the server name box keep in
mind that we don't need to give up the
HTTP or https since these are protocols
which will come in the other box and
they will be automatically taken in the
HTTP request case
so this is what I was talking about now
let's rename this name as simply
moving forward let's create one more
HTTP request for that again right click
on the thread group select samples and
select HTTP requests and go to Simply
launch website again and there we have
the resource link go to that link and
copy the URL then place that URL in the
server or IP address box
we shall remove the HTTP from that link
and add from the end cut the resource
part and paste it in the path box there
here we will rename the HTTP request as
resources
moving forward to increase a load a
little bit more we shall use one more
http
so this time we shall add one more HTTP
request again right click on the threads
group go to the samples option and
select the HTTP request option again to
add one more link to the server and IP
address go to Simply lens website go to
the corporate training link now copy the
URL and go back to the jmeter window and
paste that URL in the IP Box now cut the
corporate training part from the link
and paste it to the other path box
we shall again rename this HTTP request
box as corporate now let's save this
file
in the save dialog box let's name it as
loadtesting.jmx
now to get the results we shall add
listeners lessness are something that is
used to provide the outputs of the load
test there are different types of
listeners present in jmeter and many may
be added using plugins The Listener we
will use here is the tree as it is
comparatively easy to interpret for that
right click on the thread group then go
to add select listener option and we go
for the view results in three option now
it's time to run the test and check the
load for running the test there are
three simple ways first you can simply
click on the green button here to run
second is you can go to the Run option
and choose the run test and the third is
the way you can right click on first
diameter and then choose run let's
simply choose the green button and run
the test after we run the test we shall
go to the check the results of the test
in the view results entry section we can
see the green symbol that states the
test has successfully completed since we
had left all the values to be 1 in the
beginning that's why there is just one
test for each HTTP request now let's
increase the load and let's change some
numbers let's make the number of threads
to be 10 ramp up the periods to V2 and
the loop count to be 10.
now let's run the test again with the
green button after running the test we
shall see the results in the tree and
see the testing being performed since we
have increased the number of users and
ramp up the periods and the loop count
we can see the test being performed
accordingly since the loop count now was
done for each user the test will run 10
times so here on the screen we can see
the time taken and the number of tests
being performed on the status of each
hit onto the website this is how you
perform load testing in graphical user
mode now perform the same test and
non-graphical user mode which will
remove the listener so let's remove the
view results entry
after this we will go to the command
prompt then in the command prompt we
shall put the pin folder path in the
Apache jmeter folder let's go to the bin
folder and copy the location from here
now paste the path in the command prompt
and execute it
once that is done the next step is to
put the command prompt for J meter load
testing this command has got three parts
the first part is The Hyphen and hyphen
T and hyphen L here The Hyphen n
represents the known graphical user
interface mode hyphen T is used to
specify the location of the test script
hyphen L is used to specify the location
of our output result now go to the
location where our jmx file is stored
let's search for the load testing.jmx
file
copy the path and paste it in the
command prompt hyphen t
in the link that we paste towards the
end make sure that you add the name of
the file bit.jmx
now go back to the folder and make a DOT
CSV file make an Excel spreadsheet and
rename it with DOT CSV extension now
copy this path and go back to the
command prompt and paste it after the
hyphen l in the path don't forget to add
the name of the CSV file towards the end
then execute the command and wait for
the command to end
after the command is successfully run
you can see that the tree is
successfully created and towards the end
of that execution you can see that the
message is the end of the Run
now you can go back to the folder and
open the loadtesting.csv file in that
file you can see the entire test result
has been generated
this shows that the command has been
successfully executed and the load
testing is successful in the
non-graphical mode without any errors
this is what we had in this demo we saw
the load testing and graphical user
interface and non-graphical user
interface mode
to have a better picture we use
dashboards dashboards include several
graphs that explain the working of the
website link we use in the HTTP request
the dashboard generator is a modular
extension of jmeter its default behavior
is to read and process samples from a
CSV file to generate HTML files it
generates the report and at the end of
the load test are on demand the
dashboard reports provide metrics like
the APD ex or application performance
index the dashboard also provides a
statistics table response time over time
response times percentiles over time
active threats over time and response
times and percentiles we shall learn
about dashboards and more in the
forthcoming videos in this video we
learned how critical is load testing in
the software testing process and how it
ensures High user satisfaction a
successful load testing will help to
release high quality software if getting
your learning started is half the battle
what if you could do that for free visit
skillup by simply learn click on the
link in the description to know more
let's get started with what an API is
we often come across this term while
reading any technical blog or magazine
an API or application programming
interface is a programming code that
enables data transmission between one
software product and another it is an
intermediary software allowing two
applications to communicate with each
other to understand API even better
let's take an example for example We are
booking a flight
for that you will begin with search in
flights online concerning your
destination departure return dates and
many more filters
to make all these choices you interact
with the airlines website and access
their database and see if there are any
seats available on those States and what
the cost might be
while you're doing all this from the
time to begin to the time you finish
booking your tickets you are doing that
with the help of an API to simplify it
even more it can be said that whenever
we use an application on our mobile
phone the application connects to the
internet and sends data to the server
the server then retrieves the data
interpret set performs necessary actions
and sends it back to our phone the
application then interprets the data and
presents the information we wanted in a
readable way
this is what an API is so that means
each time we use an application like
Facebook send an instant image check
whether on our phone or make some
specific choices while online shopping
we use an API now when we have a good
idea about what an API is let's look at
another major thing before going on to
the Hands-On demo that is why we use
jmeter for API testing Apache G meter is
an open source software and it is used
to simulate loads of various scenarios
and output performance data in several
ways including CSP and XML files and
graphs
we know that the Apache jmeter is 100
pure Java application so it is available
on every OS that supports Java 6 or
later
some of these specific reasons what
makes J meter a perfect fit for API
testing are
jmeter enables fast API testing it
performs quick scope tests and enables
load and stress testing then as we know
it is an open source tool and supports
load testing and stress testing it has a
lot of plugins and extensions jmeta can
be used across several platforms and can
use various programming languages now we
know about API Basics and why we use
jmeter for its testing
it is the right time to see in the
process of API testing in jmeter
to download jmeter you can go to the
Apache jmeter website and download the
file to know the entire downloading
process and install in jmeter you can
check our jmeta download and
installation video in our jmeter
playlist
moving on I have my geometer installed I
will go to the Apache jmeter folder go
into the bin folder and open the batch
file
this might take a while and then the
jmeter window will open on the screen
the home window is divided into two
sections on the left side all the
elements of the test plan are added and
on the right side all the configurations
of that element are added
as we are on the test plan element we
can see the configurations of the scene
here the test plan is like a place or a
container where all the elements we will
use to perform this test will be stored
all the requests listeners and
everything will be stored here
so moving forward right click on the
first jmeter here and select the add
option
then in this option select the threads
option and then threads group
the thread group refers to the users
that are used or created or needed to
run this test
it has several different options like
the action to be taken after there is an
error or you can choose it the way you
want
then there is this number of threads
where you can choose the number of users
you want
then there is a ramp up period and
seconds option that states the time gap
between the user hits third there is a
loop count where you can choose how many
times the test will run for the number
of users you can also choose the test to
run in finite times
there is also a scheduler here to help
you schedule the time for starting the
test and the time for ending the test
for now let's leave everything to be one
only
now for some sample apis go to your
browser and search for some sample rest
API for testing
in this we will go to the first link
that is req res Dot N or requestresponse
Dot N
we will create and run get post put and
delete rest API request in jmeter in the
demo here in this link we have all get
post put delete apis
so we shall choose the first link here
list users
here we have the link request open this
link in the new tab
then we have got the URL for this API
copy this URL and go to the jmeter
window
then in the geometer window right click
thread group and go to add
in the box that appears select samplers
you can see all types of requests that
jmeter can work on we shall choose the
HTTP request here you will have to give
the address to some home pages or
websites
here in the server name or IP Box we
have to give the server name or the IP
so here we shall paste the get API
request URL
in the protocol box we shall put the
https if in the URL the protocol would
have been HTTP then we would have left
this box empty
in the URL we shall put the URL link
remember that we do not put any slashes
here and that anything after the URL
would be put in the path so we shall
remove the path from the URL and put it
in the path box
then we shall take part from the
question mark and use it to give
parameters
since it is the get API we will have to
give parameters we will add the name in
the parameters and give the name as page
and value as 2.
in this HTTP request drop down we can
see all the different types of HTTP
requests that jmeter accepts for now we
shall leave it to be get since we are
using the get API and also let's name
this HTTP request as get API
now when our HTTP request is ready we
will perform the test on it to determine
what the results of the test will be we
need to add some more test elements we
shall again right click on the thread
group go to The Listener options then in
the Box we can check the different types
of reports that jmeter provides us for
now we shall select two of these let's
choose view results tree and the view
results in the table
now save the test I will save the test
with the name API testing
and finally let's run it for running the
test there are three simple ways first
you can simply click the green button on
the Run
second you can go to this run option and
choose to run the test
and the Third Way is you can right click
on the first jmeter and choose to run
let's simply choose the green button and
run the test
after we run the test we shall go to
check the result of the test let's go to
the view results stream here we can see
the green status that shows the test was
successful
and the view results in a table we can
see again the status is green
since we had put the number of threads
and loop to be one there is just one
entry in both the results now let's try
one more thing we shall go to the thread
group and change the number of threads
to written and run the test again after
running the test we shall see the
results in the table and see the testing
being performed and same happens in the
case of view results in table now in the
view results tree we can click on a
request and see different information
here we can see the sample start load
time latency error Etc
same in the view results and table
you can see all such information in a
tabular format you can also see the
response data here this is the same data
as it was there when we copied the URL
from the browser
you can furthermore check the response
headers and the requests that was placed
now we are done with the get API request
let's add the second request that is the
post request again add a HTTP request by
going to the sampler in the thread group
then come back to the browser window and
click on the post API option
then open the request URL in the new
window
then go to this window copy the URL and
come back to the jmeter window
first let's rename this HTTP request as
post API
then let's paste the URL in the server
name or IP Box again let's put HTTP in
the protocol box
address in the server or IP address box
and path in the path box
and in this HTTP request drop down
select the post option this time
then let's go to the parameter part here
select the body data option and we shall
have to add body now
so go back to the browser window and
copy the body from here
[Music]
come back to the jmeter window and paste
the body here
here you can check some advanced
settings also in case you need them for
now since this is just a demo we shall
keep it really simple
so let's run this
we shall go to our two listeners and
clear the previous output
then we shall save the test and run it
now you can see the two tests are here
since the thread count is one let's make
the thread count to be 10 again let's
see what happens
now when I run the test I can see the
test running a required number of times
that is 20 times again I can see
information about different requests
that include different parameters like
latency errors Etc
now let's move on to our third API
request that is the put request go back
to the browser and click on put request
open the request in the new tab
copy the URL and come back to the jmeter
window
make a new HTTP request by going to the
sampler in the thread group
first let's rename this HTTP request as
put API
then let's paste the URL in the server
name or IP Box
again let's put HTTP in the protocol box
address the server or IP address box and
path in the path box
and in the HTTP request drop down select
the put option this time
here also we shall have to add body data
so go back to the browser window and
copy the body from here
coming back to jmeter window select the
body data option and we shall have to
add body now and paste the body here we
shall go to our two listeners and clear
the previous output make the thread
count to be 1 and then we shall save the
test and run it
now you can see the three tests here
since the thread count is one here by
clicking on the API request we can check
a lot of data like the response body and
response headers and same in the case of
view results in the table you can see
the data in a tabular format let's make
the thread count to be 10 and again see
what happens
now when I run the test I can see the
test running a required number of times
and here I can see information about
different requests
now let us add our last API request that
is the delete request
go back to the browser and click on the
delete request
open the request in the new tab copy the
URL and come back to the jmeter window
make a new HTTP request by going to the
sampler in the thread group
first let's rename this HTTP request as
delete API
then let's paste the URL in the server
name or IP Box again let's put HTTP in
the protocol box address in the server
or IP address box and path in the path
box
and in this HTTP request drop down
select the delete option this time here
there is nothing to be added in the
parameter section so let's go to the two
listeners and clear what all is there
then save this test and run it
since we did not make the number of
threads one this time we can see the
test running n number of times
we can see the information of any API
request by just clicking on it let's get
started with what is script recording
record testing in jmeta helps testers to
record and run their activity against
test targets it is a type of automated
testing but for multiple users the test
script is designed to record such
scenarios the proxy server allows J
meter to watch and record user activity
while browsing web applications with a
normal web browser when we talk about
proxy it is a component that is present
between you and the remote server let us
say that you want to record web browser
interactions when JM data starts acting
like a proxy this is when jmitter script
recording is used script recording is
one of the advanced and impressive ways
to figure out and eliminate the
complexity of browser interactions and
software testing now when we know what
script recording is and how it is
relevant let's look into how to do it in
jmeter but before that let's check the
prerequisites of script recording and J
meter there are three major
prerequisites first is having J meter
installed in your system the second
requirement is having Java installed in
your system the third and final
requirement is having Mozilla Firefox in
your system now let us have a look at
the Hands-On demo of how to perform
script recording in jmetup so the first
step is we shall go to the Apache jmeter
folder in that folder we will go into
bin folder and then select the jmeter
dot bat folder let us double click on
that this might take a while and then
the jmeter window will open on the
screen the home window is divided into
two sections on the left side all the
test plan elements are added and on the
right side all the configurations of the
elements are added as we are on the test
plan element we can see the
configurations of the same here you can
think of the test plan like a place or a
container where all the elements we will
be using to perform this test will be
stored all the requests all the
listeners and and everything will be
stored here now the first step is to add
thread group so for that right click on
the thread group select add and from add
go to threads or users and in that
select thread group here the thread
group refers to the users it has several
different options like the action to be
taken after there is an error you can
choose it the way you want then there is
this number of threads where you can
choose the number of users you want then
there is a ramp up period and second
option that states the time gap between
the user hits third there is a loop
count where you can choose how many
number of times the test will run for a
number of users you can also choose the
test to run for infinite times there is
also a scheduler here to help you
schedule the start time and the test and
time the next step is to add an HTTP
request for that right click on the
thread group go to the add option and
now go to the sampler option select the
HTTP request option here there is a
server name or IP Box we have to get
give this server name or IP index let us
pick a website and place the link in the
Box we shall use the simply learns
website here go to Simply learns website
and copy the URL from here then come
back to the jmeter window and paste it
in the server name box keep in mind that
we don't need to give HTTP or https
since these are protocols that will come
in the other box and they will be
automatically taken in the HTTP request
case then in the path dialog box we will
leave a forward slash there since we
have to access the root page now the
next step is to add the HTTP test script
recorder for that right click on the
test plan then go to non-test elements
and select the HTTP test script recorder
option the window on the screen shows
several options here we can see the
start option to begin the test then
there is a box that has the port number
you can make this number whatever you
like I'll put this number as one two
three four for now then let's go back to
the simply learns website and go go to
the resources page then come back to the
jmeters window and rename the recording
controller as resources now let us add
another recording controller so that
jmeter works like a proxy with the help
of https test strip recorder then again
go back to the resources page that we
just opened and scroll down a little bit
here we can see several Technologies and
several other links in those links you
can select any one of the links I will
select digital marketing here then go
back to the jmeter window and rename the
recording controller as digital
marketing then finally let's add a
recording controller for the home page
and rename it as simply learns home page
so now we can see that we have a thread
group here then there is a HTTP request
where we have simply learned website in
the server name then there are three
recording controllers one for the
resources the second for digital
marketing and a third one for home page
and last we have a HTTP test script
recorder here I will rearrange the
recording controllers in sequence
putting the simply launch homepage
controller on the top and then placing
the resources finally digital marketing
recording controller now let us open
Mozilla Firefox in our system go to the
general option here and scroll down to
the network settings in the network
settings option select settings in the
window that appears select the manual
proxy configuration here we shall put
the port number for now I will put the
port number as one two three four in
this box here in the HTTP proxy we have
localhost and we have selected to use
this proxy for FTP and https and then
click on ok now go back to the Apache
jmeter folder and now we shall use this
Apache jmeter temporary root ca5 which
is a security certificate file so coming
back to the Mozilla Firefox window go to
the options Tab and in this tab I will
type certificates and here we shall
select view certificates in the window
that opens let us import the security
certificate from jmeter folder here we
shall select these two boxes so that the
proxy server can access the website that
we shall enter here in the browser and
then select OK coming back to the gym
meter window let us add some listeners
to get the results listeners are
something that are used to provide the
outputs of a test there are different
types of listeners present in jmeter and
many may be added using plugins for
adding listeners right click on HTTP
test script recorder for adding
listeners right click on the HTTP test
script recorder then go to add option
and then go to listeners option and then
add view results tree now let us add one
more listener in the same way we shall
add view results entry now in the HTTP
test script recorder in the Target
controller option save the target
controller here in the drop down select
the simply learn home page option as we
will begin the script recording for the
home page finally let's start the test
by clicking here click on ok now go back
to the Mozilla browser and here let us
open the simply learns home page now
come back to the jmeter window go to the
homepage recording controller you can
see the home page controller has started
as you can see the home page controller
has started recording the scripts that
are being performed these are the tasks
that are performed on the client side to
the server side now we can check both
the listeners that we have put to see
what all functions are working fine and
what all are not all the tasks from the
time that we have entered to
simplylearn.com in our browser are
recorded in this homepage controller to
take the test further go to the test
script recorder and stop the test now
here in the Target controller select the
second controller that is the resources
controller now start the test again
select ok go to Simply learns website
select resources after opening the
resources link go back to the jmeter
window and now in the resources
controller you can see what all you
events are recorded from the client side
to the server side once we click on the
resources link now again in the tool
listeners you can check all the scripts
and tests are successful or have failed
now for our last recording controller go
back to the test tip recorder and stop
the test now here in the Target
controller select the third option that
is the digital marketing now here in the
Target controller select the third
option that is digital marketing start
the test and select ok now get back to
the Mozilla Firefox window go to
resources go to digital marketing after
digital marketing link has opened go
back to the jmeter window and now in the
digital marketing controller you can see
what all events are recorded from the
client side to the server side once we
click on that link I guess this is
taking a while you can see all steps
coming under the recording controller
and then you can also see the tool
listeners some of the tests are being
successful and some are not we can sum
this entire process as a way of
communicating between the server and the
client with a proxy server help in this
case the proxy server is rjmeter that is
why it was able to record all the steps
that are happening while we were
performing any task this is how we can
perform the jmeter script testing in few
simple steps now when you are done with
the proxy server do not forget to go
back to your browser and change your
network settings back to normal that is
go to the settings select use system
proxy settings and that's how it is done
in this complete course we will learn
everything that we need to know to excel
in Jenkins devops we have Matthews
chidanad and Anuj to guide us through
this journey we shall begin with having
a basic understanding of devops with a
short animated video after that we shall
dive deeper and understand what devops
is and its relevance in the present
scenario in this process we should also
learn about the CI CD Pipeline and how
it is important in the process of
automation
finally we shall learn what Jenkins is
its relevance and how we can install it
in this process we will also see several
Hands-On demos helping us understand the
entire process more effectively after we
have a fair amount of knowledge
regarding Jenkins we will look at some
of the Jenkins interview questions that
will increase your chances to crack any
Jenkins interview
so before we begin make sure that you
have subscribed to our YouTube channel
and don't forget to click on the Bell
icon so you never miss an update from
Simply learn now without any further Ado
let's begin with our animated
introduction
meet Tim Tim builds a robot in his lab a
climate controlled and pollution-free
environment
once he's done he drops the robot off at
his project partner Mia's house Mia
takes it out to her backyard to ensure
that the robot meets the requirements
but here is where the problem arises the
change in the environment causes the
robot to malfunction Mia is now really
annoyed and she has a lot to correct and
it seems to her as though Tim didn't
really do much this wall between them
leaves a poor robot to bite the dust
well what if we broke this wall Tim and
Miana work together in a common space
Tim develops each block of functionality
of the robot which is then immediately
checked by Mia both are now working
simultaneously instead of waiting on the
other to finish their task as a man a
feature is ready for use they are put
together to build the final product they
develop a common mindset and share ideas
to further speed up the process they use
several tools which can automate every
stage this means that the robot is now
ready sooner with less iterations and
manual work from an organization
perspective Tim would be the developer
while Mia the operations their Union is
the core of the devops approach devops
has several stages and set of tools to
automate each of these stages let's have
a look at these Tim first puts down a
plan in terms of software this could
mean deciding on the module fuels and
the algorithms to use once he has the
plan he now codes the plan with tools
such as git Tim has a repository for
storing all the codes and their
different versions this is called
Version Control next the score is
fetched and made executable this is the
build stage tools such as Gradle and
Maven will sort this out now before
deployment the product is tested to
catch any bugs the most popular tool
automating testing is selenium once the
products are tested Mia must deploy it
the deployed product is then
continuously configured to the desired
State ansible puppet and Docker are some
of the most common tools used that
automate these stages
now every product is continuously
monitored in its working environment
nagios is one such tool that automates
this space and the feedback is fed back
to the planning stage and finally we
have the core of the devops life cycle
the integration stage tools such as
Jenkins is responsible for sending the
code for build and test if the code
passes the tests it's further sent for
deployment this is called continuous
integration Giants such as Amazon
Netflix Target
Etsy and Walmart have all adopted devops
and seen a considerable increase in
delivery and quality in 2014 an hour of
downtime for Netflix would cost two
hundred thousand dollars it became
absolutely crucial that Netflix prepared
themselves for any sort of failure and
so they took to the devops approach and
implemented it in the most unique way
they developed a tool called Simeon Army
this tool created failures and
automatically deployed them in an
environment that did not affect the
users the team would troubleshoot these
failures and this gave them enough
experience to deal with any degree of
collapse
with everything being automated and
happening simultaneously organizations
can now deliver at a much faster pace so
considering the benefits of devops and
its Divergence from the traditional
methods would devops be the future hello
this is Matthew with simply learn and
today we're going to go through and
introduce you to devops we're going to
go through a number of key elements
today the first two will be reviewing
models that you're already probably
using for delivering Solutions into your
company and the most popular one is
waterfall followed by agile then we'll
look at devops and how devops differs
from the two models and how it also
borrows and leverages the best of those
models we'll go through each of the
phases that are used in typical devops
delivery and then the tools used within
those phases to really improve the
efficiencies within devops finally we'll
summarize the advantages that devops
brings to you and your teams so let's go
through waterfall so waterfall is a
traditional delivery model that's been
used for many decades for delivering
Solutions not just IT solutions and
digital Solutions but either way before
that it has its history it goes back to
World War II so waterfall is a model
that is used to capture requirements and
then Cascade each key deliverable
through a series of different stage
Gates that is used for building out the
solution so let's take you through each
of those stage Gates the first that you
may have done is requirements analysis
and this is where you sit down with the
actual client and you understand
specifically what they actually do and
what they're looking for in the software
that you're going to build and then from
that requirements analysis you'll build
out a project planning so you have an
understanding of what the level of work
is needed to be able to be successful in
delivering the solution after that you
you got your plan then you start doing
the development and that means that the
programmers start coding out their
solution they build out their
applications to build out the websites
and this can take weeks or even months
to actually do all the work when you've
done your coding and development then
you send it to another group that does
testing and they'll do full regression
testing of your application against the
systems and databases that integrate
with your application you'll test it
against the actual code you'll do manual
testing you do UI testing and then after
you've delivered the solution you go
into maintenance mode which is just kind
of making sure that the application
keeps working there's any security risks
that you address those security risks
now the problem you have though is that
there are some challenges however that
you have with the waterfall model the
cascading deliveries and those complete
and separated stage Gates means that
it's very difficult for any new
requirements from the client to be
integrated into the project so if a
client comes back and it's the project
has been running for six months and
they've gone hey we need to change
something that means that we have to
almost restart the whole project it's
very expansive and it's very time
consuming also if you spend weeks and
months away from your clients and you
deliver a solution that they are only
just going to see after you spend a lot
of time working on it they could be
pointing out things that are in the
actual final application that they don't
want or are not implemented correctly or
lead to just general unhappiness the
challenge you then have is if you want
to add back in the client's feedback to
restart the whole waterfall cycle again
so the client will come back to you with
a list of changes and then you go back
and you have to start your programming
and you have to then start your testing
process again and just you're really
adding in lots of additional time into
the project so using waterfall model
companies have soon come to realize that
you know the clients just aren't able to
get their feedback in quickly
effectively it's very expensive to make
changes once the teams have started
working and the requirement in today's
digital world is that Solutions simply
must be delivered faster and this has
led for a specific change in agile and
we start implementing the agile model so
the agile model allows programmers to
create prototypes and get those
prototypes to the client with the
requirements faster and the client is
able to then send their requirements
back to the programmer with feedback
this allows us to create what we call a
feedback loop where we're able to get
information to the client and the client
can get back to the development team
much faster typically when we're
actually going through this process
we're looking at the engagement cycle
being about two weeks and so it's much
faster than the traditional waterfall
approach and so we can look at each
feedback loop as comprising of 4K key
elements we have the planning where we
actually sit down with the client and
understand what they're looking for we
then have coding and testing that is
building out the code and the solution
that is needed for the client and then
we review with the clients the changes
that have happened but we do all this in
a much tighter cycle that we call a
Sprint and that typically a Sprint will
last for about two weeks some companies
run sprints every week some run every
four weeks it's up to you as a team to
decide how long you want to actually run
a Sprint but typically it's two weeks
and so every two weeks the client is
able to provide feedback into that Loop
and so you were able to move quickly
through iterations and so if we get to
the end of Sprint 2 and the client says
hey you know what we need to make a
change you can make those changes
quickly and effectively for Sprint three
what we have here is a breakdown of the
ceremonies and the approach that you
bring to Agile so typically what will
happen is that a product leader will
build out a backlog of products and what
we call a product backlog and this will
be just a whole bunch of different
features and they may be small features
or bug fixes all the way up to large
features that may actually span over
multiple Sprints but when you go through
the Sprint planning you want to actually
break out the work that you're doing so
the team has a mixture of small medium
and large solutions that they can
actually Implement successfully into
their Sprint plan and then once you
actually start running your Sprint again
it's a two-week activity you meet every
single day the two with the actual
Sprint team to ensure that everybody is
staying on track and if there's any
blockers that those blockers are being
addressed effectively and immediately
the goal at the end of the two weeks is
to have a deliverable product that you
can put in front of the customer and the
customer can then do a review the key
advantages you have are running a Sprint
with agile is that the client
requirements are better on understood
because the client is really integrated
into the scrum team they're there all
the time and the product is delivered
much faster than with a traditional
waterfall model you're delivering
features at the end of each Sprint
versus waiting weeks months or in some
cases years for a waterfall project to
be completed however there are also some
distinct disadvantages the product
itself really doesn't get tested in a
production environment it's only been
tested on the developer computers and
it's really hard when you're actually
running agile for the Sprint team to
actually build out a solution easily and
effectively on their computers to mimic
the production environment and the
developers and the operations team are
running in separate silos so you have
your development team running their
Sprint and actually working to build out
the features but then when they're done
at the end of their Sprint and they want
to do a release they kind of fling it
over the wall at the operations team and
then it's the operations team job to
actually install the software and make
sure that the environment is running in
a stable fashion that is really
difficult to do when you have the two
teams really not working together so
here we have is a breakdown of that
process with the developers submitting
their work to the operations team for
employment and then the operations team
may submit their work to the production
service but what if there is an error
what if there was a setup configuration
error with the developers test
environment that doesn't match the
production environment there may be a
dependency that isn't there there may be
a link to an API that doesn't exist in
production and so you have these charges
that the operations team are constantly
faced with and their challenge is that
they don't know how the code works so
this is where devops really comes in and
let's dig into how devops which is
developers and operators working
together is the key for successful
continuous delivery so devops is as an
evolution of the agile model the agile
model really is great for Gathering
requirements and for developing and
testing out your Solutions and what we
want to be able to do is kind of address
that challenge and that gap between the
Ops Team and the dev team and so so with
devops what we're doing is bringing
together the operations team and the
development team into a single team and
they are able to then work more
seamlessly together because they are
integrated to be able to build out
solutions that are being tested in a
production-like environment so that when
we actually deploy we know that the code
itself will work the operations team is
then able to focus on what they're
really good at which is analyzing the
production environment and being able to
provide feedback to the developers on
what is being successful so we're able
to make adjustments in our code that is
based on data so let's step through the
different phases of a devops team so
typically you'll see that the devops
team will actually have eight phases now
this is somewhat similar to Agile and
what I'd like to point out at the time
is that again agile and devops are very
closely related that agile and devops
are closely related delivery models that
you can use with devops it's really just
extending that model with the key phases
that we have here so let's step through
each of these key phases so the first
phase is planning and this is where we
actually sit down with a business team
and we go through and understand what
their goals are the second stage is as
you can imagine and this is where it's
all very similar to Agile is that the
code is actually start coding but they
typically they'll start using tools such
as git which is a distributed Version
Control software it makes it easier for
developers to all be working on the same
code base rather than bits of the code
that is rather than them working on bits
of the code that they are responsible
for so the goal with using tools such as
git is that each developer always has
the current and latest version of the
code you then use tools such as Maven
and Gradle as a way to consistently
build out your environment and then we
also use tools to actually automate our
testing now what's interesting is when
we use tools like selenium and junit is
that we're moving into a world where our
testing is scripted the same as our
build environment and the same as using
our get environment we can start
scripting out these environments and so
we actually have scripted production
environments that we're moving towards
Jenkins is the integration phase that we
use for our tools and another Point here
is that the tools that we're listing
here these are all open source tools
these are tools that any team can start
using we want to have tools that control
and manage the deployment of code into
the production environments and then
finally tools such as ansible and Chef
will actually operate and manage those
production environments so that when
code comes to them that that code is
compliant with the production
environment so that when the code is
then deployed to the many different
production servers that the expected
results of those servers which is you
want them to continue running is
received and then finally you monitor
the entire environment so you can
actually zero in on spikes and issues
that are relevant to either the code or
changing consumer habits on the site so
let's step through some of those tools
that we have in the devops environment
so here we have is a breakdown of the
devops tools that we have and again one
of the things I want to point out is
that these tools are open source tools
there are also many other tools this is
just really a selection of some of the
more popular tools that are being used
but it's quite likely that you're
already using some of these tools today
you may already be using Jenkins you may
already be using git but some of the
other tools really help you create a
fully scriptable environment so that you
can actually start scripting out your
entire devops tool set this really helps
when it comes to speeding up your
delivery because the more you can
actually script out of the work that
you're doing doing the more effective
you can be at running automation against
those scripts and the more effective you
can be at having a consistent experience
so let's step through this devops
process so we go through and we have our
continuous delivery which is our plan
code build and test environment so what
happens if you want to make a release
well the first thing you want to do is
send out your files to the build
environment and you want to be able to
test the code that you've been created
because we're scripting everything in
our code from the actual unit testing
being done to the all the way through to
the production environment because we're
testing all of that we can very quickly
identify whether or not there are any
defects within the code if there are
defects we can send that code right back
to the developer with a message saying
what the defect is and the developer can
then fix that with information that is
real on the either the code or the
production environment environment if
however your code passes the the
scripting tests it can then be deployed
and once it's out to deployment you can
then start monitoring that environment
what this provides you is the
opportunity to speed up your delivery so
you go from the waterfall model which is
weeks months or even years between
releases to Agile which is two weeks or
four weeks depending on your Sprint
Cadence to where you are today with
devops where you can actually be doing
multiple releases every single day so
there are some significant advantages
and there are companies out there that
are really zeroing in on those
advantages if we take any one of these
companies such as Google Google any
given day will actually process 50 to
100 new releases on their website
through their devops teams in fact they
have some great videos on YouTube that
you can find out on how their devops
teams work Netflix is also a similar
environment now what's interesting with
Netflix is that Netflix have really
fully embraced devops within their
development team and so they have a
devops team and Netflix is a completely
digital company so they have software on
phones on Smart TVs on computers and on
websites interestingly though the devops
team for Netflix is only 70 people and
when you consider that a third of all
internet traffic on any given day is
from Netflix it's really a reflection on
how effective devops can be when you can
actually manage that entire business
with just 70 people so there are some
key advantages that devops has it's the
actual time to create and deliver a
software is dramatically reduced
particularly compared to Waterfall
complexity of maintenance is also
reduced because you're automating and
scripting out your entire environment
now you're improving the communication
between all your teams so teams don't
feel like they're in separate silos but
that are actually working cohesively
together and that there is continuous
integration and continuous delivery so
that your consumer your customer is
constantly being delighted welcome
everyone to this topic on continuous
integration delivery and deployment so
this topic by simply learn is going to
explain you that what exactly is all
about the continuous integration process
continuous deployment and continuous
delivery so let's talk about these
Concepts one by one so continuous
integration is in kind of a process
which is which comes up in the first
part right so first The Continuous
Integrations comes into the picture then
the continuous delivery and the
deployment comes into the part so the
main important component are the main
tasks which we primarily perform in the
continuous integration is all about the
build automations test executions and
merging in various branches so it's
nothing but the integration of the
source code from the each and individual
developers machines to a shared location
which we often call it as any kind of a
version control system so continuous
integration is integrating the source
code into the shared repositories and
then depending on the order triggers
once the changes are checked into the
Version Control System the automated
build test cases all these executions
can really happen now in the build
process and the test cases automation
it's going to validate that how the
source code is really working uh how the
compilation is going on how the test
cases are getting executed so all these
things are getting validated during the
execution of these things now once the
continuous integration is successful we
can not assure give a hundred percent
surety that the code base is working
fine because it's just taking care of
the compilation and the test cases there
could be a possibility that some kind of
Errors may also come up into the
production in environment because those
test cases or those scenarios are not
being covered in the test cases so test
cases are very important aspect over
here because it's giving us the
authority whether we need to proceed
further or we need to Halt there itself
so after the continuous integration the
next process which comes into the
picture is the automatic release to the
repository over here right so it's just
a kind of a mechanism where we will be
releasing the source code to the
artifacts we are uploading the artifacts
to the particular component so that kind
of automation is available but that is
also happen when we are saying that yes
the test cases execution is successful
and we have to proceed further and at
the end it's nothing but the automated
deployment to the production environment
which we call it as a kind of continuous
deployment over here so these are the
overall process which we are looking
forward so that we will be able to have
an end-to-end automations going on over
here with the help of cicd automations
now continuous applications again the
build test merge these are the different
options which we do
so continuous integration is a kind of a
process a kind of a development process
which is being used by most of the
development teams nowadays that
eventually enables the developers to
merge their source code uh whatever the
changes or whatever the modifications
they are doing they can particular uh
you know like merge their source code
from their local systems to the
centralized repository so that after
that with the help of CI tools we can
actually have the build automations and
the test cases automation there so this
is the reason why we prefer the
continuous integration process because
it depends on the basis of our
modifications that how the whole build
and test cases automations can really
happen here now continuous integration
is considered as a very important
process because of the various reasons
let's talk about those reasons one by
one the very first one is that it avoids
the merge conflicts because if we
frequently sync back our source code
from our systems to the shared
repository and the same thing can be
done by other Developers was also So
eventually it definitely helps the
different developers to collaborate
their source code into a single shared
repository and that can really help you
to avoid the merge conflict situations
because you are always going to work on
the latest source code so the scope of
merge conflicts is not going to be there
it also helps us to decrease the need of
the code review because we are just
doing the collaboration frequently so we
don't require any person to be sitting
there and you know have to perform a
kind of a heavy duty code review because
uh that is something which you can
easily manage and we can work with that
so code review is something which we can
easily decrease with the help of this
continuous integration process
uh it also speeds up the development
process yes definitely because uh the
developers can easily collaborate with
each other so from collaboration
perspective also it's beneficial for us
to do and that can really help us to see
that how easily we can integrate our
source code and that differs or that
basically helps us to go for the overall
mechanism and you know going for a
profit automation process over here so
it also increases the overall
development process which needs to be
implemented during the CI process
next it also reduce the product backlog
because we are doing our changes
frequently into the repositories so uh
any kind of product backlog which is
there which is spending from long that
is also can be managed easily because
it's keep on you know reduced there so
we keep on implementing our changes we
keep on implementing uh merging our
particular changes to the shared
repository so that reduces the amount of
backlog which is available
now next thing is the continuous
delivery which is an automatic release
to the repositories here so what exactly
is in continuous delivery all about
so continuous delivery is a kind of a
practice that refers to the particular
building testing delivering improvements
to the software code so the important
part of continuous delivery is that the
code is always in the Deployable state
so we are saying that we are done with
the delivery we are ready with the
delivery and whichever environment
whichever particular server you want us
to deploy we are ready to do that so
that is where we call it is in
continuous delivery so we have our
artifacts ready and whenever is desired
whenever we feel that we want to do the
deployments we want to proceed further
we will be able to do that with the help
of this process so it's in kind of an
end-to-end process you do the builds you
do the test cases executions once the
test case execution is done once the
testing is done then you create in
artifacts you create a particular War
files jar files ER files whatever the
artifacts we have we prepare that
artifacts and then we deliver it to a
specific environment we say that yes
let's go with the delivery let's make it
into a particular state where we will be
able to deploy to pretty much any
environment which we feel as such over
here so that's a real Beauty about the
continuous delivery where we can
actually deliver it to whatever
environment we feel we want to deliver
now continuous delivery is uh also
something which is a very important
concept for most of the organizations so
uh each and every organizations are
actually looking forward to invest in
this one for a variety of regions
because uh it's something where we can
invest some of our particular efforts
budget money a lot of things are there
but the kind of benefits which we get in
the return that's what we are going to
talk about over here as such so let's go
with that so it provides the higher
quality of products yes the efforts are
there yes the investment is also there
but in the return the prime the very
important concept or very important
thing which we get is the high quality
of products here so the kind of quality
which we are getting with this one is
quite high and that's the biggest
benefit which we get when we talk about
any kind of continuous integration
continuous delivery or continuous
deployment here so the quality is always
Top Notch when we work of these
particular processes
it also helps us to go for a quicker and
less risky releases so that's another
benefit which we get this process
are also satisfied because they feel
that yes we are going with this uh
particular automated process
um within you know few days we are
getting the deliveries uh we don't have
to wait for months for getting our
delivery so that's the biggest benefit
which a customer usually gets when he
talks about the continuous delivery
and it's more efficiency is there and
the cost of Fitness of the team also so
from the cost and from the uh particular
efficiency all those parameters are
fully fulfilled when we talk about the
continuous delivery so this process
delivers a lot of benefits which can
eventually help us to go for a perfect
high quality product which we can
develop as such over here
now the next thing is the continuous
deployment which is an automatic
deployment to the production environment
so let's see that what exactly is in
continuous deployment all about here so
continuous deployment refers to the
final stage in the pipeline so which
means that the we are not only preparing
our artifacts we are not only doing the
uh particular compilations or test case
executions we are actually going one
step ahead and this one step ahead is
nothing but the deployment to the
production environment so this is what
we are typically doing when we talk
about the continuous deployment over
here that we are going to one step ahead
and that's where we are going for the
deployment of our particular artifact so
we are deploying to the production
environment so that our changes whatever
the changes we are trying to do we are
trying to make that should be deployed
to the production environment
right now
so continuous deployment again is can be
deployed to a higher whatever the
organizations want to feel or want to
deploy they can actually go with that
and there are a lot of benefits actually
which we get when we talk about the
continuous deployment so let's see about
all these particular deployments one by
one so first of all the faster
development of the products is there so
we are looking forward that when we are
going for the automations when we are
going for this deployment so if we get a
kind of a faster uh you know development
process which is there so the products
are getting developed very quickly very
fast that's the biggest benefit which
you are getting when we talk about this
continuous deployment here
and it's less risky releases also there
and it's easy to fix problems whatever
the automations we are feeling we are
trying to perform that can definitely
help us to go that how we can automate
and how we can go for this uh particular
releases over here so these releases are
very less risky because we are doing all
the things automated there is not much
of a scope which is there for the manual
errors so usually manual arrows is
something which is the biggest uh
problem or which is the biggest risk
when we go for any release but that is
something which is totally removed with
this automation here
now it also helps in continuous
Improvement in the quality so
continuously improve quality is also
getting improved as such here now let's
talk about that why exactly as when we
talk about at the industry level in the
market level also that the cicd is one
of the best practices now what is the
reason behind that why those are known
as the best development and devops
practices as such
now continuous integration and
continuous delivery are the best
practices as they create an effective
process the kind of integration and
delivering the source code these are the
prime things which we need to take care
when we talk about the development uh
teams over here so they want an
automated process first of all and they
also want to streamline process which
can you know take up the things which
should not fail it should be a Fail-Safe
process mechanism through which they can
release various kind of changes to the
production environment because
ultimately they are looking forward for
the deployment of the changes to the
production environment so how they are
going to do that that is where the CI CD
or the continuous integration and
continuous delivery helps on that part
and that's the reason why they can help
the teams the development teams to go
for an effective
process implementations when we go for
these implementations of these two
practices
small code changes can be easily made in
the software course so you don't require
much of the efforts if you are going for
even small changes in the source code
that can also be effectively deployed to
a production environment in a simple
straightforward and easy mechanism the
changes can go from the developer
machines to the production environment
that's the biggest benefit which we get
due to which we feel that yes these two
processes should be implemented into a
devops platform
right so CI and CD provides continuous
feedback from the customers and also
from the development teams the devops
teams so the increase of transparency is
also something which is important which
is implemented with these processes here
so the process enables faster release of
the product so we don't have to wait for
months to release the source code there
within a couple of hours within couple
of days we can actually release it to
the production environment provided we
do all these steps like build
compilations testing development uh
validation all these things will be done
in that duration of time so the failures
can be easily detected faster and we can
easily find out that what is the problem
with the code base what is the problem
the changes and we can even do the hot
fixes now hot fix is these kind of ad
hoc changes are also can be easily
deployed to the production environment
within just couple of hours there so
that was a complete summary on what
exactly is the ICD and the prime
important concept which we have got a
proper understanding is that why these
two processes are really important for
our development process and the only
benefit which we are getting the prime
benefit which we are getting from these
processes implementation is that we get
a effective build process effective test
cases automation or process and
automated deployment process and these
processes when we combine that is
something which we can use to deliver
our source code our features to the
production environment and eventually to
the end user so that's how the CI CD
automations really works into a devops
environment hey guys welcome to Jenkins
pipeline tutorial by simply learn my
name is chitanan and let me quickly walk
you through the topics that I plan to
cover as a part of this tutorial at a
very high level I'll be introducing you
Jenkins and then get into more details
of the continuous integration process as
most of few are aware most of the
softwares in recent times are developed
using some or the other kind of agile
practices and continuous integration is
an important or key factor in all such
agile software development life cycle
next I'll be looking at the software
delivery pipeline from a perspective of
if someone were to visualize all the
steps that is required from the time
someone gives out a requirement a
software requirement it gets translated
into some sort of a code and gets tested
may be moved into one of the testing
platforms and then migrated across or
moved across or propagated across
various environments and then finally
put out in production if one were to put
a value stream mapping for all these
steps that is involved each of these
steps could translate into a simple job
within Jenkins I will first look at what
existed in Jenkins or rather pre-jenkins
2.0 where we had a way of Upstream
Downstream mapping of jobs there was
some plugins that allowed us to
visualize all the jobs at one shot
starting from the first job that
triggered and then I will get into the
most powerful groovy scripting that are
there in Jenkins 2.0 or post Jenkins 2.0
these groovy scripting uses much more
powerful ways of defining our pipelines
there are two different ways in which
you can write your scripts one is a
scripted one the other one is
declarative one there's very subtle
change or difference between each one of
them but these gives you a much more
flexible and much more powerful feature
to write complicated pipelines for your
software delivery having said that most
of these topics that I'm going to
discuss will be followed up with a demo
and the source code for most of these
would be on our GitHub repository all
right now as a prerequisite probably it
may be a good idea in case if you
haven't already watched please watch our
previous video wherein I mentioned how
to install Jenkins and how to put up
some sample jobs on not drinking server
so what exactly is Jenkins Jenkins is
nothing but a powerful automation server
that is written in Java and it is a web
application which can also be run on any
web server but what makes Jenkins an
ideal choice for a continuous
integration server Jenkins has got
wonderful plugins that allows it to
connect to all kinds of tools software
development deployment coding build
source code kind of a tools that is what
makes Jenkins very very powerful from a
continuous integration perspective
Jenkins can connect to various source
code servers and it has also got plugins
that allows it to build deploy test all
kinds of software artifacts so this is
what makes Jenkins an ideal choice for a
continuous integration server but mind
you for me Jenkins is nothing but a very
very powerful automated server at the
heart of it there's a lot of Automation
in it but the powerful us of Jenkins is
more so because of the tools that it
integrates with and the kind of plugins
that it has got what is continuous
integration from a software development
life cycle assuming that the software
delivery is happening in very small
Sprints maybe three to four weeks is
your delivery life cycle and there are a
bunch of developers who are located in
different locations who are working on
the same code base on the same Branch if
the code check-ins do not happen quickly
as in every day if at all developers
stagger their code check-ins into the
repository finding problems at a later
stage would be very costly for the whole
project early detection of any such
issues would be you know quick to
resolve and would not affect your
delivery schedules so as a part of
continuous integration what is requested
or what is demanded is that every
developer checks in code pretty much you
know every day as long as it doesn't
break the code he checks in code pretty
much regularly and at the end of a day a
you have an automated server which kind
of wakes up pulls the latest code so
this code has got the Integrations of
all the code bases that has been checked
in by various developers so it pulls out
the code it builds on a completely
different server that is the CI server
which pulls this code it builds it it's
got all the tools that is required to
compile it build it and test it and
assuming that you've got some good
percentage of test case automation
you're also having a most of your
regression test Suites automated if at
all there is a way by which in a couple
of hours time when the team is out or
rather team slipping you have
verification that happens at a very
crucial level and then any breakages
even before the team arrives for the
next day if these are notified to the
whole team members saying an email going
out saying that something got broken
most of the code would be pretty okay
from the perspective of compilation
errors or a build errors it is the
functionality and the regression that
the team is worried about so if these
can be automated test it very very
quickly and very very fast and then any
breakages are detected early during the
day right by the time the next day
people come in they know what is broken
and possibly they know what code uh
check-in broke that particular thing and
they can have a quick stand-up meeting
and then they discuss what broke the
code and able to fix it so this way any
problem that could possibly Arise at a
later point in time if at all they kind
of move to the initial phase of the
project any detection that is early
doesn't really hurt the team so this is
all continuous integration that is about
and Jenkins plays an important role in
being the continuous integration server
because it's got connections to anything
and everything all kinds of tools I mean
and then it is also got various ways on
which triggering the job which is a part
of its automation strategy now that we
know what is continuous integration and
where does Jenkins coming to picture
let's look at the rest of the tasks of
our software development life cycle so
if at all I were to visualize the kind
of steps that is involved in delivering
my software possibly The Continuous
integration phase would be somewhere
here where multiple developers are
developing on that and then we have a
little bit of a stable code that is
there that can be kind of moved across
because I want to go ahead with the
particular build that I have and then I
want to migrate that I want to propagate
that across various environments so if
you consider the standard software
delivery approach in the first cycle you
just do some minimal testing and then
you kind of move that to one of the
environments and from there you kick off
more and more tests they could be
integration test they could be
acceptance tests they could be
functionality checked they could be a
stress test they could be a load test
there could be a system integration test
all kinds of tests that you can think
about and all the way may be propagating
the build across various environments if
all this can be considered as various
steps the workflow is such that as and
when the build moves across various
phases if there's any failure of course
us the build propagation kind of stops
everyone gets notified but if at all
everything goes well so your workflow is
progressing well and at the end of the
workflow you eventually have a code
which is pretty much good to release now
mind you I make an assumption here that
most of your test cases are automated
and you have a good percentage of
coverage of your test cases but if that
is not the scenario then possibly there
are some automated tests or checks that
may be required in between but if the
workflow can kind of accommodate all
that as well you know you can visualize
this as the steps that is required for
your software development or software
delivery life cycle now in Jenkins the
way this kind of translates is that each
of these tasks can be put out as a job
so now let me quickly let you know or
let me quickly demo what existed in
pre-age and kins 2.0 where I could put
up a couple of jobs and I can connect
them using the Upstream Downstream
linking mechanism so if this job one if
at all it is a billion in test cases if
at all that passes successfully job 2
gets triggered if the job 2 is more
about running some more automated tests
or possibly deploying it to environment
and then kicking off some more test
cases that would be job 2 but if the
deployment fails or if some of the other
test cases fail it would not propagate
to the third job all right so let me
quickly bring up my Jenkins instance and
put up some sample jobs and tell you how
to connect that or rather how would one
connect that using Jenkins 2.0 or pre
Jenkins 2.0 release I have now brought
up my Jenkins instance and in case some
of you don't know how to install Jenkins
or you don't know how to bring up your
Jenkins instance I would strongly
recommend that you watch our previous
videos on simple learn YouTube channel
where I've detailed out the steps that
is required for you to install Jenkins
and bring it up so alright so I've
brought up my Jenkins instance let me
put up few of those jobs now mind you
I'm gonna cover the pre-chenkins 2.0
feature here alright so let let me put
up my first job all right I hope I don't
have that job I say it's a freestyle
project
I don't want to change anything I'm
going to put up a very very simple job
here it's in batch command let's say
Echo first job triggered at all right
that's my first job
let me put up my second job
freestyle project
all right that's my second job
foreign
that's my third job I've got a very very
simple uh Echo statements in this so it
just prints out the system date and the
time in it
all right so I could run these jobs
individually if I want so and let me
just check running my third job so this
is what I get in the console output
third job triggered at date and time
oops
let me fix that
right
should fix it
let me check my second job
all right that's my second job all right
so I've got three jobs now if I were to
link them together or if at all I want a
scenario where after the first job is
successful you'll run I would like to
trigger my second job so I would do a
small configuration change in here I
would say after this first job is run I
want to trigger the second job so I have
something called as a post build action
so I can say that triggers some of the
jobs from here so if you see this
publish record deploy all right trigger
trigger trigger trigger let me check the
other one build other projects this is
what I would want to do so after the
first job is done I want to trigger my
second job all right I would say save
this now let me go back to my second job
and then trigger the third job after the
second job is done
all right I will add this post build
build other projects third job again I'm
not really sure if you guys notice this
there is various configurations as to
when exactly do you want to trigger the
other job and the default one is trigger
only if the build is stable so typically
this is the configuration that would
need we definitely don't want the third
job to be triggered in case the second
job fails all right so this is the
combination that I want or this is the
choice that I want and I save this now I
have three of my jobs if you see this
the second job the Upstream job is the
first job so let me check this kind of a
pipeline what I've said here is a very
very simple pipeline so after my first
job gets triggered if I build this guy
right the second job gets triggered
after the build first job is built so if
I click on the second job all right so
the first job was to get the second job
and after the second job it is
triggering the third job so this is how
first job second job and third job were
kind of linked but it's pretty hard to
visualize this as to you know if I need
to see one holistic picture where after
the first job after the second job after
the third job what was the flow it's not
possible for me to visualize that that's
wherein I install a plugin so let me go
to manage plugins right here I think I
already have it installed for those of
you who don't have it installed you can
go to the available button I mean
available Tab and click on that the
plugin is called delivery pipeline
plugin I already have it installed in
case you don't have it installed you
just go to the available you click on
this and say install without restart
this is the plugin that I want you to
install all right so now we have that
plugin installed so what I want to do is
after the plugin is installed you see
something like this so this is where I
would create a new visualization for the
pipeline that I've created so I would
say my first pipeline or I give a name
for my visualization I would say yes
this Upstream Downstream dependencies
this is exactly what I want and there
are a bunch of settings here I'll not
look at any of that now what I want is I
just want to tell this view that you
know the I can give a name for this I
would give it as simple line and what's
important is that I specify what is the
first job that should be picked up as a
part of this Pipeline and the final job
is optional because it knows that if the
first job is triggering this other job
it knows where to end this whole life
cycle so I Define a pipeline and you
give a name for my component and
initialize that as my I mean I give it
the first job so I say okay and there
you go this is much better this gives
you a beautiful visualization of as to
what happened after the first job second
job was run second job if you click on
any of these that will in fact take me
to the shop all right there is also one
other option which is pretty good option
in my opinion which is about edit view
yes this is where it is enable start of
a new pipeline build let me apply and
let me click OK on this what it gives me
is a way in which I can trigger my whole
pipeline from here so if I click on this
there you see the first job getting
triggered the second job is still
running the green means it's all run
properly and nicely second one is
triggered now the third one it's still
running all right so this is the
pipeline that existed prior to Jenkins
2.0 this is pretty decent enough and if
you see there's a one-to-one mapping but
if at all you remember we could go and
add multiple dependencies for the
projects that I set in just to give an
example let's have a go to my first job
I can do a configuration here and
Nothing Stops me from triggering
multiple jobs after this by giving me
comma I can trigger multiple jobs here
in case if I have to run few things
parallely this also gives me that option
to do that but having said that this was
the most primitive way in which the jobs
were kind of visualized and run prior to
Jenkins 2.0 now this feature became such
an important feature the users wanted
more and more complicated because the
pipelines was not a lot complicated it
was not just one job after the other
there were multiple job that has to be
run and there is also an introduction of
the Jenkins agents where multiple tasks
could be parallel run on different
agents so they wanted to Club all of the
that and the pipeline could have all the
such complicated stuff that's where in
post Jenkins 2.0 or in Jenkins 2.0
Jenkins released a version which has got
the feature of pipeline which can be
written in groovy scripts now groovy is
wonderful scripting language it's very
very powerful anybody can visualize your
pipeline or write your pipeline using
programming language and the point of
everything is code where this whole
group script gets into your source code
repository so instead of putting jobs
here and in case my Jenkins kind of
fails you know there's a crash on my
Jenkins I don't get back these jobs how
do I bring back all these jobs back so
everything is good that's the devops
principle so the pipelines will be
written as scripts that is what I'm
going to do in my next exercise in my
previous example I showed you the crude
way in my opinion of putting up a
Jenkins pipeline but this is what
existed prior to Jenkins 2.0 and now I
have post Jenkins 2.0 in terms of my
voice
is 2.107 so this supports something
called as a scripted pipeline wherein
you can write your pipeline in terms of
groovy scripts no need to put up any
jobs here and remember how exactly you
put up these individual jobs you can
write a pipeline script in terms of
groovy language Let me quickly show you
a very very simple and Elementary
pipeline that I have this is what a
groovy script would look like pipeline
any agent can run this stages there are
individual stages that is defined as a
subset of these stages so the first
stage is the compile stage and Stage has
got some steps in it you can have
multiple steps in it and once only after
all these steps successfully complete
that's wherein the stage gets through
perfectly with the pass so there's a
compile a stage there's a junit stage
there's a quality gate stage there's a
deploy stage and I'm really not doing
anything much within this other than
echoing you know some text within each
of these stages and what's interesting
is at the end there's something called
as a post which is similar to or you can
kind of equate that to what would be
there in a try catch kind of a block so
post always meaning This would run all
the time success only if at all all the
steps that were above in terms of the
stages they were completed successfully
without any failures so typically you
would have your email that is going out
here saying that the build is successful
and stuff like that failure if something
went bad if any of the steps resulted in
a failure this particular block will get
executed unstable whenever any build is
marked unstable if at all only few
things that fail within your test run
and you would want to Mark the build as
unstable or changed this is an
interesting option so this compares the
present run with the previous run and if
there's any change meaning if the
previous run was a failure and the
present run is a success or vice versa
this would get triggered so this is what
a simple pipeline script would look like
so let me copy this Pipeline and let me
put up a simple job for running this
pipeline so let me open up my Jenkins
say a new iOS say scripted pipeline yeah
this is what I want I don't want to
choose a freestyle project this is going
to be a pipeline project so I would say
pipeline and say okay all right this has
got far less options than the other jobs
that we put up so General I don't want
anything here I don't want any build
trigger right so this is where I kind of
I can paste in whatever ad copied
there's also something called as a
pipeline syntax or a syntax generator
this is like a lookup where you can
choose what you want to do and choose
the option that is specific to those
steps and you will get a pipeline
generated or a script generated for you
Jenkins knows that you're not very good
at understanding these pipelines so this
gives you this sandbox kind of an
environment where you can check out
whatever you want to do as a part of
your pipeline and then get the
equivalent groovy script from here let
me look at this in a bit later so for
now I have my pipeline syntax already
copied so what I'm going to do is I'm
going to paste what I copied alright so
this looks good okay I'm not connecting
to any GitHub repository of any of that
I'm just running a very very simple
pipeline which has got some steps in it
and it just compiles or rather it just
puts out some messages saying that this
stage completed successfully and stuff
like that so let me save this and let me
try to run this scripted pipeline all
right if you see this you'll see each of
those steps going through and if at all
I look at the console output compile
successfully unit passed all the stages
passed there was a pass the failures
doesn't show up you will see the
messages from our post or the try catch
block that I was mentioning earlier so
this is how one would put up a pipeline
and you also get to see the visualized
view of your pipeline that says which
stage run after which phase how much
time did it take and you can click on
any of these and get into looking at the
logs from that particular pipeline front
that was pretty easy wasn't it now let
me give you another scenario for a
pipeline wherein the source code of my
pipeline would be in a GitHub repository
and I will write scripts to grab this
particular code and run some part of the
code which is there as a part of the
repository so let me look at the
repository that I have I have a
repository out here on the simply learn
GitHub account which is called the
pipeline script and if you see in there
there are a bunch of batch files that
are there so the first batch file would
be a build.batch so there's nothing in
it except that it is just trying to
build a particular project you can
visualize this as individual batch files
which actually contain the scripts for
building running deploying and checking
the quality gate of your particular
project so I have a couple of batch
files that is here and this is on the
GitHub repository so I would need to
write Jenkins job so log into my GitHub
account and then check out this
particular repository from my account
and then run these batch files as a part
of those individual steps within within
the scripted pipeline so let me check as
to how I could do that
let me put up a new project for this let
me call this scripted pipeline
dead pipeline from GitHub all right so
let this be a pipeline project that's
that's good enough for me let me see my
scripts all right now this is where I
need to put in the scripts for pulling
out the code repository from my GitHub
server and running those batch files
that are there as a part of the
repository so what I want to do is I
already have the skeleton of my pipeline
that is written which is very similar to
whatever was the pipeline syntax that I
showed you in the previous step so I
just copy this out here and then paste
it here so what I have here is I've
written on the high level skeleton
without really putting in the actual
steps required for checking out rather
or rather running those build scripts so
I've got four steps one is the git
checkout step the bills tab you're gonna
test quality gate and possibly the
deployment all right so I need to put in
the actual scripts that is required for
first checking out the repository from
my GitHub server so this is where I will
make use of this pipeline syntax so as I
mentioned earlier you have a bunch of
help that is available for you to figure
about the actual scripts that is
required for you to write within your
pipeline so what I wanted to do is check
out something from git so it's git
related so search on git and you'll find
this option so I got to specify my git
repository URL and my credentials so let
me look at the repository URL this would
be my repository URL so let me copy this
I'm going to copy the https URL of my
repository and branch is good and one
thing that you got to notice is for now
the repository is anyway a public
repository on GitHub so even though if I
don't specify any credentials that would
work for me still but in case you have a
repository which needs strictly a
username and password to be specified
you can kind of add it out here using
add Jenkins and you can give your
username and password out here but for
now I don't need any of these things so
I'm going to just say git checkout or
rather the URL of my repository and what
we want is the master Branch for now I
have only one branch on my GitHub server
so this is good for me so this is what I
exactly I want to do as a part of the
script so if I click this this is the
script that I need to put in my build
script so I come over here and this is
what will check out the code from my
repository all right so now once I get
my code onto my repository from my
repository rather it will grab those
code all these patch files and get it
onto my Jenkins workspace now I'll have
to run these batch files as a part of
each of my step so let me look at what
would be the syntax so the first one
that I want to run would be my build.bat
all right so I want to run a batch file
all right and what is the name of the
batch file that I want to run I want to
run this build.pat so generate pipeline
script this is all that I want to
specify as a part of my build step and
then unit test I'm gonna just change
this to unit I think that's what I have
in my repository okay that is unit and
then deploy and quality Q Capital
quality and this one would be deploy
all right so this piece of code will
actually get into my repository and
check out my source code and grab it and
take it to the Jenkins workspace so from
this workspace since all the files are
there in the root directory of this
workspace it will run these batch files
one after the other all right let me
save this and let me try to run my
pipeline
all right so it runs a lot of things in
the background trying to get the source
code from my repository whoa whoa whoa
that was fast all right so I pulled out
all the source code from my repository
the last commit message from where the
source code was pulled out it was this
create
deploy.bat that looks good I'm saying
building checked out project building
the check dot project this is what I've
had in my build.pad if I'm not mistaken
okay building the project that's what is
there with the timestamp running unit
test cases unit dot pack it is running
unit dot bat and then giving me the date
and time stamp okay so all these kind of
pass and if I go back to the project I
will also see this beautiful view of how
exactly what is the time that was taken
for checking out the repository running
the build.bat running the unit test
cases quality Gates and all this isn't
that pretty simple now let me modify my
previous job or rather let me put up a
new job for making use of an agent
wherein I could delegate a job to an
agent typically agents can be brought up
on any other remote machines other than
where your primary region can server is
running in case you don't know or you
don't know how to start up this agents I
would strongly recommend that you refer
to our previous Jenkins video on the
simply learn YouTube channel alright so
let me just check the status of my agent
for now yes is offline so let me start
this agent because agent is not running
so I have the agent set up in my C colon
agents so let me copy the script file
that is required for starting my agent
let me go to the agents folder open up a
command prompt and let me try to bring
up my agent all right so the agent is up
and running for now I don't have the
luxury of starting my agent on a
different machine so my agent is running
on my machine but the agent's workspace
is SQL agent while my primary Jenkins
server is running has the workspace out
shares SQL and program files 86 and this
is the workspace of my Jenkins all right
I hope you can kind of differentiate
those two all right so now what I want
is I will look at the same job that I
put in earlier or rather modify that let
the steps be the same but I don't want
to run that on my master server let me
try to delegate that using the script so
let me put up an agent scripted job
all right it will be a pipeline wrap job
I would say okay
and let me copy this was a step that I
had put in for my previous job so agent
any so what I'm gonna do now is I don't
want this to be running on any other
agent I want this to be running on the
agent whose label is let me check what
is the label of my
agent that is running okay
so this is the name of my agent okay
Windows node so let me just copy that
there all right so with a very subtle
change instead of saying agent any I'm
going to run or rather I'm going to
specify the agent will be running this
job is the one who has got the label as
Windows node so this agent that I
brought on my system has got the name as
Windows node and it is configured to
pick up any job that matches the label
uh to which any job is kind of delegated
so let me come back to my jobs where is
my scripted agent job
I've got too many jobs running all right
so this is my agent scripted job that I
left halfway through so here in the
pipeline what I'm going to do is is this
is all I'm gonna need so the job Remains
the Same git checkout is going to check
out from the same repository I run the
batch files accordingly but this change
is just to ensure that this job is kind
of delegated on the agent
all right so this would be my agent job
let me save this
let me get back to the dashboard and let
me run it from here if you see this you
know the master and agent are both idle
as of now let me try to run this agent
scripted job all right so the agent kind
of kicked in and there was a job that
was delegated to the agent if I look at
what is there in the console outboard
he's pretty much doing whatever was
there as a part of the job but the
interesting thing to note is that this
is the new workspace or rather this is
delegated to the agent and the agent's
workspace is this particular folder so
this is where it's going to get all this
stuff uh run the whole thing and you
know the flow is pretty much the same
the only thing is this whole thing ran
on the agent if I need to check my agent
I would see the workspace out here agent
scripted job if you look at this all the
batch files are here and this is where
the job was kind of delegated to run so
with the very subtle change in in the
scripting I can ensure that the jobs are
kind of delegated onto the agent the
pipeline job specifically as I mentioned
earlier Jenkins provides you two
different ways of writing pipelines
called the scripted and the declarative
the first one that was launched was the
scripted pipeline this is heavily based
on groovy scripting since Jenkins ships
along with the groovy engine so this was
the first script or the first support
for pipeline that was provided by
Jenkins in 2.0 this needs a little bit
of a learning curve since a groovy is a
wonderful script understanding that may
be a little cumbersome but then once you
kind of Master it you can write really
powerful scripts based on groovy at a
very high level this is what a typical
scripted pipeline would look like
something called as a node node
represents the agent or the actual box
on which your job would be running and
then a bunch of stages are put out which
each of the stage along with the steps
that needs to be covered as the part of
those stages listed one below the other
so all these stages if they run
peacefully then the whole task is kind
of marked as run successfully since
understanding groovy or learning groovy
was a little tough for many of the
people so this is a new one from Jenkins
wherein it provides you a much simple
and friendly Syntax for writing
pipelines without really needing to
understand or without nearly reading to
learn some groovy scripting again
there's a very subtle change between
these and you there are a lot of lookups
for figuring out what is a better
pipeline for you to kind of write but if
you can figure out the difference or if
you can try to find that particular
piece of code which kind of helps you
out with your pipeline either of the
skips is not really any difference in
writing or kind of delivering your
pipeline using either of these two
methods all right so declario pipeline
is something like this where you have an
agent you can specify the agent label or
if you can say agent any it will pick up
whatever is an available agent and run
the job and then you have something
called stages stages is nothing but a
collection of stage and Stage could have
multiple steps defined by within this so
if any of the steps in any of the stage
fails then that particular complete
stage and the build is marked as failure
so very subtle difference between both
these two syntax but using either of
these you can write powerful scripts for
your pipeline now let me come up with an
example where I'm going to at least demo
one of the feature where you could run a
master and a slave job in parallel so
let me come up with a demo for that
particular scenario let me put up a new
job for my parallel agent pipeline let
me call this and this would be a
pipeline project
I don't want anything here let me look
at the pipeline script that I have a
pipeline agent none stages and there's a
first stage where this would be a kind
of non-parallel stage where there's a
need for you to possibly pull out the
source code from one of the repositories
and possibly unit test it if all the
unit test cases pass then possibly you
want to deploy it to one of the test
environments that would be what would be
there as a part of a non-parallel stage
and then you may have a bunch of tests
that could be run and assuming that you
know you have a Windows node you have a
Linux node you have some other kind of
an operating system based node you could
run these stages in parallel so for just
for demonstration I've just put in two
parallel stages in parallel is the
keyword that you're going to use for
running tests parallely so I would say
parallel stage test on Windows and I'm
going to run this in my windows node
well I could run a bunch of steps that I
want out here and then in the other
stage or other step what I want is I
will run something else on on my master
as long as this parallel keyword is
encountered Jenkins will ensure that
these two stages are run parallely for
now I have both these things running on
my same machine but assuming that these
were running on different boxes you
could kind of visualize it as these two
steps are going to be started
paralleling without really any
dependency on each other and then you
could wait for the test results and then
based upon whether both of these steps
passed or failed if one of them failed
then we could kind of Mark the build
accordingly so let me copy this pretty
pretty simple script let me put this out
here and now let me save this out and
let me try to build this
all right there you go the stage will be
executed first this is a non-paralleled
state that's going to happen then the
task one on agent task one one master
followed by as I said since I have only
one node or rather one system one with
both these things are running
simultaneously you're not really see a
benefit of this but assuming that you
have couple of boxes on which you have
multiple agents running you will
possibly want to run your selenium test
on the Windows box because selenium
brings up some of those UI which needs a
browser you could possibly need some
regression test that could run out Linux
boxes or Linux agents and then you can
kind of break down your tasks into
multiple things that is running on
multiple systems at the same time and
then collate all the results okay one
final thing all right now I have all my
particular job or rather the steps
required for my pipeline put down in in
terms of the scripts and this is saved
in this particular job that's not a good
or a recommended approach so what I'll
do is I'll copy all of these steps out
here here and then what needs to be done
is actually let's say let me go back to
this repository the most preferred
approach is where you create something
called as a Jenkins file Jenkins file
and paste all the scripts that is
required for your pipeline now this is
in a true sense the devops approach
where I'm going to save this out so if
at all you have a pipeline defined for
your project the best place to kind of
put out your configurations for the
pipeline is within your repository so
this may be a different project that I
was referring to but assuming that you
have your project where you know you
have to Define your pipeline instead of
putting that as a particular job on
Jenkins and fearing that if Jenkins
fails are the jobs there's a crash and
then you lose out your job configuration
the best approach is to use a Jenkins
file put all the steps that is required
the tried tested steps that is required
as a part of your Jenkins file and then
you can put out a job that can pull the
source code from here as well as use the
steps that is defined in a jetkins file
so let me end up by putting up another
job which is a true javops kind of a job
so I would say devops
Pipeline and this is a pipeline script
and then I'm not going to say any of
these things I would say the pipeline
script is from the source code
management so my pipeline script is
already defined it is present in sem so
what is my SVN I mean what is my source
code repository this is my source code
repository where I already have this so
let me copy this URL This is My URL I
don't need any credentials because the
preposition is anyway in public
repository that is all that is required
I would say and the scripted file it
automatically it picks up Jenkins file
all right so let me save this let me
build this
so that's the beauty of devops wherein I
have a pipeline that is defined and
instead of putting the pipeline as a job
because pipeline is nothing but a
configuration the configuration is also
checked into the source code repository
and any changes to this pipeline instead
of putting that modifications in the job
these are all captured as a part of my
repository so the changes are nicely
configured so that you know we know
who's done what change if getting your
learning started is half the battle what
if you could do that for free visit
skillup by simply learn click on the
link in the description to know more
devops today is being implemented by you
know most of the major organizations
whether it's a financial organization
whether it's a kind of a service
organization every organization is
somehow looking forward for the
implementation and the adaptation of
devops because it totally redefines and
automate the whole development process
all together and whatever the man and
efforts we were putting earlier that is
simply all gets automated with the help
of these tools here so this is something
which get really implemented because of
some of the important feature like a
cicd pipeline because cicd pipeline is
responsible for delivering your source
code into reproduction environment in
less duration of time so cicd pipeline
is ultimately the goal which really
helps us to deliver more into the
production environment when we talk
about from this perspective
now let's talk about that what exactly
is a cacd pipeline now when we go into
that part when we go into that
understanding so cicd pipeline is a
basically continuous integration and
continuous delivery concept which is
used or which is considered as an
backbone of the overall devops approach
now it's one of the Prime approach which
we Implement when we are going for a
devops implementation for our project so
if I have to go for a divorce
implementation the very first and the
minimum implementation and the
automation which I am looking forward is
actually from the uh particular cicd
pipelines here so cicd pipelines is
really a wonderful option when we talk
about the devops here
so what exactly is the pipeline term all
about so pipeline is in series of events
that are connected together with each
other it's kind of a sequence of the
various steps like you know typically
when we talk about any kind of
deployment so we have like you know
build process like we compile the source
code which under the artifacts we do the
testing and then we deploy to a specific
environment all these various steps
which we use to do it like manually that
is something which we can do it into a
pipeline so pipeline is nothing but a
sequence of all these steps
interconnected with each other executed
one by one into a particular sequence
now the pipelines is responsible for
performing a variety of tasks like
building up the source code running the
test cases probably the deployment can
also be added up in when we go for the
continuous integration and continuous
delivery there so all these steps are
being done into a sequence definitely
because sequence is very important when
we talk about the pipeline so you need
to talk about the sequence the same way
in which you are working on the
development and in a typical world the
same thing you will be putting up into a
specific pipeline so that's a very
important aspect to be considered now
let's talk about what is the continuous
integration here now continuous
integration is also you know known as
the CI pretty much you can see that a
lot of tools are actually named as CI
but they are referring to the continuous
integration only so continuous
integration is a practice that
integrates the source code into a shared
repository and it used to automate the
verification of the source code so it
involves a build automations test cases
automation so it also helps us to detect
the issues and the bugs quite easily and
quite faster that's a very early
mechanism which we can do as such if we
want to resolve all these problems now
continuous Integrations does not
eliminate the bugs but yes it definitely
helps them uh you know easily to find
out because we we are talking about
about the automated process we are
talking about the automated test cases
so definitely that is something which
can help us to find out the bugs and
then you know the development can help
on that and they can you know proceed
with those bugs and they can try to
resolve those things one by one so it's
not a kind of automated process which
will eventually remove the bugs bugs is
something which you have to recode and
you have to fix it by following the
development practice but yes it can
really help us to find those bugs quite
easy and help them to remove
now what is the continuous delivery here
so continuous delivery also known as CD
is in kind of a phase in which the
changes are made uh into the code before
the deployment now in this case what
happens that uh it's
um something which we are discussing or
we are validating that what exactly we
want to deliver it to the customer so
what exactly we are going ahead or we
are moving to the customer so that's
what we typically do in case of
continuous delivery and the ultimate
goal of the pipeline is to make the
deployments that's the end result
because coding is not the only thing you
code the programs you do the development
after that it's all about the
deployments like how you're going to
that to perform the deployment so that
is a really important aspect you want to
go ahead with the deployments that's
when you can go there and that's a real
Beauty about this because it it's in
kind of a way in which we can identify
that the how the deployments can be run
or can be executed as such here
right so the ultimate goal for the
pipeline is nothing but to do the
deployments and to proceed further on
that
right so when both these practices are
placed in together in an order so all
these steps could be referred as in
complete automated process and this
process is known as cicd so when we are
talking about like when we are working
on this automation so in that case what
happens that we are looking forward that
how the automation needs to be done and
since it's in kind of a cicd automation
which we are talking about so it's
nothing but the uh end result would be
like built-in deployment automation so
you will be taking care of both the bill
and the test case executions and the
deployments as such when we talk about
as such a cicd here
the implementation of CSD also enables
the team to do the build and deploys
quite quickly and efficiently because
these are things which is you know
happening automatically so there was no
manual efforts involved and there is no
scope of human error also so we have
frequently seen that while doing the
deployments we may miss some boundaries
or some Miss can be there so that is
something which is you know completely
removed as such when we talk about this
the process makes the teams more agile
productive and the uh confident here
because um the automations definitely
gives a kind of a boost to the
confidence that yes things are going to
work perfectly fine and there is no
issues as such present now why exactly
Jenkins like Jenkins is what we
typically understand or we you know uh
here and there that's in ci2 it's a CD
tool so what exactly is Jenkins all
about so Jenkins is also known as a kind
of orchestration tool it's an automated
tool which is there and the best part is
that it's completely open source yes
there are some particular uh paid or the
Enterprise tools are there like Cloud
bees and all but there is no as such of
offering difference between the cloud
bees and the Jenkins here so Jenkins
isn't kind of Open Source tool which a
lot of organizations pretty much
Implement as the date itself so even if
they don't want to go
um we have seen in a lot of big
organizations where you know they are
not going for the Enterprise to like
Cloud bees and all and they are going
for the pretty much you know core
Jenkins software as such here so this
Tool uh makes it easy for the developers
to integrate the changes to the project
that is something which is very
important because it can really help the
teams to say that how the things can be
done and how it can be performed over
there so the tools is really easy for
the developers to integrate and that's
the biggest uh you know benefit which
you are getting when we talk about these
tools as such so Jenkins is a really
important tool to be considered when we
talk about all these automations now
Jenkins achieves continuous integration
with the help of plugins that is also a
kind of another feature or benefit which
we get because there are so many plugins
which is available there as such which
is being used and for example you want
to have an integration with kubernetes
go Docker and all Maybe by default those
plugins are not installed but yes you
have the provisioning that you can go
for the installation of those plugins
and yes those features will start
embedded up and integrated within your
Jenkins so this is the reason this is
the main benefit which we get when we
talk about the Jenkins implementation
so Jenkins uh is you know one of the
best fit which is there for building a
cicd pipeline because of its flexibility
uh open source nature plug-in
capabilities the support for plugins and
it's quite easy to use and it's very
simple straightforward GUI which is
there which can definitely helps us you
can you know easily understand and go
through the Jenkins and you can grab the
understanding and add as an end result
you will be able to have a very robust
tool which using which pretty much any
kind of source code or any kind of
programming language you can Implement
CSD whether it's Android it's a not net
it's a Java it's a node.js all the
languages are having the support for the
Jenkins
so let's talk about the cicd pipeline
with the Jenkins here now to automate
the entire development process a CI CD
pipeline is the ultimate you know
solution which we are looking forward to
build such a pipeline Jenkins is our
best solution and best fit which is
available here
so there are pretty much six steps which
is involved when we look forward for any
kind of pipeline it's generic pipeline
which we are looking forward now it may
have like any other steps which is
available there probably some additional
steps you're doing like some other
plugins you are installing but these are
the basic steps which is there like a
minimum pipeline if you want to design
these are the steps which is available
there now let's see the first one is
that we have the required Java jdk like
a jdk to be available on the system now
most of the operating systems are
already available with the GRE like a
Java GRE but the problem with GRE is
that it's only for the build process it
will not be doing the compilation you
can run the artifacts you can run the
jar files you can you know run the
application run the code base but the
compilation requires the Java C or the
Java jdk kit to be installed onto the
system and that's the reason why for
this one we also require the jdk and
certain Linux commands execution
understanding we need to have because we
are going to run some kind of steps some
installation stuff and you know process
so that's pretty much required now let's
talk about how do cacd Pipeline with
Jenkins now first of all you have to
download the jdk and that is something
which is installed so after that you can
go for the Jenkins download now
jenkins.io download is a website is the
official websites of Jenkins now the
best part is that there you have support
for different operating systems and
platforms from there you can easily say
that if you want to go for a Java
package like a war file Docker Ubuntu
deviant sentos Fedora Red Hat windows
open Sushi uh FreeBSD ganto Mac
operating system in fact whatever the
different kind of artifacts or different
environment or different uh application
you want to download you will be able to
do that so that's the very first thing
to start upon you download the generic
Java package like a war file then you
have to execute it you have to download
that into a specific folder structure
let's say say that you have you know
created a folder called Jenkins now you
have to go into that Jenkins folder with
the help of CD command and there you you
how to run the command called Java
hyphen jar and the jenkins.bar there so
these are the executables artifacts so
War files can be easily executable jar
files bar files can be easily deployed
so just because with the Java command
you can run them you don't require any
kind of web container or application
container as such so here also you can
see that we are running the Java command
and it runs the applications as such and
once that is done so you can open the
web browser and you can open like
localhost colony80 so Jenkins uses the
ADT Port just like a tomcat Apache so uh
if you know once the deployment is done
installation is done so you can just
open the localhost colony DT now if you
want to get uh the Jenkins up and
running in the browser probably you can
you know go through the public IP
address also there so you can put the
public IP address Colony 80 and that can
also help you to you know start
accessing the Jenkins application now in
there you will be having an option
called create new jobs so you need to
click on that now once the particular
new job new item new job that's a
different naming conventions which is
available there now all you are going to
do is that you're going to do like you
are proceeding with the creating the
pipeline job so you will be having an
option called pipeline job over there
just select that and provide your custom
name what pipeline name or job name you
want to refer or you want to process
there now once that is available so what
happens that it will be in easy task for
us to see that how exactly we can go
ahead and we can perform on that part so
this can really help us to see that how
a pipeline job can be created and you
know performed on this modifications as
such now when the pipeline is selected
and we can give a particular name that
is this is the name which is available
and then we can say okay as such over
there now you can scroll down and find
the pipeline section so there what
happens that when you go over there and
say that okay this is the way that how
the pipelines are managed and you know
those kind of things so you will scroll
down and find the pipeline section and
go with that pipeline script now when
you select that option there are
different options which is available
like how you want to manage these
pipelines now you are you know have the
direct access also like if you want to
directly create the create a pipeline
script you can do that if you feel that
you want to manage like you want to
retrieve the Jenkins files also scored
management tool also can be used there
so you can work on that also so like
this there are so many a variety of
things which is available like which you
can use to work around that how exactly
the pipeline job can be created so
either you can fetch it from the source
code management Tool uh like gets a
version or something like that or you
can directly put the pipeline code as
such over there right now so next thing
is that we can configure an execute a
pipeline job with a direct script so uh
we can one see pipeline is selected so
you can put the particular script like
Jenkins file into your particular GitHub
link so you you may be having like
already a GitHub link so that the where
the Jenkins file is there so you can
make use of that now once you process
the GitHub link so what we can do is
that we can proceed with that and once
the processing is done so you can do the
save and you know you can keep the
changes and you know uh it will be
picking up the pipelines you know the
pipeline script is added up into the
GitHub and you know you have already
specified that uh let's just go ahead
with this Jenkins file pipeline script
from the GitHub repository and proceed
further now once that is done so what
next you can do is that you can go with
the build now process you click on the
bill now and once that is done so what
will happen that you will be able to see
that how the build process will be done
and how the build will be performed over
there so these are pretty much a kind of
a way so you can click on the console
output you will get all the logs that is
happening in the inside that whatever
the pipeline steps are getting executed
all of them you will be able to get or
you will be able to you know get on that
part there so these are the different
steps which is involved as such and uh
the sixth one is that you know uh yes
whatever the uh particular uh when you
run the build now you will be able to
see that source code will be uh you know
will be checked out and will be
downloaded before the build and you can
proceed with that part now later on if
you want to change the url of this
GitHub you can configure the job again
the existing job and you can change that
URL GitHub link URL whenever you require
you can also clone this uh job whenever
you go ahead and you work on that and
that's also kind of you know the best
part which is available as such right
and uh then you can have the advanced
settings over there so in there you can
put like your GitHub repository you can
say like okay the GitHub repository is
there so I'm just going to put this URL
and you know with that what will happen
that the settings will be available
there and the Jenkins file will be
downloaded as such and when you run the
build now you will be able to have a lot
of steps like a lot of configurations
going on so uh then the checkout sem so
we can have a declaration like checkout
sem which is there so when this to check
out the same is there so it will check
out a specific source code after that
you go to the log and you will be able
to see that each and every stage which
is being built up and executed as such
okay so now we are going to talk about a
demo here so on the pipeline here so
this is a Jenkins portal now you can see
here that there is an option called
create a job you can either click on the
new item or you can click on the new uh
create a job here now here I'm going to
say like a pipeline
and uh then you know you can select the
pipeline uh job type here now you have
the freestyle pipeline or GitHub
organization multiple Branch pipeline
these are the different options which is
available there but I'm going to
continue with the pipeline here as such
so when I selected the pipeline and say
okay so what will happen that I will be
able to see a configuration page which
is related to the pipeline now here the
very important part is that you have all
the uh General build trigger uh you know
options which is similar to the
freestyle but the build step and the
post build step is completely removed
because of the pipeline introduction now
here you either have the option to put
the pipeline script all together you can
also have some particular example for
example let's talk about some GitHub
Maven uh particular tool here so you can
see that we have you know got some steps
as such over here and you know it's
pretty much running over there now you
run it it will work smoothly it will
check out some source code but how we
are going to integrate like the version
in the Jenkins file into the version
control system because that's the ideal
approach we should be following when we
create a pipeline of a cicad now I'm
going to select a particular pipeline
from a CM here then go with the git here
now in there the Jenkins file is the
name of the file of the pipeline script
and I'm going to put my
repository over here in this one now
this repository is of my gate which is
like having a mieven build pipeline
which is available there it's having
some steps related to CI with for the
build and deployments and that's what we
can follow as such over here now in this
one the uh if it is a private repository
definitely you can add on your
credentials but this is a public
repository a personal repository so I
don't have to put any kind of
credentials but you can always add the
credentials with the help of add here
and that can help you to you know set up
whatever the credentials the private
repositories you want to configure now
once you save the configuration here
now what it's going to do is that you
know it's going to give you a particular
page to related to build now uh if you
want to run if you want to delete the
pipeline if you want to reconfigure the
pipeline all these different options are
available there so we are going to click
on the build now here and when I do that
immediately the pipeline will be
downloaded and will be processed now you
may not be able to get the a complete
stage view as of now because it's still
running so yeah you can see that the
checkout code is done then it's going on
to the build okay that's one of the step
which is there now once the build will
be done so it will continue with the
next steps with the next further steps
there so you can also go to the console
output log here like you can click on
this or you can click on the console
output to check the complete log which
is happening there or in fact you can
also see the stage wise logs also uh
because that is also very important when
you go for the complete logs uh it may
you know uh have a lot of steps involved
and you know a lot of logs will be
available there but if you want to see a
specific log of a specific stage that's
where this comes into the picture and as
you can see that all the different uh
steps like test cases executions the
sonar Cube analysis the archive
artifacts deployment and in fact the
notification so all this is a part of a
complete pipeline this whole pipeline is
done here and you know you get a kind of
a stage view it's success over here and
the artifacts is also available to
download so you can download this war
file is a web applications as such over
here so this is what our typical
pipeline looks like that how the
automation the complete automations
really looks like as such over here now
this is a very important aspect because
it really helps us to understand that
how the pipelines can be configured can
be done and pretty much with the same
steps you will be able to automate any
kind of pipelines as such so that was
the demo to build a simple pipeline as
such with the Jenkins and pretty much in
this one we understood that how exactly
the cicd pipelines can be configured and
we can use them and we can get hold on
that part hello and welcome to
continuous integration tutorial using
Jenkins my name is chidanand and I am
with the simply learned team today let's
get started with Jenkins Jenkins in my
opinion is one of the most popular
continuous integration servers of recent
times what began as a hobby project by a
developer working for Sun Microsystems
way back in early or mid-2000s has
gradually and eventually evolved into a
very very powerful and robust automation
servers it has a wider option since it
is released under MIT license and is
almost free to use Jenkins has a vast
developer community that supports it by
writing all kinds of plugins plugins is
the heart and soul of Jenkins because
using plugins one can connect Jenkins to
anything and everything under the sun
with that introduction the let's get
into what all will be covered as a part
of this tutorial I will get into some of
the prerequisites required for
installing Jenkins post which I will go
ahead and install Jenkins on a Windows
box there are few first time
configurations that needs to be done and
I will be covering those as well so once
I have Jenkins installed and configured
properly I will get into the user
administrative part I create few users
and I will use some plugins for setting
up various kinds of access permissions
for these users I will also put in some
freestyle jobs freestyle job is nothing
but a very very simple job and I will
also show you the powerfulness of
Jenkins by scheduling this particular
job to run based upon time schedule I
will also connect Jenkins with GitHub
GitHub is our source code where source
code repository where I've got some
repositories put up there so using
Jenkins I will connect to GitHub pull up
a repository that is existing on GitHub
onto the Jenkins box and run few
commands to build this particular
repository that is all from GitHub
sending out emails is a very very
important configurations of Jenkins or
any other continuous integration server
for that matter Whenever there is any
notifications that has to be sent out as
a part of either a build going bad or
build being good or building propagated
to some environment and all these
scenarios you would need the contents
integration servers to be sending out
notifications so I will get into a
little bit details of how to configure
Jenkins for sending out emails I will
also get into a scenario where I would
have a web application a maven-based
Java web application which will be
pulled from a GitHub repository and I
will deploy it onto a tomcat server the
Tomcat server will be locally running on
my system eventually I will get into one
other very very important topic which is
the Master Slave configuration it's a
very very important and pretty
interesting topic where distributed
builds is achieved using a Master Slave
configuration so I will bring up a slave
I will connect the slave with the master
and I'll also put in a job and kind of
delegate that particular job to the
slave configuration finally I will let
you know how to use some plugins to
backup your Jenkins so Jenkins has got a
lot of useful information set up on it
in terms of the build environments in
terms of workspace all this can be very
very easily backed up using a plugin so
this is what I'm going to be covering as
a part of this tutorial Jenkins is a web
application that is written in Java and
there are various ways in which you can
use and install Jenkins I have listed
popular three mechanisms in which
Jenkins is usually installed on in any
system the topmost one is as a Windows
or a Linux Based Services so if at all
you have Windows like the way I have and
I'm going to use this mechanism for this
demo so I would download a MSI installer
that is specific to Jenkins and install
this service so whenever I installed as
a service it goes ahead and nicely
installs all that is required for my
Jenkins and I have a service that can be
started as stopped based upon my need
any flavor of Linux as well one other
way of running Jenkins is downloading
this generic Word file and as long as
you have jdk install you can launch this
war file by the command opening up a
command prompt or shell prompt if it
earlier on Linux box specifying Java
hyphen jar and the name of this war file
it typically brings up your web
application and you know you can
continue with your installation the only
thing being if at all you want to stop
using Jenkins you just go ahead and
close this prompt you either do a
control C and then bring down this
prompt and your Jenkins server would be
down other older versions of Jenkins
were run popularly using this way in
which you already have a Java based web
server running up and running so you
kind of drop in this war file into the
root folder or the httpd root folder of
your web server so Jenkins would explode
and kind of bring up your application
all user credentials or user
Administration is all taken care of by
the Apache or the Tomcat server or the
web server on which Jenkins is running
this was a very older way of running but
still some people use it because if they
don't want to maintain two servers if
they already have a Java web server
which it's being nicely maintained and
backed up Jenkins can run attached to it
alright so each either ways it doesn't
matter however you're going to bring up
your Jenkins instance the way we're
going to operate Jenkins is all going to
be very very same or similar one with
the subtle changes in terms of user
Administration if at all you're
launching it through any other web
server which will take care of the user
Administration otherwise all the
commands are all the configuration or
the way in which I'm going to run this
demo it is going to be same across any
of these installations all right so the
prerequisites for running Jenkins as I
mentioned earlier Jenkins is nothing but
a simple web application that is run in
Java so all that it needs is Java
preferably jdk 1.7 or 1.8 2GB Ram is the
recommended RAM for running Jenkins and
also like any other open source toolsets
when you install jdk ensure that you set
in the environment variable Java home to
point to the right directory this is
something very specific to jdk but for
any other open source tools that you've
installed there is always a preferred
environment variable that you got to set
in which is specific to that particular
tool that you're going to use this is a
generic thing that is there for you know
for any other open source projects
because the way open source projects
discover themselves is using this
environment variables so as a general
practice or a good practice always set
these environment variables accordingly
so I already have jdk 1.8 installed on
my system but in case you do not what I
would recommend is just navigate on your
browser to the Oracle home page and just
type in or search for install jdk 1.8
and navigate to The Oracle home page
you'll have to accept the license
agreement and there are a bunch of
installers that is okay that you can
pick up based upon the operating system
on which you're running so I have this
windows 64 installer that is already
installed and running on my system so I
will not be into the details of
downloading this or installing it let me
show you once I install this what I've
done with regard to my path
so if you get into environment variables
all right so I have just set in a Java
home variable
if you see this C colon program files
Java jdk 1.8 this is where my my Java is
located C program files C program files
Java
okay so this is the home directory of my
jdk so that is what I've been I've set
it up here in my environment variable
so if you see here this is my Java home
all right one other thing to do is
ensure that in case you want to run Java
or Java C from a command prompt and show
that you also add that path into this
path variable so if you see this
somewhere I will see yes there you go
see colon program files Java jdk 1.8 pin
so with these two I'll ensure that my
Java installation is nice and you know
good enough so to check that to double
check that or to verify that let me just
open up a simple command prompt
and if I type in Java iPhone version
all right and Java C
yphen version
so the compiler is on the path Java is
on the path and if at all I do this
even the environment variable specific
to my Java is installed correctly so I
am good to go ahead with my Jenkins
installation
now that I have my prerequisites
all set for installing Jenkins let me
just go ahead and download Jenkins
so let me open up a browser and say
download
Jenkins
all right LTS is nothing but the long
term support these are all stable
versions weeklies I would not recommend
that you try these unless until you have
a real need for that
um long-term support is good enough and
as I mentioned there are so many flavors
of Jenkins that is available for
download
you also have a Docker container wherein
you know you can launch Jenkins as a
container but I'll not get into details
of that in this tutorial
all right so what I want is yes this is
the war file with a generic War file
that I was talking to you earlier and
this is the windows MSI installer so go
ahead and download this MSI installer I
already have that downloaded so let me
just open that up
all right so this is my downloaded
Jenkins instance or other installer this
is a pretty maybe a few months old but
this is good enough for me
before you start Jenkins installation
just be aware of one fact that there is
a variable called Jenkins home this is
where Jenkins would store all this
configuration data jobs project
workspace and all that specific to
Jenkins so by default if at all you
don't set this to any particular
directory if at all you install an MSI
installer all your installation gets
into SQL and program files 86 and
Jenkins folder if at all you run a war
file depending upon the user ID with
which you're running your War file the
Jenkins folder there's a DOT Jenkins
folder that gets created inside the user
home directory so in case you have any
need wherein you want to backup your
Jenkins or you want Jenkins
installations to get into some specific
directories go ahead and set this
Jenkins home variable accordingly before
you even begin your installation for now
I don't need to do any of this thing so
I've already downloaded the installer
let me just go ahead with the default
installation all right so this is my
Jenkins MSI installer I would just I
don't want to make any changes in into
the Jenkins configuration C colon
program files is good for me yeah this
is where all my destination folder and
all the configuration specific to it
goes I'm happy with this I don't want to
change this I would just say go ahead
and click installation
okay so what typically happens once the
Jenkins installation gets through is it
will start installing itself and there
are some small checks that needs to be
done so and by default Jenkins Launches
on the port 8080 so let me just open up
localhost 8080
there's a small checking that will be
done as a part of the installation
process wherein I need to type in the
hash key all right so there's a very
very simple hash key that gets stored
out here so I'll have to just copy this
path
if at all you're running as a war file
you would see that in your logs
all right so this is a simple hash key
that gets created every time when you do
a Jenkins installation so as a part of
the installation it just asks you to do
this
so if that is not great it'll crib about
it but this looks good so it's going
ahead
all right one important part during the
installation so you would need to
install some recommended plugins what
happens is the plugins are all related
to each other so it's like the typical
RPM kind of a problem where you try to
install some plugin and it's got a
dependency which is not installed and
you get into all those issues in order
to get rid of that what Jenkins
recommends there's a bunch of plugins
that is already recommended so just go
ahead and blindly click that install
recommended plugin so if you see there
is a whole lot of plugins which are bare
essential plugin that is required for
Jenkins in order to run properly so
Jenkins as a part of the installation
would get all these plugins and then
install it for you this is a good
combination to kind of begin with and
mind you at this moment Jenkins needs
lots of bandwidth in terms of network so
in case your you know your network is
not so good few of these plugins would
kind of fail and these plugins are all
you know all available on openly or or
mirrored sites and sometimes some of
them may be down so do not worry in case
some of these plugins kind of fail to
install you'll get an option to kind of
retry installing them but just ensure
that you know at least most or 1995 of
all these plugins are installed without
any problems let me pause the video here
for a minute and then get back once all
these plugins are installed my plugin
installation is all good there was no
failures in any of my plugins so after
that I get to create this first admin
user again this is one important point
that you got to remember
again given any username and password
but ensure that you kind of remember
that because it's very hard to get back
your username and password in case you
forget it alright so I'm going to create
a very very simple username and password
something that I can remember
I will
that's my name and an email ID is kind
of optional but it doesn't allow me to
go ahead in case I don't so I just given
an admin and I got a password I've got I
remember my password this is my full
name all right I say seven finish
all right that kind of completed my
Jenkins installation
it was not that tough was it
now that I have my Jenkins installed
correctly let me quickly walk you
through some bare minimal configurations
that is required these are kind of a
first time configuration that is
required so and also let me warn you the
UI is little hard for many people to
wrap their head around it specifically
the windows guys but if at all you're a
Java guy you know how painful it is to
write UI in Java you would kind of
appreciate you know all the effort that
has gone into the UI bottom line UI is
little hard to you know wrap your head
around it but once you start using it
possibly you'll start liking it all
right so let me get into something
called as manage Jenkins
this can be viewed like a main menu for
all Jenkins configuration so I'll get
into some of those important ones
something called as configure system
configure system this is where you kind
of put in the configuration for your
complete Jenkins instance few things to
kind of look out for this is a home
directory this is a Java home where all
the configurations all the workspace
anything and everything regarding
Jenkins is stored out here
system message you want to put in some
message on the system you just type in
whatever you want and it's possibly show
up somewhere up here on the menu number
of executors very very important
configuration this just lets Jenkin know
at any point in time how many jobs or
how many threads can be run you can you
can kind of visualize it like a thread
that can be run on this particular
instance as a thumb rule if at all
you're on a single core system number of
executors two should be good enough in
case at any point in time if there are
multiple jobs that kind of get triggered
the same time in case the number of
executors are less compared to the
number of jobs that have that woken up
no need to panic because they will all
get queued up and eventually Jenkins
will get to running those jobs just bear
in mind that whenever a new job kind of
you know gets triggered the CPU usage
and the memory usage in terms of the
disk right is very high on the Jenkins
instance
so that's something that you got to kind
of keep in mind all right but number of
executors two for my system is kind of
good label for my Jenkins I don't want
any of these things usage how do you
want to use your Jenkins this is good
for me because I only have a primary uh
server that is running so I want to use
this node as much as possible quite
better each of these options have got
some bare minimal help kind of a thing
that is that is out here by clicking on
these question marks you will get to
know as to what are these particular
configurations
all right so this all look good what I
want to show you here is there's
something regarding the docker
timestamps git plugin SVN email
notifications I don't want that what I
want the yes I want this SMTP server
configuration remember I mentioned
earlier that I would Bond Jenkins to be
sending out some emails and what I've
done here is I've just configured the
SMTP details of my personal email ID
in case you are in a in an organization
you would have some sort of an email IDs
that is set up for a Jenkins server so
you can specify the SMTP server details
of your company so that you know you can
authorize Jenkins to kind of send out
emails but in case you want to try it
out like me I have configured my
personal email ID which is on my Gmail
for sending out notifications so the
SMTP server would be
smtp.gmail.com I'm using the SMTP
authentication I have provided my email
ID and my password I'm using SMTP Port
which is 465 and I'm you know reply to
address is the same as mine I can just
send out an email and see if at all this
configuration works again Gmail would
not allow you to allow anybody to send
out notifications on your behalf so
you'll have to lower the security level
of your Gmail ID so that you can allow a
programmatically somebody to send out
email notifications on your behalf so
I've done already that I'm just trying
to see if I can send a test in email
with the configuration that I've set in
yes
all right so the email configuration
looks good
so this is how you configure your you
know your Gmail account in case you want
to do that if not put in your
organization SMTP server details which
are with a valid username and password
and should all be set
all right so no other configurations
that I'm going to change here all of
these look good
all right so I come back to manage
inkins okay one other thing that I want
to kind of go over is the global tool
configuration
imagine the scenario or look at it this
way Jenkins is a is a continuous
integration server it doesn't know what
kind of a code base it's going to pull
in what kind of a tool set that is
required or what is the code that is
going to pull in and how is it going to
build so you would have to put in all
the tools that is required for building
the appropriate kind of code that you're
going to pull in from you know your
source code repositories so just to give
an example in case your source code is a
Java source code and assuming that you
know because in this a demo this is my
laptop and I've put in all the
configurations jdk everything on my
laptop because I'm a developer I am
working on the laptop but my continuous
integration server would be you know a
separate server without anything being
installed on it so in case I want
Jenkins to you know run a Java code I
would need to install GDK on it I need
to specify the jdk location of this out
here this way
okay since I already have the jdk
installed and I've already put in the
Java home directory or rather the
environment variable correctly I don't
need to do it git if at all I want the
Jenkins server to use git git is a you
know command Dash or the command prompt
for for running git and connecting to
any other git server so you would need
git to be you know installed on that
particular system and set the path
accordingly
Gradle and Maven if at all you have some
mavens as well you want to do this any
other tool that you're going to install
on your system which is your continuous
integration server you will have to come
in here and configure something
in case you don't configure it when
chenkins runs it will not be able to
find these tools for building your task
and it'll crib about it
that's good I don't want to save
anything
manage Jenkins let me see what else is
required yes configure Global Security
all right the security is enabled and if
you see by default it's the security
access control is set to Jenkins own
user database so what does this mean you
know Jenkins by default it uses file
system where it stores all the usernames
with hashes up these usernames and kind
of stores them
so as of now it Jenkins is configured to
use its own database assuming that you
are running in an organization you would
probably want to have a you know some
sort of an ad or an ldap server using
which you would want to control access
to your Jenkins repository rather
Jenkins tool so you would specify your
ldap server details the root DN password
or the manager DN and the manager
password and all these details in case
you want to connect your Jenkins
instance with your ldap or ad or any of
the authentication servers that you have
in your organization
but for now since I don't have any of
these things I'm going to use this own
database that's good enough
all right so I will set up some
authorization methods and stuff like
that once I put in few jobs so for now
let me not get into any of these details
of this just be aware that Jenkins can
be connected for authorization to an
ldap server or you can have Jenkins
managing its own servers which is
happening as of now so I'm going to save
all this stuff that's good for me so
enough of all these configurations let
me put in a very very simple job all
right so job new item you know little
difficult to kind of figure out but then
that's the new item so I will just say
you know first job this is good for me I
just gave a name for my job I would say
it's a freestyle project that's good
enough for me I don't want to choose any
of that so unless until you choose any
of this this particular button would not
become active so choose the freestyle
project and say okay
at a very high level you will see
General source code management build
triggers build environment build and
post build in case you install more and
more plugins you will see a lot more
options but for now this is what you
would see so what am I doing at the
moment I'm just putting up a very very
simple job and the job could be anything
and everything so I don't want to put in
a very complicated job for now for the
demo purpose let me just put in a very
very simple job I'll give a description
this is an optional thing this is my
first Jenkins job all right I don't want
to choose any of these again there are
some helps available here
I don't want to choose any of this I
don't want to connect it into any source
code for now I don't want any triggers
for now I'll come back to this in in a
while build the environment I don't want
any build environment as a part of this
build step you know I just want to you
know run few things so that I kind of
complete this particular job so since
I'm on Windows box I would say execute
Windows batch command
all right so what do you want to do I
let me just Echo something Echo
uh hello this is my first Jenkins job
and possibly I would want the date and
the timestamp
pertaining to the job I mean the date
and time in which this job was run all
right very very simple command that says
you know this is my first job it just
puts out something along with the date
and the time
all right I don't want to do anything
else I want to keep this job as simple
as this so let me save this job
all right so once you save this job you
know the job names comes up here and
then I need to build this job and you
would see some build history out here
nothing is there as of now because I've
just put in a job I have not run it yet
all right so let me try to build it now
you see a build number you will see a
date and a timestamp so if I click on
this you will see a console output if I
go here
okay as simple as that and where is all
the job details that is getting into if
you see this
if I navigate to this particular
directory
all right so this is the directory what
I was mentioning earlier regarding
Jenkins home so all the job related
stuff that is specific to this
particular Jenkins installation is all
here
all the plugins that is installed the
details of each of those plugins can be
found here all right so the workspace is
where all the jobs that I've created
whichever I'm running would you know
there will be at individual folders
specific to the jobs that has been put
up here all right so one job one quick
run
that's what it looks like pretty simple
okay let me do one thing let me put up a
second job
I would say second job
I would say freestyle project
all right this is my second job
I just want to demonstrate the
powerfulness of the automation server
and how simple it is to automate a job
that is put up on Jenkins
which will be triggered automatically
remember what I said earlier about
Jenkins because at the core of Jenkins
is a very very powerful automation
server all right so what I'm going to do
I will just keep everything else the
same I'm going to put in the build
script pretty much similar to
second job
that gets triggered
automatically
every minute all right let me do that
percentage date and I'll put in the time
all right so I just put in another job
called second job and it pretty much
does the same thing as what I was doing
earlier in terms of printing the date
and the time but this time I'm just
going to demonstrate the powerfulness of
the automation server that is there if
you see here
there's a build trigger so a build can
be triggered using various triggers that
is there so we'll get into this GitHub
uh triggering our hook or a web hook
kind of a triggering later on but for
now what I want to do I want to ensure
that this job that I'm going to put in
would be automatically triggered on its
own let's say every minute I want this
job to be run on its own
so build periodically is my setting
if you see here there's a bunch of
help that is available for me so for
those of you you have written cron jobs
on Linux boxes you'll find it very very
simple but for others don't panic let me
just put up a very very simple regular
expression for scheduling this job every
minute
all right so that's one two three four
five
all right come up come up come up all
right so five stars is all that I'm
gonna put in and Jenkins got a little
worried and she's asking me do you
really mean every minute oh yeah I want
to do this every minute let me save this
and how do I check whether it gets
triggered every minute or not I just
don't do anything I'll just wait for a
minute and if at all everything goes
well Jenkins would automatically trigger
my second job in a minute's time from
now
this time around I'm not going to
trigger anything look there you see it's
automatically got triggered
if I go in here
yep second job that gets triggered
automatically you know it was triggered
at 42 1642 which is 442 my time that
looks good
and if everything goes well every one
minute onwards this job would be
automatically triggered
now that I have my Jenkins up and
running a few jobs that has been put up
here on my Jenkins instance I would need
a way of controlling access to my
Jenkins server this is wherein I would
use a plugin called role based access
plugin and create few rules the rules
are something like a global Rule and a
project role Project Specific growth I
can have different rules and I can have
users who have signed up or the users
who might create kind of assigned to
these roles so that each of these users
fall into some category this is my way
of kind of controlling access to my
Jenkins instance and ensuring that
people don't do something unwarranted
alright so first things first let me go
ahead and install a plugin for doing
that so I get into many Jenkins and
manage plugin
a little bit of a confusing screen in my
opinion there's updates available
installed and advanced as of now we
don't have the role based plugin so let
me go to available it'll take some time
for you to get refreshed all right now
these are the available plugins these
are the install plugins all right so let
me come back to available and I would
want to search for my role based access
plugin so I would say search for role
and hit enter
okay role-based authorization strategy
enables user authorization using a
role-based strategy roles can be defined
globally or for particular jobs or notes
and stuff like that so exactly this is
the plugin that I want I would want to
install it without a restart
all right looks good so far yes
go back to the top of the page yes
remember Jenkins is running on a Java
using a Java instance so typically many
things would work the same way
understand until you want to restart
Jenkins once in a while but as a good
practice whenever you do some sort of a
big installations or big patches on your
Jenkins instance just ensure that you
kind of restarted otherwise there would
be a difference in terms of what is
installed on the system and what is
there on the file system you won't need
to flush out few of those settings later
on but for now these are all very small
plugins so this would run without any
problems but otherwise if at all there
are some plugins which would need a
restart you know kindly go ahead and
restart your Jenkins instance but for
now I don't need that it looks good I've
installed the plugin so where do you see
my plugin I install the plugin that is
specific to the user control or the
access control so let me go into yes
Global Security
and I would see this role-based strategy
showing up now
all right so this comes in because of my
installation of my role based plugin so
this is what I would want to enable
because I already have my own database
set up and for the authorization part in
the sense that who can do what I'm going
to install I mean I've already installed
a role based strategy plugin and I'm
going to enable that strategy all right
I would say save okay now I've installed
the role based access plugin I would
need to just set it up and check that
you know I would go ahead and create
some roles and ensure that I assign
users as per these roles all right so
let me go to
my name Jenkins
configure all right let me see where is
this configure configure Global Security
is that where I create my rules
nope not here
yes manage and assign roles
okay again you would see these options
only after you install these plugins so
for now I've just enabled the plugin I
have enabled role based access control
and I would go ahead and create some
rules for this particular Jenkins
instance so I would say first manage
rules
so I would need to create some roles
here and the roles are at a very high
level these are Global rules and there
are some project roles and there are
some slave rules I'll not get into
details of all of this at a very very
high level which is a global role let me
just create a row a role can be kind of
visualized like a group so I would
create a role called developer typically
the Jenkins instance or the ca instance
are kind of owned up or controlled by QA
guys so QA guys would need to provide
some sort of a you know limited access
to developers so that's why I'm creating
a role called developer and I'm adding
this role at a global role level so I
would say add this here and you would
see this developer role that is there
and each of these options you can click
hover over it you would see some sort of
a help on what what are these uh you
know permissions specific to so what I
want is like you know it sounds a little
you know different but I would want to
give very very little permissions for
the developer so from an Administration
perspective I would just want him to
have a read
um kind of a role credentials again I
would just want to view kind of a role I
don't want him to create any agents and
all that stuff that looks good for me
for a job I would want him to just
possibly read I don't want him to build
I don't want him to cancel any jobs I
don't want him to configure any job I
don't even want him to create any job I
would just want him to read few things I
would not give him possibly a role to
the workspace as well I mean I don't
want him to have access to the workspace
I would just want him to read a job
now check you know have read only access
to the job run
um no I don't want him to give him any
any particular access which will allow
him to run any jobs view configure yeah
possibly create yeah delete I don't want
to read yes definitely and this is the
specific role so what I'm doing I'm just
creating a global role called developer
and I'm giving him very very limited
roles in the sense that I don't want
this developer to be able to run an
agents nor create jobs or build jobs or
cancel jobs or configure jobs at the max
I would just want him to read a job that
is already put up there
okay so I would save
now I've created a rule I still don't
have any users that is there on the
system so let me go ahead and create
some user on the system
that's not here I will say configure
managing cans manage users
okay let me create a new user I would
call this user as yeah developer one
sounds good
some password
some password that I can remember
okay his name is developer One D at
d.com or something like that
okay so this is the admin with with
which I kind of configured or brought up
the system and developer one is a user
that I have configured so still have not
set any rules for this particular user
yet so I would go to manage and gains
I would say
manage and assign roles I would say
assign roles
okay so if you see what I'm going to do
now is assign a role that is specific to
that particular level I will find the
particular user and assign him the
developer role that I have already
configured
the role shows up here I would need to
find my user whoever created and then
assign him to that particular role so if
you remember the user that I created was
developer one I would add this
particular user and now this particular
user what kind of a role I want him to
have because this is the global rule
that had created so developer I would
assign this developer 1 to this
particular Global rule and I would go
ahead and save my changes
now let me check the permissions of this
particular user by logging out of my
admin account and logging back as
developer one
if you remember this role was created
with very less privileges so there you
go I have Jenkins but I don't see a new
item I can't trigger a new job I can't
do anything I see these jobs however I
don't think so I'll be able to start
this job I don't have the permission set
for that the maximum I can do is look at
the job see what was there as a part of
the console output and stuff like that
so this is a limited role that was
created and I added this developer to
that particular role which was a
developer role so that the developers
don't get to configure any of the jobs
because the Jenkins instance is owned by
a cure person he doesn't want to give
developer any administrative rights so
the rights that he set out by creating a
developer role and anybody who is tagged
any user who is tagged as a part of this
developer role would get the same kind
of permissions and these permissions can
be you know fine-grained it can be a
Project Specific permissions as well but
for now I just demonstrated the high
level permission that I had set in let
me quickly log out of this user and get
back as the admin user because I need to
continue with my demo with the developer
role that was created I have very very
less privileges one of the reasons for
Jenkins being so popular as I mentioned
earlier is the bunch of plugins that is
provided by users or Community users who
don't charge any money for these plugins
but it's got plugins for connecting
anything and everything so if you can
navigate to or if you can find Jenkins
plugins
you would see index of over so many
plugins that is there all of these are
wonderful plugins whatever connectors
that you would need if you want to
connect Jenkins to an AWS instance or
you want to connect Jenkins to a Docker
instance or any of those containers you
would have a plugin you can go and
search up if I want to connect Jenkins
to big bucket
bitbucket is one of the git servers so
many plugins that is available okay so
bottom line Jenkins without plugins is
nothing so plugins is the heart of
Jenkins for you to connect or for in
order to connect Jenkins with any of the
containers or any of the other tool sets
you would need the plugins if you want
to connect or you want to build a
repository which has got Java and Maven
you would need to install Maven and GDK
on your Jenkins instance if at all
you're looking for a net build or
Microsoft build you would need to have
MS build installed on your on your
Jenkins instance and the plugins that
will trigger Ms build if at all you want
to listen to some server side web hooks
from GitHub you would need GitHub
specific plugins if you want to connect
Jenkins to AWS you need those plugins if
you want to connect to a Docker instance
that is running anywhere in the world as
long as you have the URL which is
publicly reachable you just have a
Docker plugin that is installed on your
Jenkins instance sonar cube is one of
the popular static code analyzers so you
can connect a Jenkins build to can build
a job on Jenkins and push it to sonar
Cube and get sonar Cube to run analysis
on that and get back the results in
Jenkins all of these works very well
because of the plugins now with that let
me connect our Jenkins instance to
GitHub I already have very very simple
Java repository up on my GitHub instance
so let me connect Jenkins to this
particular GitHub instance and pull out
a job that is put up there all right so
this is my very very simple uh you know
repository that is there called hello
Java and this is what is there in the
report there is a hello hello.java
application that is here or a simple
class file that is there it's got just
one line of system dot out so this is
already present on github.com at this
place and this would be the URL for this
Repository
if I pick up this GPS URL this is my
https URL so what I would do is I would
connect my Jenkins instance to go to
GitHub provide my credentials and pull
out this repository which is on the
cloud hosted github.com and get it to my
Jenkins instance and then build this
particular Java file I'm keeping the
source code very very simple it's just a
Java file how do I build my Java file
how do I compile my Java file I just say
Java C and the name of my class file
which is hello.java and how do I run my
Java file I would say Java and hello
okay so remember I don't need to install
any plugins now because uh what it needs
is a git plugin so if you remember when
we were doing the installation there was
a bunch of recommended plugins so git is
already installed on my system so I
don't need to install it again so let me
put up a new job here it says get job
let it be a freestyle project that's
good for me I would say okay
all right so the source code management
remember in the earlier examples we did
not use any source code because we were
just putting up some Echo kind of uh
jobs we did not need any integration
with any of the source code systems so
now let me connect this so I'm going to
put up a source code and git would sure
because the plugin is already there SVN
perforce any of those additional source
code management tools if at all you
would need just install those plugins
and Jenkins connects wonderfully well to
all these particular Source control
tools okay so I would copy the https URL
from here I would say this is the URL
that I'm supposed to
go and grab my source code from but all
right that sounds good but what is the
username and password so I'll have to
specify a username
and password all right so I would say
the username this is my username and
this is my https credential for my job
okay so this is my username and this is
my password I just save this I say add
and then I would say you know use these
credentials to go to GitHub and then on
my behalf pull out a repository all
right if at all at this stage if there's
any error in terms of not able to
Jenkins not able to find git or the
git.exe or if my credentials are wrong
somewhere down here you would see a red
message saying that you know something
is not right you can just go ahead and
kind of fix that for now this looks good
for me I'm going to grab this URL what
am I going to do this step would pull
the source code from the GitHub and then
what would be there as a part of my
build step
because this repository just has a Java
file correct hello.java so in order for
me to build this I would just say
execute Windows batch command and I
would say Java C
Hello dot Java that is the way I would
build my Java core and if I have to run
it I would just say Java
hello
pretty simple two steps and this would
run after the repository contents are
fetched from GitHub
Java that sounds good I would say save
this and let me try to run this
okay if you see there's a lot of you
know it executes git on your behalf it
goes out here it provides my credentials
and says you know it pulls all my
repository and by default it will pull
up the master branch that is there on my
repository and it kind of builds this
whole thing Java C hello to Java and it
runs this project Java hello and there
you see this is the output that is there
and if at all you want to look at the
contents of the repository if you can go
here this is my
workspace of my system hang on this is
not right
okay good job if you see here this is my
hello.java this is the same program that
was there on my GitHub repository
okay so this is a program that was there
on the main GitHub repository all right
so this was the same program that was
here and Jenkins on our behalf went over
all the way to GitHub pulled this
repository from there and then you know
it brought it down to my local system or
my Jenkins instance it compiled it and
it ran this particular application
okay now that I've integrated Jenkins
successfully with GitHub for a simple
Java application let me build a little
bit on top of it what I will do is I
have a maven-based web application that
is up there as a repository in my GitHub
so this is the repository that I'm
talking about it's called AMV and web
app it's got It's a maven-based
repository as you would know my one is a
very very simple Java based uh build
tool that will allow you to run various
targets and it'll compile it will based
upon the goals that you specify it can
compile it can run some tests and it can
you can build a war file and even deploy
it into some other server for now what
we're going to use Maven is just for
building and creating a package out of
this particular web application it
contains a bunch of things and what is
important is just the index.jsp it just
contains an HTML file that is there as a
part of this web application so from a
perspective of requirements now since
I'm going to connect Jenkins with this
particular repository git we already
have that set we only need two other
things one is Maven because Jenkins will
use Maven so in order to use Maven
Jenkins would have to have a maven
installation that is there on the
Jenkins box and in this case the Jenkins
box is this laptop
and after I have my Maven installed I
also need a tomcat server Tomcat is a
very very simple web server and that you
can freely download I'll let you know
how to quickly download and install the
Tomcat alright so download Maven first
at the various ways in which you can
kind of download this mobile there is
zip files binary zip files and archive
files so what I've done is I've just
already downloaded Maven and if you see
I've unzipped it here so this is the
folder with which I have unzipped my
maven so as you know Maven again is is a
one open source build tool so you'll
have to set in a few configurations and
set up the path so mvn hyphen iPhone
version if I specify this after setting
my path my one should work and if at all
I Echo M2 home which is nothing but the
variable environment variable specific
to my over node it is already set here
so once you unzip my one just set this
M2 home variable to the directory where
you unzip your Maven also just set the
path to this particular directory slash
bin because that is where your Maven
executables are all found
all right so that's with Maven and you
know since I've set the path and the
environment variable mav1 is running
perfectly fine on my system I've just
verified it okay next one is the Tomcat
server
download Apache Tomcat server 8.5 is
what I have on my system so I'm just
gonna show you where to download this
from
this way you download Tomcat server and
I already have the server downloaded
again this doesn't need any installation
I just unzip it here and it kind of has
a bin and configuration I have made some
subtle changes in the configuration
first and foremost Tomcat server also by
default runs on port 8080 since we
already have our Jenkins server running
on port 8080 we cannot let Tomcat run on
the same port there will be a port Clash
so what I've done I have configured
Tomcat to use a different port so if I
go to this configuration file here there
is a server.xml
let me open this up here
all right okay so this is the port by
default it will be 80 80. I have just
modified it to 8081 so I've changed the
port on which my Tomcat server would run
all right so that is one chain second
change when Jenkins kind of tries to get
into my tomcat and deploy something for
someone he would need some
authentications so that he'll be alloy
deployment by Tomcat so for that I need
to create a user on tomcat and provide
this user credentials to my Jenkins
instance
so I would go to
tomcatusers.xml file here
I have already created our username
called deployer and the password is
deployer and I've added a role called
manager hyphen script manager hyphen
script will allow programmatic access to
the Tomcat server so this is the role
that is there so using this credentials
I will enable or I'll Empower Jenkins to
get into my Tomcat server and deploy my
application all right only these two
things that is required
let me just start my Tomcat server first
so I get into my bin folder I open
command prompt here and there's a
startup.bat
it's pretty fast it just takes a few
seconds yes there you go don't get
service up and running now this is
running on Port 8081 so let me just
check if that looks good
so localhost
8821
okay my Tomcat server is up and running
that sounds good the user is already
configured on this that's also fine so
what I'll do as a part of my first job
my one is also installed on my system so
I am good to use Maven as a part of my
Jenkins so I will put up a simple job
now
I will say job
NBN
web app I call this
freestyle job that's good
okay so this will be a git repository
what is the URL of my git repository is
uh this guy https URL
okay
because this URL I will use the
credentials the old credential that I
set up will work well because it's the
same git user that I'm kind of
connecting into
all right so now the change happens here
where after I get this since I said this
is a simple Maven repository I will have
some Maven targets to run
so the simple Target first is let me run
Maven package this creates a war file
okay so mvn package is the target
package is the target so when whenever I
run this package it kind of creates it
it builds it it tests it and then
creates a package so this is all that is
required maybe let me try to save this
and let me first run this and see if it
connects well if there's any problem
with my War file or the war file gets
created properly
okay
wonderful so it built a word file and if
you see it all shows you
what is the location where this war file
was generated
so this will be the workspace if you see
this this Warfare was successfully built
now I need to grab this particular War
file and then I would need to deploy it
into Tomcat server again I would need a
small plugin to do this because I need
to connect Tomcat with my Jenkins server
let me go ahead and install the plugin
for the container deployment so I will
go to manage plugins
available
type in container
container container
deploy to container okay so let's put
this the plugin that I would need I
would install it without a restart
right seems to be very fast
nope sorry it's still installing
okay
it installed the plugin so if at all you
see this
if you go to my workspace
okay in the Target folder
I would say this web application War
file that is already built so I would
need to configure this plugin to pull up
this war file and deploy it onto the
Tomcat server for deploying onto the
Tomcat server I will use the credentials
of the user that I've created okay so
let me go to configure this particular
project again
and um
okay all this is good
so the package is good I'm going to just
create a package that's all fine now
add a post build step so after the war
file is built as a part of this package
directive let me use this deployment to
container now this will show up after
you install the plugin so deploy this
one to the container now what is that
you're supposed to specify you're
supposed to specify the what is the
location
okay so this is a global uh you know
configuration that is there that will
allow you to
from the root folder it'll pick up the
war file that is there so star star
forward slash star dot War that's good
for me
okay what is the context path context
path is nothing but just the name of an
application that you know under which it
will get deployed into the Tomcat server
I will just say mvn web app
that's the name of my thing now I need
to specify what kind of a container that
I'm talking about all right so the
deployment would be for
the stormcat 8.5 is what I need
okay because the server that we have is
a tomcat 8.5 server that I have so this
would be the URL so the credentials yes
I need to add a credential for this
particular server so if you remember I
had created a credential
for my web application so let me just
find that
my Tomcat server yes configuration of
this
okay so deployer and deployer username
is deployer password is deployed okay so
let me use that credential
I would say I would say add a new
credential Jenkins credential the
username is deployer and the password is
replyer
so I would use this deploy credentials
for that and what is the URL of my
Tomcat instance so this is the URL of my
Tomcat instance
so take the war file that is fine found
in this particular folder and then you
know context path the same in web app
use the deployer deployment credentials
and get into this localhost which is
there
8081 this is the Tomcat server that is
running on my system and then go ahead
and deploy it
okay so that is all that is required so
I would say just save this
and let me run it now
okay it built successfully built the war
file it is trying to deploy it and looks
like a deployment went ahead perfectly
well
so
the context path was in main web app so
if I type in this
all right if at all I go ahead into my
Tomcat server there would be a web apps
folder you would see the you know the
date time stamp so this is the file that
get got recently copied and this is the
Explorer version of our application
so the application was built the source
code of this application was pulled from
the GitHub server it was built locally
on the Jenkins instance test and then it
was pushed into a tomcat server which is
running on a different port which is
808.1 now for this demo I am running
everything locally on my system but
assuming that you know this particular
Tomcat instance was running on some
other server with some other different
IP address all that you got to go and
change is the URL of the server
so this would be the server in case you
you already have that uh you know if you
have a tomcat server which is running on
some other machine that's all fine with
a different IP that's all good enough
the whole bundle or the war file that
was built as a part of this Jenkins job
gets transferred onto the other server
and gets deployed that's the beauty of
Jenkins and automatic deployments or
other deployments using Jenkins and my
own distributed build or Master Slave
configuration in Jenkins as you would
have seen you know we just have one
instance of Jenkins server up and
running all the time and also I told you
that whenever any job that kind of you
know gets started on the Jenkins server
it is little heavy on in terms of disk
space and the CPU utilization so which
kind of you know if at all you're in an
organization where in your heavily
reliant on the Jenkins server you don't
want your Jenkins server to go down so
that's wherein you kind of start
Distributing the load that is there on
the Jenkins server so you primarily have
a server which is just a placeholder or
like a master who will take in all the
kind of jobs and what he will do is
based upon trigger that has happened to
the job or whichever job needs to be
built he if at all he can delegate these
jobs onto some of the machines or some
other sleeves you know that's a
wonderful thing to have okay use case
one use case two assuming that you know
if you have a Jenkins server that is
running on a Windows box or on a Linux
one and if at all you have a need where
you need to build based upon operating
systems you have multiple build
configurations to support maybe you need
to build a Windows you know Windows
based.net kind of a projects where you
would need a Windows machine to build
this particular project you also have a
requirement where you want to build
Linux the next based are systems you
also have a Mac you you support some
sort of an apps or something that is
built on Mac OS you would need to build
you know Mac based system as well so how
are you going to support all these needs
so that's wherein a beautiful concept of
Master Slave or you know primary and
delegations or agent and master comes
into play so typically you would have
one Jenkins server who will just you
know configure with all the proper
authorizations users configurations and
everything is set up on this Jenkins
server his job is just delegations he
will listen to some server triggers or
based upon the job that is coming in he
will if there is a very nice way of
delegating these jobs to somebody else
and you know taking back the results he
can control lot of other systems and
these systems may not have a complete or
there's no need to put in a complete
Jenkins installation all that you got to
do is have a very very simple Runner or
sleeve that's a simple jar file that is
run as a low priority thread or a
process Within These systems so with
that you can have a wonderful
distributed build server that can be set
up and in case one of the servers goes
down your master would know that what
went down and kind of delegate the task
to somebody else so this is the kind of
distributed build or the Master Slave
configuration so what I'll do in this
exercise or in this demo is I will set
up a simple slave but since I don't have
too many machines to kind of play around
what I'll do is I will set up a slave in
in one other folder within my hard drive
so I've got the C drive and D drive my
Jenkins is on my C drive so what I do is
I would just use my e Drive and set up a
very very simple slave out there I'll
just show you how to provision a slave
and how to connect to a slave and how to
delegate a job to that slave let me go
back to my Jenkins master and configure
him to you know talk to an agent so
there are various ways in which this
client and server talk to each other
what I'm going to choose is something
called as gnlp Java Network launch
protocol so using this I would ensure
that you know the client and server talk
to each other so for that I need to
ensure that I kind of enable this jnlp
port so let me try to find out where is
that let me try this
okay yes
agents and by default this jnlp agents
thing would be disabled so if you see
here there's a small help on this
so I'm going to use this jnlp which is
nothing but Java Network launch protocol
and you know I'll configure the master
and server to talk to each other using
jnlp so for that I need to enable this
guy so I enable this guy instead of
making the default the configuration was
disabled so I make him random I make him
you know enabled and I say save this
configuration
all right so now configured ours made a
setting for the master so that the jnlp
port is kind of opened up so let me go
ahead and you know create an agent
so I'll go to manage nodes so if you see
here there's only one master here so let
me provision a new node here so this is
the way you know in which you bring up a
new node you have to configure it on the
server a Jenkins would put in some sort
of security around this particular agent
and let you know how to launch this
particular engine so that he can connect
to a Jenkins master so I would say new
node I would give a name for my node I
would say windows node because both of
these are windows only so that's fine I
just give an identifier saying that
Windows node I would say this is a
permanent agent I would say okay so if
you see the name let me just copy this
name here with the description
number of executors since it's a slave
node and both of these are running on my
system I'll keep the number of executors
as one
that's fine remote root directory now
this is where let me just clarify this
since I have both my
my master is running on my C drive C
drive program files 86 or hang on not
86.
C colon program files
it is indeed 86.
all right Jenkins so this is where my
master is running so I don't want the C
drive what I'll do is I'll use something
called as a drive I have another Drive
in my system but please visualize this
like you know you're running this on a
separate system altogether so I create a
folder here called Jenkins node and this
is where I'm going to place my or I'm
going to provision my slave and I'm
going to run it from here so this is the
directory in which I am going to
provision my slave node so I'm going to
copy this here and that is the remote
root directory of your particular agent
or sleep so I just copy it here the
label you know probably this is fine for
me
and usage how do you want to use this
guy
so I would don't want him to run all
kinds of jobs I will only build jobs
with label Expressions that match this
particular node and so this is the label
of this node so in order for somebody to
kind of delegate any task to them they
allowed to specify this particular label
so imagine this way if I have a bunch of
Windows system I name it as Windows star
anything that says from Windows I can
give a regular expression and say that
anything that matches Windows run this
particular task there if I have some MAC
machines I name all these Mac agents as
Mac star or something like that and I
can delegate all tasks you know saying
that start with whatever starts with Mac
in this node run the Mac jobs there
so you identify a node using the label
and then delegate the task there all
right so launch method you know we will
use Java web star because we got a
we got to use jnlp protocol okay that
sounds good directory I think nothing
else is required availability yes we'll
keep this agent yeah online as much as
possible that sounds good all right let
me save this
all right I'm just provisioning this
particular node now
so if I click on this node I get a bunch
of commands along with an agent.jar
so this is the agent.jar that has to be
taken down to the other machine or the
slave node and from there I need to run
this along with a small security
credential so let me copy this whole
text here in my notepad
notepad plus plus is good for me
okay I copy this whole
but there I also want to download this
alien.jar
I would say yes
this agent.jar is the one that is
configured by a server so all the
details that is required for launching
this agent.jar is found in this ah sorry
for launching this agent is found this
agent.jar so typically I need to take
this jar file onto the other system
and then kind of run it from there so
I have this 18.jar I copy this or do I
cut this I come back to my folder my
Jenkins node I paste it here
okay so now with this provision
agent.jar and I need to use this whole
command Ctrl a control C and then launch
this particular agent so let me bring up
a command from right here and then
launched it so I'm saying in the same
folder where there is agent.jar I'm
going to launch this a particular agent
Java hyphen jar agent.jar jnlp this is
the URL of my server in case the server
and client are on different locations or
different IPS there are specified IP
address all this anyway would show up
and then the secret and you know the
root folder of your Jenkins or the slave
node
okay
so
something ran and then you know it says
it's connected very well it seems to
have connected very well so let me come
back to my Jenkins instance and see you
know if at all you see earlier this was
not connected alone Let me refresh this
guy
okay now these two guys are connected
provision a Jenkins node and then I
copied all the credentials of the slave
dot jar along with the launch code and
then took it to the other system and
kind of ran it from there since I don't
have another system I've just got a
separate directory in another folder
another drive and I'm launching the
agent from here as long as this
particular agent is up and running or
this command prompt is up and running
the agent would be connected so once I
close this the connection goes down
all right so successfully we've launched
this particular agent now this would be
the home directory of this Jenkins node
or the Jenkins slave so any task that
I'm going to delegate to this particular
slave would all be run here it will
create a workspace right here all right
so good so let me just come back and let
me kind of put up a new task here I will
say that you know delegate job is good I
say freestyle project I'm going to
create a very very simple job here
I don't want it to connect to gate or
anything like that let me just create a
very very simple
Echo
relegate to the
slave negative two I don't like the word
slave delegated to
agent
put this way
all right so delegated to agent sounds
good now how am I going to ensure that
this particular job runs on the agent or
on the slave that I've configured
right you see this if at all you
remember how we provisioned our
particular slave we give a label right
so now I'm going to put in a job that
will only match this particular label
so I'm going to say that whatever
matches this you know Windows label run
this job on that particular node so we
have only one node that's matching this
in a Windows node so this job will be
delegated out there so I save this
and let me build this
this is again a very very simple job
there's nothing in this I just want to
demonstrate how to kind of delegate it
to an agent so if you see this it runs
successfully and uh where is the
workspace the workspace is right inside
our Jenkins node it created a new
workspace delegate a job it put in here
so my old or the my primary Master job
is in SQL program files under Jenkins
and this is the slave job that was
successfully run very very simple but
very very powerful concept of Master
Slave configuration or distributed
built-in Jenkins
okay approaching the final section where
we've done all this hard work in
bringing up our Jenkins server
configuring it putting up some jobs on
it creating users and all this stuff now
we don't want this configuration to kind
of go away we want a very nice way of
ensuring that we backup all this
configuration and in case there is any
failure Hardware crash or a machine
crash we would want to kind of restore
from the existing configuration that we
kind of backed up the one quick way to
do that would be or one dirty way to do
that would be just you know take a
complete backup of a sequel colon
program files colon Jenkins directory
because that's where our whole Jenkins
configuration is present but we don't
want to do that let's use some plugins
for taking up a backup so let me go to
manage Jenkins
and click on available
and let me search for some back there
are a bunch of backup plugins so I would
recommend one of these plugins that I
specifically use so this is the backup
plugin so let me go ahead and install
this plugin
all right so we went ahead and installed
this plugin so let me come back to my
manage plugins so this plugin is there
so hang on Backup Manager so you will
see this option once you install this
plugin so first time I can you know do a
setup I would say back up this
particular I'll give a folder this
folder is pertaining to the folder where
I want to check against backup some data
and I would say the format should be zip
format is good enough let me give a name
or a template or a file name for my you
know backup this is good I want it in
verbose mode I don't want to shut on my
Jenkins or should I shut it down no okay
one thing that you got to remember is
that whenever a backup happens there are
too many jobs that is running on the
server
it can kind of slow down your Jenkins
instance because it's it's in the
process of copying few of those things
and the files are being changed at that
moment instead a bit problematic for
Jenkins so typically you backup your
servers only when there is very less
load or typically try to you know bring
it to a shutdown kind of a state and
then take a backup
all right so I'm going to back up all
these things you know I don't want to
exclude anything else I want the history
I want the manual artifacts possibly
don't want this guy I would just say
save
and then I would say back him up
so this would run a bunch of you know
steps and all the files that is required
as a part of this is pretty fast but
then if at all you have too many things
up on your server for now we didn't have
too many things up on our server but in
case you had too many things to kind of
backup this may take a while so let me
just pause this recording and get back
to you once the backup is complete so
there you go the backup was successful
created a backup of all the workspace
the configurations the users and you
know all that so all this is kind of
hidden down in this particular zip file
so at any instance if at all I kind of
Crash my system for some instance or say
hard disk failure and I bring up a new
instance of Jenkins I can kind of use
the backup plugin for restoring this
particular configurations so how do I do
that I just come back to my managing
cans
come back to backup manager and
obviously restore Hudson or Jenkins
configuration hi guys welcome to this
video on Jenkins interview questions and
answers
Jenkins is a popular devops open source
automation server it is used to automate
the non-human part of software
development and supports continuous
integration and continuous delivery
Jenkins is a server-based system that
runs in servlet containers such as
Apache Tomcat
we have compiled the most important
Jenkins interview questions that you
might face in a Jenkins or devops
interview
so without further Ado let us get
started with Jenkins interview questions
and answers so the first question you'll
be asked about with Jenkins is explain a
Master Slave architecture of Jenkins so
the way that Jenkins is set up is that
the Jenkins Master will pull code from
your remote git repository such as
GitHub and we'll check that repository
every time there is a code commit it
will distribute the workload of that
code and the tests that need to be
applied to that code to all of the
Jenkins slaves and then on requests the
Jenkins master and the slaves will then
carry out all the builds and tests to be
able to produce test reports the next
question you'll be asked is what is a
Jenkins file and simply put a Jenkins
file as a text file that has a
definition of the Jenkins Pipeline and
is checked into a source code repository
and this really allows for three
distinct things to happen one it allows
for a code review and iteration of the
pipeline it permits an audit Trail for
that Pipeline and also provides a single
source of Truth for the pipeline which
can be viewed and edited so which of the
following commands runs Jenkins from the
command line is it Java Dash jar
jenkins.war Java Dash War
jenkins.jar Java dot dash jar Jenkins
jar Java Dash War
jenkins.war and the answer is a Java
Dash jar Jenkins dot wall so when
working with Jenkins you're going to be
asked what are the key Concepts and
aspects of working with a Jenkins
Pipeline and you want to really hold out
your fingers here and go through four
key areas and that is pipeline node step
and stay so pipeline refers to the use
defined model of a CD continuous
delivery pipeline node are the machines
which is which are part of that Jenkins
environment within the pipeline step app
is a single task that tells Jenkins what
to do at that particular point in time
and then finally stage defines a
conceptually distinct subset of tasks
performed through the entire Pipeline
and tasks could be build test and deploy
so which of the following file is used
to Define dependency in Maven and do we
have A build.xml B palm.xml C
dependency.xml or D version dot XML and
the answer is
palm.xml working with Jenkins you're
going to be asked to explain the two
types of pipeline used in Jenkins along
with the syntax and so a scripted
pipeline is based on groovy script as
the domain-specific language for Jenkins
there are one or more no blogs that are
used throughout the entire Pipeline on
the left hand side you can actually see
what the actual script would look like
and the right hand side shows what the
actual declaration for each section of
that script would be the second time of
Jenkins pipeline is a declarative
Pipeline and a decarative pipeline
provides a simple and a friendly syntax
to Define what the pipeline should look
like and then you can actually at this
point use an example to actually break
out how blocks are used to define the
work completed in a decorative pipeline
so how do you create a copy and backup
of Jenkins well to create a backup
periodically back up Jenkins to your
Jenkins home directory and then create a
copy of that directory it's really as
simple as that the question you'll be
asked as well is how can you copy
Jenkins from one server to another well
they're essentially there are three ways
to do that one is you can move a job
from one installation of Jenkins to
another by copying the corresponding job
directory the second would be to create
a copy of an existing job directory and
making a clone of that job directory but
with a different name and the third is
to rename an existing job by renaming a
directory so security is fundamental to
all the work that we do within devops
and Jenkins provides the center core to
all the work that gets completed within
a devops environment there are three
ways in which you can apply security to
authenticate users effectively and when
you're asked about this question of
security within Jenkins the three
responses you want to be able to provide
is a Jenkins has its own internal
database that uses secured user data
from and user credentials B is you can
use a ldap or lightweight directory
access protocol server to be able to
authenticate Jenkins users or C you can
actually configure Jenkins to
authenticate by using such as oauth
which is a more modern method of being
able to authenticate users you're going
to be asked how to deploy a custom build
of a core plugin within Jenkins and
essentially the four steps you want to
go through are first of all copying the
dot HPI plugin file into the Jenkins
home plugins subdirectory you want to
remove the plugins development directory
if there is one you want to create an
empty file called
plugin.hpi dot pinned and once you've
completed these three steps restart
Jenkins and your custom build plugin
should be available how can you
temporarily turn off Jenkins security if
the administrative user has locked
themselves out of the admin console this
doesn't happen very often but when it
does it's good to know how you can
actually get into Jenkins and be able to
resolve the problems of authenticating
effectively into the system as an
administrator so when you want to be
able to get into a Jenkins environment
what you want to be able to do is locate
the config file you should see that it's
set to True which allow allows for
security to be enabled if you then
change the user security setting to
false Security will be disabled allow
you to make your administrative changes
and will not be re-enabled until the
next time Jenkins is restarted so what
are the ways in which a build can be
scheduled and run in Jenkins well there
are four ways in which you can identify
the way a build can be scheduled on
running Jenkins the first is when source
code management commits new code into
the repository you can run Jenkins at
that point the second can be the after
the completion of other builds so maybe
you have multiple builds in your project
that are dependent to each other and
when so many other builds have been
executed then you can have Jenkins run
you can schedule builds to run at a
specified time so you may have nightly
bills of your code that illustrates the
changes and the solution you're building
and then finally you also can manually
build a environment environment on
request occasionally you will want to
also restart Jenkins and so it's good
that when a question around how do you
restart Jenkins manually comes up that
you have the answers and there are two
ways in which you can do it one is you
can force a restart without waiting for
Bill to complete by using the Jenkins
URL that you have for your environment
slash restart or you can allow all
running bills to complete before restart
are required in which case you would use
the command of the URL for your Jenkins
environment slash safe restart so with
that we have come to an end of the
session on software testing if you have
any queries regarding any of the topics
covered in the session or if you require
the resources that we used in this
session like the code or PPT then do let
us know in the comment section below and
our team of experts we'll be more than
happy to resolve all your queries at the
earliest until next time thank you stay
safe and keep learning
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here
foreign